hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor exam pro and i'm bringing you
another complete study course and this
time it's the kubernetes and cloud
native associate made available to you
here on freecodecamp so this course is
designed to help you pass and achieve
cncf issued certification and the way
we're going to do that is by going
through lecture content doing follow
alongs in our own account we've got a
full free practice exam so you can
simulate the real exam and we've got
cheat sheets on the day exam that you
can go and print out and cram that last
minute knowledge so that you can pass
that exam and prove on your resume and
linkedin you have that kubernetes
knowledge and get that cloud job or that
promotion you've been looking for so i'm
your instructor andrew brown i was
previously the c2 of multiple tech
companies 15 years experience with five
years specializing cloud i'm a nativist
community hero and i've published many
many free cloud courses just like this
one and if you ever want to be buy me a
drink coconut water is what i like so i
just want to take a moment to thank you
the viewers for making this free course
possible because it's you who buy our
additional study materials that allows
us to produce these large free courses
and if you want to support more courses
like this one the best way is to sign up
on
exampro.comforce kcna to get that
additional study notes flash cards
quizlets downloadable lecture slides
downloadable cheat sheets practice exams
ask questions get learning support and
more and just by signing up for free
you're going to get that free practice
exam and cheat sheets with no credit
card required and no trial limit
so
if there are updates of this course the
best way is to look on the youtube and
to see if there has been an update if
you click that that's where you're going
to see things like corrections additions
modifications to make sure you are using
the latest version of this course and to
keep up to date for upcoming courses the
best way is to follow me on twitter
andrewbrown and if you do pass the exam
or you'd like to know or would like to
suggest what course to be produced next
you can go tell me that on twitter and
it's time to jump into the course
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're asking the most important
question first which is what is the
kcna's the kca stands for kubernetes and
cloud native associate and it's the
entry level uh cncf certification so
cncf is the organization that is issuing
this certification
and so this certification is going to
teach you the landscape of cloud native
technologies a close look at the core
kubernetes components a quick look at
the vast amount of cncf projects and
cloud native tooling a general overview
of security deployment monitoring the
structure and governance of cncf and the
community around cloud native so the
course code here is the kcna um and it
doesn't have like versioning like other
certifications like aws or azure where
azure would be something like the az300
and then go 301 302 for the next
versions um and a bus would have like
co1 co2 co3 on the end and so they just
don't do that's the only way you know
what version you're on is you'd have to
go to an obscure github page and see the
curriculum version there but we are on
version one uh for this so consider this
version one kcna um and kubernetes is
one of the hottest technologies being
adopted in the world it's in the top
four there with aws azure then
kubernetes and terraform so definitely
worth it to add to your journey
so uh who is a certification for well
considering taking the kcna if you are
new to cloud native in kubernetes and
need to learn the fundamentals you are
an executive management or sales level
and need to acquire strategic
information about cloud native for
adoption or migration you are a senior
cloud engineer or solutions architect
looking to quickly add kubernetes and
cloud native to your skill set and so
notice that we have um three asterisks
up here and the reason why is that um
unlike other fundamental certifications
this one feels like it was made by
engineers people that want to use
kubernetes as opposed to people that
are from the business perspective and so
it's missing things like uh adoption
frameworks uh cost like total cost of
ownership shared responsibility model um
uh migration paths so
for that i you know i kind of fill in
the gaps best i can but it's not on the
exam and it's kind of a misstep of a
fundamental certification in my sense
so if you are in the executive
management sales level and expecting to
have a lot of that stuff you're going to
be a bit disappointed to find out it's a
lot more code than you'd like but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't take it just
means that you might not want to sit the
exam because it might not be worth it
because you'll fail because you're not
really trying to become someone who can
code in kubernetes as opposed to just
understanding it from a managerial
perspective but for anyone that is like
wants to be an engineer like a
kubernetes engineer this is the right
course for you
so the kcna is a difficult uh exam for
entry level and you're going to need
both hands-on and broad conceptual
knowledge of the kubernetes cloud native
projects and i really stress hands-on
now this certification is multiple
choice so technically you could do
without hands-on but to contextualize a
lot of the questions or even to go to
the next step of certifications you're
going to be in bad shape if you don't do
hands-on so for technical implementation
roles like kubernetes engineer or cloud
native engineer
this might not be enough to get you that
role
if you already have prior experience
like you work a tech job then yes it is
a good addition uh and it can get you a
role as a kubernetes engineer but if
you're just like from starting from zero
then you might need a bit more work or
go further down
the uh road the roadmap there
so when you complete the certification
you'll be able to deploy a simple
application into a kubernetes cluster
understand uh various kubernetes
components but not enough to deploy a
production ready application so really
missing those complex production setups
like for deployment security
uh like working with a lot of different
microservices and things like that
so let's take a look at our roadmap here
so we have suggested prequels uh
prerequisites and kubernetes track
now the thing is i never ever ever
ever at a fundamental have to recommend
suggested prerequisites so this should
tell you something about the difficulty
of this exam
you will really just say i have
everything inclusive you can go ahead
from
day zero and and get into the cloud
right but this one uh you're gonna need
some linux knowledge you're gonna need
some uh
linux networking knowledge it networking
cloud networking whatever
or a associate level cloud certification
if you can pass one of these then you
probably have the knowledge for the ones
above there i'm not saying go sit all of
these i'm just making suggestions of one
of those categories here
and then from there i then i would
recommend to proceed the casing a you
can do the kcna without doing all this
prerequisite stuff you just
might be a bit more confused than
expected okay
and so after that i would generally
recommend the ckd because once you are
done the the fundamental knowledge of
being able to work with clusters
usually people want to deploy them and
so
uh you know there is the
kca which i recommend next but that one
the kca administrator is more about like
managing nodes and self-deployment of
clusters where the kc ad feels more
practical and it says application
developer but it's really not
you're not building out apps per se it's
more like stuff around them
and so since a lot of providers are
managed this feels like a better fit
for for most people after that you can
go with the cks
but if you really want to call yourself
a kubernetes engineer you're going to
have to at least make it to
this stage right either one or the other
depending on or both depending on what
you do
but generally like once you're once you
go beyond the kcna all these things are
pretty much like the kcad
seek cks and cka they're all the same
kind of difficulty just in different
kind of areas and honestly i feel like
they should have been like a pro cert
you should have just studied them all
together
um because it's like not that much work
to do the extra ones the key difference
here is that this here is multiple
choice these are all hands-on and so
that's why i say that i have to spend
extra time with you doing hands-on
because i'm preparing you for the next
level if you don't do those you're going
to really struggle the next step so
doing those hands-on is very important
how long should you study to pass well
um for this beginner i have 50 hours at
one end so if you've never done linux
networking or cloud you're going to be
doing it outside of this course but
trying to find to fill that knowledge if
you've never written a code or held a
technical role it's just going to be a
lot of work for the experienced if you
have worked with a csp like a bus as
your gcp linux and linux networking
you're looking at 20 hours um that's
still a little bit long normally i would
suggest like
14 hours and the course is like the
video content is not even
um
uh you know like 20 hours but the thing
is is that you're going to have to spend
a lot of time doing hands-on labs and
you have to factor in the time that
you're going to be doing practice exams
so it is of course longer there the
average time i would say is 30 hours um
so 50
lectures in labs 50 practice exams and
we're recommending a couple hours a day
for three weeks out uh normally like i
would say two weeks for a fundamental
sometimes even a week like in the old my
old clf c01 this uh it was certified
club petitioner we would recommend like
literally like book it the next week um
but this one is really hard so you're
going to need a bit more uh time to get
there okay
what does it take to pass the exam we'll
watch the video lectures memorize the
information do hands-on lab this one is
especially important we call them
follow-alongs but um i strongly strongly
strongly strongly recommend doing these
within your own account and when i say
that
like we're going to be doing all in aws
on cloud nine and uh there are sandboxes
out there and they are an option if you
do not have money and you do not have a
credit card but
um
if you can please do them in cloud nine
and follow along because if you do sand
boxes they're abstracting away a lot of
things that you that could go wrong and
that's the parts that you you need to
actually become a kubernetes engineer
dealing with those hard bits so you are
cheating yourself if you use sandboxes
but i understand why people want to use
them because they're just
they want to kind of have that okay so
do paid online practice exams the same
with the real exam the great thing is
that um
if you sign up in exam pro today no
credit card require kcna i got a full
free practice exam for you extremely
generous uh and if you want you can
definitely sign up with a credit card to
get access to the rest of the practice
exams all the rest of the lyric content
cheat sheets and more would greatly
appreciate it so we can produce more
free video content our content outline
is out of five domains so each has its
own weighting that's going to determine
how many questions so we have
fundamentals container orchestration
container native architecture cloud
native observability cloud native
application delivery you'll know some
say like between
x like 27 20 questions it's because if
you do the math you end up with like a
decimal point for how many questions
there are so that means that they could
have one
additional or one less on certain ones
there
and most of it's fundamental so
fundamentals is strongly focused on
kubernetes components
so where do you take this example either
in person at a test center or online for
the convenience of your own home um
for these which is through the linux
foundation uh i know it's cncf but like
cncf is part of the linux foundation and
so you'll go to linux foundation to sign
up for this and this uses the psi
network of test centers and online
proctor exam systems so it'll look like
linux foundation has their own thing but
then you'll end up on psi
and if you can please take it in person
because
online it's so stressful you know like
your dog could bark your kid could cough
someone could knock on the door
um you know the internet could go out
and the check-in process is always
painful it's not psi it's any of them
and uh you know if you want to just be
less stressed
i would
suggest in a person if that is an option
for you if it's not then you have to do
online
um i think psi they're the more strict
ones so pearson vue
uh i prefer pearson vue
but psi like you can't even have
anything on the desk so like for me i
like to have a
box on the desk in the middle of the
room to prop up my laptop they won't
even let you have that box to prop up it
up so
just make sure you're really comfortable
and you have a table that's a good eye
level for that if you don't know what a
proctor is it's a supervisor or person
who monitors students during an
examination
so let's take a look here at grading so
the passing score would be about 75
percent i say about or around because it
might use scaled scoring usually the
exam takers will point that out that
just means that um the system isn't
exact and so it's possible to fail with
the 75 percent
um and since it's on psi i just assume
that it's following like what all the
other providers are doing so always aim
for you know more at least one percent
above there but you probably can pass at
75 percent
always aim 10 above there are 60
questions and as far as i can tell there
are no unscored questions unscored
questions happen on exams for many
reasons uh
so like eight of us has like 15. i think
it's like 15 or 10 no it's 10 i think
it's 10 unscored questions
and um you know they're just oddball
questions to help
detect cheaters to see if they want to
introduce new questions things like that
they don't do this here with the kcna
so every question is scored
and there are some eyeball ones in there
so that's why i thought there would have
been some but there's not you have about
15 questions you can get wrong
there is no penalty for wrong questions
the format of the questions is multiple
choice multiple answer when i take exams
i remember the number that i get wrong
and actually count in my head like okay
i think i got this one wrong i'm okay
you know what i mean um the duration you
got 1.5 hours so that means 1.5 minutes
that's 90 minutes uh your seat time
would be 120 minutes see time refers the
amount of time you should allocate about
the time that you're sitting the exam
this includes time to review the
instructions show online proctor your
workspace read and accept nda complete
the exam provide feedback at the end
um and
really checking online is super super
super stressful because every time i've
done it something's gone wrong you know
what i mean like they don't like my card
they make me check the whole room again
there's a lighting issue or i'm taking
i'm trying to take a photo but it's
saying like it's blurry but it's not
so you know just make sure you have
ample time there and uh even if you do
do that like sometimes they start the
exam early just because you're ready um
so it might not be exactly the time that
you take it but um
and it's similar to in person as well if
you sometimes show up early they'll just
say hey you can go
um and so this exam is valid for three
years or 36 months before
recertification i don't think you can
sit in an exam uh if you have one active
that's usually the the thing there you
get two attempts to pass so if you fail
you get another try by rescheduling a
future date i actually failed my first
attempt because when i went in i just i
knew i had two attempts and so i i sat
it without a single like a study and i
got 74
which is pretty good to show like how
much cloud knowledge carries over um but
i you know i would say that uh you know
you're paying for two you should take
two so
uh you know if you want to uh fail it
and go sit it that's totally fine
because then you kind of get a sense of
like okay i need to brush up on some
areas that i don't know
um but uh you know it's up to you but
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
kcna so i just typed in kcna into google
and it made our way here and so there's
a register for the exam here at the at
the current cost at least for me it says
250 and we can see the five domains but
that doesn't really tell us a lot so
there's a handbook down below if you
click that it gives you
way too much information on
how like taking the exam works so they
have a lot of information here to me
it's a bit overkill but
um if you need to know anything it's
it's in this handbook and this is
generalized for any of the linux
certifications and you're thinking well
isn't this the cncf well yeah but
the certification is through the linux
foundation because cncf is a
uh sub-organization of the linux
foundation so you can roll this way
notice they have a bundle for a course
for 50 bucks more i can't really speak
to the quality of the course um
so i'm not sure
it kind of looks like it's pieced
together with other content
so i mean that's going to be your
decision if you want to do that um there
are always a way to get kind of a
discount 250 dollars is pretty steep
um and so if you try to reach out to
like maybe like a cncf
um community ambassador maybe they'll
know where a coupon code is but try not
to pay full price because i didn't i got
a code somewhere but here you can see
the breakdown again for uh the different
kinds of categories here we'll just
expand it here
and another place to look is the
curriculum and i wouldn't call these
curriculums they call them exam guides
curriculums are very detailed but this
is what i'm talking about where we see
the versioning right and so here they
say kcna and they might have some
resources here and i'm sure that they
will add my resources here soon enough
because i just have yet to publish my
course but i could see mine being on the
top there very soon um
but yeah so this is the curriculum here
so we'll open enough and give it a
moment if we scroll on down here are our
categories so not very detailed compared
to other other ones but let's just take
a look here so under kubernetes
fundamentals we have resources
architecture api containers scheduling
and really this is knowing the
components of kubernetes okay there's a
lot of different components and we'll go
through that
then we have container orchestration so
this is understanding uh run times what
is an orchestration system the basics of
security like the four c's of security
networking and cluster networking uh
very little knowledge we need a little
bit knowledge on service match how does
storage persistent volumes uh go into
play the network cloud native
architecture we have uh the fundamentals
auto scaling serverless community and
governance personas now personas is
weird because
it doesn't really show up on the exam
like there's a page about personas um
that talks about all the different kinds
of customers that could use it but
really the only personas you really see
are sres
and there might be like one or two
questions so if you do see something
asking like what kind of roles whatever
it's probably going to be sre
so that was kind of weird one open
standards like all the types of
interfaces that can be used telemetry
and observability so
things like open telemetry prometheus
grafana
cost management that's another squishy
one where uh they don't really have a
good definition of cost anywhere maybe
it's in that paid course by them but
it's definitely nowhere else online so i
had to kind of piece that together and
they only ask you like one
pricing question and it's such a bizarre
question that uh you know it's just what
it is uh then underneath we have
application delivery so like uh git ops
ci cd
things like that you should just know
generally the different types of
deployment tools uh for get ops but you
don't really have to know how to deploy
i mean you technically do but not like
with a pro like not with like flux or
not with argo nothing super complicated
but you do need to know the different
types of deployment strategies so
hopefully that gives you kind of idea
of what you're going to be dealing with
here but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and what i want
to show you here is just where you can
access that praxis exam on the exam pro
platform so once you sign up for your
account there if you scroll on down this
is where the prax exams will be you
generally should not attempt your
practice exam until you've gone through
all the lecture content and done the
follow alongs because you know once you
see those questions once you're you
might prime your mind in order to uh
remember them and so uh you know i
always say try to take it like a serious
attempt now right now the time of i only
have one and two in here on the
publication of this course we should
have all three in and there will be a
free one so if you're on the free tier
you'll see that shown up at the top
there but really what i want to do is
just show you what some questions look
like so here you can see i have one uh
running uh prior so i'll just go there
and resume and so i just kind of want to
you know click through a few questions
and just talk about how these questions
are maybe different from other exams and
how they're formatted so one thing i
noticed for the official exams is the
questions are very short at the top they
get right to the point um and you may or
may not like that but that just means
that usually um the choices are a lot
more complex and as you can see in this
example it is actually asking uh little
code things like cube ctl commands and
for the exam they absolutely will ask
you technical things um even though this
is a fundamental course they made it
it's written by engineers so they're
really testing your knowledge and so you
can expect to see those kind of
questions there
sometimes questions are as simple as
choosing the right service or product or
tool so here you know it's just a list
of things and so you'd have to know uh
which thing to choose there as well
and then you will see conceptual
questions where
there's not a lot of these usually
everything is tied to something
technical uh practical but you'll see
conceptual questions like here where
they say what architecture automatically
optimizes for cost in kubernetes and so
for that one i would choose serverless
because serverless can scale to zero but
that generally gives you an idea that
the questions aren't um hard to parse
but they can be tricky based on the
choices and um
there was ones where you know if you
knew too much about kubernetes and you
were doing this
you might know that there is a more
right answer but always go with the
answer that seems the most obvious even
if you know of those technicalities and
you will do very well on the exam so
hopefully that gives you an idea of what
those questions look like again don't
tempt these until you go through the
whole uh course material first and and
practice your flash cards and things
like that but uh hopefully that gives
you an idea of what to expect so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are asking the most important
questions first which is what is cloud
native so cloud native describes an
architectural approach that emphasizes
application workloads that are portable
modular and isolate between different
cloud deployment models and cloud
service providers so that's my own
definition because when i looked up
cloud native and as i understood it it
was a little bit more complicated than
that and the context seemed to change
depending on who was using the term so
one example is with cloud service
providers and so a cloud service
provider would be something like aws
azure or gcp and when they would use the
term cloud native and this is my first
introduction to cloud native when i was
using aws
was it meant everything built on top of
the cloud service provider
and so what i learned was that this is
more
uh meaning cloud first so where um you
know you could start on premise like in
your own data center but if you choose
to build all in the cloud provider that
is a cloud cloud-first approach and so
that's where that term kind of got a bit
muddy and so that's why i redefined it
up here to say something that you can
take you can build and you can move it
to anabus azure gcp
in theory
there's also kind of these like diagrams
online that talk about the components
that go into cloud native and so the
idea here is that they'll say modern
design automation micro services
containers and backing services so the
idea when they say modern design modern
design would be using a modern
architecture which below is
microservices and containers uh or
serverless architecture and then
automation which is just a component of
it and then backing services meaning
like okay most of it
is going to be probably portable modular
isolate but you might leverage
backing services like
closer providers services or other cloud
native services that run anywhere so
some describe uh
cloud native being four key principles
so you can just see there's variations
on this micro services containerization
continuous delivery and devops so it
really depends in the context and so the
context of this course cloud native will
mean technologies like kubernetes and
the cncf projects which we'll talk about
this course that are both distributed
and agnostic to any cloud service
provider and just to really uh be very
specific i found this definition by the
cloud native computing foundation it was
in one of their documents um
somewhere so i don't know who wrote it
but it is by them and their definition
was cloud native technologies empower
organizations to build and run scalable
applications in modern dynamic
environments such as public private and
hybrid clouds
containers services meshes microservices
immutable infrastructure declarative
apis
for that approach these techniques
enable loosely coupled systems that are
resilient manageable observable combined
with robust automation they allow
engineers to make high impact changes
frequently and predictably with minimum
toll the cloud native foundation seeks
to drive adoption of this paradigm by
fostering and sustaining an ecosystem of
open source vendor neutral projects we
democratize the state of the art
patterns to make these innovations
accessible for everyone and so what i
get from that when i read it is that the
cncfs approach is that it's democratized
right so if you are using a classical
provider like database azure gcp you're
really
buying into that whole system but the
idea is that you buy into cloud native
you have more uh portability
and uh you know there's a bunch of
people that are involved to make sure
that you aren't uh
you know being sucked into a gravity
well of a particular managed provider so
you know hopefully that gives some
context it is again a squishy term but
uh you know we have to kind of define it
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud native
versus cloud service providers because
sometimes people get these really mixed
up
and so i just kind of wanted to spell it
out here so a cloud service provider
also known as a csp is a collection of
cloud services with strong application
integration and their synergy between
those services they utilize metered
billing and they're under a single
unified api so examples would be aws
gcp
azure ibm cloud and there's a few others
there and so this is my definition
because you know you kind of have to
piece it together and just know over the
years what it means um but really the
important thing to know is a cloud
service provider is useful because of
those synergies between services so they
don't always have
the best in class service sometimes they
do sometimes they don't but the idea is
that by utilizing a collection of them
uh and the synergies between them it
outweighs anything like a v a single
cloud platform with a single cloud
service that's trying to have the best
one specific service metered billing
means like you pay on the hour on the
minute on the second single unified api
means that it's just very easy to work
with all the services pragmatically in
the same way
okay so on the other side we have cloud
native and this is a workload
application or system that is designed
to run on cloud services and take
advantage of cloud offering and when i
say cloud services really we're just
talking about compute right because
that's all you really need is
a place to run your virtual machines
your containers your kubernetes cluster
and then cloud native can integrate with
some
cloud service provider application or
services very common like for databases
or their load balancer but you know
they're not necessarily taking advantage
of the cloud service provider they're
taking advantage of cloud offerings like
cloud computing and that's a key thing
to point out is that cloud native
workloads cannot take advantage of all
or the full advantages of a cloud
service provider because a cloud service
provider intentionally has
proprietary technology to encourage you
to use their managed services that have
exclusive integrations
with other services and so um you know
that's just the nature of it i mean you
know if you're a cloud service provider
you'd obviously prefer them to use your
services over the cloud native solution
but both of these exist in the same
ecosystem and all cloud service
providers um you know offer support for
cloud native
and so you know hopefully that is clear
[Music]
so no fundamental uh cloud certification
would be complete without a shared
responsibility model and for the kcna
they don't actually ask you any
questions about a shared responsibility
model which to me is a bit disappointing
but
for your own benefit i thought it was
very important that we go find one and
so the cloud native shared
responsibility model is a little bit
hard to define because uh you don't have
like a large organization defining it
and the cncf isn't defining it um and so
what i had to do is find a community
member's one and then look at and say is
this good and i thought yeah it's pretty
good and i want to show it to you so
this is the
shared responsibility model that i found
it's made by lachlan
white and i did ask them and say hey can
i use this model to show off in the
course and they're very happy to say yes
go for it and so the idea is a shared
responsibility model is the
responsibility of the customer or the
team or of the organization for the
types of workloads and so the comparison
here is we have traditional it
hybrid it and then cloud native it
and i know it's really small but if you
look down the list here we have
applications data runtime middleware os
virtualization server storage networking
pretty common for shared responsibility
models
but what's interesting here is who is
responsible on the team
and there's a big word here that you'll
see
that says
get ops and get ops can be a little bit
hard to define i have a
very practical definition to get it up
so we'll get into the course but i just
want to emphasize that when you're
working with cloud native there is a
larger emphasis on git ops and so you
are seeing things like network engineers
security engineers solutions architect
sres
platform engineers data engineers and
developers whereas in the traditional
sphere used to have like your
infrastructure team your your middleware
team
and then some specialized things so
there's not really much to say here
other than i just wanted to point out
that there's git ops
and that it is core to
cloud native and so that is really all
there is to share here okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and before we can talk about the cncf we
need to talk about the lf
which stands for the linux foundation so
this is a non-profit technology
consortism founded in 2000 is a merger
between the open source development labs
and the free standards group to
standardize linux support its growth and
promote its commercial adoption and so
the linux foundation is supported by a
variety of technology companies so
there's a lot of big names here and this
isn't the full list this is just a
handful of them like anabes should be
there and all sorts of things but the
idea behind the lynx foundation is it's
just a non-profit thing to make sure
linux uh keeps running right and um that
that there is a community behind it that
is kind of steering its future growth
and so that is the premise of the linux
foundation
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at the
cncf also known as the cloud native
computing foundation and if you ever get
the initialism wrong or can't remember
the name that's okay i mess it up all
the time but i want to tell you right
now that this will be a question on the
exam for the kcna if you know what the
cncf stands for so take a look here
very carefully and it is cloud native
computing foundation okay
uh
very very very easy for me to forget i
think when i took the exam even though
i've said it a hundred times i forgot
what it was
so the cncf is a linux foundation
project that was founded in 2015 to help
advance container technology and project
is a funny word because it's not always
what you think it means
uh but it's used a lot in um like
technology stuff and a good example
would be like oh wasp where it's called
the like the
open web
security project and then it's an
organization but they call it a project
so the cncf operates as an independent
nonprofit organization from its parent
organization which is the linux
foundation
and it has all this structure and stuff
underneath of it so it has
board members that meet to decide on
things like the budget and marketing
um the cnf cncf has its own global tech
conferences like cloud native con plus
kubecon and you'll see this it's always
the same conference we'll talk about
that when we get to that uh later in the
course
the cncf has its own cloud native
certifications which is the one you are
studying for right now the kcna
and the cncf has its own collection of
projects so it's funny that it's called
a project
but it's really an organization but then
within it it actually has
technical projects and so projects here
would be kubernetes which is
the key project that we are focused on
in this uh certification course
prometheus
at c or etcd contain container d and a
lot more and we will go look at them all
okay so that's the cloud native
computing foundation
[Music]
all right so i just wanted to show you
where these websites are so we have the
linuxfoundation.org and then the cncfio
and if you go here you can go to
projects and you can see all sorts of
different projects if you scroll on down
here you can just drop on down to
anything like networking and edge and
you might see something that you know so
there is a lot
like
a lot of projects um for the linux
foundation
but uh they also have their own training
so you go here and that's where you get
like linux foundation certifications for
learning linux then if you go over here
to the cncf
the cloud native computing foundation
uh you can learn more about it scroll on
down here and look at the cnscf projects
and so these we're going to be spending
a lot of time here but not right now
we'll get to it later okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the cloud
native landscape so this is an
interactive map developed by the cncf to
showcase all the available cloud native
technologies and to help identify the
category to which they serve so we just
got to go to landscape.cncfio
and you can see the projects here and
there's a bunch of rich filters but just
to give you kind of a preview of all the
categories i extracted them out for you
we got app definition and development
orchestration and management
runtime provisioning
there's special ones like uh
certified service providers or training
partners maybe one day i'll be a
training partner who knows um
observability and analysis and then
there's these sub landscapes so we got
members serverless and the cd foundation
the landscape so not all of these are
tech projects per se they could be like
things that um are
professional services but we will take a
look at it and see you know what the
landscape looks like okay
[Music]
all right so we're back on the
cloud native computing foundation
website and if you go to projects here
um
it should be projects there will be a
thing that says cloud native landscape
and that will open up this interactive
landscape where we have all these uh fun
little boxes and these are all different
kinds of cloud native technologies so
here you can see kubernetes it's right
here i can click to it i can get a rich
information about this project
we can go to card mode here
and so this is a little bit easier to
consume
go back to landscapes here
and we can even filter it based on
category these filters should be working
i guess we have to choose based on the
projects we'll say cncf projects so
these are projects by the cncf right
and so you kind of get the idea there
it's nothing super complicated but there
are um some uh
landscapes within landscapes like this
serverless landscape so you go over here
and that's one this apparently is a
landscape the members people that are
participating or um
providing sponsorship so you know we
didn't show aws as a logo
um
in the linux foundation but you can see
these are all the people that are
putting money into this oh and is
utilizing cloud native technology so
there's a lot
of people
here
all right so you know hopefully that
gives you an idea there's also this
guide up here if i just click guide
and we'll give it a moment to load and
so there is some kind of prescriptive
stuff here that talks about like
buzzword this is so bizarre they say
buzzwords infrastructure is a code
declarative configurations those aren't
buzzwords
so whoever wrote that i don't know but i
mean i guess they kind of define things
like container registry security
compliance
key management these are like um
bare-bones stuff around these categories
to kind of help you understand based
concepts but i'm not really worried
about going through that with you i
don't think that's necessary but i just
wanted to show you the interactive
landscape
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the cloud
native trail map so the trail map is a
recommended path to adopting cloud
native architecture and so it's pretty
much a glorified pdf and so the idea is
that they set out a path of saying okay
the first thing you're going to do is
you are going to take your application
and you are going to containerize it and
then once it's containerized then you
can add ci cd to automate that and then
now you have a containerized application
um you'll want to be able to orchestrate
it and deploy it to something like
kubernetes and then you'll want
observability analysis analysis and get
data and then you'll want to uh put
something rich on top like a service
mesh uh because you know if you want to
build up microservices that will be
useful you'll care about uh security
making sure things are secure then
you'll need databases storage etc so the
idea is they just have this big old list
here and then they have like these abcs
along the side so if you look here you
can get my pen out here just says help
along the way so training certification
which is me by the way
consulting help or joining the cncf as
an end user community and i just want to
point out that the path order will vary
based on your use case they're just
trying to give you something so that
when you go to your team to your
stakeholders
to the executive level you say look we
have a road map we have a plan but um
you know the idea here is that you just
do what you need to do because a lot of
these later ones are just going to be in
the order that you need them right it's
not necessarily a strict
guide okay
[Music]
all right so let's go see where we can
find that trail map so i'm on the cncf
website i go to projects then you go to
cloud native trail map and that will
bring up a github repository and you can
scroll on down until you see it and
there it is so you can pretty much you
know click into it probably and expand
it here i'm just waiting for it to load
it's a big old png
and it's way too big but you know the
idea here is that you can read it and uh
it will have suggestions around that
stuff and so if you want to use more
than what's just listed here that's
where you go back to the landscape and
you'd filter based on
those categories so
nothing super fancy here
and by the way
if you look in the bottom left corner
okay this is where i got my cloud native
definition
when i was talking about the cncf
earlier in the course it was from this
document there you go
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at
virtual machines also known as vms
compared to containers because the idea
behind kubernetes and cloud native stuff
is that
there are virtual machines involved but
you're generally working with containers
not virtual machines
so the idea is that we'll have a virtual
machine and the example says ec2
instance that is just amazon's name for
virtual machines
so just think virtual machine there and
so a virtual machine will have a host
operating system
installed on it could be windows
could be linux and then on top of that
it's going to have a hypervisor and that
hypervisor
is what allows you to run a virtual
machine on a real physical machine
and so the virtual machine
has its own guest operating system which
is here and that is ubuntu as an example
and that's where you can install
libraries packages binaries then from
there you'd have your workload like
let's say you have a django app you have
your database you have your queuing
uh and so the thing with vms uh
is that they're great because they allow
you to run
multiple workloads on a single machine
so you are best utilizing uh that
physical machine to the best of its
ability
but the problem with virtual machines is
that they're still going to be wasted
space
because you have to
um
you know provision a virtual machine to
be a particular size and so that's where
you're always going to be over
provisioned and it wouldn't be really
nice if you know this part if we're only
just paying for this much and anything
that was not being utilized would not
cost us anything or could be used like
something to be slotted in there and so
that's where um containers come into
play so containers are very similar uh
initially so you have they run on a
virtual machine it has a host operating
system like linux or windows and then it
has
what we call
a container runtime now i have docker
daemon because docker uh is a very
popular uh container runtime um
so it could be like container d now i
suppose but the idea is you have a
container run time and so each container
would have its own uh guest operating
system that would run on and then in
that
container would be it the workload so
the django app with its own libraries
and stuff and then each container is
extremely isolated and so the advantage
here
about having these like isolate
workloads is that you know you are best
utilizing the space on the physical
machine
and the other thing is is that you get
isolation so when you're looking at this
virtual machine over here if the django
app does something to consume more
resources
it could take away from mongodb or
rabbitmq where these ones you can just
say okay you're only allowed to use x
amount of space and so conceptually
um instead of thinking of this
additional space as wasted it's
available because if you were to use
something like
amazon ecs elastic container service
that space would be able to be used by
another customer right where when you
launch a virtual machine you're always
over provisioning so virtual machines do
not make the best use of space apps are
not isolated which could cause config
conflicts security problems resource
hogging containers allow you to run
multiple apps which are virtually
isolated from each other
launch new containers configure os
dependencies per container there you go
oh and by the way just think container
run time here so i just kind of patched
that graphic there for you
[Music]
all right let's talk about micro service
architecture and to understand that we
need to compare it against
monolithic architecture so monolithic
architecture is one app which is
responsible for everything and the
functionality is tightly coupled so
imagine you have a repository that
contains everything uh the the database
caching load balancing the marketing
website the front end stuff the api the
orm
background jobs everything and generally
monoliths are installed on virtual
machines they don't utilize containers
and the issue here is that when you have
so much stuff running on a single
machine
what happens
when uh your load bouncer runs into a
problem it's not like you can just
replace it uh and so this is where
microservices come into play so the idea
is you have multiple apps which are each
responsible for one thing and the
functionality is isolate and stateless
and so here
the idea is that we are using
the cloud service provider load balancer
we're using the cloud service provider
caching the cloud service provider
database the queuing
for cloud native you might be spinning
these up in your cluster so you might
not be using cloud service provider
services
as these isolate apps but they would be
an isolate on your cluster and so the
idea is that you can easily remove or
add any of these components
and manage them and so that's the
key part about microservices now the
trade-off here is that when you have
microservices
you end up with a lot more uh effort
between communicating between all these
different little apps whereas in a
monolith
they're all the same place and so that
is one of the key advantages but that's
just something we have to overcome when
we are using microservice architecture
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at kubernetes
this is the reason why we're here for
this technology so it is an open source
container orchestration system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containers originally
developed by google and now maintained
by the cloud native computing foundation
the cncf as a cncf project and we are
going to touch on google cloud i'm going
to show you how to deploy
uh your cluster there and you're going
to find that google cloud is actually
the easiest of out of all the managed
providers because i use them all in this
course
kubernetes is commonly called k8s or k8s
on the 8 represents the
letters between the k and the s
generally if you see k8s you can say k8s
or kubernetes the advantage of
kubernetes over docker because docker is
what people always think when they think
of containers is ability to run
container apps distributed across
multiple virtual machines or as we'll
call them in the course nodes now i have
a double asterisk there and that's just
to remind me to tell you that uh this is
a gross gross gross growth
simplification docker is not as simple
as uh like an apples to or it's like an
apples to oranges comparison docker is a
suite of things it's a run time it can
have docker swarm which is an
orchestration tool so technically a
better comparison between kubernetes and
docker swarm but i'm just trying to keep
it simple here for you all right
uh a unique
component of kubernetes art pods and a
pod is a group of one or more containers
where shared storage network resources
and other shared
settings so the idea here i'm just
getting my pen out here is we have a
node which is a virtual machine and
another one here and you got pods
running across them
now
and pods contain containers in them
that's where the containers are now
as we look at pods throughout this
course you're going to find out that
basically
most components that we run kubernetes
are pods so that's why pods are so uh
front and center because basically
everything is a pod kubernetes is ideal
for micro service architecture
where a company has tens to hundreds of
services they need to manage
and so a service
um would be something like a
containerized application and the thing
is is that when you have a containerized
application you're very likely going to
be running more than one of them all
right even like redundant ones so here
we have pods and a pod would run a
specific application so let's say it's a
ruby on rails application
and i mean you could count this all as
one service or you could count each of
these as redundant services and so it's
very quick uh or easy to get into the
tens so kubernetes can be used uh quite
early on but it's going to be really
dependent on your use case
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the kubernetes
component overview so what i'm going to
do is give you a top
simplification on a lot but not all of
them but a lot of the kubernetes
components because there's just too many
it'd be
too much to go through all of them but
these are all the ones that we are going
to be spending a lot of time with and
you definitely will need to know them
all and you will know them all because
we deep dive on a lot of these and
you'll get to see them again and again
and again in the course so at the top of
our list is the cluster and this is a
logical grouping of all the components
within a cluster so mostly everything
that follows after this
is generally inside of a cluster there
are some exceptions uh the next is a
namespace so this is a named logical
grouping of kubernetes components within
a cluster and it's used to isolate
different workloads on the same cluster
i like to think of it as a slice of pie
so when you look at the icon and i made
all these icons by the way because i do
not like the ones
that are provided right now in the
community so i just made my own but i
made it look like a slice coming out of
that cluster so you can remember what
that is
then you have nodes so this is a virtual
machine or it could be a serverless
container because some providers like
google and aws lets you run it on their
service container platform but either
way it's just the underlying compute the
underlying server and there are two
types of nodes we have control plane and
worker nodes so worker nodes is where
your application or workloads run and
the control plane node manages worker
nodes so it does a lot of stuff like
that
then you have pods and pods are the
smallest unit in k-8s it's an
abstraction over containers it generally
defines an application workload but
basically
lots of these components are just pods
and we'll see that again and again when
we list out pods because i list them all
the time to show you under cube ctl
namespace
what is running they're always pods
so the next is service so a service is
something that we use with a pod to give
it a static ip address or a dns name
for a set of pods so the idea here is
that if a pod dies because pods get
dynamic ips but we want them to have
static ips and so that's the purpose of
a service but the service is also
utilized as a load balancer
and i'm going to point out that them
calling this a service is really
confusing because a lot of times a
service when we're talking about
containers means a
workload or application that is
continuously running right so if you've
ever used aws uh
ecs uh you have the option to run a task
or a service which are just containers
and based on how long they run but for
whatever reason that's what they wanted
to name it
the cncf decided to name it or
kubernetes project named it i don't
think it's a great name but that's what
it is ingress is also not a great name
but that's a name they gave it but
ingress is used to translate https rules
to point to services
but what we'll really see is that it's
commonly used and this is the hardest
component that we are going to learn
throughout this course but it's used for
getting a load balancer like an external
load bouncer on a bus gcp azure to a
road traffic
to our
pods okay
then you have the api server the api
server allows users to interact with
kubernetes components using the cube ctl
or by sending http or s requests
probably put an s on there because
probably everything
uh is encrypted in translate transit i
really doubt that they would have it so
that it's just http
and i like to think of the api server
as the backbone of communication for
kubernetes and you will see that
uh in a future diagram where it looks a
little bit like uh like um
like the backbone okay
uh then there's cubelet so cubelet is an
agent installed on the nodes cubelet
allows users to interact with a node via
the api server and cube ctl and again
that is a simplification it actually
does more than that but we will dig
deeper into that we have cubectl it's a
command line interface that allows users
to interact with the cluster and
components via the api server so the ctl
stands for
i think controller and ctail is very
very common
to put after a name for some kind of
tool that's used for controlling things
via cli
and we spend so much time
tons and tons of time
with the cube ctl so you will know
cubectl inside and out by the end of
this course
you have cloud controller manager this
allows you to link a csp like aws azure
gcp to leverage cloud services
i
never had to provision one in throughout
this course i never even noticed one i
think like when you launch a managed
service that's already there for you and
it replaces i believe the controller
manager
but i'm just saying it's there but we
don't really ever have to think about it
so we have the controller manager and
this is a control loop that watches the
state of the cluster and will change the
current state back to the desired state
so it's basically state management but
it's also
you could think of it as the brain
of kubernetes because it's doing all the
controlling
we have a scheduler so it determines
where to place pods on nodes and places
them in a scheduling queue so that's why
we have this little crane here because
it's picking them up and putting them
where they need to be
you have cube proxy so an application on
worker nodes that provides routing and
filtering rules for ingress or incoming
traffic uh to pods
you have a network policy these act as a
virtual firewall
it says as but at
sorry at the namespace level or the pod
level so it just
um
puts restrictions around how pods or
namespaces stuff in namespaces can
communicate with each other because by
default everything just can talk to
everything within a cluster
you have config maps so this allows you
to decouple environments a specific
configuration
from your container images so that your
applications are easily portable it's
used to store non-confidential data in a
key value pair so this is just
application uh configuration uh details
okay
then you have i'm not sure what's not
showing up there we go then you have a
secret so this is a small amount of
sensitive data such as a password a
token or key it's basically config map
with the option to encrypt it
then you have volumes so volumes
are basically
well there's some variations here but
they're basically mounting storage so
locally on a node
or remote to cloud storage then you have
stateful sets we do not do stateful sets
in this course because they are just too
hard to do but we definitely talk about
them in great detail so these provide
guarantees about the ordering and
uniqueness of
the pods so think of databases where you
have to determine reads and writes in
order or limit the amount of containers
staple sets are hard when you can host
use a database externally from the
kubernetes cluster so like if you have a
relational database put it on rds right
or put it on cloud google cloud spanner
but say the sample sets just basically
give you a guarantee
that you're going to send traffic to a
very particular pod
you have replica sets so maintain a
stable set of replica pods running at a
given time it can provide a guarantee of
availability
so this is just saying like take a pod
and run copies of it so that we have
redundancy there
and we generally do do not
launch replica sets directly we do them
through a deployment and this is also
how paws are deployed so deployments
deploy a replica set and the replica set
deploys pods so a deployment is a
blueprint of a pod so think like an ec2
launch template or something
that just templates up
what should be launched
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are talking about manifest files
in kubernetes so when i was studying for
the kcna and i sat it i was just seeing
uh conflicting terms about what they
call their configuration files because i
couldn't understand if there were
variants if they meant different things
but then i kind of settled on the
knowledge that they're actually all
manifest files and that's why
this slide is here for you or slides i
should say so let's describe what a
manifest is using
non-technical terms so a manifest file
is a document that is commonly used for
customs so like going over the border
from canada us to list the contents of
cargo or passengers it's an itemized
list of things
so what is that in the context of
kubernetes well a manifest file is a
generalized name for any kubernetes
configuration file that defines the
configuration of various kubernetes
components and the name will change
sometimes they'll call it a pod spec
file sometimes they'll call it a
kubernetes configuration file but
they're all manifest files right if
you're listing these this is yaml stuff
in a uh uh with kubernetes components
they're all manifest files and these are
all masked
files with specific purposes like i was
just saying deployment file
pod spec file network policy file and
manifest files can be written either in
yaml or json now i've never seen
a json manifest file but taking my
terraform knowledge i bet the reason why
there's json is if you are pragmatically
creating them the same thing with aws
with cloud formation templates whether
yaml and json um you probably would
never write
a json file by hand but it can take it
and probably it's being generated by
another app so here's an example of it
in yaml and here's an example of it in
json
so a manifest file can contain multiple
kubernetes components which makes sense
because we said manifest is an itemized
list of things so it can uh definitions
configuration so
here is an example of one and in yaml
they have the syntax which is the three
hyphens which allows you to define uh
basically an array so like we have two
different things here and once we have
all of our um
oh how what whichever amount of um
kubernetes components we want to define
in a manifest file we're going to be
using cube ctl and writing apply and
this is something that we use a lot in
this course we're doing cube ctl apply
hyphen f etc you will absolutely know
this by the end of the course inside and
out uh and resource configuration files
is sometimes used to describe multiple
resources
in a manifest file which is confusing
because manifest by definition
means
an itemized list multiple things
but that's just the terminology
throughout the documents throughout the
ecosystem there i just wanted to clear
that up for you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at control
plane nodes versus worker nodes so
control plane nodes were formerly known
as masternode and the only reason i'm
mentioning this is because
a lot of documentation out there like
tutorials and stuff are completely out
of date and they're not using the new
inclusive term so i'm sorry for
mentioning uh this term here but i just
have to because you need to know
what it is when you are looking up
information out there even the
kubernetes.i o website still has some
outdated stuff mostly in the graphics
not so much uh in the text so they seem
to fix that so you know a few years out
and i think we'll all be moved over to
the new terminology there and then you
have worker nodes
so control plane node manages processes
like scheduling restarting nodes and
then the worker node does the work as
the name implies it runs your apps it
runs your jobs and it's running pods and
containers they're both running pods and
containers but when we think of pods and
containers we're thinking about more of
the worker nodes because the other ones
even though they are pods we're thinking
them as distinct uh components okay
and so let's take a look at the the
components that are involved here
so the first thing
is the api server
and notice how i remember i said it was
the backbone of communication well look
at it it looks like a big long line here
and everything communicates along it so
that's what i mean by backbone of
communication
and the way you are talking to stuff is
generally going to be through the cube
ctl
okay or there's the api i guess they
don't have a graphic for the api
i guess it is the api server so that
would be you sending um like https
requests directly to it so i imagine
that's like how um
managed cloud service providers are
talking to it
but anyway so that's the api server then
we'll have the scheduler so this
determines where to start a pod on
worker nodes we have the control manager
so the detect states change it so like
if the pod crashes it it tells it to
restart you have xcd or etcd however you
want to call this is a key value store
that stores the save the cluster so
controller manager highly relies on etsy
and you have cubelet so this allows
users to interact with the node via the
cube ctl because cubelet no matter if
it's a worker node or control plane node
it's on both of them and so you know
generally
all of these are in the cube system i
really should have wrote this in the
course but they're in the cube system
namespace
and uh the components that can be in the
control play node slightly vary so maybe
instead of the control controller
manager you'd have the cloud controller
manager if you're using something like
k3s they probably have slightly
different control plane um components
inside of them but you generally need to
know for the exam what is in a control
plane so know know what these all are
and know that they are in the control
plane and not in the worker nodes
all right so now onto the worker nodes
the worker nodes will have cubelet so
all
all nodes will have a cubelet for
communication
and that's the way it will talk to
container runtime we'll talk about the
second and then you'll have a proxy
and so we'll have container runtimes
pods and containers so just kind of an
illustration there so
why is there a proxy and why is there a
cubelet
well the proxy
actually you know what i don't think i
have it here but
what's missing over here
is core dns okay so generally we'd also
have i can't believe i have it missing
but you'd have core dns i have it in
another slide so it's not a big deal so
we should really have that here as well
but i suppose it doesn't talk directly
to the api server but
proxy is
what is used when you have incoming
traffic right so i'm a user i use your
website and how am i reaching that pod
well it's going to be through the dns
service coordinates or
cube dns and then that's going to go
through the proxy the proxy is going to
go through ip tables which we'll talk
about in this course and it will reach
the application around the container if
we're trying to interact with our
container programmatically through cube
ctl it's going to go through cubelet and
that's going to go through the container
runtime into the container
so again if it doesn't click right now
it's okay we're going to cover this in
different variations here and you will
know it but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at probably the
most important component
pods so pods are the smallest unit in
kubernetes and pods abstract away the
container layer so you can directly
interact with kubernetes layer in my
mind the smallest unit really is
containers but
i guess they're talking about like
newly defined components that are part
of kubernetes
okay
and so here is that graphic there uh and
so a pod is intended to run one
application in multiple containers so
notice down below that we have one two
three four containers
they're all running the same app like
the same app over and over again
now uh so that the idea here is a pod
would be a database pod a job pod a
front app pod a back-end pod pod um and
what we could say is is if we use the
term service like the way we're supposed
to a service would define a continuously
running
type of application so you could say
database service job service front-end
service we talked about microservices
that's how we describe it but that's the
idea there you can run multiple apps in
a pod but those containers will be
tightly dependent i don't even know how
to do that but the idea is if you wanted
these all to be slightly different you
could but
i i again i have no idea how to do that
i don't know why you would do that
so each pod gets its own private ip
address so look up here there's an ip
address
and containers will run on different
ports so nodes here 3000 3001 8080 81
containers can talk to each other via
local host so if you have a container
i will just clear on out this uh eraser
stuff if container one wants to talk to
container two all it has to do is talk
to it on its port number on its own
localhost and that is how simple
communication is from container
container communication which we'll talk
about because we have a whole section on
different types of cluster communication
each pod can have a shared storage
volume attached all containers will
share the same volume so the idea here
is you see this line here drawn to the
pod to a persistent volume apv
and we talk about persistent volumes and
persistent volume claims we'll get to
that later when the last remaining
container dies or maybe crashes in a pod
so does the pod
but when replacement pods is created the
pod will have a
new ip address that will be assigned so
ip addresses are a
i never can say that right efferent
or temporary for pods so they don't
by default persist and that's why we're
going to need kubernetes services which
we will talk about in this course so to
get pods and show their ip addresses
it's very common you'll type in get pod
get pods and then doing this hyphen o
wide
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at the api
server now we saw a graphic of it
uh when we were looking at the control
plane versus worker nodes so we don't
need another graphic here and i think a
lot of this text i grabbed direct from
kubernetes.io because i'm just trying to
get you through the key points of it um
so this part's a little bit boring but
let's get to it so the core of
kubernetes control plane is the api
server the api server exposes http api
that lets the end users different parts
of your cluster external components
communicate with one another
cube api lets you query and manipulate
the state of api objects and kubernetes
like pause namespaces config maps events
the api server is a component of
kubernetes control plane that exposes
the kubernetes api the api server is the
front end of the kubernetes control
plane the main implementation of
kubernetes api is cube api server cube
api server is designed to scale
horizontally that is it scales by
deploying more instances you can run
several instances in cube api server and
balance traffic between those instances
everything has to go through the api
server you can interact in the uh with
the api server in three ways so the ui
api and a cli like cube ctl now i put an
asterisk on ui because i don't know what
they're talking about there the only
thing you have is the kubernetes
dashboard which is something that is
optional to launch
and um i mean you can't really launch
resources in the kubernetes dashboard
so i don't know what they're trying to
say there but technically if you are
interacting with kubernetes
uh via the api server it's going to go
to the api so i guess in that sense it
is
in terms of like how it scales and stuff
i don't really know i don't know how to
observe that directly in there but
apparently it just does it and hopefully
that gives you an idea a little bit more
information about the api server
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at deployments in
kubernetes so a deployment provides
declarative updates for pods and replica
sets so deployment controller
changes the actual state to the desired
state of at a controlled rate and the
default deployment controller can be
swapped out for other deployment tools
like argo cd flux and jenkins so
what i'm saying there is that uh
deployment is built in to kubernetes so
you don't have to install a third-party
tool but generally you want to because
the the tool there is very limited it
doesn't do git ops and so that's why
you'll want things like argo flux and
jenkin x which we will talk about more
when we get to our deployment section of
this course
notice at the top here i say pods and
replica sets but in reality a deployment
is always deploying a replica set and so
even if you're just deploying one pod
it's going to be a replica set of one
so here
is the actual
manifest file of doing a deployment
you're going to be seeing a lot of these
manifest files through the course it's
going to be kind and then the type right
so deployment and then generally i think
usually yeah then no i guess spec is
just for deployments but uh and pods and
things like that and so here spec is our
pod spec file which we'll talk about
later here it says replicas so it's
going to create a replica set with three
pods in it
and then down below here you can see uh
the container that we are going to be
deploying
for these three pods so we'll end up
with three containers so here is a
graphical example
or architectural diagram of the
deployment controller and so this one in
particular is using flux okay and so the
idea here is you have deployment it goes
to the deployment controller the default
one or whichever one you install deploys
your replica set
and that's how you get your pods
so a deployment defines the desired
state of replica sets and pods a
deployment will create and manage a
replica set
a replica set will manage replicas of
pods so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at replica sets
so replica set is a way to maintain a
desired amount of redundant pods
replicas to provide a guarantee of
availability so here's a replica set and
inside of it we have multiple pods or
you could say replica pods one could be
the main pod just who knows right
because when you distribute traffic to
them like with a service it's just
random where it goes so they're
basically all replica pods here is the
manifest file notice that it's called a
replica set and it looks just like a
deployment you specify the replicas
you're specifying the containers
okay
the pod field metadata owner references
determines the link from a pod to a
replica set
uh so
that we would have to observe that on
the pod itself so if we went
using the cube ctl and we said cube ctl
describe pod in the pod name we would
see that metadata there and that's how
we would know that it's linked to that
replica set
it is not recommended to directly create
replica sets so you can
but instead a deployment can create and
manage replicate sets for you the idea
here is that if you launch a replica set
and then you delete it it's gone now if
you delete a replica set i believe that
a deployment will say hey your replica
set's gone it will spin up another one
okay same thing like if you have a
replica set and you have three pods in
it you delete
your pods then your pods might reappear
okay so horizontal pod autoscaler can be
used to auto scale replica sets
and we'll talk about that when we get to
hpa okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're comparing stateless versus stathal
very important concept we need to know
in kubernetes but also just when
building applications when we're running
them in more than a single
virtual machine or compute because we
might want to
have a version of our application in
multiple um data centers across multiple
regions
and so how do you handle that when a
user goes to the website
but then it goes to a another server how
does it knows the same same person or
does that matter so
we're talking about stateless the idea
here is that every request so like a web
request to the server
does not care it forgets about the
previous or current state that's what we
mean by stateless so think of a goldfish
that you know
has poor memory then uh the idea with
staples every request relies on state
data to remember uh so very uh a good
example would be a database a database
you have to know who it is every time uh
like if you were to
have 10 requests in a row accessing data
uh it has to go to the same um database
the same place so that we know who it is
so think of
an elephant okay so for web applications
it's not that they don't have a state
it's just that the state is stored
outside the context of the web app
running on the virtual machine and so
that state will be pushed to something
like a database or cookies which are
are stateful but the web apps themselves
are stateless so those http requests
come to the servers uh the server does
not uh know if it's from the same person
this time around or other it just does
not matter
now that's not to say that web apps
can't be stateful
they are if they are on a single machine
and so the problem with a lot of people
with monoliths is that when they build
them they do store the state on a single
machine they might store it in memory
and that's where we run into problems
because then it makes it really hard to
scale out to multiple machines so that's
a pattern that we generally want to
break so that we can move into a
microservice architecture or at least
an architecture where we can run our
monolith on more than one machine so
when we're talking about stateful
imagine you have a database so you have
a primary database and then you have a
second version of your database but it's
only for read replicas the state here
has to remember
who can do writes and reads and who can
do reads right because in the primary
database you can always do writes but
the rewrite only do reads and so it has
to remember that state data so hopefully
that makes sense but anyway the weight
ties to kubernetes
is
stateless is where we will use replica
sets as that's where you would launch
your applications with and stateful sets
is where you would use things for like a
database if you wanted to run it in
cluster okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at stateful sets now
this is one of the few things in this
course that i'm not doing
a follow along with i'm not showing you
it hands-on because it's so hard to do
and it's out of the scope of the kcna
and generally it's recommended not to
run your databases
uh in cluster but using managed service
so for those reasons i'll just provide
the information here so you generally
have uh the know-how now that doesn't
mean that you will never have to do it
there might be some cases
but again it's just out of the scope of
this course so stateful sets are used
when you need traffic to be sent to
specific pods and the thing with staple
sets is they will always have a unique
and predictable name and address
ordinal index numbers assigned to each
pod like zero one two three four five
a persistent volume attached with a
persistent link from pod to storage
if a pod is rescheduled the original
persistent volume will be mounted to
insert data integrity consistency
because that's how you ensure state
stateful set pods will always start in
the same order and terminate in reverse
order
so that's really important
now in order to implement stateful sets
it will require to use a headless
service
to manage identities headless services
were really really really confusing i
can't tell you how much time i spent to
try to make sense of them but what i
figured out is that
headless services
are generally
used because of stateful sets so there
is a headless server service used to
maintain the network identity of the
pods and another service that provides
read access to the pods and i have an
architectural diagram we'll walk through
it so here's an example of a stateful
set i'm going to get my pen out here you
can see there's a lot going on here but
we have stateful set at the top
okay and then there it kind of looks
like a deploy so you have a match
selectors to
match to something the replicas like how
many do you want to run
um and where it kind of varies is that
it has a mounted volume so it's not like
you can't mount a volume to
a um
you know a deployment replica set what
have you but staple sets would have a
volume because they're usually for
databases so you definitely would want
uh to have a volume attached there so
that here is my big fancy
diagram and so i have some accompanying
text here that is from the documentation
and so what i'll do is read it up to you
and then try to figure out how it
matches up to the diagram so the first
thing is when we're looking about staple
sets we have a dns host name for rights
so rights will be i'm sorry i got to set
up this scenario here if you look here
what we have is a stateful set and it's
a postgres database
being deployed in cluster okay
so
the first thing is for our
staple set of a pro square database is
that rights will be directed to the main
pod
by its dns host name which is identified
by the headless service so uh
you know you have in your web
application someone wants to write to
the database so the idea is that in
order for us to know where this main pod
is we need this headless service so that
we get a dns record and so here's it
says main.psq
because we can't rely on ip address we
need to rely on that domain name or that
dns record so that's what it will do to
help it get there
then the idea is we have cluster ip for
read so for read traffic it can be
redistributed or distributed to all the
reading pods using the cluster ip
service now this part of the course we
haven't covered all the different
service types so when you
if you find this confusing what you
should do is watch the whole services
section when you get to it and then come
back to this and look at this because it
is pretty darn complicated to be honest
um but anyway so
the idea here is that when we want to do
a read
we use a um
a regular service like we would cluster
ip that's the default one and that by
default uh does load balancing at random
so here it doesn't matter because both
the pods uh can read and so you'll
either go to the main pod or the read
replica
then you have the headless server so the
headless service is a service with
cluster ip set to none
and it does not provide load balancing
it doesn't it does not provide a static
ip address a headless service is used to
identify specific pods by signing them
dns records that's all it does it gives
a nice dns record so that we can
identify uh what pod to send to okay
i have those services required in order
to uh for a stable set to work and i've
said that a few times here then we have
our pvc and our pv so
persistent volume claim and persistent
volume again we haven't reached that
section yet of the course but we will
but the idea is that
we do need to have some kind of storage
because it is a database
and we said earlier in the previous
slide that
you'd want to retain that information so
if this main pod was destroyed and then
a one was to take its place this same
volume here would get matched up it
wouldn't match up to some other random
volume it would ensure that this one
matches with the main pod so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at kubernetes
namespaces so a namespace is a way to
logically isolate resources within a
kubernetes cluster and so namespaces can
be organized based on project department
or any user defining group and so if
we're using cube ctl it's cube ctl get
namespace or ns for short but you
generally get the idea with these get
commands it's always get whatever you
want kubernetes starts with four initial
namespaces there's the default one so
this is just where your stuff is going
to end up
if you create anything without
specifying a namespace you have cube
public these are for resources that are
publicly visible and readable you have
cube system this is a namespace that
stores objects
stores objects created by the kubernetes
systems or we say objects it's pretty
much pods
okay
and so engineers deploying applications
are not supposed to touch this namespace
we say not supposed to
let's say we're using adabus eks to
deploy our managed kubernetes cluster
over there they might tell you to
if you want to have an ingress
controller and use
the load balancer with aws you would
then
for that one case
create a controller ingress or
ingress controller for aws in that
namespace so it's not that it's it never
happens but it rarely should it be done
and the cube system namespace is one
we'll see throughout this course because
every opportunity when we use a new
managed
kubernetes provider or a different
lightweight distribution i will always
look at all the stuff and show you
what's q in cube system so you have an
idea what's running on the cluster then
you have cube node lease so this holds
lease objects associated with each node
it's used to detect node failures by
sending heartbeats and so you can create
your own name sources by doing cubectl
create namespace and the namespace here
would be we're calling it production so
in clusters with a small amount of
resources namespaces aren't necessary
but it's up to you if you want to use
them you can use them
but the great thing about namespaces is
that you can apply um like network
policies and other kind of uh
permissions so if you have role-based
access controls you can say only give
access to stuff in this
namespace so um for me i would probably
always just create a namespace but they
say you don't have to might complicate
things so names of resources you need to
be unique with a namespace but not
across namespaces
they're talking about objects themselves
so like if you have a pod it um and you
call it
my app it can be my app in a bunch of
them right
namespace based scoping is applicable
only for namespace objects so deployment
services things like that
uh but not for cluster-wide objects
storage class nodes persistent volumes
so what we're talking about is there's
um certain objects we're saying objects
we're talking about components
i don't know sometimes the docs say
components sometimes the doxate objects
but the idea is that certain kubernetes
components
can be namespace and some of them can't
be so that's something that we need to
know so there are
objects or components kubernetes
components that can only reside in a
single name space there's ones that are
multi-name space so there's ones that
are clustered wide so they can never
live in a namespace so example of single
namespace objects are config maps and
secrets they cannot be shared across
namespaces they exist in one okay so
config maps and secrets then you have uh
services and pods which can belong to
multiple namespaces
um and then for cluster wide we have
volumes and nodes they do not exist in
namespaces they are just in the cluster
now i don't know the exhaustive list of
all the objects are there's probably
some way to look it up i never did but
these are the ones that you need to
remember and just realize that there are
three different kinds of buckets okay so
you can apply a system quota
restrictions on namespaces to avoid
overusage like memory compute so that's
an example of
leveraging namespaces to put limitations
uh like security restrictions things
like that if you don't provide a
namespace for a component it will end up
in the default namespace as we already
said but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to talk about entry
versus outreach so these were terms that
i kept on seeing when i was looking up
different um
cncf projects
and uh the term varied so there was no
consistency with the way this term was
used and so i'm kind of imposing my own
terminology to help us understand what
it is uh and i can tell you right away
like i was talking to some kubernetes
folks and they were dead set that it
meant one particular thing but i just
couldn't reconcile it because i was just
seeing it used in different ways so just
understand that this is my own personal
opinion it's a way to help you just kind
of contextualize it even if it's not
perfectly accurate
so in cloud native projects you'll hear
the term entry in out tree so
here is a little uh forest here to i
don't know have a visual but entry the
way i describe it is plugins components
or functionality that are provided by
default or
or doesn't mean they have to but or they
reside in the main repository so think
of entry as internal plug-ins things
that come by default with the project
then you have out of tree so plugins
components or functionality that must be
installed manually and extends or
replaces the default behavior so think
of out of tree as external plug-ins and
again this is my own definition that
some people are not going to agree with
me on um but this is the best way i
understand it
um but yeah we'll maybe we'll take a
look at something where you know i see
this in trio tree stuff okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're just trying to find the
example of entry versus out tree and so
i remember seeing this under coron dns
it's for a variety of projects but if
you go to core dns which we cover in
this course it's a gns server that comes
by default with kubernetes which
replaced uh cube dns i believe and so if
you were click to if you were to click
through to the website you almost the
top it says plugins and then external
plugins
okay and if we go to github and that's
not always the case but sometimes when
you are in a github repository and this
is where i consider the repository to be
a tree because um it's a nest of folders
or you could say it's a directory tree a
folder tree so within our
folder tree here we have plugin and here
is a bunch of plugins that would be
considered
in tree for this
project so if we go back to core dns
things that are out of tree are external
plugins
which to me those are just plugins but
um you know these are all plugins that
are not part of the repository again
entry doesn't mean it has to be in the
repository it just means that it ships
with it by default and these do not ship
by default you have to do extra things
to get them in
uh so hopefully you know that helps you
with that definition or where i'm coming
with that again we could find tons of
examples of this but this is the one i'm
just showing you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at endpoints
and endpoint slices so endpoints track
the ip addresses of the pods assigned to
a kubernetes service if that's confusing
just give us a moment we got a graphic
okay so
when a service selector matches a pod
label the pod ip address is added to the
pool of endpoints so pods expose
themselves to services
via endpoints okay so
here's the graphic that i'm talking
about so the idea here is that we have a
service right and
we learned that services are used to
load balance to multiple pods
but the question is how does a service
link to a pod and that answer is
endpoints all right so remember each pod
has a dynamic ip address so the idea is
that you are storing the dynamic ip
address in endpoints okay
and they exist in like this endpoint
pool
all right so it's the connection between
services and pods and
rarely rarely do you ever have to
manipulate these or do anything with the
end points okay but if you want you can
do cube ctl and get those endpoints
now there's this concept of endpoint
slices so endpoint slices break up
endpoints into smaller manageable
segments and each endpoint slice has a
limit of 100 pods
so
why like why do we care about endpoints
and endpoint slices well according to
the documentation it it's when you're
scaling out uh there is a cap on
endpoints like the amount of endpoints
you can have in a service and so that's
where you run into scaling issues and
then
that's why you need endpoint slices
and also the term endpoint just comes up
in the documentation all the time and
endpoints is a general term
meaning uh like when we talk about apis
an endpoint would be like you
point your request your http request to
an address or an ip address and that
could be called an endpoint i just kind
of wanted to clear that up so that you
knew that endpoint was a very particular
thing in kubernetes and we're not just
saying the general word endpoint okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at jobs and cron jobs
and before we can describe that we need
to describe what is a background job so
a background job is a one-off task that
is used to run a piece of code or a
function
and they're commonly used to perform
maintenance or to trigger a
computational workload so an example
could be to back up the database every x
minute so like every 30 minutes delete
all users who not have not confirmed
their email basically you could trigger
any kind of code but the idea is that uh
you know
they're in jobs right
so a job creates one or more pods that
will continue to retry execution of the
pods until a specified number of them
successfully terminate so an example
here would do cube ctl create job we're
saying the job's named hello
and we are using busybox which is
something we will talk about in this
course
to just do an echo hello a cron job is
just like a job but it executes based on
a repeating schedule and so a cron job
uses um this
uh kron tab expression or cron
expression so this i'm not sure what it
says maybe every minute
this will run every hour i'm terrible
chronic branches
quran expressions
but a very very common um
use case for jobs is that you want it
for long running tasks
so it doesn't hang up your main
application and a very common use case
is sending off emails so you wouldn't
hang the main thread of your main app
you would run it in an isolate job
there okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i just want to talk about the
kubernetes dashboards the kubernetes
dashboard is an open source application
you can deploy to your cluster to
provide a ui to view kubernetes
components and so it looks like this so
when i was first using kubernetes i was
doing it on aws and i launched up um a
cluster on amazon eks or aws cks
whatever they want to call it
and uh there i couldn't see anything i
was just like where's all the stuff
where's the ui
um and so i was kind of disappointed i
thought maybe it was offering wasn't
very good or maybe kubernetes just
doesn't have an interface but then i
realized um that they just have this ui
thing and you can launch it on any
provider that you want and it's very
easy it's like a one-liner but even with
um lightweight distributions like um
minicube or micro k8 s you can literally
just write like enable dashboard you'll
get one
and so you can click around and you can
see
um all the kubernetes components that
are running in your cluster and i just
noticed that there's like this create
button here at the top because i was
when i'm going through the follow alongs
i
can't seem to find a way to create
resources so that it's possible that you
can create stuff there and also when we
were talking about earlier um
about api server it says interacting
with the ui and i and i was saying like
renee's bat dashboard doesn't let you
create stuff so maybe i just haven't
noticed this button here so maybe it is
uh able to create resources there but i
want you to to know about it and it's
part of the kubernetes project
so it's not like it's a third party it's
totally safe to install
and use but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at selectors so
selectors are a way of selecting one or
more kubernetes objects remember objects
could be pods
objects is also could be generalized as
meaning kubernetes components so in
kubernetes there are three types of
selectors so we have label selectors so
selects kubernetes objects based on the
applied label and so this is the example
or the type of selector we're going to
heavily focus on
in this course but the idea here is that
you have your selector and we're saying
match on
all pods that have the key environment
with the with the
value
production and so then it selects only
those pods you have field selectors so
select kubernetes object space on the
object data like metadata or status we
have node selectors so select nodes for
very specific plot placement let's take
a look at what we do when we apply
labels so labor select label selectors
to find labels as key value pairs
probably have a slash there under
metadata in the manifest file so notice
here it says metadata and then there is
our label this is the key this is the
value as you can see we can have
multiple
[Music]
labels okay so on the worker node here
we have
for example
this one says env prod and then it says
app engine x web just to kind of match
up what that means there so you can use
the hyphen show labels to see all labels
so here's an example for pods and this
will work for a variety of different
kubernetes objects you can apply labels
with the label command
so you can do cube ctl label pods apache
web owner equals devops so you can do it
here in the manifest file or you can do
it here on the fly
i always do it in the manifest file i
never do it on the fly
um but you know i just want to make sure
you are aware of all those options
okay
[Music]
let's take a look at recommended labels
so these are recommended labels that
should be applied to every single
resource or resource object and so i say
should in parentheses
because in practicality most people
aren't doing this
so let's take a look at what is
recommended so we have name
instance version component part of
managed by created by their
self-explanatory
um
and so just note
that the prefix of the the
key here has this
app.kubernetes.io and then name so this
is the key right so remember there's a
key and a value for labels and so labels
can have forward slashes and they can
have dots in them so just be aware that
they can get kind of funky there
but if you had a label without a prefix
like the app.um kubernetes.io
then these are considered private to
users okay so just understand
that one caveat so here is what it would
look like if you applied all of those
labels and again i've never seen that
happen
i mean i'm sure it happens that people
are like packaging things for like helm
and stuff like that
because people are going to be ingesting
them and people are
usually are a bit better about that but
when you're building your own stuff you
might not be doing that at all okay but
one i definitely do said is the name so
that's something that i will do quite
often
[Music]
so we looked at applying labels but how
do we actually select labels
so kubernetes objects like
services or replica sets can target pods
based on label selectors you have to use
them otherwise it doesn't know
uh like a service will not know what pod
to associate with same with replica sets
and so here we have an example where
we're doing selector and then it's the
key and the value on a service and then
this one is for a replica set notice
that the selector syntax varies for
different templates or we could say
different kinds of kubernetes objects so
this one says match labels and this one
doesn't have it just has a selector like
that
um you can use the selector in the cube
ctl as well so you just do hyphen hyphen
selector or use its alias hyphen l so
here is an example where you are
selecting all the pods or things like
that so it's not necessarily that it has
to be for a service or replica set you
can even do it uh that way if you're
just trying to
grab resources that have labels and and
see them okay
let's talk about annotations which seem
very similar to labels but they're not
they're something else so kubernetes
annotations allow you to attach
arbitrary non-identifying metadata
to objects
so clients like tools or libraries can
and may require this annotation
in order to work
a good example here is ingress so this
often uses annotation to communicate
ingress controllers
so here we have
um
an ingress
kubernetes ingress and so it needs to
communicate to an ingress controller and
this one is specifically for nginx and
so it always expects this rewrite target
thing in here
when you look at different ingress
controllers like aws they have some
different ones
and it just varies
so that's the only use case i've seen
for annotations i'm sure they show up
somewhere else but that's all i've seen
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at a pod spec
file so pod spec is a configuration file
that describes
a pod so that seems pretty clear
remember all files are manifest files
especially if they look like yaml for
kubernetes
but here is an example of us
defining a pod but notice that it says
spec down here below
so the spec section is what we care
about and that's what makes it a pod
spec file and i want you to know that
this spec thing can show up in a service
or sorry a component that is a
kind of pod or deployment or a replica
set
uh probably also a stateful set so just
realize that's what i mean when i say
pod spec file we're talking about
this section here
so
the idea is you can define multiple
containers and you'll have the name of
the container the image here which is
nginx
the command to run on startup could be
an option it's not shown here
the port the container will operate on
the restart policy which again we don't
have it displayed here
and a variety of other things so you can
directly deploy a pod with cube ctl
apply command as we see here so it's
showing a pod but in practice you won't
directly deploy pause instead you'll use
deployments or job as the kind
so in some um uh follow alongs you will
see people deploy pods just because they
just don't want to deal with deployment
because they want to be able to delete
the pod and the pod not to spin back up
again
um but yeah you rarely ever would
never would ever make sense to deploy
pod without deployment okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we are looking at grpc
uh before we understand what grpc is we
need to know what our pc is so that
stands for remote procedure call and
this is a framework of communication in
distributed systems it allows one
program on a machine to communicate
with a program on a remote machine
without knowing that it's remote and the
concept of rpc has been around since the
1970s so grpc is
much newer it's a modern open source
high performance rpc framework that can
run in any environment and grpc was
initially created by google
so you can kind of think of grpc as an
alternate method of communication
instead of rest or graphql
and it can connect services in and
across data centers with plugable
support for load balancing
tracing health checking authentication
uh and probably more
so let's try to take a look at how this
actually works so the idea is you'll be
installing a grpc library
for your program you'll be defining a
protobuf file that describes the data
structure
and those files usually have a dot
proto extension you'll be writing code
that works with grpc
so distributed systems like kubernetes
uses grpc for pod communication and so
that's kind of the example and honestly
i was a bit lazy here with grpc because
i probably could have showed you code
examples and stuff like that but with
kubernetes you're never really touching
grpc it's just there
um and my experience with grpc is i used
it when i was using something called
nats
n-a-t-s
not to be confused with nat network
address translation that's is a
an event bus that
requires grpc these protobuf files but
you know even though i don't have it
here the idea is that
you would have a file it's it has its
own syntax but it's a file that defines
the structure of communication
and then you implement
in your chosen language like ruby or
android
how to
um uh
like you load that structure into a like
using your standard library so you can
read it so it basically
you define
the payload
in a structure and then you have files
that read it um but anyway if you ever
use an event bus you come across these
things
um and there's something kind of similar
to it it might be g you might be using
protobuffer but
uh it is like an aws um the abs event
bus with
um to remember what's called eventbridge
so that's something that's similar there
but you know for this i'm not going to
get into those examples and show you
because you're never going to touch it
at least
i've never seen anyone have to touch
unless you're developing something for a
project but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at cubelet so
cubelet is responsible for pod internal
api communication via the api server and
cubelet is a node agent that runs on
every single node
that includes both control plane and
worker
nodes
and i know this because i took extra
care to know because i wasn't sure for
quite a while if it actually ran on the
control plane but it does so what is an
agent well an agent is a program
installed on a server to obscure what
occurs for specific programs and to
communicate information externally or
trigger actions to be performed sounds
kind of uh very interesting um so
here's an example of a cube
where is it cubelet so here's our
cubelet and notice that it's on inside
of our worker node
so cuba performs the following tasks it
watches for pod changes
uh configures container runtimes to pull
images create namespaces and run
containers and cubelet uses podspec
files to determine what images to pull
and containers to run so notice we have
this pod spec file there and then it
knows to deploy that container into that
container runtime but we are going to go
even a bit deeper so we can see this
because i have another
diagram that i created here uh to try to
make it even more clear and interesting
and now you'll see why we covered grpc
so here's grpc in a few different places
to show that that's where that
communication is happening so for pods
cubelet will continuously monitor pods
for any kind of changes okay that's how
we know something's happened in the pods
is because of cubelet cubelet will send
back https requests to the api server
containers
sorry container logs and execution
requests so the logging information from
your pods uh cubelet's the one that
sends that stuff along
um for storage cubelet can interact with
storage through the container storage
interface csi using grpc uh very few
diagrams were actually show off um cloud
storage interface cloud runtime
interface and cloud networking interface
so this is the this is the very
important diagram showing you those
integrations between all that stuff
and notice it's communicating using grpc
cubelet can interact with the container
runtime interface
also using grpc
and so remember we said that a pod spec
file
is deployed to um
a container and has to go through the
container runtime and the reason i show
uh the container networking interface
over here is just to show you that it's
not cubelet this is just another route
into the container runtime okay so there
we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at cubectl
probably the most important thing when
we're learning kubernetes because we use
it so much so cubectl is a command line
interface tool that lets you control
kubernetes clusters so the idea is
cubectl is a program where you run you
write in commands into your
bash bash terminal and it will send http
request to the api server onto the
kubernetes components or objects if you
prefer to call them that and cubectl
looks for a file named config in the
home directory so notice it says dollar
sign home
so that's usually the same thing as
writing a tilde in linux if you write a
like cd tilde it usually goes to home
okay
and that will be in the dot cube
directory and then even though it
doesn't show here be like forward slash
config
and we cover config in a very
uh granular detail in this course uh but
that's during follow alongs i don't know
if i actually make a slide on it so cube
ctl has the following syntax
the idea is we have cube ctl then we
have command type name and flags so
let's cover all of these
parts okay so the first is command so
command is the operation you want to
perform
and so here you can see example where
we're doing copy
so the available commands we have is
annotation so key value data that can be
applied to resources
apply so executes manifest files to
create and modify kubernetes resources
this one we use a lot
we have auth so inspect
if you are authorized to perform an
action and we do show you this one in
the course when we're doing role-based
access controls to say am i allowed to
perform these actions under a particular
user when we're setting up their
permissions
auto scale so it creates an autoscaler
that automatically chooses the set
number of pods that run in a cluster we
definitely covered that in this course
cp copy files directories to and from
containers actually we didn't do that in
this course in the in the labs but
it's not too hard to figure out how to
do that
create so
create specific kubernetes cluster level
resources
most times we're using apply because it
creates and modify but in some cases you
just never modify particular objects so
i guess in some cases we use create but
a lot of times you can you just use the
word apply instead
delete so delete resource files uh file
names
s-t-a-s-t-d-ins resources and names by
resources and label selects we use
delete all the time describe show
details of specific resources we use
that one a lot as well diff
the online configuration with local
configs i don't think i've never ran
that once but uh yeah so there you go
for commands oh wait there's more
we got edit so edit resource from the
default editor
execute so execute command with a
container we definitely use that one a
lot expose expose a resource as a
kubernetes service that one we use a lot
too get so generally used to get the
status of an existing kubernetes
resource similar to describe but
not as detailed
cause to my so print a set of api
resources generated from instructions to
customization yaml we don't do that in
this course but we we do
cover what customizes
label so update labels on a resource
logs so print the logs of a container in
a pot or a specific resource patch so
update fields of a resource using
strategic merge patch a json merge patch
or json patch
and i mean you can do this i just never
patch i would just update a file and
then do an apply port forward we
definitely use that quite a few times in
this course so forward one or more local
ports to a pod
proxy creates a proxy server between
local localhost and the kubernetes api
server
i'm just going to wipe a bit of this
away here run so create and run
a container image in a pod scale so
setting new size of a deployment replica
set replication controller staple set we
cover scale when we do auto scale
then we have our type so type is the
resource type you want to command so
this could be deployments
resource types can have abbreviations
so you might type in deployments or you
might just type and deploy same thing
with persistent volumes might be pv
pods might be p o
uh and i think it will also take pod as
well so a lot of times i'll just forget
to write it with the s on pod and it
still seems to work so here is the same
example this and this is identical and
i'm pointing this out because when i was
doing the exam for the kcna
i would see
code and you do see
cube ctl commands we have to pick the
right one
and i got mixed up because i thought
maybe like deploy wasn't an actual
command because i just kept seeing
deployment when i watched
tutorials and i learned stuff
so just realize that
if you see a word and you know that
there's an object like
a persistent volume you see pv
uh you know you can pretty much guess
that it is it exists i don't think in
the exam they would just
make up a term like try to trick you up
by taking a name and like dropping the s
and
having to guess okay
there are over
50 plus resource types so here you can
see them all
they don't all have a abbreviations
but you pretty much learn the ones you
need to learn so like ing is a common
one
sc storage class pv
pvc
i never write pod to just write the full
thing there
um so yeah there's a lot of them but you
just learn the ones you need to learn
okay
then you have the name so the name
specifies the name of the resource so
here we have pod and notice we can
actually provide not just one but two so
sometimes they take multiples these are
case sensitive so just be aware of that
if the name is omitted details for all
the resources are displayed and very
common
it's very common like if i only have
a single resource so if i create a
single pod i know a single pod a lot of
times i'll just write cubesat till get
pods or describe pods because for
describe because i know it's only going
to show the one and i do that a lot in
this course
but often when you have a lot more
you'll be specifying the name
flags
specify optional flags um a flag is a
concept for commit like command line
interfaces you see them all the time
it's this double hyphen followed by
something here now you don't have to
provide an equals between um the flag
and its value
um but sometimes i do sometimes i don't
when i do and don't it's just random but
you'll see me do that throughout the
course some command line interfaces are
sensitive
cube ctl is not you can either have
equals or not
flags generally start with two hyphens
and i know you can't see but there are
two hyphens here it's just the font uh
group them together
sometimes flags have abbreviations with
a single hyphen so double double or
sorry a hyphen hyphen server is the same
as hyphen s
and so you know some people just don't
want to type as much so they'll use the
abbreviated ones
available flags will vary based on
commands uh sometimes flags can be
assigned values
uh or do not expect a value at all okay
so
um yeah
there you go oh just one more thing for
cube ctl there is really good
documentation it isn't uh
straightforward how to find it so i just
had to point it out that you go to
kubernetes i o four slash docs four
slash reference four slash generator
four slash coupe ctl cube ctl commands
uh if you google cube ctl
uh kubernetes
it's usually the second link and so what
i do when i'm looking at google is i
just like carefully look for this one
underneath because if you get here it
has so many examples it's really really
useful okay
[Music]
all right just because it's so tricky to
find the cube ctl documentation i just
wanted to show you so i typed in cube
ctl commands
and if you were to click the first one
you would end up at the cheat sheets and
the cheat sheets are kind of okay
but what's a lot better are the commands
and now if i go this one i don't know if
it goes oh it does right there but
usually i'll click on this one here to
get to it
okay but for whatever reason the cheat
sheets are above the commands
and the commands show you
everything so
if i want to
apply something
we could click apply might have some sub
ones there
you can go and see a bunch of different
examples here
so
that will help you out quite a bit when
figuring out how to use cube ctl
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at mini
cube so it sets up a local single node
kubernetes cluster on mac os linux
windows for learning purposes and in
particular minicube is actually setting
up a virtual machine and then running a
control plane and worker processes uh
within docker as the container
layer so um that's one key thing is that
it runs in a virtual machine where we'll
see other ones they uh operate a little
bit differently but minicube is very
popular because it's just super super
easy to use it's not my favorite i like
micro k8s but let's talk about some of
the benefits so supports the latest
kubernetes release cross platform
deploys as a vm a container or on bare
metal multiple container run times a
docker api endpoint for blazing fast
image pushes advanced features such as
load balancer file system mounts
feature gates add-ons for easily
installed kubernetes applications
supports common ci
environments so continuous integration
and so that's kind of example of
starting up a mini cube and you can see
it's kind of pretty so it gives you an
idea how easy it is to use
[Music]
all right let's talk about another
lightweight distribution uh k3s and k3d
so k3s is a lightweight tool designed to
run
production level kubernetes workloads
for low resource and remotely located
iot and edge devices and bare metal uh
it was originally created by rancher it
is a sandbox cncf project um so you know
like you can use it for testing if you
want there's no reason uh you can't
but it is a little bit more work uh to
utilize um but it's just considered a
lightweight distribution right so
a few differences is that
k3s does not use cubelet but it runs
cubelet on the host machine and uses the
host scheduling mechanism to run
containers k3s uses cube proxy to proxy
the network connection to nodes as
opposed to k uh kubernetes which uh uses
q proxy to proxy network connections of
an individual container uh k3s has a
tighter security deployment than uh
kubernetes because of their small attack
plane surface
and also one point the only way you'd
have a backing store was with sql lite
but now apparently you can use
a like a miniaturized version of fcd um
so the idea is that um k3s has some
advantages but comes with some
limitations you'll need to investigate
for yourself whether it makes sense to
use k3s for your use case we're talking
about production use case but for
testing and development you can use it
but just understand that you are
developing on a different distribution
okay it's not it's not going to be
similar uh to um
full-blown kubernetes okay so then
there's k3d and so this is a platform
agnostic lightweight wrapper that runs
uh k3s in a docker container because the
one above runs in virtual machines and
so if you want to run this in a docker
container use k3d it helps run scale
run and scale single or multi-node k3s
clusters quickly without further setup
while maintaining a high availability
mode right i guess i said virtual
machines above but really the above one
is actually bare metal i suppose you're
like right on a machine not necessarily
even with a virtual machine so i really
should have said that instead
straight onto hardware but that is k3s
and
k3d
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at kind and so
kind is another lightweight distribution
but it's primarily designed to test
kubernetes uh and it helps you run
kubernetes clusters locally in a cic ci
pipeline using docker's container as
nodes so it looks very similar
to minicube but you know the key
difference here is that it's using
docker containers so it is an open
source cncf certified kubernetes
installer that supports highly available
multi-node clusters and builds
kubernetes release build from its source
um and so you know some people like mini
cubes some people like kind i personally
like micro
kubernetes but it's just another tool
and we will give it a go and you'll see
it in action
um in the fall lungs okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at micro kubernetes
or micro k8s uh depending on how you
like to say it so um before we talk
about that let's talk about a few other
things like ubuntu so ubuntu is a linux
distribution based on debian i'm going
to explain why this makes sense here in
a moment it seems like a deter but it's
not so ubuntu is known for
lots of linux programs pre-installed uh
one of the easiest links distributions
to use more frequent updates more
progressive on new linux programs and
systems and so here's an example of
ubuntu the desktop edition uh but of
course you know we would probably be
using server or core because we'll be
utilizing it for running uh
servers right
and if you do not know ubuntu is
produced by canonical and this is the
company behind ubuntu
and another project that canonical makes
is called snap so snap is a package
manager by canonical that can be
installed on many different
distributions of linux and so here's an
example of installing ruby and a lot of
times you'll see this classic flag
and so this allows access to your
system's resources in much the same way
a traditional package so without the
flag snaps runs in complete isolation it
just depends on the state of your
uh environment but um sometimes you have
to use the flag sometimes you don't
so let's talk about micro kubernetes so
micro kubernetes or micro k8 as i say
mostly throughout this course is created
by canonical and is installed using snap
that's why we're talking about those two
things so you do like a pseudo snap
install micro k8s um and
i think this is the major reason why we
haven't seen as major adoption like
minicube as micro kubernetes because of
snap and snap is actually really great
but just the idea of having to install a
package manager manager people go
i don't want to do it you know what i
mean so
and also it's like the only time people
do it is that they spin up ubuntu but
ubuntu is very popular on all cloud
servers providers so it's pretty easy to
get a hold of so it is a kubernetes
distribution designed to run fast
self-healing and highly available
kubernetes clusters it is optimized for
quick and easy installation of single
node multi-node clusters on uh on
multiple operating systems including mac
os linux and windows as long as you have
snap
it is ideal for running kubernetes in
the cloud local development environments
and edge and iot devices you could
devices you could use it for production
use cases but you probably want to use a
managed service for that
and if you did use it you'd be using it
for um
you know a self-hosted right uh so micro
kubernetes is a modular design uh you
start with nothing and uh you can enable
add-ons to quickly use exactly what you
need and nothing more uh so i feel like
this is like
the best way of learning and so we do
end up gravitating towards this
lightweight distribution when we are
doing our fall longs but there you go
[Music]
okay so we looked at a few different
lightweight uh kubernetes distributions
and i just want to do a quick comparison
here so you can kind of understand the
differences
of of these things so the first is mini
cube which runs in a virtual machine
it's intended just for development
purposes very easy to use very very
popular uh probably the easiest one to
utilize okay
then there's kind it's designed to run
anywhere containers run so anywhere
docker is running you can run kind in
it's intended just for development
purposes it has faster startup times
than minicube since it's not spinning up
a virtual machine so you have one that
runs in a virtual machine you have one
that runs in
containers then we have a
k3s and k3d which are kubernetes
distributions by rancher uh they're
slightly different in terms of what they
start out with like how they work
they are still cncf certified all these
are cncf certified kubernetes
but these ones can be used for
production use case the difference
between k3s and k3d is this one is
basically installed on bare metal
or embedded systems and then k3d runs
wherever docker runs anywhere that is
similar to what kind does it's designed
for embedded edge devices or limited
resources and we did cover that there
are uh some uh design choices that make
uh these things limited compared to
other
things for production use case you have
to make a trade on that then we have a
micro kubernetes or micro k8s
this is created by a canonical the same
company that publishes ubuntu you need
snap to install it if there is another
way it's probably pretty hard to do
it's a modular starts with nothing
installed restarts everything if there's
a crash
well suited for
self-hosted production use cases so
everything here is great for production
everything here is great for development
but technically you can use all of these
for development and even myself i prefer
to use micro kubernetes for development
and i think it's great because then you
know if you do do self-hosted we better
reflect that production environment but
it's up to you what you want to use
and it's going to be depending on what
resources you can find so
there you go okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
manage kubernetes providers and so these
could be something like a cloud service
provider or a cloud platform that
abstracts away the effort of setting up
maintaining like such as updating
patching and cluster and they can easily
uh perform auto scaling as well
so
um i mean that's going to vary the auto
scaling part but um you know
mostly this is how people are setting up
the kubernetes they're going to be using
a managed provider very common to use a
public cloud
but we'll talk about the ones that i
know about i'm sure there's ones outside
of this but these are probably the most
popular ones especially if you are used
to using csp so the first is google
kubernetes engine gke and in my
experience this was the easiest to use
with the richest amount of features
built into the ui right so when i wanted
to set up an ingress controller
and we did this in the course or
or set up a service that goes ingress it
was so easy to do
um and it just had a really great
experience out of all the the big csps
next i would probably put amazon elastic
kubernetes service um it does have a
very difficult uh ui so
um
aws is like you know sometimes you'll be
setting something up and it'll be like
you need this thing and so you have to
go to this other place and create it
first and then go back and so there is a
bit of running around however they do
have a
a cli
called
eks ctl i believe and it really does
make it a lot easier so uh you know it's
not really recommended to use the ui and
a lot of people doing kubernetes you get
used to using cli because because of
cube ctl but the real reason i think
that amazon elastic community service i
put it second is just because it's worth
it for the integrations with other awes
services because uh you know maybe uh
eks is a bit clunky but all the stuff
around each of us and that's what you
want to be integrating with like your
managed database and and your persistent
storage and things like that it's just
such a great ecosystem that that's why i
put it second but google's really really
good
for cloud native you have azure
kubernetes service this was fairly easy
to use um you know like its interface
wasn't as good as gke but you could
basically accomplish things it has some
unique offerings like i've seen like
debugging live containers which is
really cool
um and they have good tutorials so like
the thing is is that you know even
though they're clunky um their
instructions are a lot better than aws's
and so uh you know works a little better
but this is like if you
are bought into that microsoft ecosystem
so you know all three are are pretty
decent i put these at the top three
nexus ibm
uh cloud kubernetes service also known
as iks
it's easy to use um beautiful beautiful
ui out of all the uis that i saw
it wasn't as feature-rich as i was
expecting to be and it was very very
expensive
and so like ibm likes to say it is cost
effective because they actually do allow
you to spin up a free kubernetes tier so
technically
um you know for 30 days or or what have
you you can actually have a free cluster
and this is actually a great way to test
out a managed service but the only
problem is that the nodes are so darn
expensive and so you don't play for the
control plane on uh icast or ibm
ibm cloud community service but the cost
gets so expensive so fast it's like
using heroku where it's like it's free
entry um the small sap is um
uh you know like very inexpensive but it
gets super expensive
super fast so i generally probably
wouldn't recommend unless you are
already using ibm and you like using
bare metal and you're used to paying
those kind of costs okay you have oracle
container engine for kubernetes um
oracle is known for being highly cost
effective out of all these other
providers
i don't think they charge you for the
control plane but honestly their ui is
really really bad and they even default
it to bare metal when you start to spin
it up and if you do that it'll cost you
like thousands of dollars so it's easy
to make a mistake when setting it up and
costing a lot of money
and um
you know support on oracle is not very
good
so if you do have a problem and there's
a high chance you will you know just
being cost effective is not going to
help you one thing i remember about ibm
cloud was that when i set it up it was
really good at estimating the cost and
making it very clear what things cost so
kudos to ibm for that but even still
like still really expensive you have
digitalocean kubernetes so d-o-k-s
very easy to use predictable spend
beautiful ui
um
and i mean the only thing was that it
was a bit like everything was beautiful
but it was a bit clunky to use where i
was like
like you know the experience is like the
ui so good but then like the technology
kind of fails to deliver the same kind
of reliability and so it kind of feels
like there's this beautiful ui and then
things are a bit clunky behind the
scenes that's how digitalocean felt to
me but but it was very simple to use
you're not going to get that whole
ecosystem that a cloud service provider
is going to provide you but it is very
simple and easy to manage if you're a
startup this is a very safe bet for you
to use use digital ocean kubernetes so
it's not terrible but um
uh digitalocean
is very very very very good with uh
tutorials
um and they had some stuff there but for
kubernetes i'd say it's probably the
weakest i've ever seen them for
instructional content they even had a
dead link that i had to point out be
like hey this goes nowhere so i think
it's more of a newer service for them
and uh you know as they continue to
build up the resources around it it'll
be good
then you have
um it's the most cost effective they
don't charge for the control plane
um i wouldn't say the ui is beautiful
but it's extremely simple so if you
don't know what you're doing when you
enter there you might be a little bit
frustrated at the start
um but uh like if you've used it lotion
then you'll know how to use sevos um and
they do have a nice like labs like
instructional content within sivo um but
it really is just a cloud platform but
different from digitalocean it is
specialized just for kubernetes right so
they technically do have vms and other
stuff on there
but it's just it's more focused on
kubernetes than any other cloud platform
um and so you know there's a lot of
trade-offs there you just got to decide
what you'd want to use for me i'd be
going with eks just because
my primary workloads are already there
but i really did enjoy a google
kubernetes engine for sure but there you
go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
management layers there's a lot of
management layers for kubernetes and
some of these might kind of be their own
distributions with a platform on top of
them
so it's really hard to kind of
put them in a box but i try to group
them separate from distributions as best
i could that were pure distributions so
management layers are for running
kubernetes on other platforms or allows
you to extend your control plane to
multiple platform and when i say other
platforms i mean like
um
you know like adabus has eks and that is
their kubernetes as a service offering
but i'm saying like there is no as a
service you're just like setting it up
on maybe either virtual machines or
things like that so let's go walk
through them the first is weave
kubernetes platform
wkp now if you go to the website right
now you can't find this exactly it's
kind of weird they might have rebranded
this as like weave
core or something like that but um
i just stuck with this name because i
preferred it so all of weaves open
sources tools packaged as a platform so
you can build out a git ops enabled
cluster and so what it looked like to me
was that they had a lot of ci cd stuff
and
the idea is like you could set up a
cluster relatively easy
uh most places and have good governance
over them good
way of being very uh agile and just
start to get to work
so that was kind of interesting
then there is rafae
no idea if that's the correct branch
nation but
similar to openshift and we'll talk
about openshift in a moment but with a
larger focus on governance and get ops
based management for any kubernetes
clusters running on anything including
openshift so when you go to the rayfay
website uh they'll have this picture of
like showing that they can manage
anything from anywhere and so the idea
is if you buy into their system
um you know you just need to learn one
interface as opposed to a bunch of them
and so that could be very attractive
then there's vmware tanzu so wherever
vsphere runs you can manage you uh you
can manage and deploy and monitor
kubernetes cluster
my knowledge of vmware is not that
strong like i kind of know what vsphere
is like it's a thing that you install on
your virtual machines it has to do with
virtualization so i think of it like
you go on aws and i would assume that
you install this on bare metal probably
that's what you do so imagine you have
like bare metal like machines that don't
have virtualization installed on it so
you install vsphere you press a button
that sets a vsphere and you install your
license but anywhere there's vsphere is
anywhere you could install kubernetes
cluster
um and then you could emanage it from
tanzu so like it makes it it's like a
management layer uh anywhere so kind of
similar to ray faye but rafe is actually
leveraging
the actual as a service um offerings so
like it will actually leverage eks it's
not like
uh it's a vm you know what i mean like
it's a custom install
so there's kind of a difference there
then you have these things that are
multi-cluster management so first is
azure arc and so this allows you to
govern compute such as kubernetes like
and also virtual machines or sql servers
across more than a single cloud service
provider on premise or on the edge so
it's not kubernetes specific but it is
very often used for kubernetes and the
idea is we are extending our control
plane so we have one interface uh to
govern uh compute other places right um
and
that's really useful i feel like from a
compliance standpoint so like let's say
you want to run stuff on a bus or
somewhere else um but uh you know like
it just becomes a lot more complicated
if if uh you know from a governance
standpoint so it's really nice to have a
single tool
uh for that okay we have google anthos
so this is also multi-cluster management
this one in specific
is just kubernetes and as far as i
understand it's gke so google kubernetes
uh um
engine but it's extending the uh the
cluster to be managed on other
uh cloud service providers so like i
believe aws i don't think they have
azure for some reason or on premise but
basically um it takes over vms as far as
i understand and then installs uh
whatever it installs on that and that
allows you to manage everything from
anthos um and so
you know from kubernetes productive i
think it has an edge over azure arc
um but it doesn't talk about like
governance and stuff like that so maybe
for like a security or like compliance
standpoint azure
might be better but not as nice to use
then you have platform nine so this is
similar to rayfay but relies more on
third party tooling whatever that means
but as far as i understand it doesn't
leverage native functionality from cloud
service providers so it's not using gke
or it's not using eks uh it is using
some other thing that might be installed
on virtual machines to kind of like
simulate maybe what google anthos is
doing stuff like that um so you know
there's the idea there so this is this
stuff and then there's two that i kind
of want to give a little bit more
attention to because they're bigger
deals like rancher and openshift so red
hat has openshift and it's a platform as
a service for kubernetes
and so cr openshift is just kubernetes
like it's not
it's a distribution but the idea is that
it is just a commercial platform with
kubernetes installed on it and then
they've extended like
a platform around it to make it really
easy to use
and what's interesting like when i saw
an ibm cloud you could actually launch
openshift in ibm cloud and you can
probably do in other cloud service
providers
so the idea here is that they uh they
extend cube ctl so they have their own
called oc which stands for
open shift you think it'd be os but it's
oc
cli and so it has some additional
functionality that makes conveniences
easier like rbac which is kind of a pain
to set up and they make that a lot
easier and things like that you quickly
deploy local code to a remote openshift
cluster via odo so that's another
cli tool they have that makes things
easier
they have quality assurance pipeline
built into the platform so that saves
you some time there fixing critical bugs
earlier instead of waiting for next
kubernetes release that red hat is known
for
being very very very very good in the
enterprise for um rolling up bugs fixes
very quickly right because they're used
to managing their red hat distribution
um and so you know that's really the
reason people pay for it is just to make
sure that everything's patched and good
uh their platform utilizes red hat core
os
and this is an opera operating system
optimized for running containers
so that's kind of interesting operators
hub is an automated installation tool
for one click marketplace other
providers like gke is a one-click
marketplace so i'm assuming that's even
more integrated because it's so
opinionated about even like the
operating system that it must be really
easy to set up um it has a graphical ui
for developer consoles that's really
nice code ready workspace this was
really interesting so like
developer environments
and we used one in the course cloud nine
and we look at uh google's for a bit but
um this one is specific for kubernetes
right the only thing is like i didn't
use it because um
red had such a pain to sign up for like
i tried signing up for openshift and it
couldn't take my canadian postal code
and it broke and i waited like a week
for them to fix it and they were asking
for so much information
it was i was not happy about it but like
they do have like a 30-day trial but i
don't know i thought it was better use
cloud9 in that case
but it's just very impressive to see
that there's a cloud developer
environment for kubernetes because like
you can't do it on git pod
and on any of us we do it because we're
running a virtual machine but i mean
this one's more optimized for it
we have rancher kubernetes engine
rke and uh i don't know the logo is not
there probably shows up at the end here
but it runs entirely within docker
containers um rancher is the one that
built k3s i don't think it's k3s in
particular it's their own just it's
another distribution because i would
imagine that you'd want the full power
of kubernetes it works on bare metal and
virtualized servers rk solves the
problem of installation complexity a
common issue in the kubernetes community
installation operation kubernetes is
both simplified easily automated it's
entirely independent of the operating
system and platform you're running as
long as you can run a supported version
of docker you can deploy and run
kubernetes with rke so as far as
understand you can bring our key
anywhere you want so it's like oh you
want to run on aws great make sure you
have something like a vm that runs
docker right go to google check box
docker and uh use that thing and so that
gives you a bit more ability there but
you know these are the two big ones i
would say
and that's why i gave them a lot more
detail but there you go
[Music]
so something you're going to keep
hearing is a term that is cncf
certified kubernetes what does it mean
when a distribution has been certified
by the cncf well they have this page
called software conformance
and the idea is that
they have this kind of test that you can
run
that gives a guarantee that your
kubernetes does what it says it does
that it meets
very specific requirements in order to
conform
uh to
what is expected with the open source um
kubernetes and so here you can see that
there is a lot of distributions like
even here it says like 60
something i think they say that there's
80 plus
over 90 over 90 certified kubernetes
offerings but the idea is that if they
all are certified then more or less they
will work
pretty much the same
with the expectation of what they are
asking
and uh there is like a landscape for it
here so like i clicked the link
somewhere here and it's just another way
of opening up and seeing pretty much the
same stuff in the cloud native landscape
and the way it works is um they have a
bunch of instructions here to run the
conformance tests and it looks like
um it uses this tool called sano buoy
and so this is a diagnostic tool that
makes it easier to understand the state
of kubernetes cluster so this checks for
the state
and then you actually have the tests
which probably reside
uh somewhere in here they probably
explain that there
so just kind of give you an idea what we
mean when we say cncf
certified distribution okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
container runtime interfaces and to
understand that we need to understand uh
what's um on top of it and what's below
it so the first thing uh when we think
about um
uh this kind of this kind of layered
approach is orchestration so you would
have something like either docker or
kubernetes and so these orchestration
systems will use a container
runtime interface now at one point in
time docker just meant containers right
um but there was work to be had where
they started separating out all these
components and this is basically where
we see container runtime interfaces and
container runtimes underneath which are
the actual containers
and so the idea here is that um
you know kubernetes would be utilizing
something like either container d um or
it would be using something like crio so
when we talk about container runtime
interface you'll notice that's why i
never had an icon
uh earlier in the course when we were
talking about container time interface
because the runtime interface is one of
these two okay so container runtime
interface allows you to run a variety of
different container runtimes and so the
cri actually is doing things like
pushing and pulling images and
supervising examiners it's not the thing
that creates and
runs the containers what does that is
the container run times
and the containers that we care about
are oci compliance so from the open
container initiative
and we have two types native runtimes
and sandbox slash virtualize runtimes
and the major difference between these
two types of runtimes between native and
virtual is isolation so for virtualized
it can provide security benefits through
isolization because it's virtual so you
can have more controls around it
um so you know hopefully that helps make
sense that you have an orchestration and
that's going to choose a container
runtime and then from there it's going
to choose
a uh interface and then from there it's
gonna choose a run time but i think by
default when we use kubernetes most
times what it's going to be using it's
gonna be kubernetes it's gonna be
container d and it's gonna be run c and
there used to be a lot more container
run times but i had to look at each one
and i found so many were like
no longer maintained and so i think that
this is like the new list that you'll
mostly see is like run c
nabla and
uh cata okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about container d
and with these container runtime
interfaces
um they don't really tell you a lot
about how they work internally
i tried so hard to find some kind of
visual
and i just couldn't find anything and so
you know if i can't find it then you
don't have to worry about it so
container d is an industry standard uh
container runtime with an emphasis on
simplicity robustness and portability
and the way it started was it was part
of docker and they extracted out their
container runtime into the project we
know now is container d and then
gave it to the cncf
so this includes docker functionality
for executing containers handling low
level storage managing image transfers
and container d makes it easier for
projects like kubernetes to access the
lover docker elements they need instead
of actually using docker so when you're
building images you uh you aren't
actually building uh
docker images you're building open
container initiatives which has been
standardized
um for the container industry
okay
[Music]
let's take a look at crio so ciro is an
implementation of the kubernetes cri
interface to enable oci
compatible runtime so the cri stands for
container runtime interface and the o
stands for
oci okay so that's the logic there and
it's just an alternative to container d
so it's a lightweight alternative to
using docker container d as a runtime
for kubernetes it allows kubernetes to
use oci compliant runtime as the camera
runtime for running pods today it
supports run c and cathode containers i
didn't look at what container d supports
for runtimes underneath but that's where
you know if you need particular runtimes
you might have to choose a runtime
interface
that you can use
and when you use managed providers they
might lock you into very particular
container runtime interfaces that you
cannot swap out so that is something
that might matter to you but it really
is more like a security and performance
thing uh and not so much like
functionality wise because things don't
seem to be much different
um so that's the idea there but yeah so
cro is just an alternative container d
and you know i wish there was more to
say about these container runtime
interfaces but that's all i have to find
okay
[Music]
so let's talk about container run times
and again there's not a lot to get into
detail about container run times but a
key thing to understand is difference
between virtualized and uh ones that are
native runtimes that are utilizing uh
the machine directly and so
from cata containers they have this nice
graphic that makes it very clear
visually what the difference is so
virtualized runtimes uses lightweight
vms for isolation
and then native runtimes are
on the machine and they're using c
groups
shared kernels and other things for
isolation
so
you know in that sense when everything
is in a lightweight vm you can put a lot
more restrictions around it
and so that is something that makes it a
lot better from a security perspective
it confuses me because like i would
imagine that um
you know like you can run can you run a
lightweight vm inside of a vm i don't
know um so i don't know if like you just
replace the hypervisor with something
like lxc which is something we actually
do talk about
um in the section of this course is like
um linux containers
um where it's not full virtualization
it's lightweight virtualization so i
imagine that's probably the difference
but i just couldn't find definitively if
that was the truth um so let's just talk
about run c which is a native container
runtime so it's a low level container
runtime that creates and runs containers
and it would be used alongside container
d or crio that's all i could really tell
you about it um so imagine you have
container d and remember container d or
cri
basically similar
it's a daemon process that manages and
run containers pushes and pulls images
managing storage and networking
supervises the running of containers and
then you have your container run time
like let's say run c which creates and
runs containers so just reiterating that
i know we said it like three times but
just make sure you know the difference
between a container runtime interface
and a container time okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at c groups so
what is a c group well we have to answer
what is a process first so a process is
an instance of a running program on
linux so then what is a c group well c
group stands for control groups and
allows you to group processes to apply
different kinds of limitations
so limitations could be things like
resource limiting so groups can be set
to not exceed a configured memory limit
which also includes file system cache
prioritization so some groups may get a
larger share of cpu utilization or disk
input output throughput
accounting so measures a group's
resources usage which may be used for
example like billing purposes controls
so freezing groups of processes
so they're checkpointing and restarting
so think of c groups as a way to limit
programs on linux from overusing cpu
membrane storage
and the reason we're learning about c
groups is because of linux containers so
the primary goal uh design goal of c
groups was to provide a unified
interface to manage processes or whole
operating system level virtualizations
including linux containers and um you
know i came across c groups
even recently when i was using git pods
because i wanted to run kubernetes on
git pods but i found out that uh at the
time and probably still that
they're using docker with a version
that is using c groups version one and
so to support
uh kubernetes the run within docker
which is kind of weird running docker
inside kubernetes to run docker um
uh it needed version two so c groups is
something you definitely will come
across and so that's why i mention it to
you here
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are talking about linux
containers so linux containers is an os
level virtualization technology that
allows creation and running of multiple
isolated linux virtual environments on a
single
control host and so the idea is that
linux containers or
virtual environments in particular are
paired against virtual machines quite
often because
i mean the idea is virtual environments
are more lightweight so why would you
use one over another so virtual
environments there is no pre-loaded
emulation manager software as a virtual
machine in a virtual environment the
application or os is spawned in a
container and runs with no added
overhead except for
a usually minuscule virtual environment
initialization process there is no
hardware emulation which means that
aside from the small memory
uh
small software penalty
lxc so linux containers will boost bare
metal performance characters because it
only packages the needed application and
uh ves i didn't capitalize e on that
cannot be easily managed via neat
gui management consoles and they don't
offer some neat features of virtual
machines such as infrastructure as a
service setup and live migration so i
definitely didn't rework this text
wherever i got it from
that's what it is plain but i just
wanted to mention linux containers
because
you know
uh it is a
type of virtualization for containers
um
uh it's quite popular there and i came
across it somewhere in the course and so
i just had to figure out what it was
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at container
storage interface also known as csi
and what csi does is it standardizes how
container orchestrator system so cos
access to various source providers now i
don't find
that this is a very common initialism
but
i found it so i just put it in there so
a container orchestrator system is on
one side on the other side we have our
storage providers and in between we have
our cloud storage interface so container
orchestrator systems could be things
like mesos
kubernetes and docker swarm so we know
what kubernetes is mesos was like um
a very early orchestrator system
very modular and things like that
i think it's still kind of in use but i
don't know
if they'll stay around for long because
a lot of people moved over to kubernetes
and then docker swarm is
kind of like a competing thing for
kubernetes because docker
didn't really do orchestration the same
way that kubernetes did but now it came
with docker swarm so storage providers
would be things like azure disk aws
elastic block storage
netapp trident uh openstack uh
cinder google cloud storage there's over
a hundred plus storage and plug-in
drivers
and so um
you know the csi is
uh essentially what we're using when we
are using persistent volumes okay
because persistent volumes are pretty
much dealing with block storage and
um you know most of these plugins are
block storage i'm sure there's object
storage in there as well
and the cloud search interface is not
something you really have to worry about
because it's kind of abstracted away but
if you were to develop a
uh your own search provider then you
would have to know how the container
storage interface worked because you
have to make it compatible with it in
order to provide your um your volume
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at kubernetes backing
store and fcd so components of
kubernetes clusters including pods nodes
control planes volumes
all sorts of things need a level
protection in case of disaster we need
to store the state of what our stuff is
in case we need to recover it so what
kubernetes does is it uses or it stores
the state data inside something called
at cd which is a key value star which
we'll talk in a moment but it is
possible to uh back
or use a different backing storage like
mario db i have no idea how but i know
that it's possible and so application
data is stored in persistent volumes for
applications running on clusters
but understand that the the resources um
are like the state of those are stored
in a key value store so fcd is a
strongly consistent distributed key
value store that provides a reliable way
to store data that needs to be accessed
by its distributed system or clusters of
machines and xcd resides in the control
plane node and you need to know that's
where it is
so
lcd is not just used
for the backing storage it's used by
some
other projects so obviously the
kubernetes cluster uses it because of
the control plane core dns uses it
rook uses it
but you don't see it used for other
things it's a key value store and it
serves its purpose
like in these cases okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at min io and rook
and the reason i want to look at them is
because
uh you might see them as options on the
exam and if you know what they are it's
going to really help you determine what
the right answer is
rook and midnight
are two things that we do not cover in
the fall longs because they're a little
bit too complex to set up
and they're interesting because
like
they are basically
um
i would say like special types of
storage
um but we'll talk about what they are so
you kind of understand so rook turns
distributed storage systems into
self-managing self-scaling self-healing
storage
services it automates the task of the
storage administrator so deployment
bootstrapping configuration provisioning
scaling upgrading mitigation disaster
recovery monitoring and resource
management
and it can use things like cipher fs i
believe and things like that but
basically as it says it's distributed
storage systems okay so we think of pods
pods are generally backed by block
storage
but this kind of stuff is not attached
to a specific pod it's just
distributed storage that you'd use
maybe this would be for like data
pipeline workloads or things like that i
don't know i didn't i haven't deployed
rook but i just know that i've seen the
word on the exam so i wanted to point
out kind of what it was
min i o is a lot more clear to me its
use case so it offers high performance
s3 compatible object storage so it's
essentially object storage um and it has
a
um
it says s3 compatible basically works
just like s3 so it's native kubernetes
so mini o is the only object storage
suite available in every public cloud
uh i i mean anywhere that you can deploy
kubernetes basically uh you can use it
so min io is software defined 100 open
source under uh new apgl version 3. so i
really like the idea of min io it's i
really like s3 so
midio is an easy sell for me
but yeah that's all those two things are
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at volume so
kubernetes supports many types of
volumes and a pod can use any number of
uh volume types
simultaneously so let's talk about the
different types we've got persistent
volume so these this is when you're
attaching external storage to a pod and
the data will persist even if the pod is
terminated we have a fearable
i i have looked this up before but i
just can't remember how to say
ephermal volumes so volume that only
exists as long as the pod exists
intended for temporary data storage so i
mentioned here but we don't actually use
it in the kcna
as an example projected volume so maps
several existing volume sources into the
same directory and volume snapshots so
archiving
a volume configuration and it's data for
roblox or
backups so uh yeah in the kcna i don't
show follow along on doing volume
snapshots but they're not that
complicated they're not covered in the
exam
and one thing that's not here is pvc we
cover it in the course i'm just not
messing it here because it's not a
volume it's a way of claiming a volume
now these are
types of volumes but there's also types
of volumes that are supported that you
can
be backed by right so the idea is
persistent volume attaches to a storage
class and
um you know it has to be something right
so here we have elastic block store
azure disk azure file cepher i think
that's how i pronounce the stuffer
cinder config maps
um
maybe local storage nfs
secrets
we have the persistent volume claim
so
you know there's a lot of stuff there
and you don't need to remember the whole
list but you will in practicality
understand when we use um a storage
class and we have a persistent volume
and we have it attached to something
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at persistent
volumes so a persistent volume or pv is
a piece of storage in the cluster
that has been provisioned by
administrator or dynamically provisioned
using storage classes so here is my
diagram and so a pv is similar to a node
in that it's a cluster
resource okay
so um when i say that
a persistent volume does not reside
within a node or a pod
um
and i want to point out that this
diagram here is technically not accurate
i just had it as a simplification and
also while i was learning kubernetes um
it wasn't clear to me that you had to
have a persistent volume claim
and only when i did the follow-alongs do
i realize that you always 100 have to
have one
um but there are diagrams out there that
don't show the pevc so um i thought this
was accurate at the time that i made it
but i still left the sense just so i
could say that this was technically not
accurate and that sometimes you'll see
um diagrams that do not have a pvc okay
and we'll talk about pvc in the next
slide so don't worry if it doesn't make
sense right now or future slides here so
uh persistent volumes are volume
plug-ins like volumes but have a life
cycle independent of any individual pod
that uses the persistent volume so the
idea is if the pod goes down the
persistence persistent volume
can still rebate
it really depends on your reclaim
type or uh yeah how you want to reclaim
it so the api objects captures the
details of the implementation of the
storage
be that nfs
iscsi or a cloud provider specific
storage system mounting persistent
volumes directly to a pod is not allowed
and is against the kubernetes design
principles it would cause tight coupling
below the pod volume and the underlying
storage that's why we need a persistent
volume claim to ensure decoupling so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at storage
classes so a storage class is a way of
defining a class of storage that is
backed by a provisioner and so here's an
example diagram
that we have here and just notice that i
don't have pvc in here because again
some diagrams online do not show the pvc
but they are always always there and we
will address that when we get to the pvc
which probably is the next slide
and so to set up a storage class the
idea here
is um we need to define a few things so
we need to define the provisioner so who
is this from
uh so this is from aws so it's going to
elastic block store
parameters what type of storage so to
use so in this case we are saying use
the gpu type of elastic block store on
aws
you have the reclaim policy so
you know if the pod is deleted it should
retain the persistent volume it should
not
vanish
notice the storage class is just like uh
defined and then it's um associated with
a persistent volume
so it can be
that way there but notice that a storage
class doesn't define one volume but it's
just saying like okay persistent volume
you're going to be using elastic block
and you're going to be using the elastic
block but they have their own
block storage for each of those okay
[Music]
okay so we kept on mentioning persistent
volume claims and here we are pvc so a
persistent volume plane is used to
decouple persistent volumes from pods
and a pvc
uh will ask for a type of storage and if
a persistent volume meets that criteria
it is matched and the persistent volume
is then claimed and bound
okay
so
what does that mean well if we go down
below here the idea is we have our
persistent volume claim and we're saying
i want
um i want a elastic block store and it
has to be at least
uh 500
megabytes and then the persistent volume
says oh well i have a 30 gigabyte one
here so match up to me that's the idea
there so
pvcs are similar to a pod requesting
resources from a node so pods consume
node resources so a persistent volume
claim consumes persistent volume
resources pods can request specific
levels of resources like compute and
memory as i was describing here and a
persistent volume claim can request
specific sizes and access modes
uh and here's an example of a persistent
volume claim
uh notice that the storage class is
mentioned sometimes i see it there
sometimes i don't
um
sometimes i see it with like a double
quotation
so
you know just be aware there are some
variants there not something super
important to understand
right now
um but yeah i mean that should be clear
uh yeah there's also the storage type so
this one would match on the storage type
and the access mode to
find it so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at config maps
so config maps is an api object used to
store non-confidential data in key value
pairs for pods
pods can consume config maps as
environment variables command line
arguments configuration files in a
volume and so here is an example of one
and we do use this one in the follow
along uh but the idea here is that you
have a section i mean you define the
config map you define your data uh and
notice that you can have a key and a
value and then for some uh there's ones
that are multi-line that get interpreted
a particular way when you parse them
so
here's an example of config map and just
notice that you can use a config map
for more than a single pod
a config map allows you to decouple
environment specific configuration from
your container images so that your
applications are easily portable so yeah
you are passing along basically
environment variables or things to
provide application configuration
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at kubernetes
services so kubernetes services allow
you to attach a static ip address and a
dns name for a set of pods and a
kubernetes service allows you to persist
an address for a pod even if it dies and
the service also acts as a load
balancer and i kind of regret not having
like something that looked a little bit
more like a load balancer by like having
a second
uh lined a drag layer to show load
bouncing but
i mean that's the way i designed the
icon but here you can see
we have a service we have endpoints so
that's basically um the storing of the
public ip address
so that we can map the service to the
pod
and you can see that this will have i
mean i didn't write it in here but this
would actually have a static ip address
that never changed and then it would
randomly distribute to the ones there a
pod without a service will have a
dynamic ip address so when the pod dies
so does the ip address so that is the
reason we want a service so that doesn't
happen kubernetes services have the
following service types we have cluster
ip this is the default if you don't
specify a type it will be a cluster ip
it randomly forwards traffic to any pod
set with the target port you have
headless sends traffic to a very
specific pod when you have stateful uh
pods like a database and we covered
headless
in the stateful set section there where
it doesn't assign a static ip address it
doesn't do load balancing it just gives
you
like a dns hostname resolution so you
can specify the pod that way
we have node port so external service
that allows you to use a
worker node ip address so it's a way of
exposing
um
the node like with like opening a port
on the node because generally a cluster
ip you know it's internal so you have to
access it within the cluster but we'll
talk about that when we get to
that slide there we have load bouncer
similar to no port except leverages
cloud service providers load balancers
and then we have external names so a
special service that does not have
selectors and uses dns names instead and
this is uh used when let's say you had
you have a database
um like a managed database like from aws
rds or google cloud spam or something
like that
and you can't point to an ip address and
you need to point to a dns name so use
an external name to point to external
resources
[Music]
all right let's talk about traffic
policies for services so a service
allows you to set a traffic policy to
determine how ingress traffic is routed
there are two types of traffic policies
external traffic policies so how traffic
from external sources is routed and has
two valid values cluster so route
traffic to all the ready endpoints
local so
only route to ready node local endpoints
we have internal traffic policy so how
traffic from internal sources is routed
and has the same values above cluster
and local so if the traffic policy is
local then there are no node local
endpoints then then q proxy
uh does not forward any traffic for rel
relative servants uh relative relevant
services we do not cover this in the
fall along traffic policies we do not
need to create one
but i just wanted to point it out
because i think i saw the term on the
exam and it wasn't an answer but i just
saw it and i just wanted to include that
so you knew what it was
[Music]
let's take a look at the cluster ip
service type so cluster ip is the
default service type so if you don't
specify one this is what you're going to
get it is used for internal traffic
external traffic will not reach the
service so traffic will be randomly
distributed to any targeted pod so
here's an example where we have internal
traffic it goes to proxy um which goes
to our cluster ip to your pods so
traffic originating from within the
cluster will pass through
the nodes kubernetes proxy and then onto
the kubernetes service that's where it's
using something like iptables or stuff
to do
the load balancing but we can use that
or ipvs which we do cover in this course
if you emit the emit the type it will be
cluster ip but here i am explicitly
specifying it a service can span
multiple worker nodes for cross node
pods
and that is not just specific to
cluster ip that's all of them which i
should have mentioned in the service
section there but just taking a look
here over on the right hand side
we have our port and our target port so
our target port is
the port that we want to target on the
pod so if we're running a web
application on port 8080 that would be
the target pod and if we wanted to um
send traffic
to a particular port like port 80 it
would ford over to the 8080 port okay
so hopefully uh that is pretty clear so
when would you use the cluster ip well
for debugging testing internal traffic
internal dashboards but honestly like
when i was doing the follow alongs there
were cases where there were there were
ways of
um
there were there was lots of use cases
for a cluster ip but this is what
kubernetes tells us that it's used for
so that's what i wrote there okay
[Music]
let's take a look at node port service
so notepad allows you to expose a port
for a virtual machine a node running
pods that the service is managing and so
the idea is this is what a way we can
get external traffic and it's the
easiest way to get a traffic in but not
necessarily the recommended way for
production use cases
and over here this looks a lot similar
to our cust or cluster ip manifest file
but here we're specifying node port and
now it has
this target port so there is no external
load bouncer so node port is intended
for single community service and for
non-production workloads um and since i
have the diagram here i'm just going to
quickly explain how these three ports
work and then we'll go and look at a
more verbose text description so that we
just are we're very familiar with these
three numbers so node port is the port
that you're exposing the node on the
machine so that the traffic can reach it
to
port is the service port so the port
that you have to hit internally to reach
the pods and the target port is the port
here that uh is our application is
listening on so i write 8080 but this
one says 80. okay
so just to reiterate because it is kind
of confusing and i just want to give it
some extra attention
port port exposes the kubernetes service
on the specified port within the cluster
other pods within the cluster can
communicate with the service on the
specified port target port is the port
on which the service will send requests
to
that the pod will be listening on your
application
in the container will need to be listing
on this port also node port no port
exposes a service externally to the
cluster by means of the target
target node's ip address and node port
node port is the default setting if the
port field
is not specified so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the load
balancer service type this allows you to
use an external load bouncer and the
external load balancer handles the
routing and traffic distribution logic
so the idea an external load bouncer
could be something like the aws network
load bouncer which would be managed by a
third
party cloud service
and so the example here is we are
specifying type load balancer
and then the status here the load
balancer is we're specifying the ingress
so like the ip address i suppose of the
load balancer
and then sometimes we have to specify
the cluster ip
i'm a bit confused about this because
in the follow alongs we generally use
ingress
instead of load balancer and ingress
seems to utilize um
the load balancers of a
like a cloud service provider
so
probably people don't use load balancer
often or at all
and then when i do see them in the
documentation they're describing
level three or four load balancers
so
this isn't at the application layer so
maybe there is a case for it maybe
ingress came later and then this just
became kind of mute but it is a type of
service so we do learn how to do it uh
load balancer type is well suited for
production workloads generally it's
recommended to use the kubernetes
ingress as i just said here
[Music]
let's take a look at the headless
service type and we've already had
exposure to this a couple times but
let's talk about one more time a
headless service is a service with no
cluster ip address a headless service
does not provide load balancing or proxy
proxying
so the idea is you have a cluster
you have a kind which is cluster so even
though we don't specify it is still a
cluster ip kind but we are specifying
cluster ip none okay so that's what
makes it
headless
so head lists are useful when you are
dealing with a stateful application so
like reads and rights and you need the
rights to go to a specific pod
so here is a diagram that is different
from the one that we saw earlier but
makes the point clear where you have the
headless service
it's pointing to a pod and the way it
works is the naming is based off of
um the pod and the service if you have
pod one it's called that
and then uh the server the headless
service called h serve that's gonna be
the dns record that you use how the
services need to manage network identity
for uh for or of the stateful pods by
signing a dns record teach pod so you
can route traffic to a dns hostname so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the external name
service type so external name services
is the same as a cluster ip service with
the exception of instead of returning a
static ip it returns a cname record so
what is a c name record
well stands for
canonical name
record and it's a dns record that maps
one domain name an alias
to another one a canonical name
and so an idea here would be
a cname would be like
mydatabase.example.com
which would point to like if you had um
a pod that was trying to call out to
that um
domain name the cname would route it to
the external service
and
that's how that would work though here
i'm showing pods so
um
i mean maybe it would make more sense if
the arrows went this way
but anyway the point is is that it's
used for
routing things to external services so i
don't show it here but imagine you have
rds okay rds you cannot sign an ip
address it has like
a a fancy dns host name so you would put
rds host name here
and so when the pod
in your application code would hit this
address it would go to the external
service
and that's how it would know where to go
all right so really this should be
pointing to this i suppose okay
but you know hopefully that is clear it
is very clear in the follow alongs
because we talk about it a few times
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i want to point out a very
particular command for cube ctl
that has strong relationships to
deployments to services and this is the
exposed command so expose is used to
quickly create
kubernetes services for deployment so
here it is and uh we do it quite a few
times where we'll type cube ctl expose
then the deployment then the app
sometimes the documentation will show it
like this we'll say deployment
forward slash my app again that's just a
alternative syntax that you can use you
can definitely use spaces you could say
deploy and then the app probably works
with replica sets as well but honestly
you should always be using deploys
anyway
but the idea here is that it just allows
you to quickly create a service and
attach it
so that it points to the pods of a
particular deployment so here what you
can see is that we are setting up one
that is a node port service we're
setting the name the port the target
port the node port i'm assuming i got
that right and i wasn't supposed to put
a hyphen in between there or something
um and there is another command where
it's like cube ctl create service and so
those can have kind of a bit of an
overlap but the idea there is that if
you create a service
um it still has to link to something so
most cases it doesn't make sense to do
that there's probably some edge cases
and i feel like cube ctl exposed does a
little bit more like i thought maybe
like it added a proxy or did something
but i just could not find that
documentation and i found it somewhere
online wasn't official docs so it
definitely does a little bit more but i
don't fully understand that extra bit to
explain it to you but i just know that
we will use it
and uh if you always can use manifest
files to create your services
but this is just really good for a quick
way to expose
kubernetes or like a kubernetes pods
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's talk about busybox so busybox
combines tiny versions of many common
unix utilities in a single small
executable it's basically the swiss army
knife of embedded linux as the single
executable replaces basic functions of
more than 300
common commands
and so busybox can be used to
interactively debug services to ensure
they are working
um i'm pretty sure on the
the ck ckd you will use busybox
for things and in this course we use
busybox
uh so that is something that we can do
there usually it's going to be something
like cubectl run
dot i t so interactive t i don't know
what the it stands for but i remember
doing it many times but this is an
example of running busy box that
is continuously running and you can sh
into it
and then use its many commands one
command it does not have which is very
frustrating is curl because i really
prefer curl over wget so even though
that's 300 it doesn't have curl
but i guess you can't have all the
commands you want but it is still very
useful
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at kubernetes ingress
probably the hardest
service to deal with not because ingress
is super hard to write but you have to
deal with ingress controllers and
configuring those can be kind of
difficult
and in the follow alongs we definitely
have a bit of a struggle there but we do
get through it
uh and we do it multiple times but let's
talk about ingress so ingress exposes
http and https routes from outside the
cluster to the service within the
cluster and traffic routing is
controlled by rules defined on the
ingress resource
so here is our diagram here the reason
we use kubernetes ingress is so we can
translate a custom domain on an ssl to a
service running within our kubernetes
cluster
in order for ingress to work you need to
have an ingress controller something
like abs gces uh load balancer
uh or i guess ingress controller they're
called english controllers or nginx
ingress controller generally those are
coupled to
um
uh particular load balancers right
for those providers which you'll see so
ingress enables you to consolidate the
traffic routing rules into a single
resource and run as a part of the
kubernetes cluster so getting out my pen
tool here
just making sure we're in the same place
we have our traffic it reaches our
ingress controller this one is nginx and
from there it goes to our ingress
service which
defines the routes and then it goes to
the routes to the service and the
service will reach our pods so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at dns so dns stands
for domain name systems
and uh i mean the way i'm
conceptualizing it is that it's a
service that is responsible for
translating resolving a service name to
its ip address so this is in the context
of kubernetes because dns stuff is um
complicated uh
so to say um and we could spend i don't
know like a micro course just talking
about dns but i just want to focus on
the last part translating or resolving a
service so kubernetes service name to an
ip address and so for um
a domain name system it's not uncommon
to have like a table of things that
point to things so we would have a
service registry and so in the context
of kubernetes this would be the service
name and this would be uh the static ip
address that is assigned to it so
um
you know the idea is that if you were to
use that service name or registry like
with an http request
or just use a a tool that allows you to
look up dns records like if you're
trying to resolve where
front name would go that it should
result to that ip address so now we need
to know about core dns so coordinates is
the default dns server for kubernetes
in the documentation you might see
something that's called cube dns and
that was the default prior to that uh
and it was replaced because it wasn't
that modular or had great plug-in
support and so core dns is the current
default you can swap it out this is the
one you'll want to use because it's
pretty good
and it ensures that pods and services
have fully qualified domain names fqdns
and without core dns the cluster
communication would cease to work
because it just would not know
how to resolve things to things
and you might ask what is a fully
qualified domain name so it's a domain
name that specifies its exact location
in the tree hierarchy also known as an
absolute domain probably a visual would
help there but you know it's not that
important what's important to remember
is that we have this table of service
registry and there's a way to look up
dns
and of course there is dns like let's
say you're using an aws and you had
route 53 which is um a dns service
that allows you to register domain and
then forward that domain making record
sets to point to stuff and so you know
that is like again another level of dns
and it can integrate into core dns and
things like that but
this dns is just for stuff within the
cluster okay
so uh let's look at the functionality
that is provided by core dns because
there are entry plugins internal plugins
and then
out of tree plugins so things you can
add on and so this will give you an idea
of the things that core dns can do other
than just resolving
uh you know a domain name to an ip
address so we have acl so enforce access
control policies on source ip and
prevents unauthorized access to dns
servers
any so
any given minimal response
to
this anything azure so enable server
zoning data from microsoft azure dns
that's what i'm talking about those
integrations with those cloud service
providers cache enables a front-end
cache health enables a health check
endpoint something that you'd be very
common with if you were again roughly
three they have health checks built in
so now is at the um cluster level log so
enable query logging to standard output
and many more such as like i think aws
would be in there like web 53 and things
like that so out of tree plugins get
alias uh redisk so enabled cache uh
using redis uh cuber not
tie
serve multiple uh kubernetes within a
server and many more so
you know hopefully that gives you kind
of an idea of how robust this thing is
and how modular it is let's just talk
about some tooling that we should know
especially if we're debugging this stuff
not something that we really need to do
at in the kcna level but uh it's just
practically very good to know so
coordinates pods are abstracted by a
service object called cube dns remember
everything kubernetes is pods so
coordinates are pods that run in the
cube system
and um i don't know if i wrote this
anywhere but it's very important to
remember that core dns
or whatever dns thing that you want to
use lives in the control plane node when
we were looking at a diagram that was
the one thing i forgot to put in there i
didn't have to get update the graphics
i'm just reiterating on that again each
pod
and not just
any pod uh
like sorry when i say each pod we don't
just mean coordinates pods we mean any
single pod has this resolve.com file to
help with dns resolving now this isn't
a kubernetes specific thing this is just
a linux thing where um you will have
this file on your i don't know if it's
in virtual machines but it's definitely
in containers but if you were to cat it
out like print the contents of it so
here we're logging into that pod that
container sorry and
we do that it's going to show the name
server so what we are in terms of the ip
address and then
you know the domain names that would
resolve to
this
um pod okay so notice it says default
svs cluster local things like that
and another really useful tool is using
ns lookup so let's look up name server
lookup is a way that we can discover uh
or see where things resolve so like
remember i said there's a service
registry that contains a service name
and a um
and a uh ip addresses so we could dump
an ip address in here and then it would
hit the core dns and be like what'd you
find and this is what i found right or
you could supply the service name or the
full service name because this is just
like a part of the name right the real
name would be like really long like this
okay
so just notice like how long it is and
like how short that is um but again you
know a little bit outside the scope of
the kcna but good to know um
you know in general okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i want to talk about load balancing
because we see load balancing in a
variety of different ways in kubernetes
and it can get kind of confusing so i
just wanted to describe the different
types of load balancing that we'll come
across but let's define what load
balancing is first load balancing is a
networking component where traffic flows
through the load bouncer and the load
balancer decides how to distribute
traffic to the multiple targets such as
compute nodes or other different kinds
of targets based on a set of rules so
examples of this would be ingress and
the service kubernetes service both have
load balancing but there's more than
that so we have external load bouncers
uh we have ingress we have service and
then we have internal load bouncing like
ip tables and ipvs which technically is
what service is using
so for external load bouncers um the
load balancing is controlled by third
party service think of elastic
it's weird like uh i know application
load balancer elastic load balancer by
aws or nginx or things like that then
you have um ingress so that is the
actual service itself
um so the idea is you have load
balancing algorithm back-end weight
schemes
you have service which will persist
sessions uh will have dynamic weights
and then in the internal uh turn load
bouncing the load bouncing to the
containers with the pods which is
randomly distributed so just understand
that there's more than one level of load
bouncing
and don't get too overwhelmed with that
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at probes so
probes are used to detect the state of a
container and we have three types uh
liveness probe
readiness probe and startup probe um and
in the kca i think you need to know how
to set up probes and we do actually use
um a type of probe
i think uh readiness probe yeah we use a
readiness probe um in this course but we
you know we don't go super deep into the
probes but we do get some exposure to
them so let's talk about the liveness
probes the liveness probe is
used to know when to restart a container
okay and so for example liveness probes
could be could catch a deadlock where an
application is running but unable to
make progress so restarting a container
in such a state can help to make the
applications
more available despite bugs
okay
then we have
the readiness probe to know when
a container is ready to start accepting
traffic so pod is considered ready when
all of its containers are ready and once
uh one use of this uh one use of this
signal is to control which pods are used
as back ends
for services so when a pod is not ready
it is removed from the services load
balancer
then we have start probe so this is
where we know when a container
application is started so if such a
probe is configured it disables liveness
and readiness checks until it succeeds
making sure those probes don't interfere
with the application startup this can be
used to adopt liveness checks on slow
starting containers avoiding them
getting killed by cubelet before they
are up and running so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we are looking at net filters so net
filter is a project that enables packet
filtering network address translation
and port translation so nat or napt so
knapped
not to be confused with nats which is an
event bus that uses grpc
it can be used in microservices uh
translation packet logging user space
packet queuing other packet mangling and
the net net filter hooks are a framework
inside the linux kernel that allows
kernel modules to register callback
functions at different locations of the
linux network stack the registry
callbacks functions is used when called
back from every packet that traverses
the respective hook within the linux
network stack so projects that build on
top of netfl filter that's why we're
talking about it is iptables this is a
generic firewall
software that allows you to define rule
sets nf tables so this is the successor
to iptables ipvs so this is specifically
designed for load balancing and uses
hash mapping as its means
so um
when we are using a service it can be or
sorry proxy i suppose it can be backed
by either iptables or ipvs and nf tables
is just not in the mix for whatever
reason
um and probably in the future kubernetes
will default to ipvs and just not use ip
tables but right now at least when i'm
making this course and video iptables is
still the default but we'll talk about
that and we'll talk about ib tables in
greater detail
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at ip
tables but before we do let's define
what a user space is so user space
for modern computing operating systems
segregates virtual memory into kernel
space and user space so kernel space is
reserved for running a privileged
operating system kernel kernel
extensions and device drivers user space
is the memory area where applications
software and some drivers execute so now
what is ip table so iptables is a user
space utility program that allows a
system administrator to configure the ip
packet filter rules for the linux kernel
firewall so we have iptables which is
for ipv4 and ip6 tables which is for
ipv6 but generally it's just iptables
here and
iptables is simply a virtual firewall on
linux
and it's very common uh like on linux to
have to experience ip tables so it is a
common skill and really worth to know um
so
an example would be like let's say you
wanted to restrict access based on ports
and protocols
you could
add or update to the ip tables saying
like okay the destination port is 80 the
protocol is tcp
and we will accept traffic open that up
if we list them out hyphen l we can see
what is open what is not what is blocked
and things like that
and again iptables is at least when i'm
making this the default for
cube proxy and you can change it out to
ipvs which we'll talk about next
[Music]
all right let's talk about ipvs which
stands for ip virtual server which uses
the net filter framework and also
incorporates virtual linux server lvs
so the reason we use ipvs is because
when using ip tables it can struggle to
scale to tens of thousands of services
as iptables is bottlenecked at 5000
nodes per cluster ipvs is uh
specifically designed for load balancing
and uses more efficient data structures
so hash tables i think i might have
called it hash mapping earlier but it
was i supposed to say hash tables on the
right hand side here allowing for almost
unlimited scale under the hood if you've
never heard of hash tables um
we describe it in crypto uh
cryptographical stuff like imisc 900
course we talk about it there
in the future q proxy will default to
ipvs
i really wanted to get like a nice
diagram to show how it works but i
really just couldn't find anything and
the point is is that you're just going
to end up using in the future and it's
used because of the limitations i'd be
table so that's really all you need to
know okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i want to talk about the various
proxies that we will encounter in
kubernetes because there's more than
just one and it can get confusing if you
just don't know that there's more than
one so what is a proxy well is a server
application that acts as an intermediary
between a client requesting a resource
and the server providing that resource
so here's an example i got this nice
little graphic from a wikipedia but the
idea is that once it asks them the
current time it goes to the proxy the
proxy says hey what's the current time
it says the time it sends it back to the
person so the idea is that they are in
the middle
um
uh between the communication of two
resources many or more so there are many
uh kinds of proxies you'll encounter
kubernetes and so we'll talk about all
the kinds here so the first we have is
cube ctl proxy so proxies from a local
address to the kubernetes api server
then you have an api server proxy so a
bastion built into the api server
connects a user outside of the cluster
to cluster ips which otherwise not might
not be reachable cube proxy so runs on
each node and used to reach services
proxy load bouncer in front of api
server so acts as a load bouncer if
there are several apis
cloud load balancers so for external
cluster traffic to reach pods and in
particular the ones that we will notice
will be cube proxy and cube ctl proxy i
know when i was learning uh kubernetes
getting mixed up because i thought maybe
this proxy and this proxy were the same
thing and they absolutely weren't
because they weren't
prefacing it with cube ctl
but just understand there's a lot of
different proxies and just to give more
general information about proxies
there's the concept of a forward and a
reverse proxy so ford proxy which is the
default proxy when we just say the word
proxy is a bunch of servers egressing
traffic to uh have to pass through the
proxy first so imagine i'm going to just
draw a little boxes here you have three
servers and in front of it there is a
proxy and the idea is that they're going
to all go through
this proxy all right and that kind of
acts as a way of filtering or doing
things with their requests then you have
a reverse proxy so this is ingress
traffic trying to reach a collection of
servers and this is what we will see
quite often especially with web
applications
is it is that you have let's say three
versions of your web app running and in
front of it you have a proxy and the
proxy is going to
send the traffic to those
and in a sense you basically have load
balancing so hopefully that makes it
very clear uh and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we are looking at kubernetes proxy so
kubernetes proxy also known as just as q
proxy is a network proxy that runs on
each node in your cluster and it's
designed to load balance
uh notice i have the word load bounce
there traffic to pods so down below this
is the diagram from the docs i probably
should have made one here but i also
kind of wanted to show it to you because
often they have permutations of this or
it can be really confusing i just want
to kind of clarify it up that you have q
proxy here
and uh you have a cluster ip and you
have the ip tables but they'll put it
like they always put iptable somewhere
else but where it goes is it's a program
running on the virtual machine the node
so it's really over here
okay and the idea is that cluster ip and
q proxy
can be both using it all right um and so
that to me is a lot more clear because
that is the thing that is driving the
rules to say okay how do we load balance
how we how do we filter traffic and
stuff like that and these things
leverage it and this is a program
running on the node
so cube proxy maintains network rules so
that's going to be in this case iptables
these network rules allow network
communication to your pods for network
sessions inside or outside of your
cluster q proxy uses the operating
system packet packet filter laying if
there is one and it's available
otherwise q proxy forwards the traffic
itself q proxy runs in three modes we've
got iptables which is the default uh
suited for most use cases ipvs probably
going to be the future default because
it's so good and suited for thousands of
plus services but it's fine for simple
use cases as well and then user space
this is legacy and not recommended for
use so hopefully that gives you an idea
of q proxy it is installed on all nodes
not just the worker nodes because you
need a proxy to
move that traffic around but um
you know hopefully that gives you an
idea there and there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at container
networking interfaces cni so cni is a
specification or open standard for
writing plugins to configure networking
interfaces for linux containers and so
down below here uh imagine this is the
uh container networking interface which
again is a specification for writing
plugins and then there are plugins there
are built-in plugins that ship with it
and there are third-party plugins i
would imagine
i would imagine this is where we say
entry and out of tree uh but maybe not
um but you know that's the way i'm
thinking about it and so you might
recognize some things here like bridge
and flannel and then on the side we have
calico cilium and weave which are all
very popular third-party
uh things to install uh and definitely
you'll need these you'll need one of
these in order to do network policies
okay so this is just the interface that
um is used so that containers can
leverage these uh plugins right it goes
to the container network interface just
a standard way to do it so it will run
through the container run time to reach
the containers uh and so that's the idea
is like if you want to
interact with calico
right it's going to have to go through
this path right same thing with any of
these things like if it's a bridge it's
going to be going through here so
hopefully that
helps make sense okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are talking about service meshes
so a service mesh manages service to
service communication for microservice
architectures a service meaning an
application not a kubernetes service
component so this is where um you know i
said how service is a confusing name
this is where we get that confusion so a
service mesh is an infrastructure layer
that can provide the following
reliability traffic management retries
load balancing observability some
metrics and traces security so tls
certifications and identity
uh and so the idea is that you'd have a
service control uh service mesh control
plane so the installation of the proxies
into pods as well as the proxies
capabilities is managed by the service
mesh control plane and a service mesh
uses a side card pattern carefully
listen to this because this is super
important and will probably show up on
the exam but a side card pattern
basically is a proxy container that is
installed on each pod
and
the apps container must pass the proxy
before leaving the egressing pod so the
idea is that
you when you install a service mesh
this proxy or sidecar as it will as it
will say will will sit beside it and so
the idea is the container will pass
through it and the proxy can do all
sorts of stuff all these things here
above
there is a lot of different service mesh
implementations you don't have to run a
service mesh but in most production use
cases there's no reason not to and i
forgot the e there maybe it turned into
a hyphen for some reason um but
available service messages for
communities are istio so this is
currently the most popular service mesh
but some people might debate me here for
kubernetes due to its highly
configurable nature seo uses envoy as
its proxy istio is not a cnn safe
project so when we talk about the
sidecar
um you know like like there's the
control plane and then there's the
actual proxy the sidecar that you
install and so seo says it uses envoy
for that istio is not a cncf project
but envoy is and so envoy is an open
source edge and service proxy multiple
service meshes use envoy as it's a proxy
envoy is a graduated cncf project
you have kuma this is also a cncf
project but it's in sandbox mode that
uses envoys at proxy i'm not sure if
it's competing with istio
since it's not a cncf project sometimes
that's what you see you see projects
that are competing like they're not
for whatever reason they're not a
cncf project and so then a csv project
spins up to kind of compete with it or
fill some kind of edge cases and it can
get kind of confusing because there's
some sometimes a lot of overlap on
certain stuff you have linker d which is
actually what we use or we attempt to
use in the fall longs it's a graduated
project known for having strong security
and it just works liquor d does not use
envoy instead it uses a simple ultra
ultra lightweight microproxy called
linker
d to proxy and then if we're talking
about like a third-party service like uh
hashicorp console so console's an open
source service mesh by hashicorp it's
not a cncf project console is offered by
hashicorp as a managed cloud service
mesh so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a closer look at
envoy which is a self-contained process
that is designed to run alongside every
application server
envoy can be installed on a virtual
machine or as a container so you don't
have to have a control plane
with envoy but
that's generally what you'd want so
you'd want something like sd or
something to
communicate or gather the information
that passes along through your sidecar
which is the envoy proxy and voice
supports a wide range of functionality
so l3 l4 filter arctic architecture
l7 filter architecture so l7 is the
application layer 3 and 4 is like
packets like tcp udp things like that
first class http 2 support and http 3
http 3 support
uh it has
layer 7 so that's the application layer
routing grpc support service discovery
dynamic configuration health checking
advanced load balancing front edge proxy
support best in class observability and
in practice you will likely not install
and manage to configure envoy you would
allow a service mesh control plane to
install into your pods a service mesh
will or may cont come with a ui
configuration files to configure your
envoy so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about network
address translation not to be confused
with nats
which is a event bus service that is
used with microservices and grpc but is
not the same thing
so
what is network address translation well
it's a method of mapping an ip address
space into another by modifying network
address information in the ip header of
packets while they're in transit across
a traffic writing device
okay but what does that mean
well it's practical use case is imagine
that you have a server
it's a public server right
publicly accessible via the internet
and you need to communicate
uh with a private network and so we have
two different private networks private
network one private network two
and uh they have their own address
spaces so this is in the 10.0.0.0
and this one also has it right so if
these are the same and they were to talk
to each other
that wouldn't make any sense right
because they have overlapping addresses
so a nat can translate one in another
by mapping or translating
uh there's this is like a nat table that
will um uh store
uh like it will say like okay 100.1 goes
over here but we will then give it a new
ip address and we'll remember that so
that if anybody talks to us we'll know
to send things back through that path
okay
because a uh two private
two private networks that have
conflicting address spaces are gonna
have an issue there
and um
when you send a packet over here if you
send 10.0.0.1
to the server and it sends it back it
has no idea what 10.0.01
is
so it really needs to be mapped to
something else and so that is the idea
behind network address translation okay
[Music]
let's talk about ethernet 0 and network
namespace so first we need to know what
an ethernet device is so an ethernet
device is a software or hardware
technology that allows a server to
communicate on a computer network so a
network interface card a nic
are commonly used to establish a wired
connection to a network it's the thing
you plug the internet into
a cloud service provider
such as aws or azure gcp
have virtual nics for your virtual
machines uh and you can actually manage
them too
a lot of times they're created for you
to connect to your virtual network so
what is a network namespace well
ethernet 0 represents the first ethernet
interface an ethernet device attached to
your virtual machine and a network
interface is an abstraction on top of
the ethernet interface to provide a
logical networking stack with its own
routes firewalls rules and network
devices linux by default has one network
namespace called root
and network namespace and this is what
programs we'll use by default so the
idea is you have your linux virtual
machine
you have your root
network space and then you have uh
ethernet 0 so the
these the first there's ethernet zero
and there's unit one but one is the
second device if you have one
but either zero is
primarily how things are getting outside
that virtual machine okay
[Music]
so now the question is how would you
observe these things uh so if you were
to log into your virtual machine and i
actually did this on aws what you can do
is you can
observe
uh the type of devices that are attached
to your virtual machine by typing in
ifconfig i don't know what ifconfig
stands for but i know that it'll list
out things like
zero so there that's the way that you
can see it
and there's other things so i guess down
below we have lo i can't remember what
that stands for but you might see other
things like bridge as well so all sorts
of networking devices
and you can
create and modify your own network
namespace so we said there's a root name
space but you can create your own
um
here so are we showing yeah so here this
goes pseudoip
net
ns which stands for network namespace
add namespace one so i created a custom
one there you type in
ipnetness and there is that namespace so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're onto cluster networking which
is an extremely important section
for kubernetes because if you don't
understand the networking for it
um it can be really hard to use and it
will kind of show up on the exam
indirectly not directly but you will
have questions which should be like hey
if you talk this way to that thing what
can talk
um and this is where i say as a
prerequisite why you need to know linux
and why you need to know
cloud networking or sorry linux
networking because this stuff is tricky
but
kubernetes has the following opinions
about cluster networking all pods can
communicate with all other pods without
using a nap network address translation
all nodes can communicate with all pods
without using a nat
the ip that a pod sees itself as is the
same ip as it sees
it as and even though i'm saying uh you
know without using a nat without using a
nap gnats are and can be used in
kubernetes even though
the bub is a contradiction there are
four broad types of network
communication for clusters we have
container to container pod to pod pod to
service external to service
and um beyond what i'll show you if you
really want to go deep on this stuff
there's like a long form medium article
but there's also a really good talk and
it's a cncf tech talk called a life of a
packet by michael rubin for uh so if you
want very detailed cluster networking
knowledge
uh if the stuff is just not clicking or
you just want to get more that's on
youtube and i strongly recommend
watching that as an additional thing if
it interests you
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
container to container networking so
containers all in the same pod have the
same ip address and the port space and
containers can communicate with each
other via the local host via different
ports so to help this make a little bit
more sense i have a visualization here
so here we have a worker node and pods
run in worker nodes or nodes in general
and here you can see that we have an ip
address and so that is a dynamic ip
address meaning that if this pod is
destroyed
and it spins up a new one then there
will be a new ip address and so down
below we have multiple containers here
and all these containers are
communicating on local host so if you
log into this container here and you
were to local host on port 3000 you
would reach this container
uh and that's kind of the story there so
it's not too
complicated in terms of the
configuration so here is a deployment
file and in the pod spec part of it the
spec part uh if we go down below to the
template and then into the containers
here you can see we are setting the
container port so see where it says port
80 here that would pretty much be the
same thing where we are setting it here
on the container in the graphic
obviously not the same port number but
that's the idea there so hopefully that
is pretty clear
pods can
all the containers in a pod communicate
on a local host
and
you just access them via the ports
[Music]
all right before we go any further into
more cluster networking we need to
understand what is a virtual ethernet
device also known as vet so these
devices they can act as a tunnel between
network name spaces to create a bridge
to a physical network device in another
name space but can also be used as a
standload network device uh packets on
one device in the pair are immediately
received on the other device so here is
our visual we have two different network
name spaces notice where it says net ns
that's just kind of like the short form
uh you could write to say network
namespace but of course you can name
your network namespaces whatever you
want and so that devices are always
created in interconnected pairs so
i know it's a bit gray i don't know why
i made it so dark or so light there but
it says veth pear and the idea is that
these um
two parts of it uh include the pear
and i'm just going to wipe a little bit
away here uh so you can use the iplink
command to create beth pairs so here you
type in iplink add a net ns
uh and in practicality of course you're
never doing this but i just wanted to
show you uh in case you had never
you were just wondering how those links
are established in linux so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at pod to pod
communication because we just saw how
simple
containers can communicate with other
containers within a pod just on the
local host pod pod's a bit different and
also it can be a little bit more tricky
because you have pods that can be on the
same note or you can have pods that are
across nodes on different nodes and so
it's kind of the same but a little bit
different um so i have this big fancy
diagram that we'll use as a reference as
we talk through our information here so
for pod depod communication on the same
node
virtual ethernet devices is used to
communicate from the pod network
namespace to the root network namespace
that's why we were talking about uh
virtual ethernet devices to connect two
namespaces together notes and named it
here like ef0 ef1 it's still virtual
it's just that you can name them
whatever you want and so some people
just do that to simplify it where
they'll just call this one uh f0 and
that's zero here but this could have
been one and two we could name them
whatever we want um but i mean this is
done for you right so you don't
you don't set this up manually it's just
happening but i'm just talking about if
you were to
set up
a vet pair yourself you can name
whatever you want
um so in the root network namespace a
bridge is used to allow all pod network
namespaces to talk to other pods so
that's a networking component that is
set up for you here the br0 represents
the bridge pods can see all of their
pods and communicate using their ip
addresses so notice that they both have
two distinct ip addresses in the same
network namespace or address namespace
and so if you were logged into a
container here and you were to
ping this ip address you would reach
that pod
and you could then also hit the port
number and hit a very specific container
if you wanted to i just want to
distinguish between uh routing and
bridging because
a lot of people might be thinking you
know isn't a bridge just a router but
they're not so routing allows multiple
networks to communicate independently
and yet remain separate using a router
so bridging connects two separate
networks as if they were a single
network using a bridge so just under
standard bridge is a bit simpler and
treats everything on the same network
which is what it does right because
they have the same address space at the
top there at the 10.0.0
idea there now let's take a look at
across node so here's our diagram looks
pretty similar and just so you know
there is a thing that's missing here
that goes in between and i just don't
have it there because we're going to be
talking about it uh when we look at
services so just be aware that this is
an incomplete diagram on purpose but so
pods can communicate to other pods
running on other worker nodes how pods
can communicate uh
pods on other nodes is network specific
okay okay so it's gonna be specific to
the scenario and will vary based on your
provider
so in the case of aws they have their
own implementation of the container
networking interface cni
and
it's called amazon vpc container network
interface plugin for kubernetes which
allows you
uh to have no intimidated communication
uh via the aws virtual private cloud so
if you've used aws which is a virtual
private cloud basically it's gonna
communicate on there so
your vpc
like
it's pretty straightforward right so the
idea is like i can't really show you
that in granular detail because we'd be
really digging into aws specifics or any
cloud service specifics but the point
that you need to know is that every
provider has some kind of solution and
when you set up on a managed provider
it's going to already be installed there
and so it's just going to work and
you're going to have to do the research
uh for each of those but it's always
probably going to be happening with uh
the container networking interface it's
always going to be some kind of plug-in
for that okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at pod to
service networking so here's our diagram
looks very similar but the the key
difference here is we have this element
called iptables and this is being uh
linked via a service now the way we can
represent this um as an architectural
diagram varies and you're gonna see in
the next slide when we're talking about
ingress egress that i've
done it slightly different and it's
because i looked at so many
architectural diagrams and there's just
no consistency so i figured i'd do some
variation here just so that you can
conceptually still understand what is
going on and the placement of things so
when a pod dies its ip address changes
and this
can make communication hard if you're uh
relaying
relying on the ip address for
communication right so if uh you know
this pod dies the ip address is gonna
change right
so a service creates a virtualized ip a
static ip so over here
and then uses iptables so iptables is
over here which is installed on the node
right so it lives on the node not in a
pod
to do nat so network address translation
and load balancing to other pods and
that's pretty much all there really is
to it
um so you know
that's that's all there is okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
ingress egress from an internet cluster
and here uh we are reaching the pinnacle
of very complex diagrams and notice i
told you that um
the
uh the representation of service is
slightly different here so notice that
service is having a dotted line that
goes around iptables now i didn't double
check but i'm not sure
this could be a fault on my diagram but
i'm not sure if the service
lives in the control plane or the worker
node
it could live on the worker node i just
didn't double check to be honest um but
anyway
what is clear and the reason i put it
over here is because it has to talk to
the
um the cloud controller manager so to me
that made a little bit more sense but i
did tell you that it represents service
slightly different uh like from the
prior diagram here so let's talk about
egress so egress is how uh pod traffic
exit to the internet so the idea is you
have a pod up here a container and it's
flowing out this way it's leaving the
pod and even though i don't have the
diagram what it would do is it would go
through the container networking
interface
um and the container networking
it uh it can we have a diagram with
cubelet and so cubelet shows that um it
talks to the container runtime and so
the idea is that you would have uh the
the plugin so in aws's case it's their
amazon vpc container networking
interface so that would let you talk to
uh vpc and from vpc you could then go
talk to aws's internet gateway and
that's how you'd get out to the internet
and so you know i'm just running out of
space on this diagram and that's why i
didn't kind of do that variation for
egress for ingress and i swear i
i remembered it to put a double s on
there but i guess i forgot but it's two
s's and i digress that i made a mistake
smelly ingress
it's for traffic to reach a pod so it's
going in this way okay
and so the idea is it has to travel to a
service so from a service it could be
using a kubernetes service with a type
load balancer this will work with a
cloud controller manager to implement a
solution that works with a t4 load
balancer something that does udp tcp
um but the other option is ingress
kubernetes ingress and so it will use an
ingress controller to work with a cloud
service provider load bouncer
i believe
it's specifically for um t7 because any
time i use ingress it's always using um
like kubernetes it's using the
application load bouncer can use it with
a t4 i'm not sure that might be
inaccurate so i would probably say it's
just c7 but um
you know uh the key thing is is that you
can either use one or the other okay
um but you know hopefully that makes it
clear this stuff is probably the hardest
stuff to understand in kubernetes
they're not going to push you too hard
on the exam to know this stuff for the
kcna uh there's a lot of videos out
there that go into
super technical detail but honestly it's
very hard to remember it all and you'll
be okay if you just generally understand
that
for ingress we have a type load balancer
of the service or kubernetes ingress and
then for egress it's going to use the
container network interface plug-in to
uh get to access stuff and they might
probably won't even ask that the egress
one but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the four c's of
cloud native security which is cloud
clusters containers and code and that
order does matter because each layer of
cloud native security models builds upon
the next outmost layer and so we could
describe uh this generally just as depth
and defense so you know the four c's is
just kind of a um
a framework or a mental model to think
about cloud native security but it just
really is the general idea of depth of
defense which you might see if you're
looking at the security of data centers
but it is a series of defensive
mechanisms that are layered in order to
protect valuable data and information so
the idea is that you have a malicious
actor and they're trying to make it to
your data so what layers are they going
to be going through so first we have the
cloud layer so that would be something
like aws you have your cluster layer
like something like kubernetes mesos
docker swarm containers so maybe your
runtime is container d or you could just
say docker in that sense uh and then
your your code and and there there could
be your code and
your data or information i probably
should have made a nice little like uh
data file there to indicate what they
were looking for but i didn't
but yeah those are the four layers and
you absolutely need to know the order
now how much do you need to know about
the interior or how they actually like
what uh defensive mechanisms right that
you need to implement which would be
here at the border of uh passing into it
um
not too sure for kcna i didn't see too
much stuff but we are going to walk
through each layer and look at what it
takes to secure them so that we just
round out our security knowledge for
kubernetes and cloud native workloads
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the first
layer which is the cloud layer and this
is also known as the base layer because
it's the basis for all the other layers
you have to pass through the cloud layer
before you can go to any of the other
layers so security at this layer is
going to vary based on managed or
self-managed infrastructure
so the idea here is we have
the managed infrastructure so
infrastructure as a service as we would
know
from our cloud service provider
knowledge
or self-managed so for managed
infrastructure you can think of any
cloud service provider bus azure gcp
oracle oracle ibm cloud or a cloud
platform so think something like civo
and so the main difference between a csp
and a cloud platform is a cloud platform
it's kind of like a precursor to a cloud
service uh provider same thing as like a
virtual private server it's just that um
they might not have all the elements of
it maybe they don't have a lot of
services um or they're just a
highly focused on just a very specific
thing just like just giving you
kubernetes and just a load balancer and
things like that so security is going to
greatly vary based on the provider and
you'll have to do independent research
to determine what you'll need to do so
if you're on aws and
you're deploying to eks which is what
you'd use elastic kubernetes service
you're going to have to research what
the best security practices for eks
because when you're using managed
infrastructure the responsibility
infrastructure is the cloud provider so
um
maybe all of it is taking care of you
and but there might be some things you
still have to worry about but let's take
a look at self-managed so self-managed
would be um code located servers so
think of equinix
i don't know if that's how you pronounce
it properly i've never said it out loud
before
or corporate data centers so basically
you have the machines you have the
office space or you're renting out an
office space and you're directly working
with the machines and you don't you
don't have a cloud layer or you're
installing your own cloud layer onto
um
those uh those servers so security is
going to be based on the infrastructure
security such as network access to api
servers the control plane network access
to nodes kubernetes access to cloud
provider apis access to fcd lcd
encryption um
and so you know hopefully that gives you
kind of an idea of infrastructure
security there of course if you can go
with managed it's going to be a lot
easier but kubernetes is flexible so you
can use it anywhere you want
it just depends on how much
responsibility you want to have
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
cluster layer and there are two parts of
cluster layer security you have
components of the cluster and components
in the cluster and remember a cluster
could be
um and i mean we're talking about
kubernetes in particular so you think
they'd just say this is uh
kubernetes uh security but um no matter
if you're using kubernetes mesos or a
docker swarm which are orchestration
tools that set up clusters um this stuff
kind of applies but everything in the
context here is kubernetes so for
components of the cluster we're securing
configurable cluster components for
components in the cluster we're securing
applications running within the cluster
so one is focused on the components and
one is focused on the applications so on
the component side there's a lot of
things you can do so let's go through
this list and it is huge but we will uh
do it anyway so we have controlling
access to cube api using tls for api
traffic api authentication api
authorization controlling access to
cubelet controlling capabilities of a
workload or user runtime limiting
resources usage on a cluster controlling
what privileges containers run with
preventing containers from loading
unwanted kernel modules restricting
network access restricting cloud
metadata api access controlling which
nodes pods may access protecting cluster
components from compromise restrict
access to fcd enable audit logging
restrict access to alpha or beta
features rotate infrastructure
credentials frequently review
third-party integrations before enabling
them encrypt secrets at rest
receiving alerts for uh security updates
and reporting vulnerabilities so that is
a big old list but it gives you an idea
that there's a lot of work on the
cluster side
and i would think and i don't know but i
would think that using something like
k-native which uh basically takes a
strong opinion on how to set everything
up for you might reduce some of that
burden um but i mean this is what you
get when you use kubernetes you have uh
full access of all the components
underneath so you have more of an
obligation to secure those let's talk
about in the cluster securing the
applications running within the cluster
so rbac authorization authentication
application secrets management ensuring
the pods meet the pod security standards
quality of assurance network policies
tls for kubernetes ingress so you can
see there's a huge difference of
responsibilities here between of the
cluster and in the cluster
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
container encode layer now these are
separate layers but there wasn't a lot
for me to say about each one without
going super deep on particular
ways of implementing them so i just
group them together here
so we have container layer and the code
layers the container layer
things that we can do at this layer to
protect the container would be container
vulnerability scanning or os dependency
securities image signing and enforcement
disallowing privileged users using the
container runtime with stronger
isolation
okay and that could be choosing
like virtualized container runtimes
which we talked about in our runtime
section right
for the code layer the application code
is one of the primary tax services over
which you have the most control so um i
mean you know you have a lot of options
here but we don't list a whole lot here
so access over tls only so make sure you
use https for your application limiting
port ranges of communication so like if
it's a database maybe don't make it
public facing or limit it to only your
ip address third-party dependency
security so like if you're installing
like
node.js modules make sure that they are
up to date and safe or use a tool like
sneak that will detect and tell you
whether there's a problem with it or not
static code analysis
which you know is kind of similar to
third party it actually looks it's not
just saying like hey we know that
there's a history of problems with these
things but we'll actually look at the
code and tell you if we find a problem i
think like it was devops guru does that
but you have to use particular languages
like python or java dynamic probing
attacks so you know pen testing
basically for your application um you
know and then for the code layer you
know you follow all the good wasp rules
so aus has like a top 10 for application
defense it's going to be the same here
but there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about
infrastructure security we actually did
kind of cover this in a brief earlier
when we were talking about managed cloud
service providers because they take care
of all the stuff
for you but these are the suggestions
for securing infrastructure in a
kubernetes cluster the first is network
access to the api server which is your
control plane so
all access to the kubernetes control
plane is not allowed publicly on the
internet and is controlled by network
access control lists restricted to the
set ip addresses needed to administer
the cluster so pretty clear don't make
it publicly available
network access to nodes nodes should be
configured to only accept connections
from the control plane
on the specified ports and accept
connections for services and kubernetes
to uh of a type node port or load
balancer
and you know just put a load balancer in
front of that and you should be a-okay
like you know like a cloud one or
something like that kubernetes access to
a cloud provider api
so each cloud provider grants a
different set of permissions so now
we're talking about cloud providers to
create control planning nodes it's best
uh to provide the cluster with cloud
provider access that falls the principle
of lease privilege so p-o-l-p
that's the initialism for that for the
resources it needs to administer so this
is just like imagine you're on aws and
you make a
a role just make sure that role is given
to somebody that should have it or you
know just limit that kind of stuff there
access to fcd so access that cd the
database store for grace should be
limited to control plane only depending
on your configuration you should attempt
to use xd over tls more information can
be found in the std documentation
xcd encryption so whenever possible it's
a good practice to encrypt all storage
at rest and send lcd holds the state of
the entire cluster including secrets it
disks should especially be encrypted at
rest again if you're using cloud service
providers they'll usually integrate with
the provider so like on aws it would use
kms for
azure and use um vault store and
sometimes it's like just a check box
during the setup so you know it makes
that things a lot easier for you so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about the concept
of the three a's authentication
authorization accounting framework for
identity management systems so it's just
a a security concept that is good to
know um and so let's talk about the
first one authentication this uh deals
with your identity so this is how do we
know who you are and so this could be
utilizing a static password you enter
password and therefore must be you
a one-time password so we send you
um maybe we do the password but we also
send you a one-time password to your
phone you enter it in to make sure
double check that you are who you say
you are
uh we know this is multi-factor
authentication ufa
digital certificates would be another
way so remember the identity is in the
certificate um
and so
if it's self-signed i don't know if we
can trust it but if it is signed by
some kind of certificate authority then
they say yes we attest to this person is
we are and we because we issued it to
them right
basic auth could be something um like
trying to get access to um an
application so we apply basic auth
there as well we have authorization so
to get permission so we know who you are
but what do you get to access and in
kubernetes this is going to be role
based access controls rbac
for other things like azure um you know
they and it's still role-based access
controls but they might have risk
adaptive based policies so they might
factor in a bunch of smart information
about your location the time of day the
device things like that to determine
what you get access to but for
kubernetes it's just rbac okay then we
have accounting or auditing to audit to
login audit trails so in kubernetes
there's something called audit policy so
i suppose that's just like
uh i can't remember but they have other
policies and they have audit back ends
so that's where the logs will be stored
um so you know it's not super important
for the exam but the concept of the aaa
is something that uh you should know uh
in terms of security because sometimes
they mention it especially in the
kubernetes space so i just wanted to
make sure you knew the three a's okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at role-based
access controls also known as rbac or
some people like to say are back and and
role-based access controls is not a
concept
just limited to kubernetes
but it is something that kubernetes can
do and is very popular among cloud
service providers it is a way of
defining permissions for identities
based on a organizational role so rbac
authorizations use the rbac
authorizations k-8 io api group
to drive authorization decisions
allowing you to dynamically configure
policies through the kubernetes api and
when i show you things like this it's
because i want you to remember them just
in case you see them on the exam when i
point out these random things but i
don't always describe them in detail
because i just don't think it matters um
but to enable rbac start the api server
with the authorization mode flag so if
you're starting one up you'd use cube
api um server i can remember what the
one like in the ckd or ck that use ck
they do like cube add adm or whatever to
start up clusters but you do have to
specify the mode if you are using
a lightweight distribution like micro k8
you can just enable it by adding the
add-on rbac and it basically be doing
this underneath if you're using managed
services like aws azure tcp it might be
turned on by default you might just have
to hit checkbox because you're not the
one starting up the cluster but you need
to know this
it might show up on the exam so that's
why i'm showing to you
not that we would ever have to provision
our own server
in the kcna but you might want to need
to know that flag so with kubernetes
rbac there are only allow rules and
everything is denied by
default so if you were to create a new
user they would have access to nothing
you'd have to give them a role with
permissions to be able to do something
okay
[Music]
all right so the rbac api declares four
kinds of kubernetes objects we have
roles role binding cluster role cluster
role binding so here is the diagram uh
that we see here and so we have roles
which is a set of permissions for a
particular namespace and then cluster
role which is a set of permission across
all namespaces there are some kubernetes
components that cannot be named space so
i would imagine that if you had to
give them permissions they'd have to be
in cluster rule or there are um
components that can be uh in more than
one name system at the same time so
again maybe that's where
cluster rule might play a part
so that's the reason for the two
different ones in order for um
roles or cluster roles to be bound to a
subject that's where you're going to
need um a binding and so for a role you
have a role binding for a cluster role
you have a cluster role binding and so
those are going to attach to subjects
which are just essentially identities
like a user account which would be a
single user a service account which
represents a machine user to be used by
an application service a group which is
a group of users or services service
accounts and just notice here that for
both we do have this this binding in
between each one
and the thing is is that when you're
using cloud service providers or other
things with rbac you usually don't have
to worry about that component but in the
world of kubernetes where everything is
decoupled and you can see all the
components underneath um you know we
have to manage that component
so it's not too hard to use
and just to kind of tell you a little
bit about machine user just because this
one that's a service kind of threw me
off but then when i realized it was a
machine user it made sense but if you
don't even know what a machine user is
um that's like let's say you are on
github and
or like you have a project that you want
to deploy to a server but you need to
have access to github so you go and you
can use your main
uh github account but that might have
access to all your repositories and
that's just too much
permission so what you do is you create
a new user with the intent to be just to
be used for deployment so it only has
access to the repo and permissions to
read and things like that and so that's
the idea behind a machine user it's for
the usage of service it's not tied to a
specific person okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the role
configuration example and so
i mean there is the role and cluster
role but they're very similar
but the key thing is that uh the role
sets a namespace so here it says
namespace default where with a cluster
role you're not worried about namespaces
so here you can change the kind to role
or cluster role then you have your rules
or permissions of actions this role is
allowed to perform so we have api groups
and we do this in the cube ctl extras
where i list out the api resources which
is a command that you definitely will
need to know for the exam that shows you
all the possible groups so if you just
leave it blank there like that then it's
going to consider all core api groups um
and i imagine that you can do a comma
and it's just say the exact groups that
you want then the resources of that
group
and then you have verbs so get watch
list things would be other things like
patch delete update
create things like that but the exam
doesn't really test you on that kind of
stuff but this is just practical
knowledge you should know
of course you would have to create a
rule binding we do all that stuff in the
follow along so even though we're not
seeing a lot here we will do a practical
example but we're not going to do a
cluster rule just because it's a lot of
work and outside the scope of the kcna
but this gives you kind of an idea of
what you'd have to do
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at secrets management
so a secret is similar to a config map
with the exception that they can be
encrypted so here's an example um i mean
it's very simple but
just imagine instead of having config
map now we have secret um and the
configuration is pretty similar but what
you're going to have is a type
of secret so this one says basic auth
and then the idea is we have string data
so based on the type is going to be
uh different on what you ingest here um
so basic basic auth is a way of gaining
access to a website so and it will
prompt you with a very ugly box saying
enter your username and password so it
makes sense that that's what that does
there so by default secrets are
unencrypted in scd school uh store and
anyone with access to the fcd store has
access to the secrets so anyone who has
access to pods within namespaces uh will
have access to the secrets used by that
pods so it's very important to
understand by default
they're unencrypted okay and you have to
do a bit of work
to
make them encrypted or make sure that
they are secured and so those steps
would be
to enable encryption at rest for secrets
enable or configure rbac rules that
restrict reading data in secrets use
mechanisms such as rbac to limit which
principles are allowed to create new
secrets or replace existing ones and you
know for the exam you just need to know
what a secret is
i just thought it was important that you
understand that they're unencrypted um
and they're pretty much just like
configmap but just slightly different
and they have a bunch of different types
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at network policies
so network policies acts as virtual
firewalls for pod communication and pod
communication can be restricted based on
the following scopes pod to pod name
spaces or specific ips so just to kind
of visualize it if you have a network
policy the idea is that you can control
the ingress and you can control uh the
egress um is that the right thing is
that sorry you know what one second here
i think the thing is
i mean like they both are pointing
ingress actually so this these are both
going in
right but you can also say what's going
out and so i guess this graphic could
have been a little bit better but you
get the idea there's ingress and there
are egress but we actually do set up a
network policy so you'll see in the
follow along now selectors are used to
determine to select resources with
matching labels for the network policies
to be applied to except with the
exception of specific ips
um and the network plug-in you are using
must support network policies so if you
don't have a network plug-in installed
like calco weave net psyllium i have no
idea if that's how you say it um it's
just not going to work right so you can
create a network policy but if you test
it out without having one uh a plug-in
installed it just won't do anything
it'll be like the policy doesn't exist
and we do actually cover that edge case
in the fall long so you can see uh but
calico and weave net are pretty popular
uh but there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at calico so
calico is an open source network and
network security solution for containers
vms native host space workloads and
something we absolutely need if we're
going to be working with network
policies so calco supports a broad range
of platforms including kubernetes
openshift mirantis kubernetes engine no
idea what that is but sounds cool open
stack bare metal services
and calico gives you a choice of data
planes so you can use
berkeley packets that's what
ebpfs are
standard linux
hns on windows so there's a few
different data planes for that
and data planes is just like the mo the
means of communication okay
uh calico network policies extend the
base functionality of network policies
so i say
in the network policy section that if we
do not install something uh our network
policies will either work or
do very little okay so
um calculate network policies um do a
few things it will make policies that
could be applied to any object uh the
rules it's not he
it's just the
the t is missing there so
the rules can contain um uh the specific
action you can use ports port ranges
protocols ip subnets selectors on the
rules you can control traffic flows via
dnat
um i think that's destination network
address translation i think that's the
ds4 settings and policies for traffic
forwarding
so really without it you're not gonna
like without it you're just not gonna
have good network policies uh calico can
perform better than alternatives like
flannel
uh there should be comma here psyllium
and weave nets so because i was looking
up like what what does calico do you
know what i mean like why would you use
it over other ones and basically it's
just performance
uh like in terms of resources it's using
and and its flavor of network policies
that's the major reason why
and uh calico is what we use uh in the
course okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
autonomy of a network policy file so
these are the files that we would create
um because once you install calico and
we're using them
um and i think that when you install
different ones it might change the
syntax slightly of this but i'm not 100
sure on that um but anyway so the idea
is i'm just trying to get my pen tool
out here um
is that you know
in this network policy you're either
going to specify a pod selector or a
namespace selector because network
policies are either scoped on the
namespace or the pod or you're selecting
very specific ip addresses and there's
two policy types ingress and egress and
you can have them both in the same file
so ingress defines traffic that's
permitted
to enter the pod and then you have uh
traffic that egress that can exit the
pod and you even say like ingress
is allowed specifically from this
namespace specifically from these pods
and block these ip addresses right and
the traffic has to be on this port
okay so that kind of gives you an idea
of it but we are going to write a
network policy so uh we'll get hands on
there and that's where we will really
learn what we're doing okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about in transit uh
versus at rest encryption so in transit
is data that is secure when moving
between locations like algorithms tls
and slssl and then encryption at rest is
data that is secure when residing on
storage within a database or
even something like block store like a
volume so you see algorithms like aes
ras and so
uh two protocols or algorithms we should
really talk about is tls and ssl because
they are very popular and they can be
easy to mix up so tls is an encryption
protocol for data integrity between two
or more communication
computer applications so tls 1.0 and 1.1
are
deprecated
and i use this
wrong a lot of times but i'm pretty sure
it's deprecated and so now the current
practices uh 1.2 or 1.3 is the current
best practice but at one point it was
ssl you know so um you know an
encryption protocol for data integrity
between two or more communications uh
computer application like 1.0 two and
three so it goes back and forth um i
think we're on tls now but you'll still
see us talk about ssl as if we're using
it but probably we're using tls
um you know in the context of kubernetes
when you are communicating uh traffic
inbounds you want to be
using https which would underneath be
using
that encryption transit like tls and
then your volumes which are going to be
on
uh most likely managed providers like
elastic block store or
azure disk and you're going to be using
whatever encryption method they use for
that but that generally gives you the
idea okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at certificates in tls
so kubernetes provides an api called
certificate kubernetes io which lets you
provision tls certificates signed by
certificate authorities cas that you
control the ucas and certificates can be
used by your workloads to establish
trust uh and even though like in my
15-year career i just never can remember
what these things are like i know what
they are but i just mean like the
specification and all the settings
underneath so if you find them like a
little bit uh daunting or confusing just
understand that i've been doing for a
long time and even i don't remember so
what is public key infrastructure so pki
so pka is a set of rules policies
hardware software procedures needed to
create manage distribute
use store and revoke digital
certificates and manage public key
encryption so it sounds like a very
fancy system for managing public keys
what is x 509 certificate because we
hear this a lot in the web
it's a standard defined by the
international telecommission uh union
itu for public key
certifications if you've ever had to
open up like an ssl certificate i
believe it follows the 509
standard here so these certificates are
used in many internet protocols so as i
said ssl tls and https that's where you
most commonly see it or the pro probably
the first time you ever saw it if you've
been in the uh in
the cloud or web development for quite a
few years signed and encrypted emails
code signing or document signing so like
when you submit code to your repo you
can sign it to be like yes this code
came for me um a certificate contains an
identity like a hostname organizational
individual so like who is the
certificate we're signing on the behalf
of a public key so these are algorithms
like rsa dsa ecda and you can use a
variety of different ones so kubernetes
requires pkp pki for the following
operations client or client certificates
for the cubelet to authenticate to the
api server server certificate for the
api server endpoint
client certificates for administrators
for the cluster to authenticate to the
api server
client certificates for the api server
to talk to cubelets
to talk to xcd
client certificates cubeconfig for the
controller manager to talk to the api
server it's always talking to somebody
here client certificate cube config for
the schedule is to talk to the api
server client and server certificates
for front proxies most of these are
going to be stored in
etc for close communities pki it's going
to vary for lightweight distributions
like micro kubernetes we'll place them
somewhere else minicube will place them
somewhere else
and when you create a cluster generally
it creates one for you like a key but
there's actually a bunch of keys for a
bunch of different things
we will come across this when we need to
um
do our back roll uh roll base access
controls because we will want to have a
user and we'll have to generate a
self-signing key like we are the
authority for it and we'll have to sign
it against
keys from the cluster and so that's
going to be our exposure
to this stuff and i always find it kind
of hard but you know what we do have to
learn it and it's not too bad okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at kubernetes
security best practices and i got these
from aqua security so it's just a a
summary of
what aqua has on one of their websites
and if you don't know aqua security they
are a really well-known security company
that has products and services
um and so the recommendations here is
enable kubernetes role-based access
controls uh because as soon as they're
enabled that means that all users by
default
do not have access and then you have to
give them permission and that's a great
idea
use third party authentication for api
server so um authentication could be
octa
maybe cognito
any kind of decentralized authentication
system azure active directory again i
don't know how those would integrate but
using a third party authentication is
just generally a good idea protect xcd
with tls firewall and encryption so that
sounds like a good idea i thought tls
was just on by default so i'm not
exactly sure um about that but uh i mean
it sounds like a good suggestion it did
come up
when we were talking about
infrastructure security in the or
uh cloud cloud layer of security and
infrastructure security
so isolate kubernetes nodes so maybe
isolation or sorry nodes so yeah uh i
mean if you want to isolate workloads
that's using namespaces but i suppose
isolating nodes is a different story
monitor network traffic to limit
communication so
maybe that's installing a service mesh
uh just ha like holding on to kubernetes
logs i'm not sure
uh there but i mean monitoring is always
a good idea use process white listing so
you know if you have a machine like a
linux machine and it's running
particular processes only allow certain
processes and and everything else should
be denied turn on audit logging sounds
like a good idea
logging the idea is that if you have
logs make sure that no one is tampering
with your logs keep kubernetes versions
up to date with managed kubernetes
providers a lot of them will do that for
you so that's one advantage of using
something like
google cloud's
google kubernetes engine
and we have a lockdown cubelet so you
know some of this advice we saw in
the layers section but it's generally
good advice here i just wanted to share
it again
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at auto scaling so
what is auto scaling well in computing
auto scaling is when systems without
manual intervention adjust capacity the
amount of cpu and ram to meet the demand
uh traffic from users by adding or
removing resources commonly triggered by
events uh so for pod based scaling uh we
have two things we have the horizontal
pod
scaling so that's the horizontal pod
auto scaler which is what we'll create
when we create a manifest file which
adds more pods to meet the demands and
then we have vertical pod scaling so the
vertical pod auto scaler which right
size pods for optimal cpu and memory
resources then there is node base or
cluster based scaling depending on the
way you want to call it and so this is
where we have the cluster auto scaling
and so its implementation because this
is more reliant on um uh managed
providers or things like that the
solution is uh uh kind of like
third-party or integrated so we have
cluster auto scaler and then we have
carpenter and this will add or remove
nodes uh based on the demand
and then there's the cluster api so this
is a declarative api and tooling to
simplify provisioning upgrading and
operating multiple kubernetes clusters
the cluster api can be extended to
support any infrastructure and bootstrap
or control plane providers so i don't
know for sure if cluster autoscaler is
using cluster api i think it is i just
can't remember um but you know my guess
would be you know maybe carpenter and
auto scaler leverages cluster api but
these are all kind of components that
are involved here for the case dna uh
we're not going to even uh notice
cholesterol is going this is really
complicated and vertical pod scaling no
but horizontal plot autoscaler is easy
to learn and use and so we will do that
one okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at scale versus auto
scale so the scale command is used to
update the amount of replicas in the
state of a deployment object and perform
a deploy so here we have a scale we
specify the amount of replicas and
what that will do is just update the
amount of replicas in the state of the
deployment object and perform a deploy
it's almost like opening up the manifest
file of your deployment file just
changing the number and redeploying the
only difference is that
that obviously won't persist in the
manifest file so you're doing it on the
fly
to those components there
then there's auto scale so this command
is used to create a horizontal pod auto
scaler of course you can create a
manifest file and that's what i
recommend but if you are making one
really quickly there that's all you got
to do so this one's doing a replication
controller which is really old we don't
do those anymore but i guess i just
didn't swap that out in time
but here this could be i suppose a
replica set a deployment it would be a
deployment and you'd specify the min the
max the cpu percent that's not the only
fields you can provide but just
understand this one is actually just
changing the current capacity this one
will actually set up rules to auto scale
okay so there you
[Music]
go hey this is andrew brown from exam
pro let's talk about k-e-d-a so k-e-d-a
stands for kubernetes event-driven
auto-scaling and it's a project that
allows you to scale based on event data
uh it's not gonna show up on the exam
but it's just important to know because
it is another
component to scaling
it allows you to
access a wide range of scalars that you
normally would not have access to so you
might recognize some of these things if
you're using cloud service providers so
or particular types of open source um
tools or projects so like we have kafka
active mq
aws services like kinesis sqs
tons for azure tons blob storage event
hub log analytics monitor pipelines
application insights service bus
storage queue cassandra which is um a
it's kind of like it's a it's a
column-wide database
all sorts of things datadog
elasticsearch uh
google clouds pub sub ibm mq mongodb
mysql new relic post sql prometheus
um
redis and a whole bunch more so uh you
know it is a very powerful tool to have
if you need event driven auto scaling uh
and i just didn't know what it was and i
just felt like we should know in general
uh that this thing exists okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at open standards for
cloud native or in particular kubernetes
so what is open standard or open
standards this is when multiple
organizations or technologies adopt a
specific technical standard and a
standard is considered open when a
public facing community can participate
on the development maintenance and
future changes
to that standard and so we have a lot in
our cloud native kubernetes sphere so
let's take a look at it the first one is
the open container initiative so this
defines industry standards around
container image formats and run times to
make sure that all container run times
could run images produced by any build
tool and so the container open
initiative
commonly initialized as
oci or oci compliant images
was created by docker because
um you know we needed a way to just kind
of standardize container image formats
then there's cni container networking
interface
so this is a specification and libraries
for writing plugins to configure network
interface in linux containers so we're
going to see a lot of these like
container x
interface like container network
interface runtime interface and
kubernetes has a lot of these because
um and it's not just kubernetes it's
just these are designed for
any kind of orchestration system that
wants to adopt it adopt it because if
you buy into these uh container
interfaces
um then uh you know anyone that's
building out these products that are
compatible with these plugins
can be utilized for any orchestration
system okay so it's kind of like a
middle layer
and it really just makes our ecosystem a
lot more rich
you have container runtime interface so
this plug-in interface which enables
cubelet to use a wide variety of
container runtimes without the need to
recompile
so crio is an implementation of
kubernetes cri to enable using oci
compliant runtimes as an example
and i just list that one there just
because this is a cri and this is crio
and there's no graphic
beside it you notice there's no icon
it's because it's going to really be
dependent on the runtime that you
install so they just don't have a
general graphic for that you have the
container storage interface so a
standard for exposing arbitrary block
files and storage systems to
containerize workloads
on container orchestration systems cos
sometimes the i guess i should have
capitalized the s there but that's fine
like kubernetes and then there's open
telemetry a collection of tools apis and
sdks to instrument generate collect and
export telemetry data like metrics logs
and traces so these are all the open
standards there could be more that i'm
not aware of but these are the ones that
we care about
and hopefully that gives you kind of an
idea there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the cncf
governance structure so uh it's
important to know this because it does
kind of show up on the exam and also
just to
understand uh uh the whole body of the
cncf and how they operate so that you
can really trust um the cloud native uh
projects
and the ecosystem in general so the cncf
is composed of three main bodies we have
the governing board uh initialized as gb
and they're responsible for the
marketing and other business oversights
and budget decisions and so the gb
has the marketing committee as uh one
component in the governing board then
there's the technical oversight
committee known as toc and they're
responsible for defining and maintaining
technical vision for the variety of
projects under the cncf
and in that they have special interest
groups sigs or sigs then we have end
users so euc which i don't really see
people ever using um the initialism very
often but end user community and there
to provide feedback from companies and
startups to improve cloud native
ecosystems they actually are the
companies and startups and so they have
their own sigs
and then they have user groups a user
group would be
like a a meetup you know like maybe in
toronto
there's a cloud native meetup and so
they're considered end users
and memberships are composed of
different tiers platinum gold silver end
user academic
non-profit members and we will talk
about how membership plays a role in
terms of what positions you can have and
uh what money is involved uh in this
structure for the cncf
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
memberships so the top tier for the cncf
memberships is platinum members and this
gives you the ability to appoint one
representative to the cncf governing
board
you can appoint one representative as a
voting member in any subcommittees or
activities of the governing board
i enjoy most prominent placement in
displays of memberships including on the
website
most these tiers it's all about the
governing board and again um the real
power is really being held by the toc
because they're making technical
decisions on the projects at least
that's the way i feel about it
because as you uh we read about there
the governing board is doing things like
marketing and things like that
um but you know we gotta get people to
pay so that's just how it works we have
the gold members so a point one
representative to the cncf governing
board per every five gold members up to
three maximum gold representatives
for the silver members the point one
representative to the cncf governing
board per ten silver members up to three
maximum
silver representatives we have end user
members so participate in end user
advisory community
as described so nominate one
representative to the end user technical
advisory board
um and i should state that all the tiers
above i just didn't want to cram this
slide together but if you are
uh end user and you're in one of the
other tiers you get both benefits
for academic and non-profit members
participate in limited to academic and
non-profit institutions respectively and
requires approval by the governing board
entitled to identify their organization
as members supporting the mission of the
cncf to any other rights or benefits as
determined by the governing board
so we got a bunch of tiers here but
where's the money what are people paying
to get these memberships
and
it's expensive you'll see here in a
moment so for the platinum members
370 000 usd at three year minimum
contracts so companies like aws
grafana new relic apple so and there
might be more i don't know if i grabbed
all the graphics here because we're just
limited on space but you get the idea of
like what's the spend here for gold
members 120 000 annually so we got
salesforce american express equinix hcl
for silver members it's kind of like on
this sliding scale depending on how many
employees you have uh the more you have
the more you pay so
here we just see a bunch of recognizable
names hashicorp mastercard accenture
digital ocean i thought hashicarp would
have been
a little bit more up there just because
they focus on multi-cloud and cloud
native is uh
pretty keen on that but that's just
where they are uh then for academic and
non-profit members a thousand dollars so
mitre
wikimedia cloud foundry internet2 and
then end user members there is no cost
so um really the question is what kind
of powers does the governing board have
and so we'll look at that next
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
governing board and see what kind of
powers they do have so governing board
is responsible for marketing and other
business oversights and budget decisions
for the cncf and so here's the graphic i
pulled from
the website so you can see some of the
members there and the governing board
does not make technical decisions for
the cncf other than working with the toc
to set the overall scope of the cncf so
what can they do well they can approve a
budget and that's a lot of power so
they're not making technical decisions
but uh you know if you want if you need
money for it you're gonna have to go
through them in order for it to get
approved so directing the use of funds
raised from all sources of revenue to be
used for technical
marketing or community investment that
advance the mission of the cncf they can
elect a chair of the governing board to
preside over meetings authorize
expenditures approved by the budget and
manage any day-to-day operations and
there's about 30 governing board members
and they meet about three to five times
a year
uh so just to kind of expand it's we
covered the most important ones but
let's just go through them all so that
we can see what they do so approve a
budget which we just said
elect a chair of the governing board to
preside over meetings authorized
expenditure approved by the budget so
when they say like preside over meetings
i'm assuming like any kind of meeting
not just ones on the governing board
vote on decisions or matters before the
governing board define and enforce
policies regarding intellectual property
direct marketing evangelism efforts
through events press analyst outreach
web social and other marketing efforts
oversee operations and qualification
efforts establish and oversee
any communities created to drive the
mission of cncf establish and execute a
brand compliance program
if any based on the cncf requirements
which may include a certification test
to use the brand marks established by
the toc
adopt guidelines or policy for use of
trademark provide financial governance
overall so
you know they approve a budget right
like that's what i'm going to remember
from it um and they they can preside
over meetings but of course there's a
lot of stuff here
but you just have to generally remember
that they're they're not making
technical decisions and they're
approving budgets okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
technical oversight committee also known
as the toc and they provide technical
leadership to the cloud native community
and they're not a really big team this
is the representatives here even though
they're cut off it's really a small team
and there's lots of contributions but
this is the main team
and their responsibilities include
things like um
defining and maintaining the technical
vision of the cloud native computing
foundation approving new projects and
creating a conceptual architecture for
the projects aligning projects and
removing or archiving projects accepting
feedback from end user committee and
mapping to projects aligning interfaces
uh yeah interfaces to components under
management so code references
implementations before standardizing and
defining common practices to be
implemented across the cncf projects so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
special interest groups sigs because we
did see them in the overall uh
organizational structure so special
interest groups are specialized
committees that work under or report to
the toc and there can be like end user
sigs but we're talking about the ones
that are in the scope of the tfc right
now so sigs include things around
traffic observability governance app
delivery core applied architecture
security and when i say around i mean
like literally there's a sig for each
one
right it's not like they cover all these
things they're specialized and even at
the time this is being drafted so this
list might change but this is generally
what they're thinking right and sigs are
long lived groups so they're not just
temporary groups that spin up for a
particular use case and then spin down
they are sticking around uh and they're
led by uh recognized and relevant
experts so you know if it's like
observability it's gonna be something
like people that specialize in service
mesh or something like that
and so things that are going on here
that uh you know they're supposed to be
doing is strengthening the project
ecosystem to meet the needs of end users
and project contributors identify gaps
in the cncf project portfolio find and
attract projects to fill these gaps
educate and inform users with unbiased
effective practical use useful
information focus attention to resources
on helping foster project maturity
systematically across cncf projects
clarify relationships between projects
cncf project staff and community
volunteers engage more communities and
create an on-ramp to effective toc
contribution recognition reduce some
project workload on toc while retaining
executive control and tonal integrity
with elected body avoiding creating a
platform for politics between vendors so
hopefully that gives you an idea of what
sigs can do and yes there are end user
sigs we're not really covering them here
but this is the sig that i want you to
know is the the technical ones okay
[Music]
hey let's take a look here at end user
community also known as euc or if you
want to attempt to say uke but i'm just
going to say end users so end users in
the cncf are individuals or
organizations that use cloud native
technologies but they do not sell
cloud native services so examples of not
end users would be vendors consultancies
training partners telecos
but
i kind of feel like the line's a bit
uh blurred there because when you read
the charter and how some end users can
be promoted to
roles outside the end user stuff i just
get really mixed up okay so um i think
that uh it's it's kind of a soft line
okay um the uc acts as a feedback loop
between those using cloud native and
those maintaining and building cloud
native solutions um but not just being a
feedback loop you know you're not just
there to to give them answers
as a customer but the idea is that the
end user community is an ecosystem of
finding cloud data of talent finding
local user groups uh meeting project
maintainers contribute to the cncf
technology radar um there is a class to
be like there it's free to be an end
user but then there's membership tiers
but it's confusing because like if eight
of us is a
uh like a platinum member
are they an end user because they have a
service but
um i think this is just kind of a
mistake in terms of the marketing pages
where um you have end users and then
things beyond that and
it gets confusing but anyway end users
if you are paying a particular
membership you don't have to then you
get access to things like educational
resources and um either cheaper or free
tickets uh to the cloud native
conference so that will vary there but
uh there you go
all right let's take a look at the end
user technology radar so technology
radar is an opinionated guide to set a
uh
of a set of emerging technologies and
basically looks like this um and so the
cncf end user technology radar is
intended for a technical audience who
want to understand what solutions end
users using cloud native and which they
recommend so basically they do a survey
and they ask what are you using what do
you trust and then they kind of have
this little radar diagram and this is an
original idea from uh cncf and they
admit that too that this is something
that a lot of companies like to do like
a technology radar or a radar-like thing
and they do also have uh sub-radars uh
like technology radars um for like maybe
security serverless things like that but
this is just the general one there but
let's take a look at these three
categories and what they should mean to
you when you are adopting uh technology
so the first is assess so the cncf end
user community has tried it out
they find it's promising and recommend
having a look at these items when you
face a specific need for technology in
your project
okay then there's trial so the end user
community has used it with success and
we recommend you have a closer look at
technology adopt so clearly recommend
this technology um that have been used
for long periods of time in many teams
and has proven to be stable and useful
so it's interesting because you have
projects and those are like if they're
graduated you think that's like a
guarantee that you should use them but
this is more um less of like what status
a project is of like maturity in terms
of adoption because that's just a signal
to say like enterprises you can use
graduated projects you should trust them
but this is more practicality saying
what works as a combination of
technologies um yeah so it's nice to
have that kind of balance and have that
driven by uh the end users as opposed to
just taking the word of the cncf further
projects right because like
yeah things like that okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the cncf
charter so the cncf charter is a public
document that contains the organization
structure of the cncf the mission and
values of the cncf the description of
membership tiers the definition of cns
projects
governing policies references to code of
conduct general definitions in relation
so like what does a organization
related to the charter like well how
would we describe that general rules so
it's basically a big document to help
define and guide the cncf and um in this
section i used quite a bit of
information from it so you didn't have
to read the charter and then i used the
marketing pages to fill it out so you
know hopefully that gives you an idea of
the contents of the charter okay
[Music]
so no organization is complete without
some values like things or a list of
things that they believe in
um and that we're supposed to go along
with so um i'm being a bit
tongue-in-cheek there because to me it's
just
all right you know what i mean like
uh it's like no different than the it
was leadership principles or whatever
microsoft or google does but let's read
it and see what we have here so the cncf
strives to adhere to the following
principles fast is better than slow so
enable projects to progress at high
velocity to support aggressive
adoption by users fast is better than
slow
open open accessible and operates
independently of specific partisan
intersects that seems fair
accepts all contributors based on the
merit other contributions i like that
that sounds good too technology must be
available to all according to the open
source values
fair uh sorry the technical community
and its decisions shall be transparent
so fair avoid undue influence bad
behavior or pay to play
decision making we have strong technical
identity so achieve and maintain a high
degree of its own technical identity
shared across the projects clear
boundaries so establish clear goals and
what the non-goals to allow projects to
effectively coexist help the ecosystem
understand where to focus for new
innovation
scalables support all scales of
deployment from startups to service
providers and enterprises platform
agnostic the specifications developed
will not be platform specific such that
they can be implemented on a variety of
architectures operating system so i mean
it's pretty much aligned with um
uh you know kubernetes and stuff because
it's platforgnostic
uh from from small to large but i mean
really kubernetes is not easy for small
startups but i mean you know it's cloud
native so we can't just look at just
kubernetes there's a whole scope of
projects there but yeah i guess that
generally aligns with the cncf
[Music]
all right so we've been talking about um
you know governance stuff and i just
kind of want to show you where this
stuff is coming from so if you ever want
to look it up yourself so i typed in
cncf charter and it brought me here to
the charter page and so basically a lot
of stuff we covered is from here where
i've summarized it or just kind of made
it a little bit more digestible if
you're kind of curious uh what the stuff
looks like
and if we go up to foundation i wonder
if there's more stuff in here
so
there's all sorts of stuff
not a whole lot um that we were looking
here this was pretty much uh the main
thing there but uh if we go over here
and we go to
uh here we can see the governing board
here we can see uh oversight committee i
don't think i checked what staff was but
it wouldn't hurt to take a look if we go
to who we are that's probably where i
got the values from
so yeah they linked to the charter on
the github here on the about us page
they talk about their cloud native
definition which again i i'm not a big
fan of it we did it in the beginning of
the course
it's there okay
if we go ahead and close that on off
we can see the governing board so here
you can see all the members you can view
their profiles um so nothing super
exciting what's interesting is like
uh you can read their past minutes
because everything's in the open right
so you can go here see they meet three
to five times a year click and do it and
it shows you who showed up
uh very formal um and also sometimes
what they'll do is show like on github
maybe more for
um
the toc but if we go to the tlc the
technical oversight committee
right um
they show their activity here they have
a mailing list so i guess you could
start uh talking them there you know
this is such an old school thing but hey
they still work
um if you go to the toc they have their
own page here the technical oversight
committee explains who and when and why
they got there the projects their
meeting times where the zoom call is the
passcode to get in i don't know if you
can just like kind of like show up and
uh
uh bomb the meeting or something like or
people can listen in i guess you can
come in they can just mute your kick you
uh then there's uh technical advisory
groups which we never talked about um
the tags
and
these look like sigs
so i'm a little bit confused because
sigs and tags um
basically have
the same thing so maybe they renamed it
maybe tags are the same thing i'm not
really sure oh look at that
yeah
look at that same thing so maybe this is
cigs or tags i don't know now
so that's cool okay so tags and things i
guess are the same thing
all right
um
and so you know that's pretty much it i
just oh maybe the radar thing we should
take a look at the radar so if we go to
um
and use a radar
okay
um here this says devsecops that's the
one i had in the actual um presentation
the slides if you go down below
you can see like who end users are they
kind of have a presentation it doesn't
tell you much but this is what's
interesting where you see
uh the data so like this is how you
understand how it's happening where
they're going okay
let's vote on
terraform as soon as just links to the
terraform website oh no it pops up
right and so they gather metrics to see
adoption so that doesn't necessarily
mean that that means that you should use
it just understand that's what the data
is so we have 21 companies
that's not a lot of companies
but maybe they're larger companies i'm
not sure if it shows us um
uh the information there like how do we
know what kind of company they are and
here i guess we can see the size of them
so you know
it would be nice if you could like
filter based on your company size
because that could really help you
understand or even industry help you
understand that but down below we have
different radars so we have
multi-cluster management secret
management database observability i said
serverless i guess there isn't one um
but that's totally fine there as well
and so here you can read all sorts of
stuff these things are again
you know take them with a grain of salt
they're uh they are what they are uh
only other thing i'd like to show you is
like end user stuff to show you where i
was talking about confusion so we go end
user cncf they actually have a page
right here and if you scroll on down
this is where we start seeing
memberships
and the language just keeps changing or
varies in other places so here they call
it a supporter
which is 4500 um
but you can join the end users for free
how you do it i have no idea right i
guess you just said join now and you
sign up and that's you signing up for
free i don't know like i've already
signed up before because i when you set
the certification you need to sign up to
do that so i suppose as soon as you sign
up you technically are an end user but
here you can see kind of the benefits
that you get for doing that but this
matches to the memberships we saw
earlier so everyone's an end user or
stuff like that so you know if you feel
confused just know that i'm confused a
bit too but um you know it's not really
going to show up in the exam but
there you go okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
kubecon plus cloud native con so kubecon
is a technology conference for
kubernetes and cloud nativecon is a
technology conference for cloud native
uh why is there two and why are they
combined is another question because uh
you always see presented as kubecon plus
cloud native con
so um as far as i understand talking to
people that have been in the industry
longer than me for cloud native stuff
i believe it was
kubecon existed first then they wanted
to do cloud native stuff as well
so they tacked that on i don't think
cloud native was ever its own conference
i think it was just like
an adjacent conference with kubecon so
it's essentially one conference
um and so that's the idea there and it
was only north america but then they
decided to add a european one
uh and so the attendance is actually
very significant so if we just take a
look here on the right hand side in 2018
we had 8 000 in person then 12 000 in
person
uh 22 816 attendees virtual because of
covet uh then we saw kind of a split
where i had 17 000 attendees and only 4k
in person
and so who knows what it'll be for 2022
um i'm not sure
and even at these conferences you might
see adjacent conferences in north
america like istiocon
con get up get ops con
i don't know how you draw the boundaries
like i don't know if they have like a
separate building or stuff but uh that's
a thing but you know i do hear really
good things about these conferences i
hear they're very inclusive and
welcoming
uh it's
much more refreshing over something like
abyss reinvent
so hopefully one day i'll get to go in
person but uh i just wanted you to
understand that this is a thing
[Music]
all right so i wanted to show you a bit
more about kubecon and cloudnativecon
just because i felt my slides are a
little bit lacking but just to kind of
show you
how big of a deal it is so i just typed
in kubecon plus cloudnativecon made it
to the maine's website here it's on
linux foundation if you scroll on down
you get some really fun screenshots to
get a good idea
um you know what it's like to be at
cubecon so there's probably even more
photos if i click here uh it's not
loading oh there we go so yeah we can
see uh it's it's a big deal it's just
like going to
um
like the aws re invent conference or
ignite uh their big or like azure ignite
or microsoft ignite it's a big deal
right
so you know just consider that uh you
know you can see the schedule here look
how big that stage is right uh you can
see all the sponsors so there's a lot of
money being put into it if you cannot
attend um i don't know if all the videos
make it up on here but a good chunk of
them do and so you know you can go back
and watch some videos that were at
previous ones probably go to the
playlist to see
um what they are so if you just scroll
on down here you can see there are some
featured playlists
right
so um you know like that i don't know if
all really i don't think all the videos
get on there i think it just kind of
happened because of covid and they just
put some of the videos up because
there's a lot a lot of events and i'm
not seeing
uh the volume of that i would think that
if i if i was at kubecon so you know
there you go and uh you know hopefully
it convinces you that you might want to
go okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at cncf
projects so projects are technologies
and they are managed by the cncf so many
cfcf projects are developed by external
tech companies and then are handed over
to the cncf for long-term support and
you can access all these projects at
cncf.org slash projects and projects are
categorized based on their maturity
level and i'm pretty sure you need to
know that for the exam so
here they have this diagram here that
kind of shows
some information
and this is actually based off a diagram
from a book but let's go through the
different categories so we have
graduated
meaning it's production ready for
enterprises
incubating so the this is where the apis
might be rapidly changing
and you may have incomplete uh they may
be incomplete to be adopted by large
enterprises but they are totally fine
for
smaller companies uh then you have
sandbox so experimental prototypes uh
and i would not bet that these would
pass the security review so
um you know there are so many sandbox
projects they're just not listed on the
website and the maturity level again is
based off of this book called crossing
the chasm
uh which is a diagram in the book from
1991. i don't particularly care for it
i'm not really sure why they use um
this model
like i don't know it's like to try to
sell more of those books or somebody in
particular liked it and thought yeah
that's a good framework to use
um but it's fine i mean i would just
prefer it being like stable or
you know release candidate or something
like that but that's how they name them
so
there's that but let's talk a little bit
more about sandboxes um
so if let's say you wanted to find
sandbox projects because i just said
that they're not on the main website but
they are in the the landscape so what
you can do is go to cncf projects and
then check box there and that's the way
you can see them now all these projects
um go through different kinds of eco or
life cycles and so it might be worth to
take a look at the different life cycles
so here i have project stages and this
is from
the documentation for cfc projects right
from their website so the idea is
we have
a sandbox so these are experimental
neutral collaborations
and here they're suggesting like they're
low barrier low reward
uh and so you know you might not want to
adopt them then they have this
significant barrier so this is where the
majority of development happens i think
that's what they're saying there and
then from incubation they say the
obvious pass so incubation to graduation
not a lot of descriptions around the
stuff but you kind of get an idea where
things are flowing and that some things
just completely skip over the sandbox
section and go straight to incubation
and all these have even more detailed
information so when you look at the
sandbox process the idea is that there
is a project proposal that is in the
case of a github issue um the
technical
committee will triage it and give it a
brief request a sig the sigs will make a
presentation that is recorded the
presentation slides a recording complete
recommendation template um and then the
toc will review recommendation and
presentation and then it will be in
sandbox so three toc sponsors to the
step forward so that's how we get to
that
then there's the incubation process
so
you have a project proposal
and
it goes to special interest groups again
makes a presentation
whether it's recommendation they do
their due diligence with tech and
governance user interviews
um and then here we have another review
with another presentation the toc vote
on it and it makes it into incubation so
you can see there's a lot there um i
don't think there was one for
graduated there probably is a process
but i i didn't see one because if i if
there was i'd have it here
but that's that there so there is at
least one graduated cncf project
generally for each cloud native category
and that's just something that i
observed
and that kind of makes sense because
like how do these categories exist um
you know if they don't have it so we're
looking at things that are graduated so
like container run times k or d core dns
envoy
at cd
uh fluentd harbor helm
uh jaeger i think it's pronounced jagger
like the j's the y uh kubernetes linker
d open policy agent prometheus um the
update framework so tough
rook
and uh tikvi and
vitus or vitus
lots of names i've never had to say out
loud before so hopefully i got them all
right but there there are a real a lot
of really good uh incubating projects
that uh i'd strongly recommend using so
i don't think that should be a
discouragement but this is really for
like
you know if you're a large organization
like a huge enterprise then you're
probably going to gravitate towards
these projects okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at what is serverless so
serverless architecture generally
describes fully managed cloud services
and the classification of cloud services
being serverless is not a billion answer
as a yes or no but an answer on a scale
where a cloud service has a degree of
serverless so a serverless service could
have all or most of the following
characteristics and you basically just
have to take an estimated guess to say
whether it is serverless there's a lot a
lot of debate about serverless but you
know i've talked to engineers like at
aws and stuff like that where we saw
serverless very early on and the
definition was really simple there's a
degree
of operations that you just do not have
to perform and you can just focus on
providing business value but let's look
at the elements that
i've included here that i've generally
been able to find out about serverless
so serverless is generally highly
elastic and scalable highly available
highly durable secure by default
abstracts away the underlying
infrastructure and are build based on
the execution of business tasks so for
business value serverless can scale to
zero meaning when not in use the
serverless resources cost nothing and so
the idea here in these two sections here
is we're paying for value you don't pay
for idle servers
my friend that runs the uh service
toronto user group
likes to describe it as energy rating so
the idea is that um
you know consumers uh you know what
they're gonna do like think of like if
you have like a washer or a dryer and
you have this energy rating saying like
it's out of three stars out of five of
being energy efficient right so the idea
is like some things are more serverless
than others um you know and that's just
the idea there okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
cloud native and kubernetes serverless
so
the cncf has a landscape for just
serverless um
services or or cloud native serverless
things and so what does that mean well
so the cncf classifies as serverless in
this landscape to be things like
functions as a service so aws lambda
azure serverless functions google cloud
functions
serverless frameworks such as dapper i
think that's how it's pronounced it was
sam chalice uh installable platforms
kubernetes-based event-driven
auto-scaling k-e-d-a which we did talk
about in this course
apache open whisk open foss k-native
fission
cubeless and tools things like uh
lumigo and dashbird so it's interesting
that they put um like managed providers
because i guess technically you know
they're cloud native but they're not
they can't be moved to anywhere else so
um i think it's kind of like those
things where like adabus
paid a bunch of money to be like a
top-tier uh provider and she's like hey
can you throw a little slam down there
because to me if it's cloud native it
has to be
an installable thing it can't be a um a
service that is uh managed do you what i
mean that can't be moved to any other
platform so to me this is where uh you
know like maybe these frameworks and
this is where
um actually i'm going to just
zero this out i would just say this is
what really feels to me to be um what i
call cloud day of service and these
things are just kind of like adjacent to
them right
um so just bear that in mind okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's take a look at k native so k
native is kubernetes based platform to
deploy and manage modern serverless
workloads and k native is a project to
create a standard set of building blocks
that i think that's kind of an important
statement right there standard set of
building blocks for kubernetes to enable
serverless development patterns k native
generally is composed of two parts uh
and i say generally because there is a
third part called building but k native
serving so this takes containerized code
and deploy it to uh with relative ease
it scales to zero costs you have k
native eventing triggers serverless
functions based on kubernetes api events
loop in other managed sources to trigger
serverless functions without this part
the eventing we might not consider it
serverless because if it just had
serving to make it easier to
[Music]
have an opinion on setting up a bunch of
infrastructure for you to deploy your
apps it would just be like a managed
layer um so over here you kind of get an
idea of what else is going on here so k
native has building inventing and
serving it's on top of kubernetes and
there can be layers like the app on top
like that's just istio for service mesh
like discovery to reach those functions
some considerations is that it's not a
complete serverless framework and it
does not offer function as a service
offering now that doesn't mean you can't
run functions on it but function as a
service is more of a fully managed uh
thing and so there's just some things
that are missing this is not my words
this is k native like you watch the
proper presentation uh like uh for those
uh who like do it like use it and they
even say that this is the case so uh
that doesn't mean it's not great it's
just a degree of service remember back
to the energy ratings where something
can be more servless than others but
it's still pretty darn serverless now
k native has its own
kubernetes objects that it defines with
kubernetes custom resource definitions
crds that is something that's out of the
scope of this course like talking about
crds but just understand that they're
used to make your own components and so
candidate of components is server
service so manage life cycle of a
workload route mapping network endpoints
configuration maintains desired state
revisions so point in time snapshots of
code and so basically they're using the
word service more like how we would use
the word service to run a workload
except it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's continuously running so you know
like when you use something like aws ecs
they say service and task service
something that that continuously runs
uh and doesn't spin down and the task
does it runs and it spins down but just
understand they call their service and
so here's kind of a diagram how they all
work together so of course the service
would have a configuration a service is
basically the function revisions are uh
snapshots so like backups of ones that
you made and routes that point to this
particular one and you're not going to
really be doing all the rest you're just
going to be working with service and the
way you do that with is with the k
native cli called kn and use this
alongside cube ctl because it's not like
you're not going to touch any cube ctl
but when you're working with your apps
and stuff and deploying your functions
which are called services and uh can
it's going to be like this kind of
different syntax here so think of k
native as abstracting awake deployment
services autoscaling many more k
components and you just create and
deploy
k n or k native services so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at k native
versus open fast and really all i did
was grab a excerpt from an article for
on the cncf blog from 2020 called
serverless open source frameworks open
fast k native and more strongly
recommend to read it even though we are
a few years in the future here uh i
still think it rings true based on what
i was looking at and just maybe will
help to understand the difference
between these two a little bit more so
unlike openfast k native is not a
full-fledged serverless platform but is
better positioned as a platform creating
deploying and managing serverless
workloads however from the point of the
view of configuration maintenance open
fast is simpler with openfast there is
no need to install all components
separately as k native and you don't
have to clear previous settings and
resources for new developments if the
required components have already been
stalled still as mentioned above a
significant drawback of openfast is the
container launch time depends on the
provider while k-native is not tied to
any single cloud solution provider based
on the pros and cons of both
organizations may also choose to use
k-native open fos together to
effectively achieve different goals so
one thing that was interesting is the
container launch time depends on the
provider i didn't fully understand why
didn't i mean so that's one thing i
wasn't sure about that i really tried to
research another interesting thing is
just when you see the stacks like the
tools involved
or k-native feels a lot more towards
um
the cncf's projects like
like standard projects and openfast is a
little bit different um so like canada
feels more again a better migration path
back to full kubernetes if you need it
in open fastest really feels like
serverless like you don't have to do a
lot of work there so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the pillars of
observability so before we talk about
observability in kubernetes we should
just understand uh this general concept
of pillars of observability um and i
don't really show them as pillars i show
them more like a triforce because i
think that that makes it for a better
visualization but let's talk about what
observability is
so it's the ability to measure and
understand how internal systems work in
order to answer questions regarding
performance tolerance securities and
faults with a system and application
to obtain observability you need to use
metrics logs and traces and you have to
use them together using them in isolate
does not gain you observability so just
understand they all work together
for metrics we have a number that is
measured over a period of time so if we
measured the cpu usage in aggregate and
aggregate over a period of time we would
have our average cpu metrics for logs we
have a text file where each line
contains event data about what happened
at a certain time so it's a log
and then there's traces a history of
requests that it travels through
multiple apps and services so we can
pinpoint failures or
uh performance or failures and traces go
along with spans we'll talk about that
and i say it looks like
the triforce of observability than the
pillars of observability but that's the
idea there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at open telemetry uh
initializes otel and is a collection of
open source tools apis sdks to
instrument generate collect and export
telemetry data it standardizes the way
telemetry data is collected like metrics
logs and traces
um and it uses the wire protocol which
refers to a way of getting data from
point to point like soap m q p
so
the idea here is we have applications
that are instrumented with the otel
library that go to collector agents so
an agent that is on the host and it's
going to send it to the oetl collector
service uh which essentially are back
ends and i mean that's what it is open
telemetry is a big deal because
it could uh really change the way we
collect information and we're starting
to see cloud service providers um adopt
it so you know you have aws cloud met or
sorry cloud watch but like why would you
use that when you use open telemetry
which gives you a lot more richer data
so it kind of competes with um
services
in some sense but uh definitely is a
really great tool to have so let's talk
about instrumentation so instrumentation
is the act of embedding a monitoring
library into your existing application
in order to capture monitoring data such
as metrics traces or logs so i really
like ruby so i grab the ruby example and
the idea is that you'd have some kind of
library and you'd import that library
set some defaults you'd run the
configure you'd create a tracer because
instrumentations the idea behind it is
you're creating traces right
uh and traces and spans per se so there
uh you have your tracer so you're gonna
have one trace that goes along a bunch
of projects and then in this application
it's going to create a span because the
span starts within an application you
pass it a variety of attributes like
data that you want um and that's all
there is to it and the telemetry
otel or open telemetry supports a
variety of languages so basically all
your favorite languages
and for certain frameworks uh there are
plug and play libraries to quickly
instrument your app so if you're using
spring asp.net express quarkus uh i
assume that there's kind of like built
into the background so you're not really
doing instrumentation you just say turn
it on and it just happens i'd love it
for ruby on rails maybe there's a third
party for it i don't know
um and let's just talk about the
collector for a moment so open telemetry
collector is an agent installed on the
target machine or is a
dedicated server and is vendor agnostic
way to receive process and export
telemetry data it removes the need to
run operate maintain multiple agent
collectors and this works with improved
scalability and support with open source
observability data formats like jaeger
again i think it's jagger not like
jagger but jagger sounds cool too
prometheus flew in bit sending to one or
more open source or commercial back ends
uh the local collector agent is the
default location to which intermittent
instrumentation libraries export their
telemetry data and so here they're just
kind of representing what we said so you
have oltp uh jagger prometheus
and
that's going to receivers
um and you can see that it's adjusting
on both sides here just as an example
right to
that but this is all what's inside of
the ol the hotel collector okay so
that's all i want you to know for open
telemetry they don't really say much on
the exam or if any but it is a really
important project to know okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at
prometheus and open source system
monitoring and alerting toolkit
originally built at soundcloud yes the
company that makes um or allows you to
host sound clips prometheus collects and
stores its metrics as a time series data
and that should give you an indication
that it is a time series database and
its main features are a
multi-dimensional data model with time
series data identified by metric name
key value pairs prom ql a flexible query
language to leverage the
the dimensionalities no reliance on
distributed storage single server nodes
are autonomous time series collection
happens via a pull request on http
publishing time series is supported via
the intermediate uh
intermediary gateway
targets are discovered via server
discovery or static configuration
multiple modes of graphing and
dashboarding support prometheus values
reliability so you can always view what
statistics are available about your
system even under
failure conditions if you need 100
accuracy such as per request billing
promises prometheus is not a good choice
as the collected data will likely not be
detailed uh to be or complete enough for
that use case in such a uh
case you'd be best off using some other
system to collect and analyze the data
for billing and produces prometheus for
the rest of your monitoring so let's
take a look here at um the actual system
itself that it works
and so the idea is that prometheus
scrapes metrics from instrumental jobs
either directly or via an uh
intermediate pushed gateway for short
lived jobs
uh it stores all scrape samples locally
and runs rules over this data set to
either aggregate and record new time
series from existing data or generate
alerts and grafana or other api
consumers can be used to uh to visualize
the times siri data you can see that it
also has alerting and other cool stuff
built in there um and there's not really
much to show for prometheus every time i
see grafana i always think it is
prometheus
but graphon is only the visualization
tool on top of it but it's the next
thing that we will talk about okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at grafana which is
an open source analytics and interactive
visualization web application grafana is
commonly used along with a time series
database like influx db prometheus or
graphite
and so it looks like this
and there's really not much else to talk
about it for the kcna because you don't
need to know that much other than it's a
visualization library that works with
promised to this
but there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
traces and spans because these are
things that we'll come across especially
in serverless especially in
micro service architecture like using
anything with kubernetes because you
have to track things between containers
or contain between workloads and that
can get kind of confusing so
here is our graphic let's talk about
what a trace is a trace is data or
execution path through the system and
can be thought of as a directed acrylic
graph of spans and so we're talking
about a dag this is that thing over here
so the idea is that you have
a unique id that's going to be tracked
through
uh all these um spans and then this
makes up the trace this is the trace
right uh and then the spans are the
individual services the individual
containers or or whatever that's
tracking saying this is what happened uh
in my little app this is what happened
in my little app and then there's the
context in between them like the latency
and stuff in between them or did it fail
how many times did he try so a span
represents a logical unit of work in
jager so i actually pulled this from the
jaeger documentation this graphic is
from jaeger
or jagger i'm not sure how to pronounce
it because it's used for um
tracking the stuff that has an operation
name the start time of the operation the
duration spans may be nested and ordered
to model casual relationships
so
uh hopefully that gives you an idea what
traces and spence are
but there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about cost
management now on the kcna exam i only
had one question about cost management
it was absurdly hard and obscure
um and it had to do with like if you
like it was actually scenario based like
oh if you had these many things running
if you scaled it down would it be better
to scale up or scale down or whatever it
just didn't make any sense for a casino
question so my brain i go that must have
been an unscored question or just a
bizarre one
and there aren't a lot of good resources
out there for cost management even
though it's part of the exam
i had to like scrounge for information
and try to make it kind of relevant so
let's just go through what i could find
and
i mean it's just gonna be general
knowledge but you know just understand
that uh you know it's just the best i
can do here okay so first thing is like
labeling resources if you label your
resources um with like metadata then you
can use a visualization tool like
prometheus or graphana it will end
grafana to then kind of figure out costs
all right how you get dollar amounts in
that i do not know but i do know that
that is a suggestion there you can find
idle and unallocated resources because
if they're idle or unallocated you're
paying for them the idea here would be
to visualize idle cpu memory storage and
producing graphana and say like hey
where do we see zero cpus being used but
something's running
horizontal sorry workload right sizing
would help a lot so
with that we can use a vertical pod
autoscaler to adjust the cpu memory of
pods a horizontal plot autoscaler to add
or remove to meet the demand so one is
right sizing
of the the pods usage itself another one
could be right sizing
the cluster so to speak
but at a pod level then there's cluster
downsizing opportunities which is again
i guess right sizing
where you're using cluster auto scaler
there's a double s there there should
only be one so i apologize for that uh
but it will add or remove nodes to meet
the demand um you can leverage uh free
trials of kubernetes cost tools like
cubecost you know whose recommend that
was cubecost so i think they're just
trying to use the tool but i mean it's
good advice it's not going to be an
answer on the exam but it's true uh you
can estimate future costs and so here
this is where you use like load testing
using something like speed scale
k6 j meter gatling and so you'd say well
what would it cost if i had this kind of
traffic or these kind of nodes and stuff
like that
um so
not wasting uh space this is pretty
similar to finding idle unallocated
stuff
but to kind of add to that it's like you
could adopt serverless architecture that
scales to zero so when no traffic is
received for a period of time it just
shuts it off okay
um and technical debt so maybe you can
re-architect to reduce the amount of
pods or maybe you should be using more
pods and breaking up your app into
smaller workloads so you can then
isolate what things are cost effect like
like costly and what aren't right
and also just continually evaluate cloud
native technologies and this is the best
i can do for cost management but uh yeah
for the exam probably just it's going to
be around right sizing like vertical pod
auto scale or horizontal plot autoscaler
and then making the best guess you can
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at kubernetes system
logs and k logs so system logs
um is system component logs that record
events happening in a cluster which can
be very useful for debugging and you can
configure log verbosity to see more or
less detail so logs can be as
coarse-grained as showing errors with
the component or as fine grain as
showing step-by-step traces of events
such as http access logs pods state
changes controller actions scheduled
decisions and as easy as they make it
sound and detailed information i
couldn't find a whole lot here i think i
would have to probably jump into follow
along and make a practical example to
really extract that information out but
really they just it was like cost
management it's like i could not find
good examples readily available to
digest in a slide here but there is the
cube ctl command logs and so here we're
providing the pod name or deployment
name whatever it is probably pod name
and so that would get you log
information
there's a library called k log it's the
kubernetes logging library it's based
off of g log which is golang's logging
library and it generates log messages
for the kubernetes system components
and i think we did talk about cubelet
being able to in the cubelet section uh
you know
taking log data and sending it back uh
where wherever
uh there so you know hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea
there about logs okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
chaos testing and testing so what is
testing well this is the assertion
uh that we have an expectation of inputs
and outputs of functions that's the most
basic thing in programming so the idea
is we have a variable
called hello right here and we assign it
a string called world and then we assert
using our testing framework to say does
the variable hello equal world and if it
does
uh pass if it doesn't fail okay
so that's the basic concept now it's not
going to be the same for um uh
kubernetes but
we don't really have to dig that deep
because it's not on the exam okay
so
let's talk about chaos testing so this
is building a system to withstand and
tolerate any kind of failure by
purposely introducing random failures in
a production system so it's just like
imagine if you uh had a junior developer
that was just doing whatever they wanted
you know
and you're just making sure that your
application is resilient to any kind of
problems so there's a few different
frameworks out there so for chaos
testing we have chaos cube for a just a
testing framework we have test cube and
then there's the generalized chaos
monkey which is another kiosk testing
framework so i just wanted you to know
that there was a chaos cube and test
cube
frameworks and the exam's not really
going to ask you about this stuff but
you should know it so that's why i'm
showing it to you okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at helm so
before we answer that we asked to ask
ourselves what is a package manager so a
package manager is a collection of
software tools that automate the process
of installing upgrading configuring and
removing computer programs for a
computer in a consistent manner so helm
is a package manager for kubernetes and
helm is broadly composed of three
components we have charts so these
contain all the resources definitions
necessary to run applications tools
services inside kubernetes clusters
repositories so this is the place where
charts can be controlled and shared and
releases an instance of a chart running
in a kubernetes cluster so i just want
to show you the helm chart directory
structure so if you were to create a
package this is an example i found
online where it's a wordpress
helm chart and so here you can see
there's the chart yaml file license
readme
things like that one thing is that you
always have this chart yaml file but
there's also this values yaml which
defines
the variables and the default values and
the values you can pass into this to
configure
the helm package okay so helen reserves
the use of charts direct directory crds
so i assume that's custom resource
definitions
template directories and uh
of the listed file names other files
will be left as they are
okay
i'm just pointing out that chart yaml is
important and values yamls is important
or at least i thought it was because
when i opened up the chart um
chart.yaml file i was expecting to kind
of see something interesting but it's
just kind of very boring it's like
package.json's like okay these are the
dependencies the api versions the
description
the home page the maintainers nothing
super exciting but basically if you want
to um package this and put this on their
the place where they host them which
some are listed in this section here um
you know that's something you're going
to need so let's talk about packaging
installing so to package a chart
directory in a version chart archive the
helm package command is used so that we
do helm package hyphen hyphen sign i
guess you have to sign it provide its
directory
there so version charts archives are
used by helm package repositories and i
was saying that there's a place where
you can find all these and they're on
artifact hub so you go to artifacthub.io
and there's all sorts of
helm packages you can access so i just
typed in
something like postgrass or something
like this and i found this one and often
what you're doing is you add the repo so
you know where
um where to go get
this package then you do an update then
you do an install and that's pretty much
the procedure that you're going to run
of course if you have configuration
you'll provide values uh via flags and
things like that but that's helm in a
nutshell but we do cover it in this
course so you will at least know how to
install something from helm not
necessarily make a helm package because
it's a lot of work but there you go
[Music]
let's talk about customize so customize
provides more flexibility when writing
kubernetes configuration files by
allowing you to overlay or override to
patch configurations and customize is
built in the cube ctl at least a version
of it
and so customize kind of is put up
against helm and being like an easier
simpler version of helm
we do not do a follow along on customize
just because helm i think it's just
i mean like if we were to do showing you
how to package a helm which we don't we
show you an install helm package i'd
rather do helm than customize because i
think that it's just um
has better utility for uh organizations
but uh the way customize works is that
you define your base architecture in a
folder called base so you have
deployment service anything you want in
here and then you have customization
yaml which contains how things should
get patched and so then you have down
below patches overlays whatever you want
to call it because it doesn't matter
what the folder name is you can call it
whatever you want because you're just
going to be using an apply
and so it will have a customization yaml
and that file will say in that thing
it's like a yaml file that says um
patch with these other files and these
files look very similar to the other
ones it just literally replaces
components like almost overlaying them
um
wasn't easy to find anything that would
show me how to do this really quickly i
probably would have to spend like a
couple hours just to get a simple
example for you not that it's hard but
just hard to find available
examples for customize that easily
translated over for you but it's not
going to really be heavy on the exam i
just want you to know that's an
alternative to helm and it's uh
supposedly easier to use okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at
infrastructures of code and so first we
have to kind of outline the problems
with manual configuration so there is an
advantage to manual configuration
it allows your cloud infrastructure your
cloud native infrastructure uh to easily
start using new service offerings new
apis versions to quickly prototype
architect architectures however it comes
with a lot of downsides so it's easy to
misconfigure a service through human
error or kubernetes components so this
is just a general slide that's why i'm
keep on adapting it to kubernetes terms
here it's hard to manage the expected
state of a configuration for compliance
it's hard to transfer configuration
knowledge to other team members so
infrastructure as a code allows you to
write a configuration script to automate
creating updating or destroying cloud
infrastructure and the idea is an iac is
a blueprint for your infrastructure
iec allows you to easily share version
or inventory or cloud infrastructure and
so the idea is that you'd have your
script or collections of scripts or
whatever tool you use and then by
running it once you can do it and so
kind of in a sense when you write
manifest files in kubernetes you
technically are doing infrastructure as
a code but you generally get some extra
benefits there like um
state management so uh things like that
so we're doing infrastructures of code
but like there's just other benefits
around there and so we could just kind
of have to understand
um the difference there because it's a
bit fuzzy with kubernetes okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to do here is
look at popular infrastructures of code
tools and also describe declarative
versus imperative so declarative we'll
start with that so declarative means
what you see is what you get it's very
explicit it's also more verbose but
there's zero chance of misconfiguration
so these would use scripting languages
like json yaml xml or a kind of hcl and
so every single cloud service provider
generally has their own tool or they use
a generic one
like terraform but for
azure we've got arm templates and
blueprints for aws we have
cloudformation for google we have cloud
deployment manager for everybody else we
have terraform uh does ibm cloud have
their own i don't know i think you would
have to use terraform for that and
oracle cloud you definitely use that um
but terraform is this one where uh it's
it's designed to be um multi-cloud right
on the imperative side we have uh you
say what you want and the rest is filled
in so it's implicit
less verbose you could end up with
misconfiguration
does more than declarative because
you're able to utilize full programming
languages that does come with additional
complexity but it can be worth it so
things like uh the aws cloud development
kit cdk or pollumi are two options there
um but it's interesting because when
we're talking about infrastructure code
there is the
managed infrastructure
or managing infrastructure of the
cluster but then there's managing
infrastructure in the cluster or app or
application infrastructure and that's
something we'll talk about here next
okay
[Music]
all right so for kubernetes
infrastructures of code can be a bit
squishy a bit confusing because the idea
is that you have uh infrastructure that
kubernetes has to run on like virtual
machines
like cloud service providers self-hosted
data centers but then there's kubernetes
components like things inside the
cluster and so i'm just going to try to
help you understand that it's all
infrastructure but we might just have to
contextualize it so there's managing
infrastructure of the cluster and
there's managing infrastructure in the
cluster and the tools that we use will
be a slightly different because when
people think of infrastructure as a code
they're going to default to something
like cloudformation terraform but um you
know it's not going to solve all of our
problems and so let's just talk about
some of the differences here so if we're
managing infrastructure of the cluster
this is stuff that the cluster is
running on the virtual machines or
managed services like eks google cloud
engine or or what have you and so those
can be set up with a tool like a
traditional tool like terraform or cloud
formation or
azure blueprints or arm templates or a
deployment manager use the provision the
cluster and manage services so like
relational databases or things that you
don't want to put on the responsibility
of the cluster alongside the cluster
itself okay so
that's the recommendation now for in the
cluster
you can use terraform okay you can
technically use terraform because they
have this manifest module and basically
you're just rewriting your manifest
files like the yaml files as hcl which
is the the base language or the the
language of terraform files
and so the reason you might want to use
terraform is because you benefit from
the state management provided by
terraform and that way you'll be able to
kind of detect configuration drift and
things like that kubernetes already
manages state within the controller
manager and std so it's kind of like
well
uh terraform manages state but
kubernetes already managed the state do
we need two things in energy and state
and there could be other ways of doing a
configuration drift like using the
admissions controller so it's debatable
whether it's worth the extra complexity
to manage things in the cluster using
terraform but definitely of the cluster
terraform or cloud formation or what
have you is totally fine when we're
talking about managing in the cluster um
i like to put the thing in front of it
application of infrastructure so things
like pods services ingress anything that
you would deploy as components and it's
recommended to package these as helm
charts and use that in your ci cd now
you think well couldn't i just take all
these manifest files and put them in a
github directory sure but there are some
synergies by using helm because it's
just easier to like
helm deploy than it is to put things in
there and so this is kind of where we
see a separation of those two could you
use ansible
i guess i wouldn't recommend it
but these are the two that i generally
think that would be good and i think
terraform would be good for the cluster
because if you use it once um it's that
won't be too hard if you ever have to
move uh to another provider and if
you're using kubernetes that's one of
the benefits so you know why not use it
okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at get ops so
get ops is when you take infrastructures
of code and you use a git repository to
introduce a formal process to review and
accept changes to infrastructure as a
code once the code is accepted it
automatically triggers a deploy so
here's the general example here where
you have some kind of iac tool like
terraform
and you actually commit
the changes to your code and this also
could be like helm packages and things
like that in the mix to your github
repository uh so a pr would be generated
and it could be auto auto approved or
someone can review it and press a button
it gets merged into the main branch and
then some kind of
cicd tool this is github actions but it
could be
argo cd
it could be
uh jenkins x jenkins
um flux and then from there it would go
to the cluster's providers to affect the
managed managed services or it could be
going to kubernetes to
you know affecting components or things
like that or rolling out a hem helm
package there to get our changes so uh
the most important thing is that it's a
formal process review and accept changes
of infrastructure code by via a git
repository so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at ci
cd models
and before we do i just want to mention
a couple terms if you're not familiar
with them the difference between
production and staging so production
commonly abbreviated to prod prod or
sometimes even pro
is the live server where the real paying
users are using the platform and staging
is a private server where developers do
a final manual test as a customer like
doing quality assurance qa before
deploying to production and so this is
our ci cd pipeline or life cycle
whatever you want to call it deployment
life cycle we have code build integrate
test release deploy
okay and so for these it's going to vary
because there are some different terms
like ci cd and and what have you so
let's just take a look at uh what
happens here and the first we're looking
at is continuous integration and so
continuous integration means
automatically reviews developers code so
it's this part of the pipeline where you
you have code it builds it integrates a
test but it's not rolling out uh for
release okay
then you have the concept of continuous
delivery so automatically preparing
developer's code for release to
production that means doesn't mean it
gets automatically released but it means
that it's ready uh someone's got to
press the button to get it out to the
server and then you have continuous
deployment so this automatically deploys
code as soon as a developer pushes code
if all tests pass so usually like you'd
have a pr and someone would look it over
but you could just have really good
tests and if your tests say it's okay
basically that's like the a-okay to go
roll it out so just understand that
there's ci cd here and that continuous
delivery and continuous deployment share
the same initialisms and i think some of
them uh might do like a forward slash or
not a forward slash indicate the
difference between them i don't do that
they're both just cd um but just
understand that um you know that these
share the same one and continuous
deployment is the one that does
everything whereas delivery is like
delivery as in here's the thing but
you've got to open it up uh to do
something with it okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
argo versus flex so the cncf have two ci
cd projects that serve the same purpose
but take a different approach and both
of these are in the incubating stage so
they're all both safe to use unless
you're super enterprise and you have
some kind of concern
but we have flux and argos let's talk
about the difference so flux was
originally developed by weaveworks
it takes a cli first approach it's
experimental web ui is a plug-in so you
can get a visual thing it supports
role-based access controls it supports
multi-tenancy in flux too so if you're
using flex one you won't have that it
supports helm and customization and
that's the logo for weworks uh it has
automation of container updates let's
take a look at what argo does so it has
both a cli and web ui so it's had a
little bit more to start with supports
role-based access controls supports
single sign-on supports multi-tenancy
helm customization case on it jsonnit
manual commit and sync to update
containers and so you might say well it
looks like argo basically has almost
everything so why not just use it well
generally flux is simpler in design and
cli focused so if you need to get off
the ground real fast flux is very
popular
if you want a simple solution
but you know they do have a lot of
overlap and you'll just have to decide
for yourself which one it is you want to
use
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
jenkins jack and x and cloud b so
jenkins uh what the you
piece of garbage
oh god
all right let's take a look here at
jenkins jenkin x and cloud b's so
jenkins is an open source popular
immature cic-2 tool for any kind of
workloads check-ins can be used to
deploy applications onto kubernetes
because it's for any kind of workloads
and jenkins is written in java and have
many plugins for any use case now
there's jenkins so then why is there's
this thing called jenkins x so jenkins x
is an open source cs cd tool for modern
cloud applications on kubernetes
compared to jenkins it's supposed to be
much much easier to use and jenkins x
may replace or merge with jenkins one
day to only have a single ci cd tool for
all use cases but you have two options
here jenkins and jenkins x
and it's good to know like who makes
jenkins and it's called cloud b's this
is the commercial distribution of
jenkins and jenkins x for large and
compliance first organizations clouds
bees was acquired by infra dna yeah for
dna
organization created jenkins originally
so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
circle ci which is a proprietary fully
managed ci cd service to make
deployments easy and seamless and can
support deploying applications to
kubernetes so the key part here is that
it's proprietary
but it is fully managed so it is one of
the easiest deployment solutions out
there but also uh you know it's just not
open source so that's just something
you'll have to consider i just want you
to know a tiny bit about it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at deployment
strategies so a deployment strategy is a
way to change or upgrade an application
and there's two terms that i think you
should know uh regarding deployments and
that is rollouts and rollbacks so a
rollout is when you replace or update
servers with new versions of an
application and the word server could be
just replaced with pods in this case
because the the um
nodes is may or may not be something
that is getting rolled out it really
depends on what happens there we have
rollbacks and this is when you replace
revert recently updated servers back to
the previous version and so there is a
um
a rolling update but understand that
rola is just a generalized term that
applies to all of these deployment
strategies so there are several
different deployment strategies that can
be utilized with kubernetes
some of these
it's a lot easier to do them if you have
like argo or
flux or jenkins
but deployments are built into
kubernetes you don't need to have an
additional tool to do them but you might
be limited in your options and some i'm
going to list here are a little bit more
advanced and probably won't show up in
the exam but you should know them anyway
and that's why i'll go through them but
i'll point out which ones uh that you
definitely need to know versus the ones
that are nice to knows so the first is
recreate so terminate the current pods
and create new pods all at once normally
we call this in place deployment but
they call it recreate then you have a
rolling update so replace one or more
multiple pods at a time
then you have canary so add new pods and
route a subset of your users to the new
server if no bugs or errors occur roll
out changes to all the pods you have
blue greens to deploy an exact copy of
your entire infrastructure and when we
say infrastructure it might not
necessarily be cluster infrastructure
but just application infrastructure
because kubernetes is a bit different
then you swap the traffic and then
terminate the old environment or roll
back to the old environment
in case you know the the new
environment's not working out you have a
to b testing or red and black
deployments red and black they won't
come up but a to b might
very similar to canary so
the idea here is that
you aren't necessarily tearing down um
that alternate traffic you're leaving it
up for a subset of users to test
features um and so you know it's just
the difference between temporarily or
permanently then we have dark launches
so this is similar to a to b testing
except it's happening um
like the a to b is happening
at the application
layer so
um it's not it doesn't require
a rollback or anything like that you're
just flipping a switch in the code but
we will go in detail and show you a
diagram of each of these so that you
thoroughly understand them but like red
and black deployments dark launches
that's not going to come up but
everything else should and you should
know them pretty well okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at a
recreate a strategy so the idea here is
that it will terminate all running
instances and recreate with a new
version when i say instances we're
talking about pods
and this is also known as an in-place
deploy that is generally the term used
in clusters providers and everywhere
else but here they call it a recreate
and so the way you'd specify that is in
your deployment file
in your replica set probably in your
deployment file because i can't imagine
you can do it other places
but in your spec area that's where you
define your containers you can add a
strategy and just specify the type as
recreate so i'm not showing the whole
file there for you but it's as simple as
that so let's just kind of visualize
this so we understand so imagine we have
an app running
and i put argo cd there but you know
it's not like the perfect diagram but
the idea is that
we're showing argo as the deployment
tool but you don't necessarily have to
use it um and so the idea is we
terminate all servers and there's a
period where the traffic is interrupted
now recreate would work really really
fast so the downtime would be very
minimal but it would happen
uh new servers are created and uh we
route traffic to these new servers so
users will experience downtime
it can be very fast very simple but
rollback
is not possible i mean it's possible to
roll back to the previous version it's
just not possible to roll back to
running servers so i think i should just
clarify that because with deployments
you have a deployment history so there's
definitely something we can roll back to
but it will mean that we have an
interruption again right so it'll be uh
you know rule forward
interruption roll back
interruption and not rolling back to
something that's running so this is
ideal for non-production workloads or
where interruptions can be tolerated
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
rolling updates so these slowly replace
pods one by one or based on as many as
you want to specify and this is the
default strategy of kubernetes so
imagine you have um some instances there
or pods running and you terminate uh an
amount of pods so in this case we're
terminating one and then we spin up a
nude pod to take its place so as you can
see this is the new pod here
uh and then we tear down the old one and
then replace that one there and so
we are all done and so again you can do
that in
chunks or sets
um
and you can you can have it so that it
either terminates first or
if you want you can have it so that it
spins up a new one and then tears down
the other one which we'll talk about
here in a second so with rolling updates
you have reduced availability and i put
an asterisk there because it really
depends on how you configure it which
might happen while each set of pods is
taken uh taken terminated as the new
ones are created rollbacks can be slow
and hard deploys will be slow
because it's doing one at a time or
a few at a time
so
let's just talk a little bit more about
availability because that's kind of an
important thing that might get glossed
over here that you need to consider so
um available what is availability so the
quality of being available to be used or
obtained so if there's not enough
capacity like memory cpu bandwidth to
meet the demand of traffic then users
can experience degraded delayed
experience or no access to services at
all so if you have two servers and you
only have one then you know uh that
means there's more traffic going to that
single machine there may be enough cpu
but you know it might make the machine
slow or the the app might hang
completely so
that's where you have to be careful
about availability so
uh there are some values not sure about
the graphics not showing that there we
go that you can set the first is max
surge and then we have max unavailable
so max search says the amount of pods
that can be added
added at a time and so that means if you
want to
replace two at a time you can do that
and then max unavailable so if you were
to set this to be two and two that would
ensure there would never be a drop in
availability um but the deployment would
have to first because the total would
have to first create the new pods before
tearing down the old ones so i don't
know for sure 100 how this works like
uh when i say that i just mean that i
haven't been deploying a ton of these in
practice i mean this is the default
behavior but you know we don't observe
it to say okay was this server there was
this server not there but i do know that
if you were set two and two or match it
that you wouldn't lose any availability
there okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
canary strategy so the idea here is we
deploy a new version of the app into a
new pod and serve it to a subset of
existing users if there is no error or
bug that has occurred then the rollback
changes to all users by replacing old
pods
with new pods so imagine you have a
bunch of pods let's say we're using argo
because it probably make it a lot easier
and the idea is you create a bunch of
new pods now i show it like as if
they're replacing ones
but uh you know originally like when i
think of canary usually the default
behavior in other ones is that it tears
down some and replaces them so might do
an in-place or add new ones
and stuff like that but the way it looks
like
kubernetes works is it actually spins up
new ones alongside them
so you know that's just kind of a bit of
a difference there but generally the
concept's the same so we'll be fine here
but the idea is that uh we're gonna send
a portion of our traffic um to these new
pods and if we are happy
uh with the traffic like there's no
problems everything's going fine then
we'll roll out uh to all the rest
meaning like tear down the other ones
and replace them with pods with new
versions so we got fast roll out because
you know when you look at um
a roll with a like rolling update it's
just like a few at a time where this one
will just like completely switch all the
ones over very quickly uh it has a slow
roll back
it should not have a drop in
availability because even though it
looks like it's
replacing these ones here these actually
just be additional to these okay
if that makes sense
um and so canary will use the load
balancer weighted rules to only send an
amount of traffic to the carry pods in
the original pods just so you know how
they're doing that balancing there
but there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at blue
green deployment so blue green is when
you completely create a new environment
of all components and you send all
traffic to the new new or green
environment and if it's okay then you
terminate the old blue environment if
anything goes wrong you can roll back to
blue and tear it down so let's kind of
get a visual to understand so imagine
you have uh two pods and you define that
to being the scope of your environment
right
and that's the key thing with blue green
is that
um
you know you could consider
a set of pods to be an environment you
could consider
like a node with everything running it
on a environment you could consider the
whole
cluster
um a an environment so it really depends
on your scope but the way that i was
reading about blue green for
kubernetes is it we're generally talking
about in cluster components defining an
application workload but just understand
that scope's going to change and the
mechanism that you swap on will change
but the idea is we have whatever it is
that we that we have as our
our application and its surrounding
components and so we spin up complete
identical so we wait till it's ready
and then when it's ready we switch over
to it and if we like it if everything's
okay then we tear down the old one if we
don't like it we can just switch back to
the old one and so the idea is that you
might have to wait a little bit a while
for the new environment to spin up but
it's going to be faster because it's not
doing one at a time
and it's a lot safer to move back back
and forth so blue green is very popular
but again if you need to roll things out
really really fast
the deployment time can be
possibly slower but it really depends
like how many pods you have so zero
downtime no reduced availability slow to
deploy but
faster than canary if something goes
wrong larger impact to users immediately
instantly roll back to previous
infrastructure so if there's a problem
they're going to be able to resolve it
extremely quickly so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about a to b
testing or red and black uh deployment
uh red black i rarely ever hear but i
mean the concepts the same here so the
idea is that this is similar to a canary
or blue green but the method of
deployment uh is the same but it serves
the new apps experimental features to a
subset of users based on a set of load
balancing rules so the idea is that
you might
you'll have 60 percent of your app on
the old app and 40 on the new app but
the idea is that you're not tearing this
thing down it's not like okay this
feature works related to everybody it's
let's leave it up for a good period of
time and so that's the the context or
key difference between a to b
versus canary and uh red and black
versus blue and green is that it's your
intent to test something over a period
of time and you're not necessarily
rolling back on it
at least not immediately okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at dark
launches this definitely will not be on
the exam but i thought it was
interesting and we should include it so
similar to a to b testing except a to b
happens at the application layer so
within the app code so let's say you
want to test a feature on a subset of
users you code a feature flag in your
app to turn on the new feature on and
off if the users like it the feature you
leave it switched on if they don't you
just turn it off and then the next
deploy you could remove the code if you
wanted to doesn't require you to roll
back at the infrastructure level so fast
rollbacks
so just imagine you have your
applications running on pods and you
could just flip things on and off when
need be so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at how deployment
history command works so you can check
the history of the previous deploys with
the following command cube ctl rollout
history and then the name of the
deployment to deploy hyphen the
deployment name uh you don't need to
have a forward slash in the middle there
uh it's just an alternative syntax i'm
just pointing that out because sometimes
it trips me up
and so here if we did that we could see
the previous revision
and when i did this repo uh deploy i had
to do this
flag here even though this is deprecated
uh because i uh otherwise it wouldn't
show the cause of change so i would
imagine that if you have uh automated
systems deploying stuff like that then
maybe this would be
good in terms of description but this is
a way to see
your history okay
[Music]
let's take a look at deployment rollout
status so you can get the status of your
deploy with the rollout status command
so very similar similar to history but
using the word status and the idea there
is you can see it as it's deploying so
say waiting for deployment and then what
it is successful say that it has
successfully deployed
[Music]
all right let's take a look at
deployment rollback so you can roll back
to the previous deploy shown in the
rollout history with a rollout undo so
you type in rollout undo which
essentially is rollback uh and then here
what we'll see is um
no output when we run the command but if
we were to run a status you can see that
it's uh waiting to do that roll out and
finish and so the idea is we'll roll
back to that previous version okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along i'm going to
show you how to set up your own
kubernetes cluster for development using
a lightweight
kubernetes distribution so kubernetes uh
generally is very hard to deploy and
most people uh like in like for general
use case do not set up their own
clusters for production what they'll do
is they'll use a managed provider like
aws's eks which we might do throughout
this course i haven't decided yet but if
it does show up that might be something
we do
but that can be really expensive because
you have to pay for the control plane
almost all providers charge for the
control plane the control plane node as
we learned throughout this course is a
node specifically intended to
orchestrate and coordinate all your
worker nodes and the pods and everything
so it's like the brain of kubernetes and
on aws at least it's 10 cents an hour um
so there are providers like sivo and so
civo is actually very cost effective
pricing comparison i wonder if they have
it here so if we go here
they might actually compare the
different prices between the providers
so sivo the control plane is free
and this is a guess right and this is at
scale so if you're using this for
learning like if you made a civo account
they'll give you 250 dollars i think for
uh
to start with and for this course you
will not end up spending all that so if
you are really strapped you could use
civo i'm going to be using aws but we
aren't going to be launching eks right
now what we're going to be doing is
launching a virtual machine so that it's
only the cost of the virtual machine
that we're paying if you really have
zero money another thing you can do is
use catacota so catacota is a sandbox
environment by o'reilly and so they have
this section on kubernetes introduction
it is not sufficient enough for this
course but i'm just pointing it out if
you are very very strapped and but you
want to get some hands-on this is an
option for you i would not recommend
doing this as your uh
as first because the problem with
sandboxes is that you aren't going to
experience the hard bits and the hard
bits is the experience that you're
trying to obtain if you go do these
you're going to follow them blindly copy
paste them and the problem with that is
that you're just not going to absorb any
information but i want to make sure that
you're aware of these resources this
would be good for drilling so after our
follow alongs if you wanted to just make
make sure that you cement that knowledge
you could go back here and try catacota
but i think we really should set up our
own uh cluster so we have a few options
we have mini cube con k3s and micro k8s
and so
uh there are four different ones and
they are all a little bit different so
minicube is known for being extremely
easy to use but it requires the most
resources notice it requires two
gigabytes of memory 20 gigabytes of free
disk space but they all kind of require
at least 10 gigabytes then you have
k3s and kind so k3s and kind are
essentially the same thing but kind is
uh it has a wrap around it so that you
can deploy your cluster onto
docker and so
kubernetes k3s is designed to be
directly on bare metal or virtual
machines as you see edge iot whatever
this is made by rancher so rancher is a
company that provides
kubernetes managed services
and the thing is is that uh k3s is not
uh or like the rancher's version of
kubernetes is not the same as kubernetes
it's not vanilla kubernetes you'll see
components in the control plane here
like
kind and flannel these things don't
exist in
kubernetes so there's something slightly
different here
so there's that and then we have kind
which is again it's like k3s it's just
wrapped in docker so you can see the
little boat here to emphasize that and
there's micro
micro k8s so micro k8 is by canonical if
you don't know canonical they're the
ones that uh create and manage ubuntu
and so it's actually really easy to
launch microcase on your ubuntu machine
surprisingly because it uses snap but
what's nice here is they actually will
compare the difference between
micro k8s k3s and mini cube and now i
said k3
k3s is basically kind so just substitute
that with kind because we're not going
to do k3 3s we're going to do kind in
these fall lungs here
but let's just look at some of the
comparisons so vanilla kubernetes so k3s
is not vanilla as i as we saw in that
diagram they had things that were
slightly different that made up a
different kind of control plane uh they
mostly support the same things but here
you can see the memory requirements
micro k8s requires the least amount of
memory minicube requires the most amount
of memory then we have add-on
functionality so micro k8 is very very
uh plug-in driven so like it comes with
nothing and you have to add everything
it's very modular and that's probably
why those memory requirements can go
lower than those other ones mini cube is
kind of like that as well uh k3s you
just get what you get or kind then
there's different container run times
you can run on different ones there's
different networking components that
work with them storage is a bit
different gpu acceleration is if you
would want to do like something like
machine learning um because you can run
machine learning workloads on kubernetes
there's a project for that can't
remember up top my head
so you can see there's kind of a
difference there but they all generally
kind of work the same um and it's going
to be up to you to decide which one you
like to use um i end up using my mini
cube quite a bit but i generally like
micro k8 when i can get it to work
so uh just because it starts up so fast
but yeah mini cube takes the longest to
boot kind is very fast because it's in
docker and then micro kx is like instant
um which should be no surprise here but
uh what we'll do here is um we'll make
our way over to aws and before we can
even run any of these things we're gonna
have to have some kind of uh application
to deploy and so what we'll do is we
will create ourselves from scratch i'll
show you how to do it uh a docker image
and we'll host that somewhere in a
container repository and we will use
that uh as the thing that we will run in
all these different uh lightweight
containers um and so that's what we're
going to do now okay
[Music]
all right so we are going to go build an
application and we're going to use aws
so you will have to go create yourself a
bus account attach a credit card this
isn't going to cost a lot i'm going to
be very careful about spend here it will
cost something but i really don't want
the cost to go over 10 for the entire
month while we're doing all these labs
collectively like throughout the entire
course
but the thing i have to tell you is why
i chose aws so the reason i chose abs is
because it has this a service called
cloud9 which is
a um a cloud developer environment a
cloud ever developer environment is a
developer environment running on the
cloud a very popular one is git pod and
i would have used git pod because i
really like them but the problem with
git pod is that they uh use docker as
the way that they run their environment
and so um they're using docker with um c
groups version one and in order to run
kubernetes on docker you need c groups
version two if you don't know what c
group says don't worry it's covered in
this course we do have to learn it but
we could not use git pod so we had to
use a virtual machine and we could have
just launched any virtual machine up
right we could have
just went over to ec2 instances and
launched one up or or
azure virtual machine but the problem is
is that
there is more work involved launching
those clusters like you have to specify
the drivers and the base image and just
be and you have to install docker and it
became too complicated
and so
cloud9 just makes it really really easy
for whatever reason they just have all
the stuff to to to make the cluster set
up uh super easy um and so that's why
we're going to use it okay so what i
want you to do is go type in cloud9 at
the top here and we will go over to
cloud9 we're going to create ourselves a
new environment i'm going to call this
k-8s env and we'll say this environment
will be used
to run
a
mini cube
kind
and to build
our docker application
okay
and so we'll go ahead and hit next steps
and for this we'll create a new ec2
instance for direct access that just
means that when we launch this and it
has a terminal that terminal will be
directly attached to the virtual machine
and so this will have a virtual machine
attached to it so we have to choose the
size now remember minicube requires at
least two gigabytes of memory and just
to be on the safe side i'm going to go
to a t3 medium notice that it's four
gigabytes of ram uh so we'll do that
and we have some options here amazon
linux 2 amazon linux ami ubuntu and so
ubuntu is fine but sometimes i run it
with like pseudo issues and other stuff
and so amazon x2 i would like to use it
for everything but we can't use it for
micro k8 because it we don't have snap
installed so we're going to do amazon x2
for two of them and then for ubuntu
we'll have to set up a separate one this
will turn off after 30 minutes of you so
if you forget to turn off your
environment don't worry it will take
care of it for you and so we'll go ahead
and hit next step
and we'll go and create this environment
so if you've never calculated costs in
aws we'll just go over ec2 pricing just
so you know what you are spending when
you are doing this stuff and we'll go
over to on demand and we'll look up a t3
medium t2 probably costs the same thing
but i'm going to look for t3 here so say
t3 medium
and this is the hourly rate and so the
way i calculate anything is i take the
adult the the cent amount that's the
hourly and we go 7 30 because there's
730 hours generally in a month and so
that would cost us 30 if we ran this
nonstop which we're not right we're just
going to use it when we need it it's
going to shut off when we when we i
don't need it okay
so while that's spinning up we're going
to see cloud 9. uh you might have this
dark mode or light mode i don't know but
we'll give it a moment and then we'll
kind of just configure it so it's a bit
nicer for us
notice that the keyboard mode is vim you
might be on default i'm using vim
because i like that please say on
default vim is very difficult to use if
you're not a vim user you can also
change
the look of it so this is the classic
dark theme
there's a new flat one
that i kind of like
and so
i want um i want this to be dark i just
think it's nicer when it's dark so i'm
going to go to
preferences maybe and there should be
themes here
and if i drop down here
i can't seem to find it but that's fine
so
there's just one that's really really
nice that i like and it is flat dark but
it's not letting me choose that for some
reason here today which is totally fine
so we'll just go back to
um or maybe it's this one here
uh
this one ah we'll just stay on that okay
we're just fiddling too much but we
already have a virtual machine so this
is an ec2 instance so if we go over
to aws again just make sure you're
logged in there
and we'll sign in here
we're going to go over to ec2
i just want to show you that there is a
virtual machine running
okay so there it is there's our virtual
machine running
and uh the one thing that we didn't get
to choose usually when you launch an
instance a virtual machine you'll get to
choose so we'll say like amazon likes to
we'll go to storage now we gotta go next
here we just get to choose the size but
it defaulted to eight gigabytes right
and that's not going to be enough space
for our virtual machine and by the way
aws has like a new
layout here so this is like another way
of creating a virtual machine very
confusing i don't like that they did
that but um
the problem is this virtual machine does
not have enough storage on it if we try
to create our cluster we're gonna run
out of space um but we'll worry about
that later on so i just wanted to point
that out but right now all we care about
is creating ourself a new docker image
to work with so what i'll do here is
i'll go to the left hand side and i'll
create ourselves a new folder and this
is going to be our app
okay and in here what we're going to do
is create a sinatra app so i'm going to
do sinatra
um
uh docker okay there should be like a
very easy tutorial for us to find here
yeah this one's fine i just need the
base code i know how sinatra works if
you don't know what sinatra is sinatra
is a very very
um simple web server for ruby that's
like this simple
um
and it's just going to be really easy
for us to use okay so what we'll do here
is we'll just go and copy this code here
so this will be the sinatra app so we
will call this
server.rb
oops that's a folder we'll go ahead and
delete that
but we will create a new file here this
will be server.rb we will need a gemfile
that's how we install our plugins
gemfile
and then we need a
config.ru
and i think that's
everything and so we'll go back over to
here and we'll just start copying so
we'll go here and we'll grab the actual
server code they call there's hello i'm
calling mine server just because we
should really call it the server you
know
and it's not copying here we'll try this
one more time i'll right click
sometimes pasting is kind of a pain here
so we'll paste this again
there we go and i'm just going to say
hello world
and that's not hello i'll be able to
take that out of there we will need our
gem file so
if we go back to this little project
here this is all we need
we just need to specify a source
we also need to
choose a default web server so we're
going to choose web brick for that i
know that they left that out of that
tutorial that or it's just an old
tutorial configure you that is for
using rackets away it's like a
lightweight interface for
servers it's not that important to know
you just need to know that you need it
so we'll include that as well
and that looks pretty fine and then we
just need the docker files that's what
we're missing here so we'll say new
file docker file
and then we'll just copy the contents
here
actually i'll take the simpler one here
i don't need all the documentation
okay we'll paste that in there
this is using ruby 2.7.4
so the great thing about cloud9's amazon
linux is that it comes installed with a
lot of stuff so if i type in ruby hyphen
v it comes with a version 2.6.3
right now the latest version of ruby is
probably like 3.0 or something so i go
to ruby here
and we go here we can see the latest
version is 3.1 so just to be safe i'm
going to update the latest one rvm ruby
version manager is a way of installing
multiple versions of ruby if i do rvm
list this is the version installed so
i'm going to go rvm
install 3.1.0 this might complain
and if the reason why is it because it
doesn't know that it's up to date so i'm
going to type in rbm update which is not
the command but i wanted to get the
actual command we have to type which is
rbm gethead
and that's just going to tell it to look
at the latest versions of ruby so now if
i do rbm install 3.1.0 it'll install
that i just realized my text is really
small so i'm going to bump that up for
you okay
so we'll go over here and i will try to
find that font while it is installing
maybe user settings
um terminal okay so terminal we can bump
up the font here
okay code editor
um is the font okay yeah it's fine but i
think we can make it a little bit bigger
this is terminal code editor
here we go
okay that's better all right sorry about
that
i don't think there's much i can do
about these there might be something to
bump that up but i'm not sure so ruby
3.1.0 takes a little bit of time to
install um so we will have to wait a
little bit here but let's just take a
look at the dockerfile if you've never
done docker before
you really kind of need to know a bit
about docker to work with kubernetes
because a lot of times you are packaging
um
images to be used with kubernetes and
docker is the most
common one here
but here we have the ruby version
so this is referencing a
base image
from docker hub so if i was to go and
type in docker hub ruby
okay this is what it's referencing it by
default it's going to pull from here and
it's pulling from this here this 3.1.0
okay so if i click into here it'll
actually show you the content so this is
the uh the way they are setting up ruby
for that image and then notice that it
extends from bullseye so you can keep
going down the rabbit hole but basically
this is just a fancy back script for
installing uh stuff and then packaging
into a container okay we'll go back over
to cloud nine it is still installing it
what it's going to do is say look at the
working directory and take all the code
so
um and then it's going to copy the code
into that folder so create a new folder
on the docker image called code and then
copy the contents here all of these
files into that directory
and then do a bundle install so whatever
is in the gem file install those uh
bundles and expose on port
four five six seven we can make this
whatever port we want three thousand i'm
gonna leave it as four five six seven
and then
uh when the docker image is is invoked
like it's told to execute or run it's
gonna run this command first bundle exec
rack up so that's runs rack host bind on
0.0.0.0 that means to anywhere in the
world you always need to bind to
0.0.0.0 very common for web apps and
then it's going to uh listen or it's
going to run on port 4567 so we're
saying expose 4567 so that that port is
open for the docker uh uh instance and
then uh being able to access that okay
so we will have to wait for this to
finish um
installing and also get back here in a
moment okay
all right so after a short little wait
there it looks like our ruby version is
installed so what i'm going to do is
type in rvm list that's going to show us
the versions there and notice this is
the current version up here
oh sorry it is set to this current one
but i'm just going to say rvm use 3.1.0
just in case and say rvm
[Music]
default
i think it's use 3.1.0
default i can't remember what it is
that's okay we don't have to default it
but now we have the right version of
ruby installed so now i'm going to see
into that app directory and we're going
to do
bundle
install because we want to make sure
that this works before we
turn it into a docker image or file
right so
now that that is ran we can just start
it by typing bundle exect
ruby
server.rb so bundle exec means do this
in the context of what's installed in
the docker file ruby to execute the ruby
file server.rb and we'll hit enter and
we'll see what comes out so it looks
like it's running i'm just going to
close that tab there and if we want to
quickly test now we could open up a port
to see if it's working but
i'm going to open up a new terminal and
what i'm going to do is type in curl
localhost
and it says connection refuse so i'm
just going to check to see what port it
actually started up it actually started
on port 8080
okay so if we go back here and do port
there it is hello world and that's
totally fine
um because when it actually launches
we've actually told it to start on port
4567 okay but by default it's starting
on port 80 but notice when we did a curl
we got hello world so it's really
copying the contents of what was being
served which is html right so it's just
a plain text string called hello world
so that means this is ready uh to turn
into a docker image so docker actually
comes pre-installed on amazon linux 2
for cloud9 not amazon x2 itself but the
version that is being used with cloud9
and so i can just type in docker build
hyphen t
sinatra
sample
and i think that's how we specify the
name i don't do this every day so
yeah there we go and that would tag it
so sinatra
sample and we'll hit enter and that
should create ourselves a docker image
so it's just downloading
stuff and building it
okay this usually doesn't take too long
because we're really not making so much
here but once that is done we will be
able to go and do like docker images so
i'm just going to type docker images for
the time being see what comes up and so
notice that we already actually have
some pre-installed like python node.js
and stuff like that
and
this finished off so fail to register
layer
no space left on the device ah so we
forgot to resize our drive so if we type
in df
um h hyphen h stands for human
df is like disk something i can't
remember what stands for df
is for
report file from system disk so i don't
know the name i don't know what df
stands for but it's going to tell us
about the disk so if we type in df this
shows mounted volume so this is where
our storage is
and one of these is our um our primary
volume and so i can't make sense of this
so what i always do
is i type in hyphenates which means
human show it in human display and so
here we see 10 gigabytes and then we
have 9.0 gigabytes used and this is all
that's available so based on looking at
this this is the biggest volume here we
know that this came with like an 8
gigabyte or 10 gigabyte drive volume and
so this must be the one that we are
using it's already filled up because
docker can fill up
drives pretty darn fast so what we'll
need to do is make our way over to ec2
okay if you're not there we'll just
click on databus logo here at the top
type in ec2 we'll go over here
and we'll just close that and we'll look
for instance if you expand the name we
should be able to see it kate's cloud9
that's the one there we'll checkbox it
go over to storage drag up go over to
the volume and we can see what size it
is uh click into the volume again maybe
and this has 10 gigabytes so that sounds
right based on what we're looking at so
this is where we're going to go ahead
and modify this now if we were on the
free tier video bus which we'd have to
be using t2 micro which we totally can't
uh there is a limit of like 30 gigabytes
to stay in the free tier but we're
already out of the free tiers so and
we're not going to keep this around for
long so it doesn't matter so just make
it 40 gigabytes i know that um uh
minicube said 20 gigabytes but four
gigabytes because we're going to be
running more than just
um a mini cube on it okay so we'll go
ahead and modify that and we'll click
that
now aws should automatically expand it
sometimes you have to
do some weird learning commands to do it
or reboot the server but um elastic uh
scaling should just happen like elastic
uh volumes is something that works with
uh supported images
and so we're going to go here and just
refresh until it's been modified i'm
just watching it here this is probably
the drive yeah here here's the new one
40 gigabytes
and so i'm just waiting for it
uh to do something so it's just
optimizing i don't know if we have to
wait for it to optimize
but what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go over back back over here i'm going to
hit up
and notice that it still says 10
gigabytes
so sometimes i'll do this and it will
show up and sometimes it requires a
reboot
i'm not sure if it's because it has to
finish optimizing
and i don't know how long it's going to
take to optimize so what we're going to
do is we're going to go back over to ec2
or instances and we're just going to to
reboot it you don't want to terminate it
that would lose all of our work we can
stop this instance and we will not lose
our work we can reboot this instance and
we'll not lose our work but we'll go
ahead and reboot
sometimes reboot will take down cloud
nine but if see how it's reconnecting
but because reboots are so fast it
should reconnect without us having to
close this and reopen it okay so just
give it a moment to do that
we'll go back over here
now if it still says reconnecting okay
it reconnected we're fine okay so um
sometimes if it takes too long i'll
close it and reopen it i'm gonna close
these things here and so now if we hit
up
we can see we're 40 gigabytes so we
should be fine to
go and build that docker image so we'll
go ahead here and hit that again
unable to prepare context unable to
evaluate simulation docker file
no such file or directory it's because
we're not in the right directory when we
restarted it put us back to the root
folder there so we'll type that in and
we'll hit up
and we'll let it go again and so these
were already downloaded so
i guess it downloaded again but
sometimes it doesn't have to download
twice
but we'll just give it a moment here
so we'll just go over to here type in
docker images
notice that ruby's been downloaded says
2.7.4
um
maybe that was already there because
ours is 3.1.0 up here did we save this
file
i'm not sure if we saved it
so if it wasn't saved we'll just have to
do this one more time
yeah so i think that was the problem
there so if i hit up docker images
notice like the sizes are showing up
here so
we might not want to have this image um
let's see docker
remove uh ruby
2.7.4 i don't use docker on a regular
basis but i'm just trying to
remember how to do it
there we go and so if i hit up here just
because these are all taking up space
right
and so yeah 2.0 2.7.4 is gone and now
there's a 3.10 we'll go back here this
has been successfully tagged and so this
docker image if we go back over here is
right here right it's somewhere on the
machine
um but we need to actually now put this
into some kind of repository so we can
use it
and um there are things like docker hub
and other things like that but we're
going to use aws's solution because it's
very cost effective
and we're already using aws so why not
so i'm going to go back to aws
amazon.com
we'll sign in here so i just have
another tab i'm already signed in but
just how their home page works at the
top here i'm going to type in ecr and so
ecr stands for elastic container
registry that's a place that is like
it's like a git repository specifically
for docker images we're going to go
ahead and hit getting started we want
this to be a public repository just to
save us a lot of trouble we'll call this
sinatra
sinatra example
and uh notice we can upload this stuff
so we'll say this for linux now this
will be public facing so people will
know where this is
generally don't share that out because
you don't want to be paying for a
traffic going out of aws because that's
something eight of us will charge you
for but for uh for our purposes no one's
gonna know what our url is so it's
totally fine
and we're gonna go ahead and create
ourselves a new repository
and it creates it pretty quick almost
instant and then we click into the
sinatra example and up here we have the
view push command so these are the
things that we will have to run in order
to push it now when we use cloud nine
this already has our aws credentials
built in if you're doing this on your
own machine you'd have to install the
aws cli and it's a big pain in the butt
but with cloud9 it's already directly
integrated with aws credentials so it's
going to be super easy so i just copy
this line here
okay and what that does is it gets our
login password and stores some
information for ecr okay so go ahead and
hit enter so it has stored credentials
so notice here it says your password
will be stored unencrypted in this
config.json so it's storing temporary
credentials here
for us to use ecr i don't think they're
long-lived i guess they're long-lived
because they're living on the machine
then we do our docker build that's what
we already did
and then here after the bill complete
tag your image so you can push the
repository so we copy that we go back
here and paste it
no such image sinatra example so maybe i
did not spell it the same way here so if
we go back
and type docker images
and we'll just scroll up here so is this
spelt the same way
that's all i can think of that's wrong
sinatra
example so sinatra sample
oh okay
so what i'm gonna do
because that's a bit silly i'm gonna
just go ahead and delete this one we'll
say
docker remove
image
sinatra sample
or sorry it's image remove i think
okay and we go back to docker images and
we can see it's been removed and we'll
go back over here and this time we'll do
example
and actually just to do a sanity check
will actually just copy what's over here
to save us some trouble
okay
we'll paste that in there
and this will be a lot faster because it
already has the ruby 3.10 image so built
a lot faster we'll go back over here
we'll hit up to docker images you can
see that it's there with the proper name
and we'll just hit up until we get back
to this tag so we're going to tag it
great and we'll go back over dcr and we
will go grab our next line and this will
push it
all right and so what it's doing is it's
actually pushing it over here
so if we go back and refresh
we're going to wait till it shows up
here go back here and watch it as well
it shouldn't take too long
and it's pushing all i think the layers
so like every each one of these lines
runs as a layer so
that's all the layers that it's pushing
and there's obviously layers within
layers when we look in the base image
there as well but it's almost done you
can see it's a little bit bigger than
i'd like it to be but that's what it has
to be
and it's pushed so we go back here we
give it a refresh
there it is so it's 361 megabytes so
it's a little bit big we click into this
here nothing super exciting you know it
just shows that that it's there but now
we have our docker
application
that we are going to run in kubernetes
okay so we can go we'll leave this tab
open we'll go back here and uh we'll
start
installing mini cube
[Music]
all right so it's time to go set up mini
cube so what we'll do is go over to the
mini cube website if you just type in
minicube and getting started it'll have
all the instructions here just note that
you choose the right operating system so
we'll go over to linux
x6x8664 is the type of architecture
we're using
notice there's binary debian rpm we're
using amazon linux
which is based off of centos
but we don't have that option there so
we're gonna have to do a binary download
which is not a big deal
and we can copy it over here on the left
hand side i'm gonna do each line at a
time because sometimes when you do
multiple lines it just acts kind of
funny doesn't matter what tab we'll go
to the first tab maybe we'll just cd
back here for a second so we're at our
top level here and we'll go ahead and
paste that on in here and hit enter
okay and so that has been downloaded and
then the next line is going to now it's
now that's down with the binary we can
see that it's right here but we need to
i guess extract it out and then put it
in a executable location so we'll go
back over to here and notice this is
sudo install and it's going to install
it into user local bin which is where we
always put things on linux when we're
installing binaries and so now i should
be able to type in minicube
good and so you can see there's a bunch
of commands here
um you know you can pretty much follow
through this but i i we're not going to
do exactly this but i know all the
commands now since i've done this a few
times so let's say mini cube start and
what that will do is it will start up a
cluster for us it'll do all the work for
us
notice that it detected that we're
running on amazon linux 2 so it's that
smart that even knows about amazon linux
distribution it's starting up a control
plane it's pulling that base image
notice we didn't have to specify it's
going to probably be using docker as the
driver uh normally that's something
you'd have to specify is like the driver
in the base image but we didn't have to
deal with that we didn't have to install
docker so we're saving us some trouble
but this would have been the base image
that we would have specified as like a
flag to it
it does take a little bit of time to
start up but it's not a big deal things
that are really nice about mini cube is
that you can actually use it to run not
just a single cluster but multiple
clusters so if you wander around more
than uh one
kubernetes cluster you just have to
specify a different port number okay
so i'll give that a moment to start here
and this is taking a tiny bit of time
it's not going to take forever but we'll
give it a little bit of time here
great and it's done so here it says cube
ctl not found if you need it try mini
cube
cube ctl so cube ctl is what we use to
interact with kubernetes um it's a cli
interface and so you can install it
independently i've been finding that
it's been causing some troubles in some
cases so i don't always install it but
we can try to install it but i'll just
show you here the fact that if you run
mini cube ctl it will install it within
the context of mini cube so we can type
in mini cube cube ctl and do hyphen
hyphen get pods
okay
notice that it's installing cube ctl for
us but it'll always only work when we
type in municube ctl we have no pods
running if we do hyphen a
it shows all possible pods so
technically there are pods running
because we have cube system namespace
where we're running things like core dns
at
etsy or etcd
api server control manager the q proxy
the scheduler storage provisioner if you
don't know them now don't worry
throughout this course we're going to
learn about all these components so if
you come back into this tutorial uh
later on it'll it'll totally make sense
but anyway um so this is running and we
can see all of them there it might be
kind of a pain to keep on running mini
cube cube ctl so i suppose we can try to
install it so we'll type in cube ctl
install
and we'll see if we can just quickly
install if we can't it's totally fine
we'll just kind of
dial that back there but it says
download the latest
binary here so we'll go here
and it really depends on the version
that you're using so this is stable and
i'm hoping that it's the same version i
don't know how to minicube how to check
what version of kubernetes we're using
if we scroll up maybe we might see it
somewhere here
so i have no idea what version is i'm
going to assume that it's using the
latest and we're just going to luck out
and have both here if it doesn't you can
always uh fall back to that mini cube
qpctl so if i do ls here's cube ctl so
it's a binary and so
and i'm just going to make sure that we
did it for the right environment so
yeah linux okay
we go back here we need to make it
executable so we type in chamod chamod i
can't remember what it stands for man
chamod here it is change file mode bits
okay because just because you download
file doesn't mean that you can start
using it you have to
say that it's allowed to be executable
so it's safe to use so use in the
context of user a plus x is for it to be
executable
um as far as how i remembered anyway and
we'll hit enter and so now uh it should
be executable so if we type in um is it
shown i just can't remember now
oh yeah sorry it's just lsif and la if
we type in ls hyphen la
notice here that
there's these things here and whether
it's sex cable or not will
flip i thought it was just yeah it's the
x over here because there's three
different user groups there's everybody
there is um a particular user or
something that's broken up into three
that if you see that but the x's here
mean that it is executable but we don't
want to leave it here because then we'd
have to always type this like cubectl
pods
which is kind of annoying like this
because we can't just do this
right so what we'll do is we'll move it
into our use your local bin directory
which is the standard place of putting
things we'll need sudo because you need
you need pseudo permissions in order to
move cubes like a binary into that
directory
so we'll type in uh cube or sorry move
sudo move cube ctl
user local bin okay and now if we type
cube ctl
it's everywhere okay so that's going to
make things easier for us
so now we don't have to do that whole
mini cube
uh hyphen hyphen thing which is kind of
annoying okay um but anyway we'll just
clear that out there and we'll type in
cube ctl get pods as you can see there
are no pods running so that's what we
want to do we want to deploy
that and so sinatra is kind of like a
ruby on rails app so i'm just going to
go to google and we're going to type in
ruby on rails uh kubernetes
tutorial and i think honey badger has an
okay one and they make it complicated
because they have like all these
different kinds of files so they have
um
like they show you how to start the
cluster and they have a config map and a
migrate job we just want to deploy it so
what i'll do is i'll copy the deployment
file they have here and by the way
everything i'm doing here will end up in
a repository anyway so at some point i
will point us to that i'm just doing it
on the fly here so bear with me here and
so we have that deployment file and i
want to just put it somewhere so i'll
make a new folder here
um i'll call this one
k8s
i mean you can call it whatever you want
doesn't really matter
new file and just say deployments
the reason i'm getting confused is
because normally i would call it app but
i made that for the actual app itself
and so this is for the kubernetes files
but we'll go in here we'll paste that in
and there's a bunch of stuff in here so
if we go to the top here
specifies api version and this is for a
deployment now we could call this a pod
right but generally in kubernetes you
don't deploy pods directly which we will
do in this course to show you but you
always do deployment so that it can set
up pods for you so you have an
additional layer of stuff and then you
will have a bunch of metadata so it's
not you don't have to have this metadata
but generally kubernetes recommends like
they have recommended labels so if we go
recommended labels for kubernetes they
have a bunch here and they're actually
supposed to have all of these here right
like this insane amount here but um
for our purposes we'll leave the name in
because we will need some kind of label
to do selection we'll delete out the
process one because we don't need that
we're gonna just call this sinatra
sinatra
and then we need the name of the actual
deployment so the name of the deployment
will be sinatra
okay so you could do this to make a
little bit clearer
and um this should be sinatra as well
and then we have our docker image which
we'll talk about here in a moment so the
idea here is that you have
a deployment it's called sinatra we're
going to provide a label as recommended
by kubernetes so that if we need to
select things or
isolate or group things based on labels
we have that then we define our spec so
that's
spec is specifically for pod spec files
so we're specifying the template for our
prospect file we have a selector so
selectors are required in order for this
to work because we have a deployment we
need to select
the correct um
template and so this is a bit redundant
but you have to have it i think it's
like selecting from here to here
we talk about selectors in the course so
don't worry about it too much but the
idea is we will need that
then spec is actually where we define
our containers
we only have one container defined this
one wants to run on port
3000 which is the default port for ruby
ruby on rails or changes to 4567 because
that's what we decided to make ours
uh this is for config map we're not
using config map that is for
configuration uh environment variables
we need our image and so for our image
we'll go back to ecr and we're just
going to grab the image uri so it takes
basically these kind of urls here we can
paste that in and we'll take that you
can use that for docker hub or all other
kinds of ones this one it's public so we
don't have to worry about trying to
authenticate to a private repository i
don't even know how to do this i've done
it before but i don't remember off the
top of my head but i'm sure it's a pain
in the butt so we'll skip that we have
this image pull policy so image pull
policy means
every time this pod is deployed or do
you pull the image every single time or
only if we never have deployed it before
pull it once i'm going to set it to
always just because
just in case we have to change it it's
just going to make it a pain if we have
if not present okay then we have our
name here we'll call this sinatra
okay
and then we have our ports so container
port is going to be
port 4567 because again we said that
that's what we're running it on and then
we have a readiness probe so we'll learn
about readiness probes within the course
but readiness probe just says like
it determines whether this is running or
not so if for whatever reason
our
our application decides to not run
like it's broken or something and the
radius probe can't reach it so it's
sending out a um an http request to this
path and it doesn't return it a status
200 then it will fail okay so we'll do
four five six seven we could not have
radius pro but i'd like to have them in
there so we'll leave them in there just
because it was already there for us and
so we have our first deployment yaml
file okay super exciting again don't
worry if you don't remember all the
stuff even for this uh course it might
be or sorry for the certification course
the kcna it might be a bit overkill but
you know the more we do the better the
better we'll be prepared okay
so
now that we have our deployment file we
are ready to do a deployment so we'll do
cube ctl apply hyphen f
and it doesn't matter if this is a
deployment file a config set file or
anything you're always going to do this
apply hyphen f thing like apply and
specify the file because kubernetes just
has one way of of setting up stuff and
it's always through this way here so
we'll do app deployment
oh sorry it's kate's right k8's
deployment here
we'll hit enter and here it says the
deployment sinatra is invalid spec
template yaml invalid selector does not
match the template labels and this has
happened to me before so
let's just quickly carefully look at
what's going on here
um
how did i fix this last time so the
deployment sinatra is invalid
spec template labels
spec template metadata labels so spec
template
metadata
labels
hmm
i don't see the problem here
because spec
template
ah metadata
labels invalid value map string
kubernetes so it's saying this is
invalid
okay um what if we just delete it and
see what happens okay i don't remember
if i needed it or not
spec template metadata labels all right
so i can't remember what's wrong with it
but the great thing is i already have a
repository for this because i already
done this ahead of time and so i'm going
to go pull up our example repository
this will be the repository that i will
share for the course but it is just one
i created temporarily as i was going
through this so i'm just typing off on
the side here to get to it okay
and
so it is this one here it's basically
the same app
um
actually no it's not here so one second
i got it on my other computer so i'm
going to pull up my other computer and
i'm going to just quickly take a look at
what the difference is
because i can't even tell here
okay
so i'm just going to look here
starting at the top here this is fine
and then under spec selector it has this
so this is fine oh it's a spelling
mistake and you're probably staring at
this the entire time being like hey
andrew you have an obvious spelling
mistake i'm dyslexic i'm very sorry i
cannot notice those mistakes so we'll go
there but it was clear it says saying
spect template metadata labels and
clearly that was the problem there so
we'll go ahead and hit enter and it says
that it's created so what we can do now
if we want to see this
is type in cube ctl get deployments
okay
once you start using a little bit of ctl
it's very very easy to use and we do
cover in the course how this the the
patterns to ctl but it's like if you
want to know pods you type in get pods
right it's very straightforward so here
we can see we have a deployment says
zero out of one is ready we'll go back
to pods and we'll say that it is running
it says zero to one that it's ready um i
don't know if we can do probes we could
try probes
probe
see i i don't know i just i was just
trying there um
but what we'll do is we'll type in
deployment and we're just waiting for
the probe to determine that it is
working so now it says one out of one so
it definitely is working and remember
that is running on port
um
uh four five six seven now i don't know
how to look up the ports here but i do
know um that we can try to just kind of
like ping it there so what we'll do
is type in um
curl
localhost 8080 or sorry 4567 and we'll
see if we can reach it okay
okay so it says failed to connect to the
port
all right and that's totally fine
because
just because we set up a pod doesn't
mean that the pod is immediately
available in order to access that we
need some kind of service okay so that's
what we're gonna have to do next um
or we might be able to just do port
forwarding but we'll figure that out a
moment i'll be back in a second okay
okay i'm back so
all right it was what i thought it was
but what we were doing was we were doing
port forwarding so when you have a pod
running kubernetes you uh by default it
is not available like it's uh externally
uh the pod has a dynamic ip address and
so normally what you'll do is you will
attach a service to expose the pod or
have a way of getting to the pod right
so there's no port and
load balancer and
things like that but a very easy way
without even having to use a service is
to just use uh port forwarding so
there's a command if you type in cube
ctl and we type in hyphen hyphen port
forward or sorry not we don't need the
hyphen hyphen that was when we're doing
minicube so we type in port forward and
then we can specify that we want this
deployment called sinatra
um which is our deployment file yeah
it's called that there here
and what we can do is say forward port
um i'm just trying to think like usually
port 8080 is what you have to use cloud9
if you want to expose it to the internet
so do 8080 and we'll say 4567
and we'll do address space
0.0.0.0 you have to bind to 0.0.0.0
or we can't see it outside of
this cloud9 environment like into the
web browser so hit enter and so that is
forwarding for forwarding um that port
okay i know it looks backwards because
you'd think like four five six seven
would point to eight zero eight zero but
that's just
how they showed okay
so now what we can do is go back over
here and if we do a curl
uh we'll just say localhost 8080.
now that's saying hello world i think if
we do um
hyphen l it might show us more
information nope okay i was trying to
see if we can see like html as well but
i guess it really is just text but let's
say we want to see this in our web
browser so for cloud nine
um
we need to expose port 8080 so
because by default the security group is
not open on the ec2 instance so we go
back to our ec2 again if you don't know
where that is type in ec2 at the top
here is that cloud9 environment we're
going to go over to security
inbound rules and this is all that we
have is we can s or sshn which is not
very useful so what we'll do is click
onto the security group
and we're going to go ahead and edit the
inbound rules
we're going to add a new rule and this
is going to open on port 8080. now
cloud9 can only run on like in the open
on port 8080 and 8081 so we couldn't
make this 4567 if we wanted to or 8 000
okay
so here i'm just going to say my ip so
the idea is that only this computer that
i'm on right now can access this that's
a very secure way of doing that and just
say andrew's computer
for some reason you can't put hyphens in
here and exclamation marks but we'll hit
save that rule and so now that port is
open
so we can do is go back to ec2 however
you want to get there click on instances
and what we need is the a public ip
address of this so we go to the
networking tab and there's that public
ip address
and we'll go to the top here
we'll paste it in here and we'll do
8080. and so there it is it's exposed to
the internet now this is obviously not
what you do in production but this is
just a very easy way uh to do that so we
didn't cover services which is fine
we'll cover that later because right now
we're just focused on learning how to
use
uh you know uh like launching a cluster
and stuff like that there's one other
thing i want to show you with minicube
and um that is the ability to run a
dashboard okay so um there's a thing in
kubernetes called the kubernetes
dashboard
kubernetes dashboard okay
and it's like a plug-in i'm just trying
to find it here
okay see this and it's not specific to
minicube it's just it can run as a pod
and then you can access this and it's
just kind of like a nice way a visual
way of seeing the stuff that is running
in your kubernetes cluster and so uh you
know we have figured out how to do that
it was quite the pain
to figure out how to get this exposed um
on um
cloud9 but i do
know how to do it so the first thing we
need to do is we need to stop our
cluster
okay
so i'm going to type in
cubectl or sorry minicube
stop because we need to start this and
make sure that it's listening on 0.0.0.0
remember i told you if you're not
listening on that things can't reach
outside cloud9 it's just it's a very
common um thing that you need to do is
bind on port zero zero zero even when
you're deploying a real world web
application you have to do that so what
we'll do is type in mini cube start
hyphen hyphen listen
address
and then here we're going to do equals
0.0.0 if you're running like how do i
know all these commands i just go and
type in mini cube
mini cube start commands and then here
this is how we figured it out we just
went here into the docs
nope that's not it
maybe it's this one here here it is and
it just tells you what all these flags
did so we went through this and said
there must be some way to bind right and
so that's how we found out that you
could do the bind that way okay so what
we'll do is we'll go ahead and hit enter
and so that will make it so that
our um that we're binding on there
notice that is restarting everything
pulling the image i don't i think that
since we stopped our cluster our
deployment might be gone so we'll have
to wait for that to start there
but once that starts we'll have to also
set up a proxy a kubernetes proxy so
and make sure that that address is also
on 0.0.0 and then also disable filtering
because there's just so many
preventative measures and proxima that
we have to do so it is running i believe
so we'll type in cube
cube ctl
get pods
okay notice that our our app is gone
which is totally fine
so what i want to do now is i want to
start up
a proxy so i'll type in cubectl
proxy oops
address equals
0.0.0.0
and then we'll disable the filter
we'll say true all right and so that's
going to start up a proxy and it's going
to allow us to be able to um get things
out of the cluster all right because if
we don't do that we're not going to be
able to do much there
and so now what we can do is we should
be able to start in another tab um the
dashboard so we type in minicube
dashboard url and by the way like if you
already had a regular kubernetes cluster
you'd have to install it but this is
just like a shortcut that currently does
for you i'm doing i've been having url
because if i don't it would try to open
it up in the browser right away which it
can't do from cloud9 so we just want the
url
and so here it's going to
export expose that address and so we
have this address and it's really funny
looking which is totally fine
um i think actually we can open up port
8 000 i think again in the 8000 range we
can open up on cloud9 so what i'm going
to do is go back to
ec2
uh we actually already have a tab open
here so i'll use that one here and i
want to go back to our security groups
and i'm going to edit inbound rules i'm
going to add a new one here and it's
going to be for 8001 and this is for um
technically this is the web app
uh
sinatra app might make more sense i
wrote andrew because sometimes when
you're working with multiple people
you're running what this ip address is
for right
and then this one is going to be for k8
dashboard
we'll save that rule there
and so i think
what we can do here
is copy this
go up here change this to eight zero
zero one assuming that's what uh we
specified everywhere else i think that's
what everything defaulted to place that
in there fingers crossed and there it is
don't explain to me like don't ask me
like how these ports and all these
things work i'm not very good at
networking i know enough uh to get
around but
i just have the instructions that we
figured out that works but here we can
see all of our stuff so we go to cron
jobs and stuff
or pause and see what is working and
what is not so what i'm going to do now
is go back to this environment here
and this tab is taken up and this tab is
taken up so we'll go here and make a new
terminal tab
and here we'll type in cube ctl and
we're going to deploy our app again okay
so we'll say deployment yaml and we'll
go ahead and create that
and what we can do is go back to our
dashboard here and look we have a pod we
have a deployment
one out of one it started really fast
okay so this is kind of nice as a visual
we can click into it
we can get some some kind of data with
here which is really nice okay
and so with that running now um
it should oh we don't have port
forwarding so if we went back to this
here right
okay and we tried 80 uh 8080.
okay we're not going to see anything so
we'd have to go back and forward that
port so we'll go ahead and make a new
terminal tab
cube ctl
port
forward i'm trying to do based on my
memory here
um address actually would be we have to
specify it so deployments
sinatra
and
it would be
addressed
uh 0.0.0.0
and then it's
80 to 4567
okay um we'll just hit up till we get
the right command
so what did i get wrong cubectl port i
forgot the r i always forget that and
the flag is over here i don't think it
really matters what side it's on we'll
hit enter we'll go back over here
and there we go so that is minicube okay
so nothing super complicated there and
what i'll do is i'll go back here and we
will just stop this
and we'll type in cube ctl
i don't know if it's still running let's
go back here is it still running
does that stop the do that stop it
cube ctl
get pods
okay so it still is running so we'll
type in mini cube
stop
and i'll power that down there
just stop these other tabs here we'll
close them for now close
and we'll close and we will close
okay
and so that's mini cube and so we'll
move on to
uh doing kind next okay
[Music]
all right welcome back and so this time
we're going to go ahead and use kind so
kind seems very similar uh to
mini cube so it'll just be up to you
what you decide that you want to use for
your local development
but what i'll do is just to make things
a little bit easier i'll just close some
of the tabs we have here
let's just do a little bit of cleanup
here
i don't need a mini cube open up here
and so we'll take a look at kind then
we'll close some of these tabs here
so kind as a tool for running local
kubernetes clusters using docker
container nodes primary design for
testing kubernetes itself but may be
used for local development and ci a lot
of people like it because it's like a
lighter version of mini cube and can be
very very fast though a mini cube can be
very robust and useful in a lot of cases
it just depends on what you need and how
small you want to go here so
to install it we'll go over to the user
guide here
and i believe the way i installed it was
from a binary but we'll go to
installation here we'll take a look here
so notice we'll see package managers
like brew that's for mac os choco
which chocolate which is like brew but
for windows mac ports which is an
alternative and then for linux it's just
going to have to be a binary which is
not a big deal so we'll be copying these
lines here so we'll go back over to
cloud nine here uh oops i forgot to copy
the lines here but we'll go and copy one
at a time so we'll first curl
and make sure we're in the environment
directory there you might have to cd
back there to do that and just type
clear again
we're having some funny business where
it's just showing that top line there we
go
which is fine i guess
uh but we'll paste that in there
and we'll go back to the quick start and
we'll do chamond notices plus x you
could do u u plus x that's just what i'm
used to doing but it doesn't really
matter and then notice it's going to say
some kind of directory but the directory
we want that to be in is going to be the
user local bin so we'll go here
and we'll type in user local bin
and this is not going to work unless
we do this okay
and so i should be able to type kind and
there it is okay
and so now that it is installed we'll go
back to
quick start
and we need to create our cluster so
creating our cluster is very
straightforward it should be a concrete
cluster we can even name our cluster if
we want but we'll just go ahead and do
that so we'll say
kind create cluster
and we'll give it a moment there and it
should start up a cluster now remember
we have cube ctl already installed so it
should be pretty easy but i think if we
didn't we could probably do kind cube
ctl as well
um but anyway this is supposed to be
faster than minicube um
and we'll give it a moment here it's not
feeling much faster but when i was using
it before i felt it it felt really
blazing fast but i'm not sure what's
going on
it is taking some time to create that
control plane which is totally fine
um oh there we go so installing c c and
i storage class things like that so set
cube ctl context to kind kind
um oh it did okay so you can now use the
cluster within here so cube cluster info
to get some information so we'll do that
so it says kubernetes control plane is
running here core dns is running here
to further debug and diagnose cluster
problems use cube ctl cluster info dump
so if we type in cube ctl and we were to
type in um
get pods we can see there's no pods we
could do hyphen a notice that it has
looks like a different amount of pods so
we have core dns and then we have
maybe this is a proxy i'm not sure here
uh we have a control plane running uh we
have kind net we have api server control
manager proxy scheduler path provisioner
local path provisioner not sure what
that is although i guess oh storage path
okay and so you know you can just see
like it's not one to one with mini cube
right so there's going to be a different
amount of pods doing uh slightly
different things
but now that we have it let's just go
ahead and deploy our application like we
did before so what we'll do
is we'll type in um
cube ctl
and that's in our k directory so we'll
say k uh oops apply hyphen f
k8
deployment right and so that should go
ahead and deploy that and
now if we want to see that we can type
in cube ctl
get deployment
and if a deployment ever messes up what
you can do is you can type in describe
you can get more detailed information
and you can type in something like
sinatra works with pods works with
everything and sometimes you get a lot
more information so here we'll be saying
like scaled up the replica it'll say
what it's up to and a lot of additional
information so if you ever have a
failure always try to describe to help
yourself out but we'll say deployment
and we're just waiting for it to get
ready and it is now ready um so that is
started if we do a curl localhost 8080
um notice there's a connection refused
so there's has to be some way for us to
access that
um i'm to remember cube ctl is a
command that yeah it's not specific to
uh to kind or mini cube so we can
probably do that as well so we'll type
in cube ctl
port forward
don't forget the r there i always forget
it deployment
sinatra 8080 4567 because that's what it
actually runs on and then we'll have to
bind it to
uh zero zero zero so zero zero zero zero
enter
and so now
if that's all set up we should be able
to open a new tab here
terminal
and we'll type in curl local host
8080 andrew brown there we go
i never tried to set up kind for a
dashboard so i'm not even sure how to do
it we solved it for mini cube and it was
really hard to solve just because we're
running it in a virtual machine to
expose it
um so i'm not sure if we need to do
anything beyond that but that's just
kind there so it's not super difficult
i'm going to take a look here to see if
i can figure out the dashboard i'll be
back in a second okay
all right so i looked it up and it
actually is a bit involved so mini cube
definitely makes it super easy but like
here it's just a medium article where
they go through that process and so they
say okay we create a kind cluster then
we are going to use helm helm is a way
of packaging uh applications together so
that could make our life a lot easier if
we tried to use helm
but that's a little bit farther in the
course i don't know if i really want to
dig into that but the idea is that you
would add a repository like this github
dashboard so kubernetes github is a
repository like the dashboard is if we
go like kubernetes dashboard
dashboard git hub
it should probably have one here so it's
pointing to this basically
right and in here there probably is a
helm package somewhere here
and but anyway so the idea is that you
do that and you do helm install
dashboard kubernetes dashboard
kubernetes dashboard
so it looks like we it also creates a
new name space
and then you'd have to set up a proxy
and we had a proxy before
and then you'd have this
link and then you'd have to authenticate
because you can't just
log in you have to have a token or
something and so then to log in the
dashboard they're creating um a service
account so that's like a type of role
like permissions that's rbac
and i would imagine that i mean they
didn't activate it but they might have
to activate rbac so you can see it gets
really really involved right so i think
that um i mean this would be good to do
but maybe not right now because it's
very complicated this is more like ckad
or cka kind of material but i just
wanted to show you uh the effort would
be to go get that there so maybe that's
one advantage of using mini cube and
probably will stick to using mini cube
but for kind we pretty much did what we
wanted to do with it just to see that we
can install and it was easy to use so
i'm going to type in kind delete cluster
i think that's probably what it is i'm
just guessing and it still works that's
great and so kind to solve the last one
i want to do
is micro k8s okay so that's what we'll
do next okay
[Music]
all right so we're going to take a look
at how to uh run micro k8s and i found
this one
like it was very fast i like how it's
modular but i found it the hardest one
to use to be honest i mean they're all
generally pretty easy but the complexity
comes because we're running in a virtual
machine like a developer cloud developer
environment in the cloud so there's
additional stuff that you have to
consider um and so
you know if we want to install micro k8s
we'll go to the docs
and uh we will go and look for i thought
it was like on the homepage they
explained even how to install yeah you
go to linux and right away they go snap
use snap if you don't have snap get snap
installed i'm not installing snap uh
that's like a package manager i'm not
installing it for our amazon linux 2 and
since that sounds like a nightmare but
what i will do is go to our dashboard
and i'll spin up a new instance so um we
don't need this one right now i'm going
to leave it open and so i'm going to go
ahead and create myself a new
environment this is going to be
micro
k8s
env
this
cloud developer environment
env just to savor some trouble is
specifically
for micro
k8s and we'll see if we have a little
bit less problems ubuntu is great it's
just sometimes they render problems with
it so it takes the least amount of
resources but still i'm going to run it
on a t3 medium because i just don't want
to have to deal with any kind of like
having to delete it recreate it
run any issues so here we have ubuntu
server
18.04 lts so this one will have snap
snap was introduced in like 14 it's like
a replacement of
uh get install or app install or
whatever you want to call it so we'll
shut off after 30 minutes that seems
fine to me leaving that on the default
there and we'll go ahead and create
ourselves
another cloud9 environment
again i would love to do this and get
pod but unfortunately can't run
kubernetes clusters there right now but
we'll take a look here and see what is
being suggested so it says pseudo snap
install
micro k8
hyphen hyphen classic so if there's
something that's not classic i'd love to
know
but i don't know much about snap
so give it a moment to start up here
and then we'll end up copying this
command doing that command
but notice here like turn on the
services that you want notice with the
other ones that we didn't have to turn
anything on like we didn't turn on the
dashboard we just said start the
dashboard and maybe it wasn't installed
it just pulled it at the time of when we
needed it but with micro k8s you can't
turn on the dashboard unless you enable
it right so everything has to get
enabled so when we start this up it
doesn't even have anything right and
maybe we'll see that when we look at the
pods okay
so we'll just wait here for cloud nine
to start
another way we can observe this is we go
over to ec2 we go to our instances we
can see
them here and it gets kind of confusing
because um
it doesn't show like
the uh
what it is but like we don't have to go
based on the name so i don't think it'll
say here like ubuntu anywhere right so
if we go to our
ami or amazon machine image that's the
thing that's running it oh down here it
says cloud9 ubuntu so we do have an idea
what it is okay but generally sometimes
you can't tell what it is if it's not in
the name like they didn't write it in
the name go back over to cloud9 it is
ready everything is nice and big which
is nice this pop-up is driving me crazy
we'll close that here we'll copy this
and we'll go over to our new environment
and we'll paste in sudo snap install
micro k8 classic
now this is an amazon x2 so it's
slightly different
this is kind of nice i like this
experience
with snap
and it will install good
like i think like when you install it it
actually starts the cluster up right
away
because it says check the status of
community service so you don't have to
say start it just as it's installing and
it starts at the same time so i'm
surprised i would think they would just
like install it and then you'd start it
separately but i guess that was their
decisions there
and while it's waiting we'll just take a
look here see if there's anything else
interesting i don't think i dug too deep
into the docks for microcades i'm mostly
familiar with um
mini cube and i think that's what we're
going to be sticking with throughout
this project
nothing's super exciting here we'll go
back over to michael k8s
and it's still taking time so once this
is done i will see you back here in a
moment okay
so after a short little wait it looks
like it is installed so we'll go back
over to the home page and look at the
instructions here so we have micro case
status
weight ready so wait until it says it's
ready
and it says
insufficient permissions to access it i
like how they're like sudo here but sudo
not here okay so we got to go ahead up
actually has some instructions you can
either try again with sudo or add the
user ubuntu to the micro kh group
i'd rather do this i did this before and
i did not have much luck but i'm going
to try to follow through with it
okay it says after this reload the user
group either via a reboot or running new
grep
new group micro k8s
okay so we'll type in clear
as i was talking about where i started
having issues with sudo
it was more than just this but we'll see
what happens here
so it is running and then it tells us
what add-ons are enabled right so this
is very add-on based as you can tell
so high availability it's it's no so
it's obviously it's running on one node
so that makes sense
what's enabled an h a cluster high
availability cluster which is
interesting because it's not highly
available and then what's disabled right
now so we don't have ambassador uh uh i
don't know how to pronounce that
psyllium ci limb the dashboard's not
enabled dns is not enabled we got
nothing we don't have link or d we have
nothing okay
interesting that we can see some stuff
so like kubeflow we talked about doing
machine learning so it's really nice if
you want to install kubeflow you could
just enable that if you want k native
which is for
kind of like it like set does a lot of
stuff where you like scale down to zero
it's the kind of server stuff you want
an open source framework so it really is
good as as long as you can deal with
ubuntu if i spend more time with it i
think we'd be using this as opposed to
mini cube but i just want things to be
easy okay
so anyway what we'll do is we'll go back
to here
and we'll take a look here so it says
turn on the services that you want so
right now i'm not going to turn on any
services and i want to see if we run
into any friction without having to turn
anything on because obviously there's
nothing but if we type in cube ctl
actually that's not even installed on
this machine so here it says pseudosnap
install cube ctl sure why not
so this revision of cube ctl is
published using classic and thus may
perform arbitrary system outside etc if
you understand i want to proceed run
classic
okay
i mean
uh
micro kh was classic so it must be fine
to do this okay so we'll type in cube
ctl
okay it works great
last time in this i hadn't i could not
get cube ctl to work but uh we'll type
in cube ctl get pods
uh the connection of the server
localhost 8080 was refused did you
specify the right host or port
ah interesting it's not working yet i
wonder why so i think the reason why is
because we don't have anything installed
we don't even have a dns installed right
so like dns is the way
that outside traffic can communicate or
just like
traffic in general can communicate
within a cluster so i bet we have to
enable that so we'll go over here and we
will only enable
we'll only enable dns so i i don't have
micro uh k8 down to a t here so i'm
copying paste we'll type enable dns okay
probably need a dns
and we'll give it a moment here notice
it's say look what it's creating a
service account a config map these are
all kubernetes components deployment
service you learn about all the stuff in
the course um core dns role based access
stuff restarting cubelet and dns is
enabled so now we'll get getpods
and it's still saying this okay i
remember this before
what if we type in
[Music]
micro k8ss
hold on here
okay so i i think this is what i
remember i remember i installed cube ctl
i got this error i have no idea i was
getting that error so then i just by
default it to micro k8 cube ctl and then
i was having less problems so i'm not
sure if we had to have dns to do
anything there but it's really hard to
do anything without a dns in kubernetes
so we probably had to enable it anyway
let's do hyphenate let's see what we
have look there's only three pods
there's nothing here remember how much
there was when we did kind
and
uh the other one like
mini cube
so there's literally nothing we have
calico cube controllers core dns and
calico we'll learn about core dns
core dns is what kubernetes use it's the
dns service here it is covered in the
course we'll learn about it calico is
a very popular um
it's a cat i used to have a calico cat a
long time ago but um calico kubernetes
is a project by uh tigra tiger i don't
know you call it but they are what is
used for
um
uh i don't i remember cni it's in the
course
it's for it's for um it's for something
i can't remember proxy or something i'm
just i'm blanking here but anyway
there's only three things here so
there's not a whole lot so let's see
what happens
if we go and those some things are
pending and some things are running so
let's go ahead and deploy our
application so we'll go here to the left
and we'll go to
deployment
we'll have to copy this over here
and we'll create ourselves a new folder
k8s
don't need a folder but i'm just making
one for fun we'll say deployment.yaml
we'll double click this we'll go ahead
and paste that in there we will save it
scroll on down
and so now we should be able to do mini
cube or sorry
same mini cube micro k8s cube ctl
apply hyphen s
k s application oops deployment yaml
it created it
so now we can hit up because this i just
can't type micro k so i can't remember
how to type it get pods
okay
remember we do hyphenate shows us all
the pods right
and i'm just waiting for that to become
available
we can try deployments as well see if it
was successful
i'm waiting
and we might be waiting on the the probe
here so the probe is what's doing the
business right it's the one that's
saying
hey after you checked a few times then
we can determine it's ready if we didn't
have the probe it'd probably start up a
lot faster but i don't know if we're
missing another component right
still pending
so one thing we can do if we're looking
at this we could probably put the name
in here like this maybe we'll get some
additional information
uh describe instead
describe is your friend
okay so we'll scroll up
aha so we see something here
zero out of one nodes are available has
taint
node kubernetes disk pressure the pod
didn't tolerate if you look this up it
might say like hey you're trying to
deploy into a node that's not supposed
to be there
or
the other issue is that there's we're
running out of storage so let's see
where it says disk pressure like the
disk is under pressure it means the disk
is out of space probably so if we do dh
hyphen f oh it's not even installed
oh sorry d f hyphen h i spelt it wrong
um
we can see that we have
most of it used up so that's our problem
here so it's that problem from before
that we had no biggie we'll go over here
micro khs that's what we want we'll go
to storage we'll go to our volume
we'll select our volume
and we will
modify our volume and we'll bump that up
to 40. we probably don't need 40 but i
just want it to work
and it says it's in use so i think we're
in good shape here and if we hit up
does it auto expand
elastic it's called like elastic
something i can't remember the term 99
percent use so we're gonna have to
reconnect
reboot the server here
by the way if you do have to like stop
and come back to this you can always
just stop these by the way you can
always just hit stop and as long as you
don't terminate you can always start it
back up and we can always pick up for
where we last left off or just let the
um it shut down after a certain amount
of time like if you go back to the
cloud9 interface
you know if you go here
if you close these tabs you can always
just go back to cloud nine and open them
there and they will auto shut down right
but anyway um
we need to restart this so we'll go here
or sorry reboot and we'll reboot that
rebooting is super fast so hopefully we
don't have to close this
but when it does reboot um the cluster
might not be started but i guess we'll
see
so i don't know if we'll have to because
like remember we didn't have we didn't
start the cluster we just installed it
but if it's smart it might always do it
you know what i mean
so it is reconnecting
go back over to ec2 we'll just check the
status here
no it is running
if cloud9 has a hard time reconnecting
you just close the tab
we'll go back to cloud9 we'll just do it
this way
it happens sometimes
and we'll go over to micro k8s
and i'll probably instantly open and
have no issues
if we're lucky i suppose
it's having some real trouble here
go back over to ec2
i'm just going to check the volume maybe
the volume is not ready i think the
volume is ready attached
doesn't seem like there's any issues
here
okay so i'm not sure what the problem is
but what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to take a break i'm just going to
close this tab
i'm going to take a break and then i'm
going to come back to cloud9 i'm going
to launch it and it should probably work
okay if you ever run into problems like
that sometimes it's just worth taking a
break there
but i'll be back here in a bit okay
all right i was gone for like three
minutes i went in here press this button
it launched instantly so we're back in
business here
now is the cluster still running i don't
know so we'll go back over here we'll
say microk status because i don't know
if it's just going to start up when we
restart the machine
and
that is k-8s we want this one right
micro k8
hit enter
and we'll see if it's ready
it is running okay great so we're fine
um i don't think our stuff is still
there so if we type in micro k8s
uh cube ctl
get pods
oh it's still running okay cool well
that's cool like when we when we uh i
don't know if we did it in this but i
know that when i restarted um like kind
or mini cube this stuff did not persist
right they were lost so it's really cool
that it just everything went back up i
think that's actually one of the
benefits of
okay so high availability low ops
minimal pr
there's something about the features
they say like that you know yeah
autonomic
automatic autonomous and self-healing
right
so basically you know if you restart the
machine everything's back in the shape
that you wanted to be which is great
um like the entire cluster like that's
that's awesome um so now that that's
running the question is okay can we
access that of course if we do curl
localhost 8080
we're not going to see stuff here so
this is where we're going to do our
usual
um port forward so port
forward i'm trying to do this from
memory so deployments
forward slash sinatra
um 8080 4567
and then we'll say address
address
0.0.0.0 enter
and i forgot the r always forgetting the
r on that one eh
we'll hit enter and so that port is
being forward and so now if we open a
new terminal
and we type in
curl
localhost
8080. there it is okay so it's the same
thing as before it'd be nice to see we
get the dashboard working um i'm not
sure if that'll be easy but we can give
it a go and see see what happens here so
what we'll do is go back to the homepage
here
and
yeah i think it's just because they had
a couple lines here
where is it where'd it go
oops
that is not what i wanted
oh linux we had to click on linux um so
we definitely need to have the dashboard
installed
we don't need to register our our istio
so i'm going to go back here
oops first second tab here and we don't
want to turn off our port forwarding but
we're going to type in micro k8s
enable
dashboard
now if the dashboard is just accessible
then maybe we'll just stick with micro
case i really do like micro creates out
of all these
um but you know
we'll just see what goes here
uh lots of stuff about role-based access
if rbac has not enabled the dashboard
using default token retrieved with
this in rebac enabled you need to create
a user with restricted permissions shown
in etc
so
we'll see what happens here um
so this is going to assign it to
something uh what if i just paste that
in there
okay so we have a token now that i think
we used to log in but let's see if we
can actually get into the dashboard very
easily i'm not sure if this is going to
be hard
so we'll go and type in the dashboard
proxy so that probably launches the
dashboard or something here
checking if dashboard is running
ah and i didn't get to show this earlier
but what i wanted to show was the fact
that uh the dashboard is just a pod so
if we go to micro
k8
cube ctl
get pods
and we do hyphen a
we should see the dashboard here
so the dashboard is probably metric
server like when i ran it um for um
kubernetes over here
maybe we're still running the dashboard
i'm not even sure no because we stopped
my mini cube so it's not running but um
there was two pods one was the dashboard
and one was the metrics but i'm pretty
sure the metrics one here is the actual
dashboard even though it's not showing
properly here um but we did
start this here i'm just trying to find
um
dashboard ah so micro case dashboard
wait for the dashboard the dashboard
will be available here
at this port number use the following
token to log in
okay so even though we have this on port
i don't know if we can open that port
we'll try it for fun
we'll see if we can just open that port
up but i don't think it's going to work
i think there's going to be a lot more
work there and honestly to get the
dashboard working i i needed a lot of
help i had to pull my co-founder who
knows linux networking a lot better for
me to figure out so
um we will give it a go here but i don't
think i'm going to solve it
we're just going to try to open up the
port
so we'll go here into microkates we'll
go to networking
and we will choose oh it does say
networking i meant security we'll click
on the security group
and we'll edit the inbound rules here
we'll add this and we'll go
and put in this port number here we'll
say uh k8's dashboard
and we'll make it my ip so we don't have
to worry about anyone else trying to get
into this thing and we'll save it and so
now
we'll go back to ec2
and what we need here is the actual ip
address so
we'll go to details
public ip address
we will paste it over up on to top of
kind and then i need the
[Music]
port
which is here
client-side http
gpus to an https server okay so it has
to be https i i will try to do this
we'll advance it's totally fine
oh this is so much easier okay great
because like with minicube it was so
hard to figure out how to get that
address to listen on that that port
number but here's this token or
uh cubeconfig so we can go back over to
our michael k8 environment here we'll go
ahead and copy this
and i'm going to go ahead and paste that
in there and we'll hit sign in
and there we go so we're in
we can go to our pods we can see that
our pod is running here the usage and
stuff this looks i don't know this looks
any different is this the same as the
other one it seems like there's a lot
more going on here
i can't tell because they're not both
pulled up side by side but maybe we'll
say with micro k8s maybe we'll use mini
cube but the idea is that we have both
our environments set up
and that's all i really want to cover
for now so to shut these down what we'll
do is go ahead and
just close these
and i'll go over to ec2
and we will go ahead and just turn these
off so stop the instance don't terminate
them stop them
otherwise you're going to be having a
lot of extra work here and so we have
two developer environments that we can
use for the rest of this course so that
should be fun hopefully that gives you
kind of an introduction into kubernetes
uh just obviously a lot going on there
but we will unravel it piece by piece
throughout this course
and there you go okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i have here is kind of an
amendment to our lab so i did a bunch of
labs where um i'm typing constantly
micro k8s as cube ctl because i couldn't
figure out how to get cube ctl
configured properly so when i run this
like get pods i would get this error
saying localhost 8080 refuse and i'd
look it up and it'd say you have to
configure your cube config file but i
could not find like the examples they
were showing did not work and so
eventually i did figure it out but i
shot a bunch of labs where i'm typing
micro k8s cube ctl and just to save you
some pain i just want to show you what
you can do
uh to fix that problem uh and so you
just do this later on when you're doing
a lab so you don't have to deal with
this but i'm going to type in micro k8s
micro k8
config
and then right angle bracket and then uh
tilde forward slash
um
dot cube
forward slash config just going to
double check to make sure i spelled that
right
there we go and we'll hit enter and so
now if i type in cube
ctl get pods
we're all in good shape so
um i realize that you know depending on
when you're watching this video you
might not know much about kubernetes but
just when you start seeing me type micro
case coop ctl if you just want to save
yourself the trouble of typing that 100
times run this and then you can just
write cube ctl and that will be a lot
easier okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
take a look at a variety of ways that we
can expose our pods via
kubernetes service and we're going to
continue on using the environments we
set up earlier in other follow alongs in
our cloud9 environment uh and just
looking at the costs here it's we're
only at three dollars so we're doing
pretty good for this account here but
what i'm going to do is make my way over
to cloud9 so just type in cloud9 at the
top here and if you uh turned off not
not terminated but turned off those
environments shut them down they should
still be here and so we have that k8
environment with both kind and mini cube
and then micro k8 environment i'm
preferring the micro kx environment so
i'm going to go ahead and open that one
up just because i'm finding that one to
be pretty easy to use
and we'll just give a moment for this
to launch here okay
all right so our environment has
launched here i'm just waiting for our
terminal to appear there we are
everything is nice and big
uh and so we had deployed something
prior so micro k8 is really great
because if you had something running
prior and you shut it down and start the
machine up it should still remain so i'm
going to type in micro k8
uh k8s okay it's kubernetes or cube ctl
and we're gonna say uh get pods
and it would be really nice to use cube
ctl directly i tried looking up the
solution for it it has to do something
with the config file but i can figure it
out so i'm just going to keep typing
micro case cube ctl it's not a big deal
for me and so there's that sinatra
application and it should end up
deploying so there we go so now it's
running again so we don't have to worry
about deploying uh that sinatra app
again i'm going to see what services i
don't think we have any but we'll just
double check so i'm going to type in
cube ctl
get services you can also type in svc
which is the shortcut but i'm going to
stick to typing things
full out here but on the exam you might
actually see uh initializations which is
kind of frustrating because they really
should just always use the full names
for people learning but here you can see
that we do have a service here which is
for kubernetes and it's a cluster ip
this is the system one that always shows
up here so we're not going to touch this
one but just showing you that it does
exist
and before we actually
even go ahead and launch a service let's
talk about pod communication so if we go
back here and type in get pod
we should see all the pods that are
running and so we only have one which is
sinatra uh but this actually has an ip
address and so what we can do is type in
o
which stands for output hyphen o which
is a flag type the word wide and we'll
get additional information so here we
can get the ip address um there's the uh
the node that is running on things like
that
so every time a pod is terminated or or
stopped or whatever
it will have a new ip address and
because
dynamic ip addresses make it really hard
to make microservices because your ip
addresses are changing all the time it's
going to be really hard to communicate
and so that's the purpose of services is
that it can have a static ip that's one
reason to have it but let's kind of
observe what happens if we were to um
terminate this pod okay so what i'll do
is i will copy the name of the pod here
and we will put in micro
k8s cube ctl and i'm going to say delete
pod sinatra
okay
and what we'll do is just go to the top
here and i want the wide and notice that
even though the pod is destroyed because
there's a deployment it's going to
always launch a new one because it
expects there to be one pod but notice
that we have a new ip address so it's
not the same one the old one was ten one
twenty two nine the new one's ten one
twenty two thirteen so that's an example
of that dynamicism happening there now
if we wanted to communicate with that um
like right now the ip address is here
but we are not within the node
and so if we were to try to type in if
we go up here for a second and we were
to try to take this ip address and we
were to write something like uh curl
localhost
8080. okay it says connection refuse
because you know these are internal uh
internal traffic within the cluster were
not inside the cluster
so how could we communicate that without
a service so one thing that we could do
is we could um uh basically uh a remote
login into
a pod and that's something that you can
do in kubernetes and so
one thing we can do is uh launch a new
pod and so what i'm going to do is just
type in service debugging kubernetes
because the commands that we want are
there
and so if i pull up the documentation
here they have a couple commands so we
have
this one where it says
if you want to run a pod you can run
this one called busybox and if you've
never heard of busybox we do cover it in
the course and we might have already
covered it before this tutorial but busy
box is basically a um
it's a
container and it already contains a
bunch of utility libraries that we can
use right and so it's just a really easy
way to get started so if we go back over
here and we look at this what it's doing
is saying create a new pod
never ever uh restart this so if we if
we terminate if we like we exit the
command line it will or the shell it
will delete and use the image from here
so it's on
the google's
container repository here called busybox
and it's going to launch bash so we can
interact with it so what i'll do is go
ahead and copy this
go back here and we'll type in clear and
we will launch that and so what it will
do is we'll launch up a new pod
oh sorry we're going to type in micro k8
in the front here
but it's going to launch up a new pod
and it's going to enter us into bash and
so if we go over here we can now type in
micro ka test if you don't have a new
tab just go here and open a new one here
and we'll type in cube ctl get pods and
so we can see busy box is running
all right and we could have written our
own deployment file or pod file in order
to provision it it's just a lot easier
to just write it at this one line
because as soon as we terminate this
it's going to oops we'll type exit it
will then kill the pod we don't have to
worry about it so if i go back to here
okay see the pod is gone but what i'll
do is go hit up on my keyboard to bring
back that command and it's going to
enter us back not did not just launch
the pod but enter us into the pod so we
can execute commands so we are within a
pod and so technically pods can talk to
other pods because now we're inside the
cluster and so if we were to type in
let's say the other the other one runs
on four five six so if we typed in
localhost four five six seven let's see
if that works okay so we'll say
locals4567 and we will do
curl here and so oh curl's not on here
so we'd have to type in wget
okay so w get and that same thing as
curl and so it says connection furiously
remember pods
communicate sorry containers within a
pod all communicate on localhost but uh
pods have their own ip address so let's
go back here and type in o
wide
and we can see there's an ip address
here so if we were to copy this ip
address
okay paste it in here put w get in the
front
and then do
oh sorry 4567 right 4567
it's able to access that index.html so
if i just do ls which lists out all the
files there it is and we'll check the
contents of it by typing cat index.html
and there it is so we were able from one
pod uh to communicate with other pod by
using its dynamic ip address okay but
you know if it
if we kill that pod or it gets replaced
uh you know that ips is going to change
and that's where that pain comes from so
that is what i want to show you the pod
so next we'll move on to our first
service which will be cluster ip okay
[Music]
all right so what we're going to do is
take a look at
launching our first service so a service
allows you to attach a static ip address
and also can do load balancing to
multiple pods that it selects and so
what i'm going to do here is go to the
top and we'll type in service kubernetes
because most of the code is here we can
just tweak it um and i always like to
show you where i'm grabbing the code
from so here's to finding a service and
so this is an example of one
but we want cluster ip if we scroll on
down here um
i mean that one up there is cluster ip
but i'm just trying to see if they
actually have a very specific one for
cluster ip
nope okay so that one up there is
cluster ip okay so we'll go back to the
top
i'm going to go ahead and grab on this
one here and we'll go back over here and
i'm going to create in our folder here a
new file i'm going to call this one
service
cluster
ip.yaml
we'll double click into this and we'll
go ahead and paste that on in there and
so one thing is that we
will need metadata so the the metadata
name will be the name that shows up when
we do
uh get services so i'm just going to
type in
service
cluster ip
and then we need your selector so
uh i'm actually going to
leave the selector incorrect so i'm
going to go here and do sinatra
uh i'm going to go over here and see
what this is called so this one is
called uh sinatra yeah okay so i'm going
to call sinatra and then down below we
have the port so tcp is great uh port 80
is the port that we want to access
within the cluster so we'll say 8080 and
the target board is four five six seven
so very similar to when we were doing
port forwarding right which technically
probably was creating service and also
proxy at the same time um and then down
below here are we still in this
environment let me just type exit if we
didn't exit busy box there and we'll
just type in clear and so
a few too many tabs here i'll close the
first one um i don't care about that tab
but uh so the idea here is that we will
um
uh provision or deploy the service and
so we should be if we're within the
cluster access that port 80 uh um the
pod via port 8080. so what we'll do here
is type in micro k8s and we'll type in
cube ctl
and then we will type in
um
apply hyphen f
k 8 s service cluster i p address now
notice i didn't actually specify a kind
and i just kind of want to point that
out before we proceed forward because
notice these ones have
uh there's like a kind option here so
normally you're supposed to do
well maybe it's not there let's go down
to
uh node port will be an example that
shows us here
i'm just trying to find the code example
so under type for spec it would be here
okay so if we go under here
and we set cluster ip
okay that's how you know it's cluster ip
but if you don't specify it will
automatically be cluster ip so even if
we don't have this here we dilute it out
it's still cluster ip and this should be
two tabs two space tabs otherwise we're
gonna have a lot of trouble here
um and what we'll do is hit enter okay
and so created the service and so we can
type in micro k8s
um
yes or sorry cube ctl
get uh svc services
and so notice here that we have our
service cluster ip it's showing us it's
cluster ip type and it has a cluster ip
address so this service now has a static
ip address of 10 132 183 and 8 and any
um
any pods that are associated with this
like that are linked through them
is going to be accessed through this
static ip address that's never going to
change okay we can terminate pods all
day and they will be the same
and so you can see that it's for port
8080 okay so that's the the port that
we're going to need it on the question
is did we properly
select the pods and so one way we can
tell is if we were to go ahead and type
in details so if we go micro
k8 or sorry describe and then go
service
and then put the service name here
we can get some additional information
uh that was described
it is described i'm probably spelling
around describe
maybe services
oh you know what i'm forgetting cube ctl
here
cube ctl
okay and so we get some information so
it's in the default namespace
notes it shows labels none
uh annotations none selectors name
sinatra cluster ip single stack ipv4
that's its ip address
but notice down below here
it says endpoints none so in the course
we'd say that
endpoints is the way a service
links to pod or pods and if there are no
end points then that's an indicator that
this service is not selecting the proper
pause and so there's probably a mistake
with their selector which there is i
purposely did that because i wanted to
show you uh that end point now what i
want to do is i want to now go back to
our busy box example that we had earlier
so i'm just hitting up to grab that and
if you want to find it again just type
in service
debug
kubernetes and get that link and so
we'll enter in here whoops
did you specify the right host report
oh yeah sorry micro k8 in the front
again
so we'll go ahead and enter here and so
theoretically what we should be able to
do is use the cluster ip address
right and type in wget
and do um
8080 and it should be able to download
that page but notice it says can't
connect to remote host because it's not
linking to anything okay so we'll go
ahead here and type exit we'll type
clear just to clean things up here and
what i need to do is i need to update
this because this is incorrect so
there's a couple ways that we can update
this we can just change this and do an
apply
um or we can use the
i'm to remember the name of the command
because usually i'll just i'll just
update it and apply it but it's
oh i can't remember let's go take a look
here so we say cube ctl commands
it's in the course
um
we got viewing updating
not replace patching so probably with a
patch we could probably do it so
i rarely ever run patches but let's give
it a go and see if that works if not
we'll just update the old way
or the way that i like to do it but what
we'll do here is type in micro
k8s
cube ctl
patch
and then probably the service name so
we'll say service
and then it's called service
cluster ip
just to make sure i'm going to go here
and type in svc so i can see the name
yeah it's service cluster ip if i just
made a spell mistake i'm just double
checking we'll hit enter
and it says must specify patcher patch
file containing so we'll just say patch
okay that didn't work as i thought that
shows you how often i do patches here
but
oh here goes hyphen p okay so basically
apache what you can do is kind of change
the value here so so do hyphen p and
then provide json
um
right i guess we can do it that way it's
not as clean as i'd like but
i guess we'll see here
so i mean the other way is probably
edits
but it's not great to edit things
on the fly i'll try patch for fun okay
so just to make this a bit easier what
i'm gonna do is go over here and this is
the actual proper selector that we need
now you know it's too much work we're
just gonna do an apply because i'll do
this in another video where i'll show
you how to do patch properly
just because it's kind of a pain so i'll
do hyphen f
and we'll do k8's service cluster ip
it says that's unchanged oh because we
never updated anything okay so what
we'll do is copy this because this is
actually the way we're going to select
it
and we'll go back here and then paste
this on here oops in here
and so now
we will then go apply that and if we go
back over to here and we do get
cvs
okay and then we go
uh describe
cvs
service cluster ip
we've got a spell right if we want to
work
we can now see that there is an endpoint
all right and so that should suggest
that it's now pointing to the correct
pod let's go take a look at the pods and
see if there's any new information there
so get pods
um
oh hyphen wide
and so notice that it says that the ip
address is 10 1 22 13. so if we go up
here and look at the cluster ip its ip
address is
10 132 8 um
183.8 but notice that this is the end
point so this one is going to point to
this endpoint okay so it doesn't matter
that this ip address is not the same as
the cluster ip because it will be
because it'll just forward this when we
access it through the service
so what we'll do is go back over to here
it will hit up until we hit micro okay
it's cube ctl and we start our busy box
and so this time what we'll do is go
ahead and grab the cluster ip address
which is this one here
and we'll go ahead and paste this in
we'll do
8080. we'll do wget
and notice to download the page and so
we'll just do cat index.html
okay and so you know that's showing that
we're we're able to access that
um
that pod through the
service cluster okay
so that allows other pods to be able to
communicate with a static ip address
which is really useful
so type in exit
i will type in clear and so that's
pretty much
all there is for the cluster ip now i do
want to show you expose because expose
is a easier way
or just a like one liner of being able
to
launch a service so i'll type in cube
ctl service command and we'll see if we
can get some kind of examples here
and type in uh expose
and so create a service for this is
replicated nginx
and it should be easier than that
um
yeah replicate that's for replication so
we should be able to do it for deploy so
let's see if we can try to do this uh
running this one command here because
that's what a service is doing is
exposing pods by giving a static ip and
giving it a point of entry so what we'll
do is go back over here i'm going to hit
up until we get to rsvcs and all i want
to do is go ahead and destroy this or
delete this so we'll type in micro k8
cube ctl
um
delete
svc
uh
paste and then we'll go back up here
make sure that it's gone
it is gone and i want to try this micro
k8s
um cube ctl expose so it's gonna be
exposed
and we're gonna what do we wanna expose
want to explore a deployment and so
we'll need to know what our deployment's
called it's actually just called sinatra
so i can just type in sinatra
sinatra
and
um looking at our
cheat sheet here
okay so it's going to be
whatever it is so this is a
replication controller set or whatever
and so then it's the name and so the
port and the target port that's what we
want to
adjust here so we'll paste that in and
so our port is the port that we want it
to be
on the cluster and then it is the port
that we're listening to for the
container or the pod which is four five
six seven so if we hit enter
and we go back up here and hit up we
will see now that we have
um a service called sinatra so it didn't
change the name it probably is a flag
for name not sure what it would be
um but
the idea here is that it has a service
here with the cluster ip here and so we
should be able to access our
um our pod the same way so we'll go back
up over to this on the left hand side
we'll go back and launch our busy box
and what we'll do is go ahead and grab
this ip address here
and actually before we do that let's go
and do a describe on this
i'm just hitting up to find it from
before and we'll type in sinatra
and notice that it's pointing the end
point to 10 1 22 13.
and its ip address is this and so we'll
go take a look at our pod again or pause
with the hyphen o wide and notice that
is the ip address over here so
definitely is working properly but just
for fun in our
busy box we'll just
triple check here to make sure so i'm
grabbing the ip address of the
service and we'll type in wget paste and
we'll do 8080. notice that it downloads
if we cad it index.html it shows the
contents of that file so we'll type in
clear we'll exit busybox and so that's
just another way and so expose can be
done
uh you know with any other one so if you
want to do node part as well i think you
just put the the flag
kind hyphen have inclined but i prefer
to uh do it always through the yaml
files because then we can take that code
and commit it to our repository and have
infrastructures of code or what have you
there which i think is just a lot easier
to do
but anyway we'll go back to our services
here and i just want to go ahead and
delete this one here so we will type in
a micro k8
cube ctl
um
delete
svc
sinatra
and i've seen some people where they
literally just have to type in key uh k
and then you know delete svc but you
know
just for us we're just gonna be typing
it over and over again but that's okay
because then you will know it uh
by heart and you'll pass your exam no
problem by being able to remember all
these commands
but anyway um so that was cluster ip and
i guess we'll move on to node port next
okay
[Music]
all right so we are back and this time
we are going to have a service but this
time it's going to be a node port so
what i want you to do is go to the top
here we'll leave our cheat sheet open
just in case we need it i want to type
in service kubernetes i'll go back to
the documentation here and i'll scroll
on down and i'm looking for
uh one for node port so we scroll on
down keep going here and we have
multiport service which shows that you
can have more than one port which is
great
uh and we'll make our way over to node
port so here is our node port example
and so i'll go ahead and copy that
and we will make a new file here and we
will call this service
node port yaml
okay and we'll double click into it and
we'll paste the contents of it and i
will just bring this down here for a
moment so we can see what we're doing
and so this one's going to be called
service node port
and the type is node port which is fine
and then the selector needs to be uh
this label here so it actually can match
and uh that's the clustering p once
we'll close it and so we will paste that
on in there
and then here for containers it
specifies the environment variable port
four five six
uh seven we don't need to pass any
environment variables so i'm pretty sure
we can
can we safely delete this there's a lot
of stuff i always look at this and
wonder if the indentation is incorrect
oh whoops you know what um
we are in the wrong file i was modifying
this one by accident here just making
sure i didn't mess up our deployment
file
sorry we actually want to go to this one
here okay so
um service node port type node port
selector app my app and i was going over
deployment because i just wanted to copy
the contents over here so we'll go here
they're all the same so it doesn't
matter which we pull from from there go
ahead and paste that on in there and
notice that we have um three port
numbers okay so these are confusing the
text here so i'm going to delete these
out and we'll write our own descriptions
here so the port is the port that you
want it to be
for
in cluster so the in cluster
port
so or we could say
the
port
number
that
[Music]
resources
within the cluster
we'll use
to communicate
okay and then you have the target port
so the target port is
um the port that we are targeting so
that would be so this would be probably
80 80
is what we'd want and this would be four
five six seven right so
uh the port number the container
uh is listening on right because we told
sinatra to start on 4567 and then the
node port is
the external
uh
external port
to uh connect
to the node all right
so i'm just going to make it 3000
30 0001 all right so hopefully that
makes sense but it'll make sense here in
a moment when we actually put it into
action i really wish this would default
to two spaces
probably is the way here because the
thing with the ammo files is they're
highly sensitive to indentation and
they're supposed to be two-spaced by
default so just to make sure we don't
have any more problems here i'm going to
just double check here and see if i can
find
um the indentation levels i'm just
trying to think about where that would
be we'll go to user settings
interface maybe
indents indentation
uh indent
uh cloud nine
setting
that's not useful i just can't remember
where it is honestly
oh anyway we'll just have to be careful
about that it's not a big deal
i just don't want to spend all day on
screen scrolling here or stop the video
just to try to find that option it's
really not that big of a deal but anyway
so the idea here is we want to be able
to without even launching busybox we
want to be able to do uh sorry curl wget
is very similar but curl is just easier
to use and we want to be able to do
localhost
8080 or sorry 3001 right 30 0001 and so
that's the idea here is that we don't
have to we can access
the service outside of the cluster right
okay
so what we're going to do here is go
ahead and launch our new node port
service so we'll type in micro k8s
cube ctl
uh apply hyphen f
service
i love to type it by hand here i was
trying to hit tab to auto complete it
and we'll hit enter
and i forgot to type the folder name
here k8s forward slash notice there's a
folder we'll hit enter
and created the service so we'll type in
micro k8s
cube ctl
get
svc
for service
and
there it is notice we have a cluster ip
address
and so that is assigned right now there
is no external ip address
so i guess we'll have to take a look at
that in a moment here
um well i guess
we don't yeah because we don't have an
external ip address so external ip
address would be for if we set up a load
bouncer because we need an external ip
address for external load bouncer to uh
forward it's or like to find the actual
service so that makes sense why we don't
have an external ip address let's see if
we can just get more information on this
particular service to see if there's
anything new here i'm not expecting
anything but let's just take a look here
and see if anything is different
so whoops
head up here and did i type it wrong
micro k k disk cube ctl describe svc
service oh i typed it wrong yeah
all right and so we'll take a look here
and see what information we have so
default none none that's totally fine
it's targeting this so the selector
looks correct here it's node port single
stack that is its ip address uh the port
here and then here it tells us the node
port we can see that the endpoint is
working so it is going to something
all right and so now what we should be
able to do
is type in curl
uh we'll try the localhost here and
we'll do
the port number here
okay and notice uh that we're able to
access it outside of the cluster all
right so that was what was uh very
impressive okay
um
and so the next thing
that we can do here is just check the
cluster ip like just as we did before so
what i'm going to do is go ahead here
and launch
up a micro kx cube ctl
with the busy box
and we will go and just test this
cluster so we'll go grab its ip address
and we'll type in wget
and then we'll do 8080
and we can see that we can access that
file again
okay
so that is node port all right and so
now that we did no port i guess the next
thing to do would be to do um the load
balancer one before we do that let's go
ahead and just make sure we get rid of
that service so we'll say get svc i'm
going to copy the name so i i have to
figure it out we'll hit up we'll type in
delete and we'll paste that on in there
and then we'll go back and hit up again
and see that it's gone and so now we're
ready for load bouncer
[Music]
all right welcome back uh so we are
going to do a service and this time we
are going to use the load balancer type
so what i want you to do is create a new
file here we'll just type service load
balancer and i want to tell you that
we're not actually going to be able to
complete uh this service
type here at least we might do it in
another follow along if it is easy
because we might launch uh eks and if we
do then it'll be an opportunity for us
to use the load bouncer i'm having a
really hard time typing this balancer
dot gammel
okay
and so we'll go over here and again if
you don't know how to get there we'll
type in kubernetes
service to go to the official
documentation and see if we can grab
some code to work from and so i'm going
to just type in load balancer because i
just want an example of one maybe click
through here and so here is an example
we'll go ahead and copy it
and we will paste it in
to the file here
and we'll change the name so service
load
balancer
and we need the selector to match our
actual application here so we'll go back
here and paste it on in
whoops we'll try that one more time
that doesn't work it was just right
click copy right click paste
gives us less trouble here and so
there's a few things here we have
the ports
so again it's like what poor is it
running on so this would be port 8080
for our service target port would be
four five six seven
um notice that it's specifying a cluster
ip address and then we have a type load
balancer and then we have status load
balancer ingress
ip address 19202 127. so what is going
on here well
the thing with service load balancer
it's used for connecting to an external
load bouncer so the idea is that you do
something like
um an abs would be
elastic or elb
so
if we go here those are the load
balancers for aws
so if i go here and create a load
balancer we're not going to do this
right now because it's not going to work
if we do it this way but the idea is
that aws has load balancers um there's
nginx right nginx has their own called
nginx plus
all right
so that is a load balancer that we could
use or if you're using azure it has a
load balancer if you're using google it
has a load bouncer and the idea is that
you can
have the load balancer from the service
provider be used to distribute traffic
and make sure your application's highly
available which is recommended for
production use case and if you were to
use one you'd be using the network load
bouncer because i don't think you can
use the application load bouncer in this
way you always have to use a like a t3
or sorry
level three slash four load bouncer
um because application load bouncer is a
bit more tricky but the idea is that
when you launch
uh this here
right and if you like if we if we were
using eks
right so we launched up an eks cluster
which is a managed kubernetes service
and we were to launch this load bouncer
it would automatically provision us a
network load bouncer and would connect
it okay and so this configuration is
going to vary based on your provider so
if we go back over to here and look at
load bouncers notice down below
it tells you that if you go here and
like you look at gcp aws
there are some very particular
configurations or for if you want
logging or stuff like that so
we're not exactly going to be able to
be able to do this here but we could try
running this i don't know what we'd have
to do for the cluster ip here um
i mean i guess it's the cluster's ip so
if you go to our cheat sheet maybe we
get some information here
if there's a cluster commands maybe we
can do cube ctl cluster info and see
what there is
so i'll go here and type in micro k8s
okay and so
i mean it's running
127.0.0.1 i don't know much about this
because i haven't really done this yet
but maybe we'll know more when we go
through here but i figured we'd just try
something here i don't think we always
need this value here so i'll go ahead
and delete this and we'll just see if we
can actually run it if it doesn't work i
don't care um but i just wanted to give
an attempt here to show you but
hopefully you understand the idea behind
the service load balancer that it's for
connecting to external load balancer
service we'll type in cube ctl i'm going
to type in apply hyphen f we'll type in
k8
service load balancer
yaml
and we'll scroll up here and so we can
see here is that it says um the service
is invalid cluster ips
invalid value failed to allocate this
value the provided value is not in the
range okay so what if we just go back
and put this value in again i'm not a
networking expert so i'm not sure what
we can put in here i'm going to try it
one more time and just see if it even
works
okay so we can't do that so i'm not sure
what to set for this right now but if we
do get ek set up
we'll give this a go but i just wanted
to show you the service load balancer or
just make an attempt here and explain
why
we're not going to be able to do this
locally now technically we could
probably set up nginx plus because it is
open source
and you can deploy it so if we did like
engine x plus
kubernetes
uh load balancer
service
there is a tutorial for it on nginx
right so we could do this but it's a lot
of work i just want to show you kind of
the diagram they here have here so
um you can see that you have nginx plus
load balancer going to the controller
going to the pod and
i guess the svc somewhere here that's
not a very good diagram
but if we go down here it should have
all the instructions nope this is not
the right one
let me use this one here
i have the link on my other computer i'm
just trying to find it very quickly here
just to kind of show you how many
instructions there were
maybe try this one here
they're not making it easy for me so i'm
just going to pop on my other computer
here just so i can see what the link was
that i was looking at
um
so
i'm just gonna double check here
engine x plus
load balancing kubernetes
service
and just see if i can find the link here
i think it's this one
yep this is the one so
if you were to follow this i think this
is how we could actually uh install a
load balancer to test it out but it's a
lot of work and it's out of the scope of
this course so i just kind of want to
show you this article showing what
they're doing so here they say okay we
have some uh
nodes here
and actually that's something that we
haven't even done is ever ran this
command let's go back over here and take
a look the nodes we have
um oh sorry
micro k8s
okay so we have one there which is kind
of interesting
and then down below
we've actually never ran api resources
might be fun to run
again micro k8s we need that in the
front
this is a command that does show up on
the um
uh exam and so i probably will make a
separate follow along and show this part
but this shows us all the i guess api
endpoints that are available things like
that if we go back over to here
uh first we choose the first node and
add a label to it so they label it here
they're using replication controllers
which i think are old i don't think
you're supposed to use replication
controllers anymore in kubernetes
they are replaced with replica sets
which is what we cover in the course
okay so they basically make a replica
set
uh and what that is doing is launching
nginx plus as a pod
in your cluster okay
and i guess you label it because maybe
you're targeting a very particular node
for it to run on
and then you what you're doing is you're
grabbing the docker image so you're
saving it i guess they're loading it
um they're configuring nginx because you
probably have to configure information
so you put the stuff in there
you go ahead and
create the replication set it's a
replication controller i'm going to say
replication set you can see that the pod
is running so that you have a
load balancer then you are getting the
node information so you're getting the
external ip address of it
and then you're able to access it
and so i guess here they're creating the
service so this one i guess would be the
load bouncer one
i don't see the type so this is a
cluster ip address because we don't see
the type there
um
this is i cluster ip none so that makes
it a headless one i'm just looking to
see if they do load balance here
okay so this is definitely not an
external load bouncer because if it was
they would use load bouncer but i guess
the load balancer can i mean i guess it
is but i guess load bouncer can only be
used with public cloud service providers
like the ones that are defined over here
if we go back up to the list
right so we don't see the nginx plus in
the list here so i think that nginx plus
is a load bouncer that you can use
but i guess that would technically be an
internal load balancer because these are
all external ones so
just to confirm
i guess i was wrong with the nginx plus
but it is interesting to see that there
but uh yeah so the service is really
only intended to be the load bouncer
type is only intended to be used with
external ones there but that's all we
need to do for that one and there's one
more type for kubernetes which is
external name and i guess we'll give
that a go next okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking still at service but for the
last type which is external name so what
i want you to do is create a new file
here we'll type in service external name
yaml
okay and we'll open up that file and
make our way over back to our service
kubernetes page that i hopefully you
still have open and we'll type an
external name at the top you can just
search it and command f to do that and
here is that example there so we'll go
ahead and copy that code in and so the
idea behind external name is is that you
have a service that is able to
communicate or talk to you something
outside of your cluster so maybe you
have a database that you're using like
you're using on aws rds which is a
relational database and so if you had
spun up a relational database it takes
forever to spin one up so i'm not going
to do it but it would have like a host
name like a domain name that you could
use because you can't um you can't get
an ip address from rds it'll only give
you a host name like a domain name and
so
this allows you to say okay
i'll have my database here and so
whenever the service is hit always send
it over to that database okay
so what i'm going to do
is maybe we can try it with a virtual
machine because that might be a little
bit easier it will have a host name i
don't know if it'll work but let's try
anyway
okay and what i'm going to do is go
ahead and create myself a new ec2
instance and so we'll go ahead and
launch an instance
and
we'll give it a moment here we'll say
launch instance here i don't know why it
didn't take and so the idea is
i want to launch a new machine so let's
say amazon x2 and i know so we're doing
it with the old experience just in case
it's the future and you don't have
the old view i'm going to give you the
new view even though this might change
but the idea is that we need a web
server so i'm going to call this apache
web server and we want it to be amazon
x2 i really do not like this but this is
how it is it's going to be amazon's 2
instance it's going to be 64-bit
architecture x86 uh t2 micro is totally
fine we do not need to log into the
server so proceed without a key pair
and
we need to have
let's see here allow us to say traffic
we do not care about ssh traffic but we
do want http so that's totally fine
because we want to be open on port
and then down below the storage is fine
and then we've got to go to advanced
details and this is where we're going to
uh go all the way to the bottom this is
all new to me too so i'm a bit confused
and this is where we're going to enter
our user data so what i want to do is
install
a apache server i've done this a lot of
times but i can't remember so what i'm
going to do is just go to a github
and go to exam pro code because i
probably have an example because i've
done it so many times we'll go here and
i'm just going to search probably in
terraform i've done it
like there's an abus apache example so
this actually this example probably
would have it
if we go to the user data yaml
those are the two commands we want okay
so i'm going to copy these over
and technically this is a bash script so
we're going to just take this out here
whoops
um
i don't know if i have confidence in
that i'm going to go back and maybe
we've done it in the solutions architect
solution
free
the free
i have a bunch of free repos here they
should show up so let's take a look at
uh we'll open the developer i know it's
somewhere in here maybe it's in the
cloud practitioner the competition is i
think pretty much updated here
um we'll try
vbc follow along is it in here no
and
we have this one that one's
i don't see it in here
here's the developer
i'm just looking for that file i know i
have it somewhere here user data.sh
yep that looks kind of right to me yeah
this one's right so this one what this
will do
is it will um we don't need the ec2 user
here but it's going to install apache
which is called httpd i know it's
confusing and here it can actually
create a custom file and then start it
up so this isn't the free intimus
developer associate i do have a
repository for the project we're working
on so it will be in there as well so if
we go back over to exam pro here
i'm just updating as i make the course
here so it's not completely completed
here but i have this repository here i
don't know why it's blank because i
definitely uh committed code to this the
other day but that's fine this will get
filled out and we'll have examples there
okay but for the time being i'm just
going to go ahead and grab this on in
here and we'll paste this in and i don't
need all this content all i want here
is
to um
i need this line so that it knows that
it's doing bash
okay and so we have sudo yum install
apache sudo yum or sorry sudo systemctl
so startup apache and if the server
needs to be restarted make sure that
it's there and so that should be enough
to do it and so what i'll do is go ahead
and launch this instance
and we'll just wait for that to work
there okay
and so we'll go view all instances
and so i'm waiting for this to be
running and so the idea is that we have
this we have the public ipv4 address but
that's not what i want i want the
the dns name okay so like this is an
idea where it's like kind of like a name
domain name or something so what i'm
going to do is go ahead and copy this
and go back to our micro k8s here i'm
going to just paste that on in here
and i'm going to call this
service apache
here they have a namespace
i'm going to take that out because i
want it to be in the default name space
i don't want to go anywhere strange
and down below here which is something
funny so i'm just going to type in clear
and we'll go back over to our ec2
instance we're going to refresh here
and see that it is running i'm i grab
the public ipv4 and just make sure that
it works
okay so see how it's hanging if it's
hanging it's either apache is not
running or the port is not open oh no it
works okay we just had to wait for it to
pass so when you have an ec2 instance it
has to be running and then the status
checks have to pass if we refresh here
well
it's working but usually you wait till
that you get two out of two but we're
impatient here and we're just getting
ahead of ourselves so it does work at
this address and so the idea is um
we are going to we pasted that into here
and so i'm hoping that this will have an
ip address or something and then we will
just curl it or wget it and hopefully
we'll get the contents of this page
so now that we have this
external service we're going to type in
micro k8s
cube ctl
apply hyphen f
k8s
service external
name yaml
okay
and then we will type in micro
k8s cube ctl
uh get svc to see what services we have
here and notice that this one actually
has an external ip address now if we got
the load balancer to work in the last
one which was uh not ready for that yet
it would have had an external ip address
where it would have showed that address
so that you know
for the load bouncer to connect to but
here we can see that this external name
doesn't have a cluster ip address but it
points to external ip
so i guess my thought is like okay
i guess the other services would just
resolve to this one if it knew how
so i'm just trying to think here because
it is external
so what i'm going to do
is i want to log into the the
our busy box pod here just to see what
we can see
okay so we'll say wget
uh clear
and i just want to do like a w get on
google here.com yeah that's external so
i'm not really sure i mean i understand
why we have one but i don't understand
the use case so i'll be back here in a
moment i just want to try to find the
reason why okay
um
like like what can we test to make sure
that this is working as expected because
i know if we do a w get here this this
is gonna work right we do wget
oh this is 403 forbidden
um is the port not open
oh it actually is forbidden yeah so
i wonder why we're getting a 403 on that
type an exit here
if i do a curl on this no that works
here
huh
so we got a 403 forbidden
okay well i'll look into it and i'll be
back in a moment okay
all right so i did a little bit of
reading and says when looking up the
host name so whatever it's called the
cluster dns service returns a cname
record with the value to that so it
sounds like that we will have a
um an address here and so what we'll do
is we will go here and type in micro k8s
cube ctl
um and we'll say describe svc
and this one's called service external
name and maybe we'll be able to see that
information because that's what i don't
know
um and so i might be t must be typing
this wrong so we'll type in uh get
svc for services
oh it's called service apache
i'll see if we get some more information
here and so if we scroll on up here
we have
this here so what i'm trying to
understand
is how do we get this so when looking up
the host because i don't know if this is
always just based on this pattern here
okay
so we have my service prod so i assume
that this is the namespace so we're in
the default namespace
and our service is called
service
dot apache or hyphen apache svc because
it's a service it's in our cluster it's
local and so this is what i want to know
so we do curl could not resolve so i
mean i understand what it's saying here
but i don't know uh what to do with this
okay so that's what i'm gonna find out
next okay all right so after a little
bit of digging on kubernetes we have
debugging dns resolution so i think this
would be the way that we would figure it
out but there are a few things here that
it says that might not work well so you
have to have a kubernetes cluster cube
ctl it's recommended to run this uh with
at least two nodes and that you're not
acting as the control plane host so if
you do not already have a cluster you
can create one by using minicube so the
thing is is that there is only a single
node so i'm not sure if we can just spin
up another node
um
and everything i think is just one node
because
we're not running multi-nodes it's a
single it's a single one there so
i guess what we can do is we can try to
launch this pod here so this is a dns
utility and so what they're doing is
they're using this and then they're
doing an ns lookup
right and so i don't know if i can do
that from the c2 instance but um this is
what i would give as an attempt even if
this doesn't work that's totally fine uh
it's we're kind of going way out of the
scope uh for the actual kcna but if this
if we can't get this to work i figured
it doesn't hurt to try right so what
we'll do is we'll go back over here
and um this is dns utils so i'm going to
go back over to this here and we'll make
a new file here i'll call dnsutils.yaml
and i'm going to go ahead and copy the
contents here
and we'll go ahead and paste this in
so it will launch a pods it's not a
deployment it's just a pod ds new tills
um
and here it's pulling a very specific
image so it says e uh end to end test
image jesse i don't know who jesse is
but thank you jesse dns utils 1.3 and
then it has a sleep and 3600 so the
first thing it does when it launches it
sleeps pull if not presence of pull once
restart policy so always restart this
pod
okay
so we'll go back to the debugging here
and here we can see that it gets
deployed in fact it looks like we don't
even need to have this file here we
could just
hold on here
we haven't we haven't done an external
file so i'm going to go and delete this
here whoops
and we'll just actually copy this if
because if it does that that's even
easier right
and i'm typing clear
and what we'll do is go over here
hit enter next to the server was refused
um micro k8
we'll be doing that all day here so it's
created that dns util
and so if we go back over to this
here
we should be able to do a lookup so i'm
going to leave whatever the default is
actually we'll look up the pod first to
make sure that it does exist and get
some descriptions here i'm not sure if
we'll find any info interesting
information about the pod but let's just
do it because they're doing it too
right so there's the pod we know that
it's working
and if we go back over to
the debug page here we're going to go
ahead and copy this now this is for
kubernetes default so
this should show us something
right that's not for the service that
we're looking for but we'll go ahead and
paste that on in there
again micro k8s in the front there if
you're wondering how like i'm jumping to
the front there i'm actually hitting
control a
okay so ctrl e oh well it's not doing
what i want but control a would jump to
the the back control e would jump to the
front but control e is overridden by
this file command here so we'll type in
micro k8s
hit enter and so notice that it is
resolving here so we have the server and
it's going there all right so now what i
want to do
is i want to delete this out
and
we have this so this is what i'm going
to try
see if this resolves anywhere
aha and it does and look what it returns
our ec2 52 201 234 550 compute one
amazoninbus.com and there's the ip
address so that looks like that is our
server um so the core dns the dns
thing that is
part of the control plane is definitely
resolving to there so that is absolutely
working how that works on the app like
how we would use that within the app i
don't know but that's great to see that
that works so i just wanted to make sure
that we had a way to validate there so
what we'll do is go back to our ec2
instance and shut this down so we'll
terminate this one here
okay
and we do not need um
the that service running anymore for
debugging so i'm going to go and type in
micro k8
cube ctl get pods because i can't
remember the name
and we'll just hit up here we'll say
delete pod dns utils
and that pod will vanish because there's
no deployment so there's nothing that
will persist it there and so i think we
pretty much covered everything i wanted
to cover with
um the service types because there's the
four types and if we have an opportunity
to test the load balancer later we will
do that
but we're definitely going above and
beyond and i'm hoping that this really
solidifies your knowledge of kubernetes
um and i'll see you in the next follow
along okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we're going to
learn how to
set up a kubernetes
ingress object so ingress as we covered
in the course is for um
exposing pods externally and so it's an
alternative to use from using a service
load balancer and actually generally
recommended to use um but you know
getting one set up is a little bit
tricky uh so hopefully we'll figure that
out here so i just launched my micro k8
environment because michael k it's going
to make it really really easy for us to
do whereas if we use something else i
can't say for certain if it's that easy
so we have our environment
here and so what i'm going to do here is
i'm just going to take a look at what we
have running so we'll say micro k8
uh cooper cube ctl get pause we'll see
if our sinatra pod is running and it is
and then we will look if we have a
deployment here and we do
so let's take a look at what we can find
about kubernetes ingress i'm going to
tell you the documentation the main page
not very good uh for helping you get set
up so they do have this thing here and i
guess technically it is correct so
that's for the nginx but the thing is is
that ingress also requires you to have
an ingress controller and so you don't
have one by default you have to set one
up so if we go to ingress controllers
here you can see there are a lot of
kinds so we have
way to bust gce engine x and then
there's a whole bunch down below here
all right and so we could probably
figure out a way to hook up the aws one
but that might be a little bit too hard
for our developer environment be a lot
easier if we were already using eks it
doesn't say that we have to cks with
this but i would imagine that it'd
probably be a lot easier and so there's
nginx
which is an open source button you can
see there's a lot of different ones that
we could use but this is probably what
we'll end up using which is the engine
x1 here so we'll go over here
i'm just trying to find the page that
has the documentation uh yeah this looks
like it so
um if you're doing nginx they have a
bunch of different ways that you can do
it uh based on your provider so we have
micro k8s and so
you know i showed you all the
lightweight distributions but i didn't
tell you that you could actually use
docker desktop or
rancher desktop in order to run your
developer environment without using a
cloud developer environment um but i'm
going to tell you docker desktop is such
a pain like an incredible pain to set up
um
an ingus controller because you have to
use i guess it's not that hard but you
have this very complex template here i'm
just going to show you this and
we don't need all of this here it's
going to take that out and so this is
what is required as you can see there's
a lot of stuff going on here in order to
deploy our ingress controller so to kind
of sift through that and make sense of
it would be very hard but the great
thing is since we're using micro k8 if
we just go up here for a moment we click
on the micro case it's as simple as
enabling it and basically that script i
just showed you that was for the docker
desktop basically does the same thing
but does it in one line and we know that
it's going to work
we could take a look at maybe like what
minicube does
so minicube also has an add-on so that's
nice to see i'm not sure what there is
for kind or if they even have kind
listed here go to aws that might be
interesting to see so then it'll be to
expose the nginx controller behind
service load balancer type so something
more interesting going on there but what
we're going to do is stick to our micro
k8s because it's super easy so i'll go
ahead and copy that command we'll go
over here paste it on in and we'll
enable ingress and so that will install
our ingress controller so you can see
it's doing a bunch of stuff and so i bet
if we looked at the contents of that
desktop
docker file where we saw that yaml file
i bet it was installing all these things
so we have a namespace for ingress it
made a service account it made a cluster
role rbac
role-based access control
there so we have a role a role binding
role binding config map and a daemon set
so a lot of stuff is being created there
but you can see we didn't have to uh
worry about it i just get like uh
worrisome when we have those external
scripts and we run them because there's
so many moving parts
but this way it's all set up pretty easy
so now that we have our ingress
controller what we need to do is set up
our ingress resource so if we go back to
the tutorial here actually this looks
like the up-to-date version so this is
the one we are looking for sometimes you
might come across one that is older
but this one definitely looks correct to
me so i'll go ahead and copy this and
we'll go back over to our environment
i'm going to just make a new file here
and we're going to call this um
ingress
dot yaml we'll go ahead and uh paste
that in here so we'll say paste and
we'll just take a look at what we need
to change so
up above we have the ingress type uh
minimal ingress that'll be its name this
annotation thing so sometimes
annotation is just a type of metadata
that is sometimes used by
tools or providers so this one is
particular to nginx
as you can see this nginx ingress
kubernetes io so there's something with
rewriting so you're specifying the root
path there
then there's the ingress class name so
we'll leave that alone that's totally
fine
then we have our rules
so here what we can do is type in
sinatra
and the path type is prefix which is
totally fine and then we're saying
where's the back end so we are
specifying something
so here it's targeting a service so
if that's the case we will need a
service i'm just going to double check
if we can target a deployment i'm pretty
sure it always has to be a service
because if we go up to the diagram yeah
it always goes to here so we will need a
service so i have another tab open here
and let's see if we actually already
have something running so we'll type in
micro k8s
um
cube ctl
and we'll type in get sbc
and we do we have uh service apache but
that is an external name on which we're
not using anymore so i'm going to go
ahead and delete that one just to kind
of clean up what we have here if you
have it you can go ahead and delete it
too delete svc
but what we'll do is whoops um
cube ctl micro
case
must be spelling it wrong today
micro
k8s there we go and so what we'll do is
use that expose command to just quickly
create a
a
a cluster ip service so we'll have
expose
deploy
and we need the name of it so it's
called sinatra
and then we need the port so the port
will be 8080 and then the target port is
going to be 80 or sorry 4567 okay and so
it'll say here
still typing micro k it's wrong
micro
okay eights
there we go and so now what i'll do is
type in micro k8 cube ctl
get
svc
we can see that it's there i'm just
going to describe it i just want to see
that the endpoints are there so we don't
have any problems there is an endpoint
so it must be going to the correct pod
so we are in
aok shape
and we'll just go back up there and just
type in get again there so it's called
sinatra so if we go back to our ingress
we're going to target these sinatra
and uh the port it operates on is 8080
right
and so what we'll do now is just save
that and we'll go ahead and deploy
our ingress so going back over here to
the other tab here it doesn't matter
what tab we do it on it just that's the
tab on so we want micro
k8 cube ctl
um apply hyphen f and by the way we've
been doing apply this entire time we
could probably use create so
apply is just does create and modify and
so create it's just if you only want to
create um you know like if you ran it
twice it would create two resources
where uh modify if it already had the
same name it would i wouldn't do it
twice
but i guess we can try that for fun just
because i haven't been using that at all
and so here it says that it's created
the minimal ingress and so we will now
type in micro k8s cube ctl get um
ingress
and so here we have our ingress here and
maybe we can describe it a bit more and
see if there's any additional
information that might be interesting to
look at
and so if we just scroll up actually we
don't scroll up at all but here it's
launched the the default namespace
default backend port 80 endpoints
default http backend not found
um which might not be a problem i don't
know if this error actually matters um
and then we have four slash sinatra
and here you can see it's pointing to
the back end sinatra's service name port
8080. so let's take a look and see if it
works so
this should be all exposed on the local
host and so
i think we'll be on port 80 or just
localhost in general so i think that we
can just type in his curl localhost
and notice it says not found and so
nginx is working it is going to the um
ingress controller
which is engine x but let's now go and
type in forward slash sinatra
sinatra
okay and that didn't work so we'll type
in now 8080 sinatra
okay cinatra
so it looks right to me i'm just going
to go double check what i wrote
oh you know what it was i think what we
need we might need the protocol in here
because it's not going to know what
protocol if it's http or https so i'm
just going to try this
and
[Music]
it's not giving us what i want it's
localhost sin
not true i'm gonna double check making
sure i'm not spelling anything wrong
here
sinatra
hold on hold on
hmm
what did i do wrong here
because i definitely definitely have had
this working uh when i tested before so
maybe there's an issue with our cluster
let's just double check to make sure our
cluster is working so we'll say svc
this is a cluster ip here external ip
that looks fine
um so i know we have our busy box that
we were doing before i'm going to see if
i can find that here
we'll say
debug service
kubernetes
and we'll go ahead and grab our one
liner
here and we'll go on back here we'll
paste that on in
and it says connection refuse that's
totally fine we'll type in micro kx
and we'll do
wget oh i don't know what the um
oh yeah we do know it's right here okay
so what we'll do is just type in wget
8080.
okay so it does work cat index html
so
maybe if we go back up to here
maybe this has something to do with it
okay default needs to be backend 80
endpoints defaults to be back and not
found all right so i'll be back here in
a moment and see if i can solve it okay
all right i'm back and so one thing i
notice is that this one sets an ingress
class name and when i compared my other
code that i found somewhere else it
didn't have this field at all and it
defaulted to public so i'm thinking that
if we change this to public then that
will go to the 127.00.1
i'll be able to use it that way so
that's what i'm going to try here we'll
so we'll try to update this
so we'll say cubectl apply hyphen f
k8
ingress and we'll see if that will take
um so here it says missing the cube ctl
last applied configuration etc etc
so it doesn't like it for whatever
reason i'm just going to go ahead and
delete that line for a second
okay it says it's configured but did it
change it
no it did not so i think in this case
what we'll do
because i just i'm just curious if we
set this to public if it will do what we
think we'll do but maybe what we'll do
is just delete
the um the ingress controller and that
might fix our issue here so we'll just
say ingress i think it's short for ing
if we wanted to do that so we'll say
delete ing ingress
okay
this is all called minimal ingress
all right and then we'll just go ahead
and reapply this
and then we will take a look here
so the class is now public but it's not
assigning the ip address so what i'll do
is just remove this here just because i
notice my other one does not have it
and we will go ahead and just delete it
because maybe it's doing more than just
that if you specify the class
okay
and still no i p address interesting
but even though it is a public class
let's go ahead and just try it anyway
for fun
localhost sinatra
oh it works there we go okay so i'm not
sure why the ip address is not showing
up here
1270.0.1 but i think that class has
something to do with it there's another
thing where you can set the class and
the annotation uh so you can see there's
some variation there
notice like we can do curl we can do
you can put http in front of here if
you'd like this is running on port 80.
so we didn't specify port 80 but that is
just if it's public i suppose that's
where it would go by default and we have
rules for http and so that is port 80 uh
which is what we'd be using by default
here um so that's ingress for you so
hopefully that wasn't too hard but uh we
did get through it and we're all good
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along what we're
going to be taking a look at is jobs and
cron jobs so what i want you to do is go
the top here and type in kubernetes
jobs and this should bring us to
hopefully the jobs page here maybe we
can take a look at this one as well uh
and so we have some example jobs
okay this one's a little bit more
complicated which is fine but we'll also
go to the cube ctl cheat sheet
okay because in the um
in the course i do use to the samples
from here we just type in job
and so
here we have one where it says create a
job which prints the word hello create a
cron job that prints
hello world every minute okay so what
we'll do is we'll go ahead and copy this
first one here
and you can see it's cube ctl create job
hello maybe we'll just type it for fun
uh just so that we get better at
remembering what is what so we'll type
in micro k8s
uh cube ctl create job we could do apply
i suppose but jobs they run and they
they die so i don't think you'd really
be updating them maybe you'd be updating
this one and using apply so they have a
name called hello
so we'll just copy the rest there to
make our lives a bit easier
okay hello hyphen hyphen image equals
busy box so that should resolve probably
go to docker hub and there's one called
a busy box so a lot of times we were
using the one that was sourcing google
but i think we could just do that as
well and so it will run the echo command
and it should work so we'll hit enter
and it says job.batch hello created
notice we don't see where the output is
i'm not really sure where we would
observe that but let's just take a look
here and maybe type in describe
okay but you can see here it says job
completed completed and it ran the
command echo hello world of course we
didn't see it but we can see that it did
pass that in as the initial command so
it definitely did operate that
now the next question would be to take a
look at um
let's just take a look at all of our
jobs here for a moment but to run the
one on a schedule so here says hello one
out of one duration two and age so go
back over here very similar um but we
have this very interesting looking thing
and that's a cron job so cron job cheat
sheet i wonder if there's something that
we can just show you really quickly here
so if you've never seen a cron so cron
is part of linux so the idea is that
it's a it's a um a thing called cron tab
and
uh what you're doing is you're saying
okay run this on a schedule and there's
this thing where you specify the time in
minutes hours days month uh
monday it's a month month and weekday
right so if you have the value zero here
which is uh minutes
um
i guess that's way hold on one two three
four five one two three four five
so this says every hour
uh so zero i guess
is one
that's interesting you'd think it'd be
like if you put a one that'd be every
hour but i guess it's zero based on how
the numbers are i'm not sure if it shows
all the information and oh yeah here we
go
zero so minutes zero to you really think
this would be one because it says hours
why is this every hour okay
whatever uh so then we have this one
here it says uh
uh four slash fifteen so every 15
minutes
uh then you have zero
whatever so you kind of get the idea
here i don't fully understand the logic
here i've done this for years but i
always have to look it up
but just to show you if you want to read
that yourself but we'll go back to the
cheat sheet here if we read this
they say every minute so
i guess that makes sense because if you
took an hour and divided it by
one did you get that well anyway that's
what it says it does but you know this
is not so important to know for the exam
but just to understand that that's where
that logic comes from if you want to
learn it on your own you can totally do
that so what we'll do is hit enter
and oh we have to type in micro k8
all right and then we'll hit uh
does that look great micro case yeah
enter
and so what we can do now is to get the
jobs
oh maybe we have to do crown job for
this
we do so there it is
and so it says last scheduled it is
active i assume it's active um but i
guess we'll just wait here a little
while and see
when it does trigger while that is going
on
let's take a look at what it looks like
to create a cron job file
so you use batch version one you have a
job
metadata you specify your container
image name command
whether it should restart or not
and back off limit so
you know if it fails then it will retry
after a certain amount of time it
probably does exponential back off i'm
not sure if it's uh every few
seconds or whatever so in that sense you
can make a job that is reoccurring in in
some sense there
but yeah that's pretty much all there
really is to jobs but we just want to
observe this thing works
okay and notice that the one minute's
going to come up here in a moment ah so
it just ran so it says one active last
scheduled so let's see if we can get a
describe since there's only one it
should pull the first one there notice
we haven't been specifying the name at
all
okay
because usually you'd write the name
whatever it is right and i don't know
what the name is it is called hello
so we'd say like hello
right
and let's just take a look at what we
have here so namespace is default no
labels no annotations that's our
schedule
currency policy allow
uh suspend false
nothing super exciting here you can see
what the pod is
last scheduled time so last time it ran
whether there's a job that's active
right now
and then we have events here so it says
create a job saw a completed job i would
think that if this runs multiple times
we'll see this kind of like a list
but um
what we'll do is just go back to get
so probably trigger very soon
uh so when it's actually active it's one
and then when it's not active it's zero
so this doesn't count up like to say oh
it's ran four or five times it's just
true or false zero or one right
um
so we'll do is just hit up here
go back to describe because it might
have already ran again yeah so here it
is you can see that it's starting to
um pile on there i'm just curious like
uh time to cron uh cron expression
just wondering if there is a tool there
that we can use okay so let's say we
wanted it to be every single
um
every second
is it changing real time okay so it'd be
this okay cool
let's say you want to do every minute
which you want to do every hour
okay so i'm not saying i can make sense
of this
at one point i did know how these uh
chronic expressions work but i'm sure if
you really wanted to know yeah here they
all are uh you could uh look up and try
to understand the syntax there but again
out of the scope of this and we
understand how to run a job in a cron
job i think what we'll want to do is
just destroy that crown job so it's not
constantly running
so we'll just say
delete quran
job hello
i'm not worried about the job one
because it ran and then it stopped so
that's okay there and um i guess that's
it for jobs okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are back with another follow
along and this time we're looking at
replica sets so technically we've
probably been using replica sets if we
go back to our deployment file
originally here again we are in the
micro k8 environment i don't know if
we'll ever be using mini cuber kind now
that microcades works so great but um
here it's not specifying the
replicas account but generally if you
were just to add
a value i think right here like replicas
you could then say okay create a replica
set underneath and that's how you would
create a replica but let's go take a
look at replica sets um kubernetes here
and see if we can specify one manually
now you never would do this in practice
you'd always use a deployment but just
to show you that you can do it right so
if we go ahead and copy the contents
here of this one here and we'll make a
new one and we'll call this a new file
replica set
yaml
okay and we go ahead and paste that in
there we can kind of read it and see
what's going on here so we have some
metadata
um so we have labels like names like go
say name
sinatra
rc
and we'll just say sinatra rc
and here we can see how many we want to
run
and then we i guess we need to have a
selector um and so
[Music]
i'm just trying think here match labels
template oh yeah probably they just
these probably just have to match the
template like this
okay
and then we can go to our deployment and
just grab our container image here
and i think that should work
so that should launch us three pods in a
replica set that are managed
okay so we'll type in micro k8s cube ctl
um
get
or sorry apply hyphen f
k eights
replica set yaml and we'll see if that
works it looks like it worked no problem
there and so we'll type in micro k8
cube ctl
get
uh rc for replica sets or maybe it's rs
there we go and so here's the one that's
for the deployment right and then here's
the one for rc so even though we never
specified replicas originally here it
did set up a replica set for one to one
and then here you can see the replicas
that are is set to i wrote rc i should
have wrote rs we have the desired
current and ready so generally desired
means like go back to that's generally
what you want to be running
so
um again we don't really want to be
doing it this way so i just wanted to
show you that you could do it that way
so we'll just say cube ctl delete
rs
and delete that replica set and just so
this is less confusing if we ever go
back to this file we'll type in rs
i think the reason i wrote rc because
the old one was called replication
controller so at the top here um
maybe not here but notice here this
replication controller this was replaced
with replica set and that's probably why
i wrote rc
but
rs is the new way of doing it
so now let's take a look at how we would
um
modify this file here so if we go over
here
and we already changed the two so i'll
just save that file and if we were to
type in micro
k8s
cube ctl
update or no sorry apply hyphen f
because that will do a modify and update
essentially
and then we'll do our deployment here
and that should update our replica set
to now have two so see the desired is
two and so if we go check our pods
we should now have a second one trying
to run and it is
okay
all right and so that's pretty much all
i really want to cover about replicas
that's right now of course there's more
to it um and we'll see that when we look
at scaling okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're doing a follow along and this
time it's all about scaling and also
using hpa the
horizontal pod auto scaler so just make
sure you launch your micro k8
environment that we've been using uh
this entire time so i'm going to type
clear here and so what we'll do is look
up the scale command kubernetes and so i
haven't been showing this uh throughout
this but there is
um like a cube ctl commands
a reference
let's see if we can find it here
and so this is really useful if we ever
want to just kind of see examples
and so there is a scale command and then
there's an auto scale command so if we
look at scale
down below setting new size for the
deployment replica set replication
control or stateful set so you know when
we did it uh in the last um like the
last volume of the replica sets that we
ch we changed this to replica set or
replicas 2 and then did apply so this
basically does the same thing
um except it doesn't update this file of
course our original file but it will uh
update what's in the cluster so if we go
here
we type in micro k8s cube ctl scale
and then we'll go over to our reference
here and take a look at how it works
um
here we can see hyphen hyphen replicas
so we can just specify the new amount
replicas
and maybe we would say four
and
then i'm just trying to look so i'm
assuming it's going to be whatever the
resource is forward slash the name
so we probably type deploy or deployment
and then it's going to be sinatra
and so it says that it has scaled
all right and so if we go take a look
i don't think you can uh yeah hold on
here we'll we'll go
get deploy
and see what it says here so notice it
says two out of four already so it is
working on deploying the rest of those
it says two out of four ready for up to
date two available
ah there we go just have to take some
time and it will say get pods
right so we see there are four pods and
then we can go get svc
and then from there we could um take a
look oh sorry i wanted to look at the uh
replica set and there's four out of four
and if maybe we'll just describe it for
fun
replicas that
okay and
you can see
some information here that it says
replication controller under so i guess
it was a replica set controller sorry i
almost got confused with replica
replication controller there so nothing
super interesting here but um you know
that's all great
so that's scale uh one thing i'd like to
show you is what happens when you have
an svc that has multiple um pods uh just
to show you that we have all our
endpoints here okay because when we
looked at it before we saw one but if we
have four pods one two three four we
should see four and we do which is great
so we looked at scale and let's take a
look at auto scale so if we go up here
so auto scale is going to create us um a
horizontal pod auto scaler so let's type
in hpa kubernetes
here and see if we can find an example
that's a resource
don't see one here one moment
let's see if there's one in the
walk-through
so here they have a deployment and a
service
so i want to show you the code ah here
it is okay so
here's an example of a horizontal pod
autoscaler
so the idea is you're setting the scale
target reference
you're saying
you're targeting the deployment for it
you're setting the min replicas the max
replicas and then you can say all right
you should scale up
if the utilization exceeds whatever it
is beyond 50 right and so that's an
example there i thought i had more like
a streamlined example here i'm just
going to go double check my other
computer
to see what i have
and i didn't save it but i know it's
generally this okay so
this is something we can write out but
there's an easier way which is using the
autoscale it's basically going to just
create
this file here
so what we'll do is do a cube
cube ctl autoscale so we'll go back over
here
and actually we didn't scale down our
pod so what we'll do is go back to
our scale
we did here a moment ago
and i want to just put this to one okay
and then we'll go and make sure that
it's scaled down so it'll say describe
deployment
describe deployment
sinatra
or i guess we'll just do get because
it's a bit easier to see that
okay so we have one and one so now let's
say we wanted to set up auto scale so
that's going to be micro k8s
cube ctl
um
autoscale
and then we'll need to figure out all
the other options here so
if we scroll up it probably shows us a
very simple example
oh yeah the name right what do we want
to autoscale so we'll say deployment
replica
or sorry uh sinatra
and then here we'll base it off the cpu
percent
and then
we can set our min or max right
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
set it to 2 so that it'll automatically
scale up to 2 because it'll expect there
to be at least 2
and we'll hit enter
and notice that it created created an
auto scaler so um
what we can do is type in micro k8s
uh cube ctl hpa for horizontal pod
autoscaler
um
or maybe get in front of it first
and so here it says unknown targets
because it's still trying to figure out
the targets i suppose two mins max pods
replicas we can see that it is going to
the right place
okay if we know that this is working we
can just go get pods and see how many
pods are running
so notice there are two pods
i'm not sure why the target is unknown i
don't know if we have to have something
additionally installed for it to know or
this just it needs to collect more
information over a period of time but we
can see that this works so it's as
simple as that
if we were to try to flood traffic
towards those
containers or pods i should say then it
should spin up another one we're not
going to do that because it is a bit
complex uh to do that and it's kind of
out of scope here
and so what we'll do is just get rid of
this hpa that we created here
actually before we do that i just want
to show you the edit command which we
haven't really been using much so if we
do edit hpa sinatra
this will open in a local editor so it's
i think using bim is this vim yeah it's
vim and it looks very similar to our
definition file but this is actually
basically the definition file and active
data here so you're going to see
additional information
uh here and so you can actually edit
this uh like you i could change the
value here maybe change um
the minimum
to three and i think that it will take
effect right so i edited it and if i go
hpa notice that the min pods is now
three
so generally you don't need to edit
things on the fly like that but it is
possible for you to do that if i go over
back to our pods get pods
we should see that there is now three
running so what we'll do is go ahead and
delete
hpa
sinatra
okay and then it should go back to the
right amount of pods
let's see if it'll actually do that
what if we have to scale it down
okay
and i think the reason why is because if
we go to our deployment
and we describe it
again we only have one so we don't have
to specify the name
i think it has like a min and a max in
here
three desired three updated three total
three available
maybe because we scaled it to three from
before i can't remember why so what i'm
going to do here is just scale it back
down to one so we'll type in scale
deploy
forward slash sinatra
and we'll just say replicas equals one
and then we'll go back to our pods
and now we only have one pod so you know
hopefully that gives you a clear idea
how horizontal pod auto scalers work
they can get quite complex because there
is more logic that can be implemented
with
auto pod scalers
i don't know if we'll do a vertical pod
scaler i'm not sure if that's really
that necessary uh i haven't decided yet
but anyway you can see there's a lot
more fancier rules that you can
implement for horizontal pod scaling
but yeah there you go
hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along we're going to be taking a
look at how to use config maps so just
make sure you're a micro k8 environment
and so i am in mine here and i think i'm
going to actually need to use the k8
environment as well because that's where
we created our
original uh docker file we might need to
do an update there but the idea is
config maps allow you to pass data into
multiple pods so you have consistent
data across your containers so what
we're going to do here is just type in
config map kubernetes
and we'll go here
and we'll take a look here and so here's
an example of a config map so we'll just
copy the contents here
we'll go over here and we'll say
new file
configmap.yaml
and we will go ahead whoops uh
reload and we'll just paste this content
in here so this looks a bit confusing
but the idea is that you have your data
and then you can have a key and a value
but then you have some values that are a
little bit more complex and the reason
why is that um these will turn into like
json or yaml file formats not super
important for the scope of what we're
doing so i'm just going to simplify this
so it's not as complicated and what i'm
going to do here well we might leave
actually it in because i don't think
it's going to hurt anything if we do
leave it in hold on here and i'm just
going to go ahead and just
leave it in maybe we can view it as yaml
but i want to
set a message here and we'll just say
um
uh
i remember like how do you say
how do you say hello in bar soon
okay
so hello
okay so if you don't know bar soon
barsoon is the uh mars books i think
it's bar soon that's how you pronounce
it
and so we'll say
bar soon and that's basically saying
like hello mars okay
and so the idea is that we will update
our original file to consume that
environment variable so if um
we'll say like hello message maybe
is a better name here and actually just
to make things a bit easier for me so i
don't have to kind of guess what it is
i'm just going to type it in all caps
hello message
and so what we'll do is go back to our
original k environment and this is where
yeah we created our app and so in our
ruby app what we can do is
do something slightly different i'm
going to do env
[Music]
oops
single quotations here it's being a
little bit silly and so if there is an
environment variable it will use that
otherwise
use hello world i'm gonna just put an
extra exclamation mark here so that we
know that it's working and so that
shouldn't cause any issues so we'll
double check make sure this works we'll
cd into that directory here we'll do a
bundle
install shouldn't shouldn't need to but
we'll just do it for fun
um
okay
let's see here um
could not find bundler
oh okay oh sorry rvm list so rvm used uh
3.1.0 remember i couldn't default it
before i just didn't want to look it up
because i figured we weren't going to be
going back here too often and now we'll
do a bundle install make sure
everything's fine
and then i'll do bundle exect
ruby sinatra just to make sure that it
or sorry a server just to make sure that
it's working correctly
and then on a new tab here i'm just
gonna make a new file tab here i think
this is running on port 8080
yes so we'll just do a curl oops
that's a file i want a terminal
we'll do a curl localhost 8080 and it
says hello world the double exclamation
mark okay
now if we were to pass an environment
variable we'll just double check to make
sure that works so what we can do is go
to the front of it and type in hello
message
equals
new message
okay
maybe double quotations here i'm not
sure if it'll take double or singles
and we'll go back over here and we will
hit up make sure that our app works it's
not taking it one second here uh maybe
we don't need the semicolon maybe we'll
just take that out like that
there we go all right so
it is accepting um environment variables
so now what i want to do is i want to
repackage that docker file so i think we
might have wrote it in here no we did
not just came with it and so i'm going
to write
um bundle
docker
or sorry docker build hyphen t or sorry
period hyphen t
um
we called it sinatra yeah i don't
exactly remember so what i'm going to do
is just go over to the console here open
a new tab we'll go over and go grab it
from ecr just because if i make a typo
here it's always a big pane to fix so
we'll go to our container registry here
and we will go into our app here we'll
view the push commands we'll take a look
here and this is the one i want
so that way i'm not making any mistake
okay
and i'll make sure i'm in the k8
environment here and we'll go ahead and
just erase that out there hit enter and
that's going to build that new one and
then what we can do is then copy these
next lines here and have a really easy
time so go ahead and paste that in
and we'll go ahead and paste this in
okay and so now we have our
your authorization tire is
expired that is totally fine if that
happens we just go back to the top here
and we paste that on in okay hit up up
to go to the last one there and now it's
just pushing the updated version there
so now that that's all updated what i
want to do here is i want to double
check my deployment file and see if it's
set to always yeah always pull the
public image
and so what we can do
here again we're back in the micro k8s
we're going to go ahead and just delete
our deployment so we'll say micro kx
um cube ctl delete deploy sinatra
and then what we'll do is say cube ctl
apply hyphen f
k 8
deployment
and so that should pull the latest image
it didn't seem like it did though
usually it would say like downloading or
something maybe it is pulling it
but what we'll do here is just
get
our pods
and wait for it to run so maybe it is
pulling because it is taking some time
so let's say describe deployment see
what's happening
i don't know if we can see the the
images here docker images
no it doesn't show them
okay um also maybe this has changed so
that's something that we should just
double check
okay so if i go into here
oh yeah that's way different okay
so what we'll have to do is just paste
that on in there
does that say latest it doesn't say
latest
maybe we just click in the latest there
yeah okay so it should take it i just
want to double check to make sure i
think because like that was a very
particular version and i would i didn't
click into that we pasted that in there
yeah this is the same thing
so
um i mean we should be in good shape so
let's just double check here and say get
pods i just can't believe it pulled that
fast right like i figured we'd see like
a message like pulling the image or
something
so then what we're going to know is if
we kind of expose this and take a look
here do we still have our ingress
controller running
ingress
oh we do nice okay so if that's the case
then what i'm going to do here is just
do um
curl local host forward slash sinatra
ah we have our double exclamation mark
so it is definitely
uh using the latest image so now we are
set up and so the idea with our config
map is we're going to create this and
then we want to get this message to show
up here
um this will just be like config map
data here
name that there and so what we'll do
is type in um
micro k8s
cube ctl apply
hyphen f
k eights
config map
i'm gonna say okay so that created that
config map there
and um i'm just looking off screen here
because i want to see if there's a way
we can visualize it as a yaml file
um i'm just looking here
yeah there's like a way like output so
what we can do is type in cube ctl get
config map to look at it for a moment
here
oh maybe we should say oh micro k8 it's
in front here
okay so we have this one which is the
certification root thing and then we
have config maps so we'll say get
configmap configmap
maybe not a great name for it should
probably called it sinatra but whatever
and so um that doesn't tell us much but
we go hyphen o yaml
now it shows us in the format of a yaml
file so
we can kind of look at that data
and see what it looks like so we have
hello world equals that game properties
equals this
kind of see what the structure is i
suppose
i'm not sure if there's like a nicer way
to look at it i'm just double checking
here
no that's pretty much it okay so now
that we have that we need to now
associate that to our pod or a
deployment so if you deployed a pod you
could specify it there but we're doing
it through our deployment and so we can
either mount it as a volume or we can
pass it along as environment variables
and so i think what we want to do is do
nvar here so we'll go over back to our
reference file here and we'll just say
nvar
and
i'm just off screen here with like this
one because i know i've seen it
somewhere here
environment variables
maybe it's in
this ultimate guide here to config maps
because there's one where you can mount
yeah this is what i'm looking for and
and and env from okay
so you think they'd have that in the
main
it's always a lot of work to figure
stuff out here so what we'll do is go
back to our deployment and so this one
is showing with a pod but i'm going to
assume that i can do that with a
deployment because why not
and so
i think it would probably go
in line here oh we have env up here
so we could say env from
see i don't think we need to set this
yeah so like here we could probably
override it first let's just do this as
a test before we bring in our config map
and so we'll just say um goodbye goodbye
goodbye moon okay
and then what we'll do is do an apply
before we do our configmap we'll just
see if this works
deployment
k8 deployments
great and then we will just want to do
our curl here
to see if it would take it
uh and it didn't take it hello message
i'm just wondering here
i'm just looking at our server file here
yeah it's called hello message
so it should load that instead
all right well that's totally fine what
i'm going to do here is i'm still going
to specify um an and and n bar or n from
i think the reason why i see this is
confusing is because
it's indented here but it's actually on
the same line here so
this didn't work but we will just delete
this out
or actually we'll just change this to n
from
and then we need to figure out how to
map it so we'll say config
map ref
colon space space name example or sorry
whatever the config map is called so
it's called config map and so i think
that's how we should be able to map it
again i'm just trying this i haven't
done it before so i'm just hoping that
it works first time
and what we'll do here
let's go ahead and do a deploy here and
we'll see if we get an error so
um and from
unknown field called name
all right so that didn't work as
expected
so we'll have to go here and look up
some stuff so
config map for
deployment
kubernetes
so this again this one's for pod
that is frustrating
it should it should be able to go in
here it just says name though oh did
maybe i put a hyphen in front of it so i
made an array and that messed it up
which by the way um no actually the
other the other resource was fine no i
did it correctly
just make sure that we've
done this right
i'm just copying off screen the contents
here making sure i typed it right
looks right to me
just double check here we'll paste it in
paste
um
making sure i'm getting the indentation
correct here
yeah that's indented and we'll try one
more time
maybe maybe it's too far indented there
there we go and so we'll try this again
okay so it says
unknown field name v1 env
emv from source if you choose to ignore
these errors
hmm
unknown field
okay so i'll be back here in a second
and figure out what's wrong okay
all right so uh staring at it for a
little while here i think that the issue
is that this needs to be indented so
we'll try that first because i just
found a stack overflow that just said
hey your indentation is wrong and they
have an example here where this shows
more indented from this one and this one
is more indented from that one
so uh we'll just do both of that so this
one
from from the e that's where we have to
look maybe we'll just do that as a
sanity
check
ah there we go so it looks like it has
now been configured so
oh but it's the wrong name
so we'll have to type in configmap
because that's not gonna work if we do
that
okay we'll try this again
and so it says now it's now configured
so we'll go back to our deployment here
and just see if there's anything
observable that's interesting here so
you say describe deployment since
there's only one it's going to select
the first one i know i said 100 times
but just so you know
and here it says environment variables
from configmap configure map optional
false i'm not sure what the optional
false is but it looks like it must be
associated
and so i'm just hoping that if we do
a localhost that's going to work now i
don't know if we have to restart the
pods or if it would restart the pods so
i'm just looking here
so 12 seconds go scale down scale up so
i think it did turn off and turn back on
the pods
so
if we go here and do our um curl local
host sinatra i'm hoping that it will
show
bar soon oh it does there we go so for
whatever reason when we set an
environment variable it didn't work
maybe it was indentation or something
but here it's definitely accepting the
environment variable for a configuration
set there so that is really nice now
there's another way to uh use or to to
pass them along and that's by mounting
it as a volume which is kind of
interesting let's see if we can do that
really quickly here so volume
okay and so what you can do is specify a
volume mount
and this is on a pod
and assume it works the same way you
just have it with the containers
and then we specify a volume so i think
what we would need is a
volume mount here i don't know if that
would be enough for it to work
so go back to our micro k8s here and
we'll just scroll on down here hit enter
paste that on in
and
making sure that is right we didn't grab
it all did it
oh it's right here okay and so i think
that would need to be the same level
indentation here and so we'll indent
here and we'll
uh
now that indentation's fine
and so we have
name config which seems fine
uh we'll just have a config map
we'll go to config
actually i think we would have to
associate so we have a volume mount and
then we'd have to actually have the
volume to associate with so we'll have
to go back to here and then the this is
the volume so we'll go and
go here and then paste that on in
and here it looks like it's just doing
it in line
so
set the volumes at the pod level then
mount into the containers inside the pod
provide the name of the config map you
want to route an array of keys to uh to
convey to create as files okay cool so
now going back to this it kind of makes
sense that when you have this this would
be isolate files and we have all those
in there for example so we can give that
a go
in terms of indentation level we need to
figure that out so this one is
at the same level as containers
so we will go
up here
and hit back
and follow the line
so it has to be here
there okay
and we'll go down
and i think that's okay sometimes like
when it's like this you have to have it
the same line indication is kind of
weird and so it says here so this one's
called config map
an array of items array of keys from the
configmap to create as
files
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to comment out
our old one here so
i kind of want to leave it in just in
case we want to pull it back up i'm just
going to put image right i'll put a name
at the top here
okay
and then i'll just comment this
out and then i'm going to go over to our
config map well we'd have to update our
config map for this to work so what i'm
going to do here is go exclamation mark
exclamation mark
and
then
what i want to do here
is um
yeah this all looks fine so i don't know
if this is going to work because we
don't have we didn't specify this as a
file since it says an array of keys from
the configmap to create as files
so i'm going to assume that it's going
to default back to hello world okay
so now that we have this and assuming we
have got this all right
um we'll go ahead and deploy let's see
what happens so we'll type in micro k8
cube ctl
apply hyphen f k8 and
deployment.yaml and so that's going to
update it
and then we will do our curl
it still it still says
um
caror bar soon because of course we did
not push this so that's why that's not
updated and i don't know if it would
actually restart the pods for that if it
mounted the volumes or maybe it's still
doing it so let's go and
look at what it's doing so we'll
describe it
and here it says
nothing fancy
i'm just taking a look here
ah so it does mount to config
which is great
and we have config map here
okay
and so i don't think it's um the other
original config map i don't believe is
there anymore so it shouldn't be saying
that so i'm guessing that it didn't
restart the pods let's just try again oh
there we go so it probably was just
shutting down the pods right so
restarted so it definitely is uh loading
the other one and it doesn't have that
environment variable so now what i'd
like to do is see if we can get into
this
machine
and be able to
view that mounted directory so we'll
look it up like
kubernetes pod ssh
all right and it's not ssh it's more
like
it's like execute here so this is the
line that we want execute
if we look over here you can see what it
does so execute execute a command in a
container and so the command that we're
executing is saying uh get us into
the actual instance here and i'm
assuming shell demo needs to be a
particular container just double check
here
so verify the container is running so
get pod shell demo get a shell to the
running container so probably one of the
running containers which will be sinatra
here so go ahead and paste that in and
we'll just swap this out for sinatra
and it was refused because we didn't
have micro k8s in the front as per usual
and i didn't type it right probably so
we will
oh and i'm in the wrong environment
that's why
so
just be careful about this one and i
don't need this anymore because we've
already updated uh that
and so we'll paste that on in here
whoops
we'll type in micro k8s
and says sinatra pod not found maybe we
called it sinatra example or something
so we'll say
micro k8s
cube ctl get pods
okay yep they're very uh they're very
unique okay so then we'll have to
actually give it the pod name here
right and so now that we're here we'll
do ls and we'll go to cd to the root and
we have a config directory we'll go
inside of there and notice we have
game.properties user
interface.properties so if we really did
want hello world to be propagated over
there we would have to write in
that file you know hello world and then
its path okay and if we go into game
properties is that oh that's a file so
we can go cat game properties and see
its content and so there we can see the
files so yeah that's pretty much config
map
two different ways to access it very
cool
and yeah that's it
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at secrets so
we did config map which uh are uh
completely
not encrypted in any way whatsoever and
so secrets is a great way for us to pass
our sensitive information into our pods
or containers uh so what we'll do is
pull up the kubernetes secrets
now by default by default uh they're
stored in unencrypted api
api so in order to do that we'd have to
enable encryption at rest for secrets
rbac rules all these other things
i'm not sure what we'd have to do for
that i mean like for the ksna it's a bit
out of scope but let's just take a look
at micro kds and type in status and see
if
um if there is any kind of like
extension just to turn that stuff on to
configure it
micro k8s status
micro k8s
am i crazy today am i not typing it
right
oh you know what it's because i didn't
type exit i was still in um
in our pod from before so micro ks
status
i'm just curious what we can see here in
terms of options so
we don't have rbac turned on so i'm not
sure if i'll have to turn it on to use
it but there's rbac
and i don't see anything in particular
for secret so you know there might be
some things we need to configure but uh
i don't particularly care if they're
secured i just want to go through the
motions with you to see how it would be
done so there are different types of
secrets that you can set so pay is what
generally is for user defined stuff and
then we have a variety of other ones
here i would imagine that maybe
the encryption is different or something
i'm not really sure um but you know
we'll go through the motions of setting
up our own secret so it's very similar
to doing the config map so
here's an example of some data
so we'll go ahead and grab this secret
here and make our way back here and
we'll create a new file
called secret.yaml you can also ingest
them from a file so even though we are
placing uh the data right in here you
can include additional key value pairs
opaque so you can pass the data in just
like that
um say like username password
andrew brown testing one two three
and notice here it says service account
token so if we go back here and we look
at the types we can change it so maybe
basic auth would usually have a username
and password
okay so go ahead and paste that on in
here
and then there's annotations for the
service account name that's with role
based access controls i don't know if we
need this right now uh i have a feeling
that we probably do but i'm going to go
ahead and delete it out and see what
happens so we'll just say
basic auth
say sinatra basic auth
as the metadata name
and so we'll see if we can actually
create this here
so type in micro k8s cube ctl apply
hyphen f
k8s secret
okay
so it says error when creating secret in
version one uh cannot be handled as a
secret illegal base64 data as the input
okay
so i guess it expects us to do something
with it so we'll take a look here
um
oh they actually have an example right
here oh string data okay so we'll change
this over here so i guess it's going to
vary based on what you're doing so this
says data this one says string data
because that's technically what it is
i guess it was b64 we'd have to just
encode it but we'll go switch that over
like that
hit enter and it created it so now we
can type in micro k8
s
cube ctl
get secret
secrets
micro
there we go uh maybe we get some detail
so say uh describe
secrets
sinatra basic off
all right and so notice that we cannot
see the contents of it says 10 bytes and
11 bytes um still we didn't go through
all those motions of setting up these
other things so i'm just hoping micro k8
did it for us because i don't know if
like we didn't set up secrets as it said
uh above here with all these options if
it would show plain or show just in
bytes but at least it looks like it's
obscuring from us so that's really great
if we want to go fetch that secret
that's a good question so we'll go back
here and see if it allows us or shows us
how to fetch that data
it is not
you can edit it using secrets i just
want to see how we can see it
okay so i know
uh let's see this is secrets and this is
on kubernetes as well this is managing
secrets using a configuration file i'm
just looking for the cube ctl command so
we can view it
so we scroll on down here
so verify decode ah so maybe that's what
we want so cube ctl get secret
um
yeah this one shows bytes
oh did they do something similar to us
like basic auth
well let's give a go and see what
happens if we run this but this we're
not following this tutorial so i can't
expect this to work the same way
but we will try for fun
and we will say here
the proper name which is this
paste that
in and we'll type in micro k8s
micro k8s
oh it does okay great so that did work
so we have this output json path so i
guess what we're saying is get the
secret
and then we specify get us the data even
though it says string data i think it's
just saying like the data is being
inputted as a string but we want to grab
the data and so that is one way for us
to access our data using cube ctl but
how do you get it within a pod that's
the question so it's no different than
what we were doing we can i think we can
mount it as a volume i think we can do
that so we go over here um back over to
this and we say volume
i know we can do it with a volume
whoops
volume
as a file volume mounted so it's going
to be the same process
as we did with config map
as you can see here so
nothing's super exciting we're not going
to go through all that but we will look
at how to do it for um
just not like we did the environment
variable so we can go secret
um
what's the one we set that we commented
out up here config map ref it would be
like secret ref
secret ref
yes so if we wanted to do it uh like
pass it this way here we could do secret
ref here
and if we wanted to update this maybe we
could try like hello hello message
say like secret message
i don't know if this will work but we'll
try for fun
and i'm going to go here and type in
clear and then we will go ahead and
apply this if we can find it here
and so now we'll make sure that we
actually have that data
yeah it is here so notice that it is
encrypted and so i'm hoping that we can
just pull that information out so this
is called
secret base basic auth even though basic
authors don't be using a password that's
totally fine i don't care
um just copying that
paste that in there
that looks okay and so
what we'll do
is we will update
apply f will update our deployment
and see if that takes
and i got type cube ctl in there
okay
and then we need to
wait for our containers to or pods to
spin down and spin back up
and by the way as we've been doing all
this we actually haven't been using the
um dashboard which
surprised we haven't been uh it might be
fun to go take a look at that
just because uh we've been adding all
these things and we haven't used it at
all
so
i think the easiest way is to go to the
home page here go to linux scroll on
down go to micro8
proxy dashboard proxy
and i'm going to make a new terminal
here tab hit enter
and this is the token we want so
i want to
[Music]
go and find the ec2 instance and get its
ip address because i don't know what it
is
and here it is
so we'll go ahead and grab that
we will override this one and i need the
ip address here so go grab the
port number there and it says
cannot find the request http colon
client sent hp request to an http server
yeah okay it should be colon oh sorry
we'll just put the s in and then we'll
advance because we don't have a
certificate attached
and then we need the token so we'll go
back here hopefully we've grabbed it in
time i don't know if it's going to
expire or something and we'll sign in
and now it's just fun to kind of look at
this so we had a config map here below
you can see it was created over here
can we edit these in place oh that's
cool
so yeah if we wanted to just edit this
that'd be really cool to do
um
we don't have any persistent volume
claims do we have or we have our ingress
service just poking around for fun here
we'll look at our
deployments so what i'm curious about is
like did our pods change so available
progressing new replica set available so
nothing super new here
this happened a minute ago so i think it
did happen one minute ago it did replace
our
our pods there so that means that we
should be
okay to do a curl local host
and do sinatra
ah there we go so it worked um so yeah
that's secrets
okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are doing another follow along
and this time we're dealing with volumes
and and specifically with uh persistent
volume so we have our two environments
and we're going to use our micro cage
environment here and so what i want you
to do is make your way back over to here
and within
micro creates we need to enable storage
so we type in micro k8 status
there is an option to
uh
have a storage here and so all this
storage thing does
is um i'm just trying to find it here
here it is so it will create us a
storage class uh and
the reason why we're doing this is
because when you usually have a storage
class you generally are
linking to something external so it
could be like um aws ebs or
azure disk or something like that and
just to make this easy for development
uh micro case has this storage class
that is locally on the machine uh so
we're not gonna learn how to create a
storage class because it's gonna create
one for us but we are going to use it
and it's just going to make learning
persistent volumes and persistent volume
claims a lot easier so we'll type in
micro k8s
and we'll type in enable and then
storage and that will enable our storage
so it's just going to go ahead and
create us a storage class there
okay and so here it says it created an
rbc authorization so a cluster role
cluster role binding service account
storage class stuff like that it says
it'll be available soon so now what
we'll do is type in uh cubectl
and uh we'll say get
maybe sc for storage classes yep there
it is and so this is the name it's
called micro k8 host path and so the
idea is that on this node uh we will
have um our volume or our or something
mounted to our directory here okay
and so now that we have that out of the
way i'm just pulling up the instructions
i wrote earlier and so what we'll need
to do is create a persistent persistent
volume so a persistent volume
is
basically
uh it's saying okay this is the volume
and it uses this type of storage class
all right and so that's what we're going
to be doing there and ignore my stream
deck i really hate how it always pops up
but i'm just going to uh say remind me
later okay i usually don't get pop-ups
in my in my videos but there's one there
so what we'll do is go and type in
persistent volume and see if we can just
pull some code from the kubernetes
website to start with okay so we'll just
load that up here and i'll just scroll
on down and i'm just looking for
persistent volume
an example of persistent volume so we
have uh here's one okay so what we'll do
is just basically kind of grab this one
this is clearly not enough
but i do have my code off screen here
that we will bring in here to make it a
bit easier and so i'm going to make a
new file here and we're going to call
this pv.yaml
all right and then we'll go ahead and
paste that on in there and so we'll just
take a look at what we have so
the first thing is we'll need metadata
i'm going to call this mypv i really
don't like when people type foo and
we're going to apply labels type local i
don't know if we need to have the label
there but that's the example that they
are using
for micro k8 so if we typed in micro k8
storage they might show an example there
let's see if there's an example here
no
we might type in like tutorial
and it's the same page here
and it could be this one
no but that's okay like i just have it
off screen i just like to show you where
i'm grabbing the code from so you get
very good at googling too because really
with kubernetes you have to spend a lot
of time looking for stuff because the
main docs is always kind of uh not that
great so the storage class name is going
to be the storage class that we want it
to be so this is going to be micro k8
i'm going to copy and paste it so i
don't
type it wrong here and so we have cube
ctl sc and we'll go grab its name from
down below
and paste it in the storage class here
and then we need to specify the capacity
so how much we're going to reserve of
space for this and so i'm going to do
capacity
storage
and we'll say one gigabyte okay
making sure i split capacity right and
then we might want to specify our axis
mode
so the axis mode is like can you read
and or write okay
and make sure you set those to two
spaces over there
and so we'll say access modes
and i think this is an array so we'll do
hyphen there we'll say read
write once
um
claim reference we don't need that um
but what we do need is to set the host
path and so we're going to actually say
for this
storage volume where is it going to be
accessible on our node or our local
machine here and so i'm going to say
mount data and so that means
uh not within uh the pod but here in our
developer environment our virtual
machine on the forward slash mount data
that is what will be will be shared to
our uh pods okay
so this looks okay to me
but i did type a lot by hand so
hopefully it is all correct and so what
we'll do is go ahead and deploy this
okay and so we'll type in k8
pv yaml
and it's created our volume there and so
what i'll do is go ahead
and we will go view the contents of it
so say cube ctl
pv or sorry
get pv
i gotta spell it right
okay so
what we see is the name the capacity the
access mode whether to retain it is it
available but notice there is no claim
so technically it's not linked to
anything right now and so that will be
what we'll do next with the pvc the
persistent volume claim let's get a bit
more of a description here to see if
there's anything interesting
and so we'll just expand that up
and it's pretty much you know same
information nothing super exciting so
now what we need is a persistent volume
claim
okay and so what we'll do is just go
back over here and see if we have an
example and there is one
so we'll do is go
back over here and say new file we'll
say pvc.yaml
and we'll go ahead and paste that
and we need our metadata i'm going to
call this mypvc
uh we don't care about namespace we'll
put in the defaults here
and we do need to specify a storage
class so that one will be the same as
the other one
so i'll just go over here
okay
and
we'll paste that on in there
and we'll delete that
and then we need to specify the
resources
i don't care about the volume name we
don't have to write that in there it
will just set it to my pvc i think and
so we'll say resources and we'll tab in
we'll say requests
and then we'll say storage so we're
saying how much we want to request so
i'm going to set it the same value and
this is not going to work because if
this is one gigabytes and this is one
gigabytes it's just taking up too much
of the space and you have to be less
than that but i just want to show you
what happens if we match it one to one
okay so what we'll do is type in clear
and i'm going to do cube ctl
apply hyphen
f and then we'll specify k8 uh pvc
gamble
and notice that my pvc is in valid
access mode required at least one axis
mode so maybe my indentation is the
wrong levels or i deleted it out
oh no i didn't even specify it so we'll
go here
these darn spaces um
two
maybe this little cog will let me set it
nope
nope i just don't feel like looking it
up
okay
so we'll go here and type in storage
class name colon and then oops no no no
no no we already have that what we want
is our access modes it's going to be the
same thing because what it's trying to
do is say
a pvc is saying like tell me what you
want like this is what we want and then
the pv uh the person's volumes this is
what we have and if it matches up then
they will uh match up via a claim okay
so we'll go here and paste that in and
i'll go back and hit up and so it
created the pvc and so now what we'll do
is type in
cube ctl
get pvc
um
type that right
there we go and so it says status is
bound
and we'll type in pv
and
it's bound and it's claimed okay so it
did match up so i don't know when i was
doing this and i had it the the wrong
side or one one to one it didn't work
but i guess like if we were to set this
to be like two then i would expect this
not to work so let's just go and change
that to do
because clearly that's too large right
and here it says forbidden only
dynamically provisioned pvcs can be
resized
okay well we don't really want to resize
it so what we'll do is delete it first
so we'll say cube ctl
delete
pvc mypvc
okay we'll type in clear we'll go take a
look at the pvc make sure there's
nothing claimed
not sure how it's claimed when it's not
there anymore
okay
well
uh what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and just delete
the pv here
and we'll just run them again okay
okay so we'll type clear and i'm just
going to hit up
because i want to
run uh pv
and then i want to see that it is
not claimed and then what we'll do is do
pvc
okay and then we'll go back to get pv
i'm just going to stretch this a bit
larger here
and uh notice here i don't know why it's
so hard to read i don't remember seeing
this many columns here but
we have the name i'm just going to try
to expand this a bit more and run this
again
maybe i'll just bump down the font here
to make it a little bit easier because i
can't see what's going on here with this
font this big
so go back to our terminal here
terminal terminal terminal where are you
there we go and we'll just bump this
down a little bit so there we go that's
a lot more manageable
so here we can see my pv and this one is
not claimed and um it's i guess it's
showing up the pvc that we have here but
notice that it's not matching up because
it's it's too large right so
what i'll do here is i'll change this
back to one i'm going to see if i can
actually change it i know it said like
before we can't resize it but maybe we
can if
it's not claimed yet
so we'll run that
field cannot be less than the previous
value so notice here
okay so i guess you can expand it but
not shrink it so that's fine
so what we'll do is just go ahead and
cube ctl
um
delete pvc
we'll say my pvc
and we'll type clear
okay and so now what we'll do is we'll
go and then run it again
and actually before we do that i just
want to shrink it so it's smaller i'll
say 200 megabytes
there we go
and then we'll go back there just trying
to figure out the bounds of this stuff
so it's claimed it's bound um so now the
only thing that we need to do is we need
to actually have a deployment that has a
volume attached so what we'll do is go
back to the kubernetes page here and see
if it actually shows an example with the
deploy i think it shows like with a pod
maybe here
keep scrolling down here
yeah and so this is pretty much
yeah so it says pod but we can do this
with a deploy and so what we're going to
do is go back over here to our deploy up
here and there's a lot of stuff going on
here so i'm just going to go copy the
contents here make a new file and call
this deployment
with
pv
or storage
and we'll paste that
and we do have some old stuff here that
i do not want so first we will delete
uh and make sure you put the
yaml part on the end of it or it's not
gonna work properly
it's not for coloring so
obviously we've done a volume mount with
a config map but
here we have sinatra so i'm going to say
sinatra with volume
or storage
okay
and we're just going to keep
up with that maybe
just say pv
like with
pv just trying not to type a hundred
things here
oh we have our container name sure we'll
just update that as well
and this all looks fine we don't need
environment variables
ports are fine the readiness probe is
fine so that's what we would have if we
had our minimal one for before
and so what we need to do is make it so
that we attach a volume to it so we'll
go back over to here
and notice that we need to do a volume
mount so we'll go ahead and copy paste
that in that needs to be aligned with
the name image within the containers the
indentation is a little bit tricky but
we'll figure it out so i'll go ahead and
paste that on in there
and we'll just fix our indentation
i'm noticing this is all four spaces
okay and so this
should be
i would say like that that looks okay to
me
and then what we need is the volumes
part so we'll copy that that's going to
be aligned with containers
and we probably can just paste it even
above to make our lives a bit easier
okay and so we have the
we gotta see what we need to match this
up with so
for the volumes part
we'll give it a name like mypvc
and then what we're putting here is
mypvc so we're matching what volume
claim we want to be attached or like
associated with this actual
pod
okay and then under the containers
itself this is what we want to define as
the mounting directory so i'm going to
just call this mount
local
data here
and then
underneath here we just want the names
i'm going to say my pvc
all right and so
this should be the mount directory on
the actual container okay and so now
what we'll do is go ahead and deploy
that so i'll type in cube ctl
um apply f
deployment
or k8
with storage
and i gotta spell cube ctl correctly
and so that's deployed
and so what we'll do is just type in
clear
and then i'll just say um cube ctl
get pods
so we can see all of our pods and then i
want to
describe the one with storage notice
that we have two of them maybe we had
replicas on two here
yeah we do
and so i only want a one so i'm going to
scale that down so i don't have to deal
with two or actually we can just
probably apply it
to set up there update the value there
get pods
there we go
and we'll just wait for that to connect
while it's waiting we can just go ahead
and describe it
um
so this will be for the deploy
or we can describe the pod as well um
we'll describe the deploy first no no
we'll do pod
we'll do pod and then we'll just copy
the name here and just see like what
kind of volume information we can see if
any
um so it says persistent volume claim my
pvc not found so that's an error and
that's why it's not proceeding forward
so we must have spelled something
incorrectly
so we'll go back over here to my or our
pvc here it says my pvc
so that seems like that should be the
name
we'll type in cube ctl
get pvc
and there it is my
pvc
persistent volume claim
not found
[Music]
let me just take a look at my
instructions
well it looks like it's totally fine
let's just hit up and see if anything's
changed
no it still can't find that volume
so let's take a look at the
pvc volume itself
and describe it and see if there's any
issues
so it has a volume it is bound
and we'll go pv
and that looks okay as well
so i can think of is there's something
wrong with my script here so i'll be
back here in a moment and just compare
my uh my old script with this one okay
all right i'm back and so i just
carefully stared and i can see what the
problem is this is mv it should be m y
so that's probably what our problem was
and so what we'll do is just type clear
and redeploy that hopefully it takes
effect good
and then we'll hit up until we can get
to our pod the pod is going to have a
different name so we'll have to go get
pvc or sorry get pod
and then from there we still have two
one is running one is probably going to
stop
and if there's two deployments i'm just
going to double check here
nope we only have one
we go
and so i'm just going to grab that pod
name and we'll just say cube ctl
get pod here
and we'll just describe it make sure
there are no issues
well
gotta type it in the right place you
can't do get described that makes no
sense
okay and so here we can see
um there are no issues i'm just trying
to see if there is the claim here it is
read only false persistent volume
so it's all in good shape so that's good
to see let's go take a look at what it
looks like for the actual
um deploy so we'll say deploy and it's
called
sinatra with storage
and there we can see the volume claim
information again
okay
so now the next question is
can we see if our volume is actually
working
so what we'll do
is we'll go to that directory so i told
you it was local here mount data
remember this if we go back to our pv
here
we specified it's here so we actually
have a mount a data directory there and
i can just make a new file so i'll say
touch
and we'll just say hello.txt
now we'll do a pseudo on that because it
just doesn't like if we don't do sudo so
now that we created the file what we
should do is ssh or i guess um i say ssh
but we're actually just remotely
connecting to the shell so we'll type in
cube
execute hyphen i t
and then we need the name of a container
and then we'll have to have bin bash
notice before we did like sh we probably
do sh as well it's basically the same
thing
um in a new tab i'm just going to go
ahead and grab
the pod name so we'll say cube ctl get
pods
and that is the name of our pod
double checking there
yep
and then we'll go ahead and paste that
in here
oh sorry cube ctl
and so we're within our actual container
now
and so we mounted this at mount
it's being kind of silly here we mounted
this at mount m8
mnt
local data
so i'm just going to do ls on here i
don't i don't know why this uh this is
kind of being a bit glitchy here
if you notice i'm typing it's kind of
going weird soft to type it out by hand
no problem
and notice we have hello txt and that's
within our container so that's pretty
much
all we need to know for our persistent
volumes
i'm not going to clean this stuff up i
think it's totally fine it's not going
to heat up a lot of our resources here
but yeah that's it for storage so just
note that you always have to have a
persistent volume claim
um in order to attach a volume there
there might be an edge case where you
can attach a persistent volume to like
static resources with a persistent
volume claim but you always have to have
a pvc with a pv with a storage class
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this fall on we're going to be
taking a look at net policy so again i
want you to launch your micro case
environment that we set up earlier in
the course and what we're going to do
here is just type in clear and
get started here so in order for us to
use net policies we're going to have to
have some kind of cni so
um
cni plug-in right and so there's a
variety of different kinds but for cube
ctl they don't have a whole lot of
options we just have
psyllium so i'm not sure if that's the
proper way to pronounce it but that's
how i'm going to pronounce it here i'm
going to type in cube ctl status or
sorry micro k8 status
and give it a moment here to load and so
there might be other options here but
the only one that i recognize here is
called selem or cilium and so that's
going to allow us to have uh full
network policies all right so we'll go
down below here and we're just going to
type in micro case enable
and then put in psyllium
and then once that's in there what we're
going to need
this is taking a second here uh what
we're going to need is to have some
namespaces so with network policies we
can isolate based on or like control
traffic based at the pod level or at the
name space level
i'm going to do it at the namespace
level for this example because we don't
need to go
too super deep into net policies we just
need to get something working
and i'll just pull up while that's going
we'll type in net policies kubernetes
and see what the documentation gives us
all right and so here we are if we just
scroll on down so here is a general
network policy ours is going to be a lot
simpler than this this says ingress and
egress and
it's quite quite fancy
so what we'll do is go back here and see
if it's ready it's not yet but i already
kind of know what we need to do so
what we'll do is we will create three
different name spaces and we'll launch
a server or a
deployment into each of them and the
idea is that we'll have
uh one namespace that we'll try to talk
to and one will
be blocked and one will not be okay so
what we'll do is create our name spaces
we'll type in cubectl
ns for short for namespace you can type
namespace if you want but ns and we'll
have one called fire
and um
oh sorry create
and then we'll have fire ice
and wind and so those will be our three
name spaces that we'll be using
then we'll have to launch some pods i
don't feel like launching our sinatra
app so i'm just going to deploy
nginx
all right and so we'll just put the
image in here and say engine x and we'll
make sure the namespace is uh for fire
and so we'll hit up here and then what
we'll do one is for ice
and then we'll do one for wind
okay and so now we should have all our
pods so we'll just type in cube ctl get
pods and ice
wide
hit up again
um
[Music]
no resources found in the ice namespace
what if i just type in
pods here
huh
i guess the deploys are still happening
let's just get deploys
maybe just without the there okay and so
we see that they're ready but they're
not doing anything here so i wonder if
we've like used up all of our resources
on the machine
so what we'll do is get deployed we'll
say describe
deploy hyphen end ice
and we'll say ice engine x and we'll see
what it's complaining about
there's no errors so maybe it's just
taking time
i mean we are doing all this stuff over
here so i'm not sure if that was
conflicting with it we are seeing a
connection refused issue so it looks
like this probably didn't install
properly
okay
and we'll go back here and do a get
okay yeah so it just took some time here
now this didn't work out
i've never seen that happen before i'm
just checking here created
because when i when i did this it never
failed a
so we'll try one more time and see if we
need to do that
so it's already enabled so i'm not sure
about all these errors i don't know this
is going to run us into an issue but if
we create our network policy and doesn't
work we'll know that we don't have it
properly installed but maybe we have
enough installed
and we'll be lucky okay so looks like
all of our pods are running and stuff
like that so
what we're going to need to do is
basically ping a pod from one other pod
and so what we'll
do i'm just going to
write out a command here so we'll have
to do cube ctl hyphen n
choose um
a name say so i'm going to do fire then
we're going to have our pod name and
then we're going to curl a ip address
to somewhere and maybe i guess the idea
is like
this ip address is going to be like what
we want to access so we say okay from
from uh from an ice
from an ice um
pod
hit this fire ip address okay
that's what we're gonna do so what i'll
do is just type in clear and the first
thing we need is that pod name so
we'll go and type in cube ctl
get pods n
ice
we'll go ahead and grab that name on
there
i'm going to just move back there
and then
what we'll do is get fire hyphen o wide
because we're going to need its ip
address so there is its ip address
okay and then we'll go to the right here
and paste that on in
and just complaining about this because
maybe we forgot a word like exec
there we go
great and so the idea is nginx is
running an nginx page if you hit this
and so
we can access the fire server from the
ice server okay
and just to show for
the wind one so we'll do wind here
and then we'll go ahead and grab
wind
okay
we'll go ahead and delete this out
great so
right now we don't have network policy
in place so it makes sense that they're
able to communicate so now what we'll do
is create ourselves a network policy
i'm going to call netpal
fire yaml
and what we'll need to do is grab us
some code
so go to the network policy page we have
up here this is a way too much we don't
need this much code but we'll go here
and i don't feel like dealing with
egress so egress means
leaving the pod ingress would be
incoming from the potter container so
we'll delete out the egress here and i'm
just going to take a look off screen
here to the policy that i created
okay
and we're going to rename this so it
says net paul fire to ice so that's what
it's going to be so we're going to allow
communication from fire to ice or i
should say ice to fire ice can
communicate with fire okay but wind
won't be able to communicate fire but
it's all about fire so we'll just call
it the pull fire here
and then what we'll need is a pod
selector so what we're saying is this is
going to apply for our fire engine x
right so select all those pods
and then we need a policy type so we
only want ingress so we'll just take
that out for now
and then from here they have like a from
and they're doing ip block uh notice
there's a namespace selector pod
selector they're just showing a lot more
information that we need this is going
to be on port 80
because that's going to be how we're
doing the curls just on a
port http there
and so
we're not going to do pod selector we're
just going to do namespace selectors so
anything from that name space will be
able to communicate
and so what we'll do here is just change
this
we'll need to figure out what the label
is we're not going to do ip so we don't
care about that but what we'll do is
figure out
what kind of label we can apply here
because that's what we're going to need
so
what we'll do is type in
cubectl
getnamespace
wind actually won't describe probably
here
and see what kind of ener labels we have
so this is a label so we'll do is just
grab this part here
and paste that on in
and then this part is going to be
wind all right and so that should
work
uh we have to specify this is the fire
namespace because it's definitely not in
the default namespace
and double checking
looks okay to me
all right so let's go ahead and give it
a deploy so we'll type in apply f
k8s
netpole
fire.yaml
it's created the file so hopefully it
works
we'll type in cubectl
get netpol
oh hyphen end fire
and we'll describe its contents just to
see
what there is here and so it's saying
um pod selector is for fire allowing
ingress traffic to port 80 so traffic
into port 80 to fire but only from wind
okay so ice should not work and wind
should work so now if we just hit up we
already set this up before and we'll
just hit up until we find the commands
we want so we'll try wind first
and wind was able to download the page
no problem
and then we will go over to
ice
it's working so if they're both working
and the policies in place that means
that psyllium is definitely not
installed properly so what i'm going to
do here is type in micro ks disable
psyllium
see now when i ran this it was smooth as
butter i just enabled it had no problems
so i'm not sure why we're having
problems here but we'll disable it and
then maybe we'll re-enable it and
hopefully it works but if the network
policy is not in place then that's why
it would not be working okay
all right and so now we'll enable it
again and we'll hopefully it'll just
work because maybe when we were
installing it there was just like
network connectivity issues not relating
to our environment but just
what we were downloading it from
and so i'll see you back here in a
moment when this is done downloading
okay and hopefully it installs properly
all right so it looks like we're still
having this here now again i did this uh
same environment just a different
account and had no problems with it so i
just don't trust this environment i feel
like there's something wrong with it so
what i'm going to do is just type in i'm
going to make a new volume so this will
be micro k8
of
netpol
env
and so this will be our environment
specifically dedicated for testing this
example here so i'm going to go back
here again you might not have this
problem it might work perfectly for you
and you'll just proceed forward with no
problems but what i'm going to do is go
ahead and set up a new
pod here so we'll go ahead or sorry uh
environment so i'm going to spin up this
new environment i'm going to make my way
over to the aws console
right and from there i want to go to ec2
and i'm gonna just see if there's any
new machines here
i'm not sure why it's not spinning up
another machine
[Music]
not having much luck here today
we'll go back to ec2
normally ec2 instances show up pretty
fast so i'm kind of just surprised there
it is okay and so we'll go to our next
uh network policy environment just for
this case we'll go ahead and go over to
our volumes
and
i'm going to click into the storage i'm
going to modify it we're going to set it
to 40 gigabytes so we don't have any
problems here
and then i'm just going to wait for this
environment to start up uh here then we
want to install micro kh so we'll go
micro
i mean it's just snap so
well we'll go to the website micro
creates
and just quickly reinstall micro k8 on
this environment because it was so easy
since last time we did it so we'll paste
that on in there
and looks like our volume has resized it
shouldn't be a problem here
probably shouldn't be running commands
unless we know it's been resized but you
know i just want to get it done
and so michael kate's there we'll have
cube ctl
and then we learned from our fix that we
can do micro k8s
config
and then do a
cube config
maybe about to touch that file first
just make an empty file
well maybe we type in cube ctl and maybe
it'll generate out that directory for us
all right remember we have to type these
things in
so we'll go and paste that on in
then we'll paste that on in
then we'll type in micro
case cube ctl
get pods and then it'll download
oh no it didn't have to download it
great and so maybe we'll hit up now to
um that line we have here
there we go and so now it did that so
now i can do cube ctl cap pods
good and now i'm going to just make sure
i have enough space on this drive here
and i'm just looking for
the drive usually it's 10 but we set it
to 40 gigabytes
so looking for it here
it's still at basically 10. so we'll go
over to our ec2 instance back to it
and i'm just going to go ahead and
reboot it
and we'll give that a moment to
reconnect
and so if this works that'll be great if
it doesn't that would suck but i hope it
does
worst case scenario i could always just
open my other environment and show it
there but it's just kind of frustrating
if i can't replicate it here
and if this hangs too long you can just
hit refresh sometimes that helps here
too when it's doing a reconnect here
or if it does that another thing i do is
just go
back to the cloud 9
interface here
and then i would open up netpol
and if it is rebooting we can go back
here and just double check
so it's two out of two
i guess whenever it decides to connect
i'll be back here in a moment okay
all right so i did a few refreshing and
then finally let me back in here so it's
not always perfect when reconnecting so
we'll type in micro case status to see
what we have installed because this is
now completely fresh here
micro k8 micro k8 status
there we go we had to wait for it to get
running there again i'm going to scroll
up here and so all we have is the h a
cluster so we'll want dns for sure
so we'll go here and say enable dns and
then um we want
the psyllium right so we'll go here and
grab psyllium
and so i expect the nest install without
issue but i'm hoping psyllium just works
with a fresh
fresh fresh fresh environment
so this will take a little bit of time
but i will wait until it's done here and
i'll see you back in a moment okay
all right so look it actually worked no
problem this time so for whatever reason
the old environments just kind of bust
at least for that particular use case so
we will have to uh back pedal here and
redo a lot of the stuff we just did
which is not a big deal it's not going
to take too long to do so i guess we'll
just go ahead and do it again and
practice makes perfect right so we need
our
name spaces so we'll say create an s
fire
create ice
create wind
and then we need to create
deployments so deploy
fire engine x
image engine x
hyphen n
fire
and then we got ice
okay and then we got wind
great and so then from here what we'll
do is we'll create ourself a new um
file which will be our net paul fire
yaml
and we'll go back to our original
environment here that we're running
and i'm going to go ahead and just grab
this file here
we'll go ahead and paste that on in
okay and that looks
what we were using before so it's
totally fine and so we'll type in cube
ctl apply hyphen f actually before we do
um let's go make sure we can communicate
between our nodes
so
um uh let's remember what that command
is so it's cube ctl whoops
cube
ctl hyphen n fire exec
and then we need
our pods here so we'll say new terminal
so say cube ctl
get pause and fire or sorry ice
and then we'll say
wind
and then for fire we need hyphen o wide
and so we'll go ahead and grab our ip
address here
paste that on in
we'll go ahead and grab this one here
and this is actually going to be for
it was wind here a moment ago i already
kind of forgot
and i believe it goes here
well the first one is ice
wind oh sorry that says ice here so
change that to ice
and i believe it was uh hyphen hyphen
curl
and then localhost or i guess uh
whatever the ip address is yeah there we
go okay great so this one's set up and
then i'm just gonna quickly do the wind
so we'll do
wind
and then that one wind okay great so
that works no problem now let's go ahead
and deploy our network policy so we'll
do cube ctl
apply
hyphen f
net pull fire yaml
and so it created it and so now what we
can do is go hit up try out wind it
works fine
try out ice
it works fine
okay so
one of those should have hung like it
should have not worked
but it didn't um
so maybe there's something wrong with
our selectors it does say roll up here
which doesn't seem right to me
so let me go back over here now
like psyllium definitely did not install
properly so i don't think our network
policy was our problem i do believe that
uh it wasn't installed correctly but
let's just take a look at the actual
selector name so we'll say
describe
pods
and fire
because i think it's just app by default
yeah so it is so change this to app
okay
and then we'll have to redeploy our
fire policy
we'll type clear
i'm just trying to find our commands
that we type below maybe it's in this
screen here there we go so does ice work
notice that ice is hanging look it can't
connect
right because we said that wind is
allowed to have access and not
um not ice and so we go to wind
and there we go so that's all there was
to it unfortunately we had to take a
bunch of detours there um but you know
that's the learning experience and
that's the hard parts that you're
looking to watch so
that's pretty much it
and you can delete this environment
because we're done with it so what we'll
do
is close the network policy environment
and we'll go back over to
our environments here i'm going to go
ahead and just delete this one because
we are done with it
okay
there you go
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this following we're going to be
looking at k native which is a
serverless or serverless-like
platformer tool
for kubernetes and so because this is
such a heavy duty tool on top of
kubernetes i don't want to pollute our
existing micro k8 environment so i'm
going to create a new environment here
we're going to call this k or micro k8
okay native so it is a bit work to set
up but in this case it makes sense to do
it okay so we'll do env i'll do it next
we're going to choose a t3 medium just
so that we have sufficient space
and or memory and here we'll choose
ubuntu and we'll go next steps
we'll go ahead and create that i really
really wish aws would let us choose the
storage size i'm just going to check if
there's any additional options
no they really should let you do that
because it's such a pain that you have
to go resize stuff we'll go ahead and
create this environment
and while that is creating i'm going to
go over to a new tab we'll type in
console.8bus.amazon.com we'll make our
way over to ec2
and we are looking for this new
environment because we need to increase
that volume size as per usual
so we'll give it a refresh here
and
[Music]
is it here yeah it's right there so
we'll go into here we'll go over to
storage
we will choose the volume
and i will go to actions
and is the volume ready yet oh we have
to choose it
modify the volume and we'll change this
to 40 gigabytes we'll hit modify we'll
hit modify we'll go back to ec2
and even though it is running we are
going to restart it reboot it
just to save us some trouble here
and so now we just have to wait till
this connects
and then from there
oh did it really reconnect that fast
nope it's reconnecting okay great
and so we just need to wait for that
reconnection to happen as that's going
let's go take a look at k native so k
native here is enterprise grade
serverless on your own terms so it says
kubernetes-based platform to deploy and
manage modern service serverless
workloads if you're wondering what k
native is compared to open foss or other
serverless frameworks strongly recommend
reading this article like versus open
fos it is an article
on the cnsf blog and it's very very good
at explaining the stuff i like to the
point that i actually grabbed this quote
here and put in the course so we could
understand the difference between the
two but if you get an opportunity to
read this whole thing and it doesn't
just talk about those twos it talks
about all the types of
open source frameworks
serverless frameworks for
kubernetes but coming back over here the
idea is kubernetes and just going
actually to this article because it does
outline it pretty well
but k native already uses um components
that we're familiar with like istio
and it uses
kubernetes underneath of course but
there's three components to building
eventing and serving and so venting
serving is where we're spending most of
our time but the idea is serving is the
ability to quickly serve stuff that will
automatically scale from scratch have
routing and networking so the idea is
that
um when we are utilizing kubernetes we
have to uh provision all these things
like services and pods and deployments
and so the idea with k native is that
you just have one line and it does all
the stuff for you you only have to set
up you don't have to set up horizontal
pod auto scale or anything it just all
works for you does snapshots it
has revisions for your code and then on
top of that it has eventing so the idea
is that not only does it make it easy to
just
provision
things
and have all those nice services around
it but eventing allows you to
trigger
when these
functions should run based on a bunch of
stuff and so there's a whole ecosystem
with that not sure why the redirecting
is kind of messing up here so yeah down
below
they had on the website before i'm not
sure why i can't seem to find it right
now
but
on the k native page here they had a
good description out here serving and so
they talked about
the integrations they had i can't seem
to find it right now but the idea is
that you can trigger stuff for that to
happen so
oh we're under serving i wanted a
venting that makes sense now
so the idea is that you have triggers
channels descriptions there's all sorts
of ways to uh trigger your k native
events but now this environment's ready
what we'll do is get micro k8 installed
so we'll do the classic here
okay
and while that is going i'm going to
install cube ctl just to save myself
some time
we'll just do cube ctl
uh
i think i might have just accidentally
canceled that out there
okay so cube ctl is installed micro case
is almost installed here
and then we'll have to wait for the
server to spin up as that is going we'll
go back over here and look at the
tutorial to get getting started here
look at the quick start here
uh we'll have to also install um kn so
kn is the um
k native
utility library so we'll have to go grab
the binary as well
um so the easiest way to do this is to
go to the release page here
and then what we need to do is download
um the one that we need so
amd 64 is x64 architecture x86 sorry and
so that is the file that we need
and i'll need to show that in finder
and it's just downloading there as well
while this oh now that we have michael k
it's installed
type in microcase dns
and also k native
uh enable
assuming the uh micro kx is ready oh
right we need to run these two lines
here so we'll run this one
and we will run this one
[Music]
and then we'll run this line here
and then we'll go back up and we will
enable dns and k native and those both
will install assuming that
the cluster is ready
and i'm still waiting for this to
download okay this is now done
and so the idea here
is trying to hide some things
in my screen here but here is the file
so i have it downloaded here and i'm
just going to quickly rename this to kn
because it is a binary right
and then the next thing we need to do is
upload it to
cloud9 so if we go to file upload local
files i'm just dragging that kn file
it's just that file here right that we
just renamed
and it's going to be there so we'll go
ahead and close that it uploaded pretty
darn fast oh it's still uploading right
here you can see the percentage
so we're just going to wait for that to
finish as that is going i'm going to go
here and
um make it so that we can use cube ctl
so we'll type in micro k8 config
tilde
q a period cube config
um
maybe we'll close this tab here and
reopen a new tab close
and open a new terminal
and hit up again
we already did this so i'm not sure why
i have to do this twice
maybe i made a mistake
maybe i forgot the s on there
okay and then we'll go back there
oh you know i forgot to put the
um right angle bracket
and so now we should be able to do cube
ctl get pods
clear
we'll go over here and it looks like
installation is still going
and while that's going we should move kn
into the correct directory so we'll go
back over to k native and we'll have to
chamod it
so go over here and we'll check mod and
then we want to move that into a
location like user local bin
so we'll say sudo move
kn to user local bin
great so kn is now
ready to go there and if we go back here
we're just waiting for k native to
finish
i'm just going to double check to make
sure that it's anything else there we
might check the version afterwards which
might be okay to do so we'll go over
here
check our version
cannot execute binary file exec format
error
i wonder if it's actually a binary let
me just double check
oh did i download the amd
did i download the wrong one
that's probably what it is
all right well we'll go back over here
and uh no amd is right yeah that's the
one that we want oh but i downloaded
darwin i needed linux for xxx darwin is
for mac os i'm sorry so we'll download
that one and i guess we'll have to go
ahead and delete this other one here so
we'll say remove
sudo remove
user local bin
kn
and now that's done downloading i'm
going to go ahead and go grab that one
so i'm just going to delete the other
one here
and we will open up our file upload here
so
file upload local files
drag that on over
we'll rename this to kn
we'll drag that back on in there we'll
have to wait for that to upload which
shouldn't take too long we'll go over
here and the k native should be
installed uh we'll do cube ctl get pause
and we'll just take a look at what was
installed
because everything's pods right so here
you can see we have istio so istio was
installed for it
um we have cave native serving cave at
native eventing just to kind of show you
what's going on here and we're just
waiting for this to download and then we
can proceed generally forward
but maybe i'll just take a look and see
what kind of code i have here
yeah we need to wait for kn
so once we have kn installed we will
then go towards serving our first
service so here they have a hello world
go example and notice we just do kn
service create
and it will do a bunch of stuff for us
okay
so that is now uploaded so now we'll
just hit up and do the same thing we did
before so we'll chamod our kn
i'm just gonna close this so it's out of
the way
and then we will move our stuff into the
correct directory
okay
kn version
great
so
i think we're a-okay
um
so go back over to here
we'll go ahead and grab this now they do
have yaml notes that's using k native
dev so the specification is different
but looks pretty similar to what we
normally see so we're going to go ahead
and create this
hit enter
it's going to go ahead and create the
sample
now
i think that
when i created this i remembered that
this hung for a long time even though it
did create the service
so if this takes too long i might just
cancel or kill it out okay so i'm gonna
type clear here
and as this is going i'm just gonna go
back up here and type in pods and just
see if that spins up so yeah it is
creating the container
and maybe we can just kind of inspect
what that pods doing so we'll say um
i was going to type um
cube ctl get
pods paste that in there
and then maybe describe it
let me just kind of read what it was
doing so down below
it's successfully creating the image
it's pulling the image
it's creating a proxy things like
that and i'll just hit up here again
okay so that pod
is
there
so go back here
and the idea is that when we run this
we're expecting this output to happen
which
seems like it's never going to occur
anytime soon
but we did just describe the service
well hold on here so
okay i know that's never going to finish
but i know that it's ran so what we'll
do is we'll just proceed forward so i
know we didn't have this and so i had to
go look up kind of see what the command
is so if we type in kn
service list we can see all the services
we deployed so there is hello don't
worry that it says it's not ready
because it totally did it did definitely
work we'll type describe hello
and as you can see here it says hello
default one revisions okay type age
reason so definitely is working but i
don't know why it hangs like this all
right so but we did install k native we
did run through the basis of the
tutorial so technically you know we we
did use k native uh in terms of the kcna
it's not like you really need to know
how to do this i'm just kind of showing
you so you get more domain knowledge on
this kind of stuff and kind of show the
experience of where you might hit
friction there but i'm just going to
stop there and that's all i really
wanted to show you 4k native so we are
done and what i'm going to do
is go back to our um
uh
like our cloud9 stuff
just because we have so many darn
environments i just want to go ahead and
delete this one so you are not
having spend
we'll type in delete
and that's it for k native okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i showed uk native now let's go take
a look at open foss and let's go set
that up and we will have to set up a new
environment i know this is a pain but
it's better to set these up in islip
just because um it is quite the large
install so what we'll do is create
ourselves a new environment we're going
to type open foss
faas
env maybe just put micro k8 so we
remember that it's micro k8
and we'll go ahead and hit next step we
will choose t3 medium
then we'll choose ubuntu we'll scroll
down and we'll hit next step we'll
create that environment
and we'll give that a little bit of time
to create as that's going we'll type in
console aws amazon.com
make our way over to ec2
and i'm just waiting for that new one to
spin up as that's going
we have this nice article
which is open fast k native and more
just to kind of show the architecture so
with openvos it uses docker and it could
either use docker swarm or kubernetes it
has prometheus function watchdog api
gateway it has a lot of stuff compared
to k native
and this article explains like that open
foss is easier to use than k-native but
you might have some issues moving from
one provider to another
so that is one concern there but you'd
have to read the whole thing to fully
understand it
but what we're going to do is go to the
open fos website
and i think they kind of have a tutorial
here that we might be able to kind of
follow
maybe getting started here deployment
kubernetes
ah here we are micro k8s
nope that's no help i do have the link
here off screen that i was using
let me just go take a look
um
i think it's like first python function
that's what we want so we'll type in
open fos
first python function
that was definitely what i want to use
here
okay and we will have to install the
fast cli well actually we don't because
it's part of
micro k8 so this environment is starting
to run and so what we'll do is hit
refresh here and we need to resize our
drive as per usual so we'll go here to
storage
volumes
and we'll go ahead and modify
our volume and we'll change this to 40
gigabytes and hit modify
and while that's going we'll install
micro k8 so we'll just go to micro k8
website
i think by now i have this memorized but
i do not
we'll go sudo snap install micro k8 it's
classic we'll make a new terminal here
and then we will do the same thing for
cube ctl
okay
and we'll wait for that to install
we'll check on our volume our volume is
probably resized but we'll have to wait
for microcase to finish installing
before we do our reboot here
there we go and then we will type in
micro k8
cube ctl
and then it'll spit out the stuff here
that it wants us to do so we will paste
that on in there
we'll do new groups micro k8s
okay and then we'll do micro k8 cube c
or uh config
port slash cube
config and see if that works
i forgot the um
arrow
micro k8
cube ctl get pods
up again notice that it works now no
problem okay and so we'll go back to our
ec2 instance
and we'll just reboot it
so we'll say reboot reboot
and that will have to reconnect
and so yeah i mean it's not super tricky
we don't have to install uh fast cli
like we did uh kn because microcase has
it already and it's kind of a pain to
install so i'd rather not
do it this way
um
yeah i think we could do microkids i
can't remember actually now no you know
what i think uh i think we actually do
have to install it okay so we will
install i'm just trying to remember
right so
i guess we can try when this is
reconnected we'll type in microcades um
and we'll see if it actually works but i
think actually for this that i it is
there but i ended up installing open
fast cli because if we didn't i ran into
an issue later on in this follow along
and that's the reason for it
but we have to wait for this to
reconnect okay
so i'll see you back here when this is
reconnected all right so after waiting a
short little while here it is ready
again so uh we are in good shape so i'm
gonna type in micro k8 dns and then
we're gonna do open foss
and i have to probably write the word
enable in front of it so that it
actually works and so that's going to go
ahead and start to install open fast for
us
we also need to install
the
cli here so copy this line from where we
ever found it here on the first python
page
and so
it's saying running with sufficient
privilege permissions attempt to move
fast cli
so we are okay okay for shape if i type
it fast cli it does show up that is good
and open fast is installing so it'll
take a bit of time after it's installed
we do need to verify it i'm going to
close the micro cades page so it stops
popping up and driving me crazy
i'm just going to double check what we
need to do for
the next steps because we do need to
verify the installation
and i'm just double checking here to see
if it's here i think um
micro case is going to prompt us to tell
us hey
run this so you know that it's running
yes it does and so what we'll do is grab
this line to see if it works
and the next thing is we need this
password to actually use it so we'll hit
enter and we'll get this nice little
password so i'm just going to drop it in
here i'm going to clear this out
and then i'm just going to grab this
password for the time being and save it
here
because we'll need it for authenticating
to open bus
and now what we need to do is actually
go ahead
and build our function so
we'll go back over here and
they have one here so they make a
directory called functions and they put
all these these files in here and stuff
so let's scaffold a new python function
using the cli
sure why not so we'll go ahead and do
this
and paste that in
and here it's provisioned us a new
folder and hello python wow that's a lot
easier than typing it all in by hand so
if we open it up we can see the content
so it says open fos it's saying where it
is
here is the function it's going to the
handle is going to point to this
directory which is going to open this
handler.pi file if you have ever
deployed an as lambda function or
anything serverless this is looking very
familiar right like a handler file and
so here is our fancy handler file you
have your requirements.txt for anything
you want to install so what i'm going to
do is go back here and take a look at
the next step here and so it's just
telling us to update the file with this
print hello so we'll get back over here
and replace the contents of this file as
such
and we will save that
go back over here
and i think that this stuff is showing
up because it thinks that this is
a lambda function which it is not it's
an open fos function and then it's just
saying look at the contents of that file
it looks like it's correct because it
set it up all for us which is great
and then down below we can just build
it as such so we'll go here
and we'll type in fos cli build hyphen f
it's going to prepare our function
okay
and i think that the image is being
stored locally so it's not going out to
uh
because we didn't we don't have a
remote repo i guess it's i guess it's
building it here on the machine never
mind
so
the image is built
and by the way while we're at it we
should do get pods hyphenate just look
at all the pods that open fast added so
we have prometheus basic auth alert
manager gnats um
q worker gateway and stuff like that and
the gateway is something that we're
going to have to use next because we
have to have a way to connect to that
pod
so i'm just scrolling on down here and
seeing how we can see
the pod
next
because we want to deploy it right so we
built it and then we want to actually
deploy it so i'm looking for deploy
ah here it is okay
so now that we've built it the built the
image let's go deploy it so we actually
run the function and notice that we get
an error it says connection refused
failed to deploy with status 500
and so
for this i know
that we will have to do port forwarding
because i looked up another tutorial on
getting started with open fast and what
they had to do here
was to port forward
open fast
and specifically for the the service
called gateway
we do 8080 colon
and so now that we have port forwarding
i have to go over to our other tab here
and then what we can do is try to deploy
again
and we don't have it in the context of
this batch file so we'll just go ahead
and copy this line here
paste it on in
it says unauthorized access so we have
to log in first so we'll go ahead and do
fast cli login and so now it wants the
password so we'll have to do hyphen
hyphen password
and then we'll have to provide the
password that we have it here
okay and now we can go ahead and deploy
and it says hello python so there you go
that's how you deploy
a serverless function with openfast
so we're all done here and what we can
do
is go back to cloud nine and shut down
this environment
we'll go over here to open fast micro
case environment we'll delete
will delete
and there you go again it's not
needed to know the stuff for the exam um
well there are serverless questions but
just to kind of like really cement uh
what these things are just by going
through the motions of it okay
[Music]
hey everybody this is andrew brown and
welcome back to another follow along and
this time we're going to learn about
helm so what i'm going to do is go to
google and type in helm and here we go
to the helm website so helm is a way of
packaging your various scripts like your
manifest files into
a single package that people can use to
quickly uh set up projects here and so
i'm just waiting for the helm page to
load i'm not sure why it's so slow here
today but we'll click it again
maybe they knew i was up to something
and that's why it's slow but here it is
the package manager for kubernetes
so yeah just think of anything like ruby
or python or node.js like npm install so
you're installing basically a program
but it's installing like those files
into
your cluster so above here we have
charts and i'm not going to show you how
to package um
a helm project because that gets pretty
complicated but we will install a
project and take a look at the contents
of one so helm has this artifact hub
where you can uh view or browse a bunch
of different kubernetes projects but i'm
going to go up here and just type in
postgres
and um i just want to see one that
actually has a bunch of code so we can
just kind of look at uh what would be in
a helm directory there's one for azure
that is pretty good so i'll type that
one in here and it's bitnami for azure
okay so uh we'll go here and here is a
project
and if we go to the github repository
they're almost always hosted on github
but i'm just looking for the templates
if we click into templates here it shows
us all the files that are
involved and notice that we have these
like handlebar stuff here so you can see
that you know you might have a template
like a config map but then you have this
pragmatic stuff where you can pass in
values to helm and it will change that
stuff but let's go find the repository
if we can here that's what i'm looking
for
um
where are you i know it's here somewhere
so
i mean there's the that's the azure uh
uh
uh container repository so i'm not sure
if it'll show us that let's go ahead and
grab that actually never go to the azure
container repository there we go so we
can't see it there so maybe this one is
not a great example which is totally
fine but here says this is the repo okay
it is on github there we go so here it
says postgres h a so high availability i
assume and the idea here is you have
templates
and in your templates you can start to
see we have a variety of different files
you have postgres
pg pool again i'm not going to get super
deep into how this actually works but
just to show you that the files are
there then there's this values.yaml
thing this defines the type of
parameters that we passed into the
template so there's a lot there i would
imagine that when you use helm you you'd
have a command flag like hyphen hyphen
values and you pass the values you want
or you could specify a file most likely
but anyway that's the contents of a file
but let's take a look at how we go ahead
and install one so i'm just going to
open up my off screen here my my helm
instructions when i was trying to find
something out i'm just trying to find an
example of something that was um that
worked very well and actually you know
what i used juice box from oh wasp and
that was actually really easy to use so
what i'm going to do here is going to
browse all packages
and i think what i did is i went to like
security or maybe i went to web
applications that's probably what i did
and if we go here we'll probably see the
juicebox app so it is here or juice shop
sorry and so if we scroll on down you
have some instructions here but the real
instructions you can see there's all the
values um configured here but if you go
to install it gives you the two steps so
here it is but we'll need helm first
installed on our micro case environment
so launch your micro k8 environment and
then once you're in there we're going to
do ls
we're going to need to install helm so
if you do micro k8 status what you'll
see here is that they do have a helm
uh
plug-in add-on whatever you want to call
it module
right here oh it is enabled on this
cluster great so
um but anyway the thing is is like we
want to use helm 3. there is helm 2 in
here so if you were to do micro creates
enable helm that would give us two and
the problem with that is that it uses a
tiller server it's like this additional
thing that's really complicated and so
we'd want to activate helm3 now it looks
like it got activated for another reason
we could have been using something else
and it had to be activated so i think we
typed in like micro k8
micro k8 helm 3 that's how we would
probably access it yeah but i'm going to
actually go and directly install
the
helm
cli without having to do through michael
k8 and we can just do that on ubuntu by
doing sudo snap install helm i'm not
sure if it'll ask us to do classic yeah
it asks us to do classic i don't really
understand this whole classic thing but
we'll go ahead and hit enter and it's
going to go ahead and install helm so
now we just type in helm
okay and so if we go back to our juice
shop we're going to copy the first line
here because we need to add the repo to
know where this is stored all right so
that could be on github it could be on
elastic container repository azure's
container repository
docker hub maybe
i guess not docker hub because that
wouldn't make any sense but some kind of
repository right
and so
um
i'm losing where i am here we are so
we'll go ahead and paste that in there
yeah i guess the ecr
might not make sense because that's for
docker containers but um anyway so if
you add the repository we'll go back
here and we'll go grab our install chart
and if we go back and paste that in it
will uh go basically set up that
application so if we read it here it
says um
default namespace deploy get the
application url by running these
commands and so this is the command we
can run so all it's doing is doing a
port forward because it's already
running so if we do cube ctl
um get pods a bit we can probably see it
running there so there is the my juice
shop i'm not sure what else that
installed but uh i guess if we wanted to
know we would just probably go to the
repo and take a look here so where is
that repo
where are you source code here on github
and so this is the i think the the one
that uh we're using here and if we go
into templates so it deployed a config
map a deployment ingress a service so it
deployed a bunch of stuff
and um what we'll do is go back here i
really wish i had deployed that in a
namespace so we could easily delete it
but that's totally fine i don't think
we're going to run into a lack of space
here but what we'll do is paste this
line in here that's the one they
suggested but one addition i'm going to
do address
0.0.0.0 so we can access this outside of
our cluster
and i'm going to
change the port here from 3000 to like
8081 something like that maybe but
clearly the app is running on port
whoops
uh is running on port 3000 so almost
like a ruby on rails app it's probably
php though
when you talk about vulnerable apps php
is usually the one to go with so anyway
this is now running and i don't know if
the ports are open on that so what we'll
do is go over to ec2
and
maybe just open all the tcp ports for
our ip address so we don't have to
worry about opening individual ports
because this is just for development so
we'll go to security we'll go to
security groups
and yeah so we only opened up that port
but i'm just going to go ahead and say
all por all tcp ports
okay and that'll just save us a lot of
trouble there so save that rule and then
what we'll do is get the ip address of
the cc2 instance that's running our
environment here
so if we go up here to details we're
going to grab that public ip address we
said it's on 8081. i'm just hoping that
it works 8081 fingers crossed there it
is and here's the awas juice shop if
you've never heard of owasp it's um
it's for security so it stands for open
web application security project but
really it's a organization that has um i
think it's nonprofit yeah nonprofit
organization that has not just one
project but a lot of different projects
and resources and stuff
um to help you secure applications and
they have like chapters like user groups
meetups all around the world um and so i
mean this is one of their apps or
projects that helps you learn how to
better secure apps so it's purposely
insecure but that is the owasp app okay
so maybe we'll just kill the olaf's app
maybe by killing the deploy there just
so it's not uh or run it in here but
we'll do cube ctl get pods
and i'm just gonna kill it
so say cube ctl
delete
um
pods this one
okay and those other resources are still
there but because it is an app that's
designed to be vulnerable i know it's
only access by rip address i figure we
should just kill just in case but yeah
that's all i wanted to show you with
helm it wasn't that hard there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we are going to
set up a service match using linker d
now i did do this
lab ahead of time but i'm going to tell
you that i just couldn't get it 100
working at least in cloud 9 because when
you wanted to
see the viz dashboard you have to have
an ingress controller and that has to
run on port 80 and if we are running in
a cloud 9 environment we can't run on
port 80 we're just not allowed to open
up on that port so
um i mean we can do it in cloud 9 and
kind of get an incomplete tutorial but i
figured let's try to do it in ec2
and
hopefully there we will be able to see
the dashboard now if that doesn't work
it's totally fine because we can see
everything in the
buoyant dashboard but
we'll give it a go and do our best here
uh for the kcna you're not expected to
know how to set up a service mesh but i
just want to go through the motions with
it with you so you can kind of see and
be able to really understand the purpose
of a service mesh so i'm going to go
over to ec2 and instances we're going to
launch a new instance and it's going to
go to the old wizard we're going to go
to the new wizard even though i don't
like it and we're going to type in here
k8
or a micro k8
linker d
okay
and we need to choose ubuntu
and it's going to be on 20 which is
totally fine 64-bit architecture here we
want to have a t3 medium or we can have
t2 but we'll just do t3 because we've
been doing that this entire time
t3 medium
we'll scroll on down here and we will
allow ssh traffic that's totally fine
we're going to allow http traffic from
the internet
that's going to be totally fine
and we're going to want to have 40
gigabytes here
and we'll go to advanced details
and i'm just going to look through here
to see if there's anything else we want
i want to set a roll
but where the heck do they put this is a
totally new interface i don't know
because i don't want to have a key pair
i'm going to say no key pair here
and what i want to have is attach a roll
where the heck did they put it
i'm looking for i am roll
roll
where are you
is always changing the stuff on me like
crazy
shut down stop terminate detailed
elastic credits
capacity
is it just gone
hostname oh it's right here we're all
for frick six and so we're gonna need to
create a new i impulse uh profile get a
new interface i'm not used to where
things are and i probably already have
one for ssm role but we'll just make a
new one so we'll go here create a new
role
because we want to use sessions manager
to connect to stuff and this is new too
they just won't stop changing things on
me so um
they used to have like nice little icons
so you could see what you're looking at
so we are creating a database service
account it is for ec2
oh my goodness what is going on here
introducing the new experience what do
you what do you think it's terrible
like
no it's like the the drop out the the
drop down
is
it used to be very clear
what to click okay
whoever is doing their designs i don't
know they gotta send back the uh
the intern okay because it's you can't
even revert to the old experience and
it's weird because it's still like using
old elements but anyway so what we would
need to do is choose um the use case for
the service so we are doing the ec2 i
guess this is clear i just i'm getting
confused we'll go ahead and hit next and
so i want ssm roll so hit ssm
and we are looking for
uh the proper one i'm just checking here
because this one says this is deprecated
use this one so that's the real one i
want to look for and that's going to
allow us to use sessions manager so we
don't have to ssh and do anything super
complicated so i'll just check box those
there
where is it
okay we'll type in ssm again
it is being super glitchy today
and
i want
is it this one
i'm gonna double check here
amazon ssm manage instance core
i'll type core instead
there it is okay so we'll go ahead and
hit next
and we'll just say
micro k8
linker d
roll ssm just so we know what it is
click create roll
and there it is okay so we'll go back
here and now we'll type in
linker d
there it is and so now we can use
sessions manager
we'll go ahead and launch this instance
a lot of work
tons and tons of work to get this going
here
and now that that instance is launched
we can go view it
and the experience is not going to be as
nice i'm going to tell you right now
it's not going to be as nice as using
cloud9
but we are going to get through it and
you will learn how to use a virtual
machine without a nice environment
so we'll refresh here
because i'm waiting for these two status
checks to pass we don't necessarily need
to wait for it i'm going to hit connect
and if it works that's fine so we see we
have four options here is to do instance
connect sessions manager ssh client ec2
serial console they just won't stop
creating new connection types we're
gonna go with sessions manager here
which is gonna be totally fine
we'll give it a moment here to launch
and hopefully we don't have to spend
drivers or anything else with micro case
but i guess we'll find out here in a
moment um so
it's connecting
[Music]
actually i'm just thinking this is an
ubuntu instance so i i don't even know
who i am so type who am
i
ssm user
um good question i usually do those
amazon links too so
we'll type in sessions manager
ubuntu
user cause i don't know what the user's
called
like who's the default user
okay so
aws ubuntu
default user
it says okay so for amazon linux 2 it's
ec2 user and it's ubuntu because we need
to be the right user when we do this it
always logs us as the ssm1 which is
silly we'll type in sudo su hyphen and
then we'll type ubuntu and we become the
user that we want to be there we go
we'll type in clear notice that this is
a lot more limited and you'll just have
to live with it it's not a big deal and
so what we'll want to do is go install
micro k8s
and hopefully we don't run into any
serious problems but we'll go here
and hit
paste
we'll try again copy
and then paste there we go hit
enter and that will install it
close that off there
and we'll wait a little bit of time here
shouldn't take too long to install
actually while it's going let's go take
a look at link rd
so
i mean there's istio there's linker d um
we're doing liquor d just because that's
what i do the lab with uh we could have
done istio but
it's just what it is so linker d is a
service mesh it gives you all this cool
functionality on top of it and it makes
it really clear once you start to see
the dashboard so if we type in like
linker d
linker d uh viz here
i'm just trying to show you what it
looks like here if i can find a
screenshot
maybe type dashboard
the idea is once we get it running we're
going to get all this kind of rich
information
about our network and stuff like that
and that's really useful when you have a
lot of pods and you're just trying to
figure out what's going on like where
are requests coming from what's the
latency
all sorts of information that's within
prometheus
okay and then there's buoyant which we
might use here so let's go back here and
see if it's installed it is installed so
now we'll install cube ctl
and now we will see if our
micro ks is running so we'll say get
pods see if it works
that's okay we'll type in micro k8 in
the front of it
and we'll run these lines as per usual
as it likes
so it's a bit tricky here so you might
have to right click
go paste
and then we'll grab this here
if the font is too small i'll try to
bump it up here
there we go
and we'll go back here and now we'll
type micro k8
um config or actually we'll type in cube
ctl first
get pods we don't expect to find
anything good
and then from here we'll type in config
lesson arrow
tilde
and then
cube config
we'll put pseudo in front of that
oh it's really not liking today
permission denied okay well what if we
get the contents of that file
because that's all we need really um
cube ctl get pods
no
because all that's doing is it's
probably piping this information into
here
so maybe we can just copy the contents
like this
and i'm going to type in vi
tilde cube
config
it's in vi so by every key matter so hit
i to go to insert mode
right click
paste
okay and just make sure it's not cut off
at the top i hit escape to go back to
visual mode notice when i hit i it goes
to insert mode i hit escape i'm out of
here so now what i want to do is type in
colon wq
exit type clear then we'll type cube ctl
um get pods
okay so now cube ctl is working as
expected so now we'll go and type in
micro k8
dns
and then linker d
linker d
and we'll have to type enable in the
front there
so that's going to go install a bunch of
stuff it's going to create its own name
spaces and stuff so you can see it's
creating service count config maps
deployments all sorts of fun stuff while
it's going let's go look up
linker d
tutorial here
getting started
i'm just going to see if this is the
thing that i use to go through it yeah
generally i think so we'll have to do
link or do check here
okay
we'll go back over here
the only uh unfortunate part is that we
don't have multiple tabs right so
uh when we're running things here it's
going to be a little bit hard hopefully
we don't need to have more than one tab
for this to work
i'll see you back here when this stops i
don't know this is just going to happen
for a very long time or if it will
finish after a while but i'll see you
back here if and when this is done okay
all right welcome back so it did it did
finish installing it installed a lot of
stuff like tons and tons of stuff let's
just take a look at what we have um so
we'll type in cube ctl get pods hyphen a
and you can see that we have a linker d
name space
a linker d vis namespace
identity destination proxy injector
grafana prometheus web all this sorts of
stuff um just to understand the
architecture better we'll type in linker
d
architecture i don't know if it's going
to help much but we'll take a look at it
anyway because they have this
architectural diagram so the idea is
that it created a control plane and a
data plane right so and these are
um well i guess this is your usual stuff
right this is your stuff but it created
its own control plane uh in the linker d
name space and here it has an identity a
destination proxy stuff like that but
what we'll need to do is we will need to
run a program and then inject
um
the sidecar into the pod so that
link rd can monitor it and we could be
using our deployment yaml file with our
sinatra app but because we're in this
very constrained environment we'll just
use the one that they have okay so they
have one here for uh emoji voto and so
we'll go ahead and copy this one and so
it looks like
they have their own yaml file so we'll
go ahead here
back to sessions manager and we will go
and paste this in below
and hit enter
and it looks like we have an app
deployed
so then we will go back over to here
and then it says oh we have port forward
so we can do some port forwarding here
to
this
unable to board for it because it's not
running so i guess we're waiting for the
pods to
run so we'll go back here to pods
maybe to deploy maybe it's still
deploying
did this deploy in a particular
namespace i'm just going to double check
yeah it does have its own namespace
so we'll go here and then say
n
emoji
photo
and they're ready now so we'll go back
here and we'll do some port forwarding
okay so that's on port 8080 um
oh sorry so
um
yeah i think it's forwarding to 8080
which is totally fine i don't know if we
need to yeah it's going from 127 0 to 0
0.0 like anywhere do we need port
forwarding i guess we do
double check here what did it create
because we don't have an ingress
controller so it must be internal
it's probably not exposed anyway so
we'll go back to our instances and from
here we need to find our ip address
everything's kind of big because i
expanded it for
this page here it's just going to keep
bumping down like that
we'll go in here we'll grab our public
ip address
and we'll paste this in here and it
shouldn't work because we need to open
up that security group so we'll go here
to our security groups
and we'll go to security groups again
and we'll edit the inbound rules and we
will open up port 8080 so we'll say all
tcp
custom actually not all tcp yeah we'll
do it for us because i don't care i
don't want to have to open all the
individual ports let's say andrew's
computer
that's our ip address so no one else can
see it
and now when we go here to port 8080
we should see there app
give it a moment here i think it's just
loading i think it is working
if it's not we'll do http colon slash
sometimes the protocol matters
says it should work
my thought is that it's not binding to
uh the address a it's on localhost
and i'm gonna bump this up here
so we have port forwarding
here
but it's not creating a proxy per se
um i'm going to look at how we did this
earlier because we obviously did it
earlier in our like mini cube and cube
ctl stuff i just don't remember
how we did it so just give me a moment
here
you know what yeah we need to bind on
the address
so it's address and then we'll say
0.0.0.0
okay and then we'll go back here hit
enter
cool we can vote for emojis um
i always use upside down
and it isn't an option so i guess that's
how it is
we'll do the leaderboard cool that's a
nice little app they have there
all right
so our app is running
and we will go back over to linker d
and uh if you click around you might
notice that it's a bit broken for
example if you try to vote for donut
you'll get a 404.
sure let's give it a go
where's the donut let's try taco
that's fine
vote on your favorite donut ah 404 okay
so we got a 404 there
these errors are intentional so we can
identify the problem so with emoji
installed running we need to add a mesh
to it
so we are basically injecting it so it
says cube ctl get emoji deploy
it's going to then do link or d inject
and so liquid d inject is going to
inject that data into there so this is
what's going to install it
like the sidecar so that we can track it
okay so we'll go back here i'm going to
kill this
we'll paste that oops we'll paste that
in there hit enter
uh command not found linker d
i think it's because we all have to do
micro k it's like this micro k8s
hit enter
there we go so now it's been injected so
technically linker d should be tracking
it
um it explains it that's totally fine
and so then congratulations you now add
link or d just as the control plane is
possible to verify everything is working
the way it should check your data plane
with linker d
proxy check so we'll copy that line
we'll go back here paste it on in hit
enter
we'll have to do micro k8 in front of it
we're getting a bunch of check boxes so
i'm assuming yeah we're waiting for the
data plan to be good it says everything
is a-okay so
it looks like it's been installed
properly
i'm kind of curious if we take a look at
we say um the pod so we say cube ctl get
pods and
what's the thing called emoji vote
we'll do cube ctl
get
uh ns
it's actually emoji
photo
and then i just want to take a look at
the app because all these have been
injected right so i'm just curious if
we'd see anything in the describe i
don't think we will but
just for
sanity i'm just going to check okay
describe pod
paste the pod name in here
pods
well the pod is right there so i'm not
sure what it's talking about
did i make a mistake emoji no it looks
right
all right well whatever oh you know what
it's because we need the namespace
emojivodo
there we go
um i'm just trying to see if like we can
see anything because the idea with like
link or d is
that it's it shouldn't touch the code or
anything here but we are seeing stuff in
here so we can see things like linker d
proxy
so there's some volumes that are mounted
to our thing
and then there's a bunch of this stuff
so look at the proxy so yeah i guess you
can see stuff so i just wanted to see if
that was the case
we'll go back over to here
and we'll explore linker d so we want to
install a viz and so visit is an
extension that allows us to see metrics
so we'll go here and install that
all linker d install is doing if you do
vis install what it will do is output
i'll just run it without the other one
just so you can see what it does
so we'll paste that in there paste
micro k8 and all it's going to do is
print out
code so this is actually what it's going
to run so when you see it piping here
it's actually going to do an apply
by taking that content so go back here
paste the full line in here and run it
we have to put micro case s in the front
here every single time
and so now it is installed vis metrics
and then down below here it says to
install buoyant and so we don't have to
install buoyant right away because that
is a third-party cloud services this is
them being tricky to try to get you to
sign up for um services so buoyant is a
cloud provider that
um tracks a bunch of stuff and it's
optional and i might uh do it in this
tutorial here but i just
like the fact that they did that without
telling us what was going on here but
now that we have that running we want to
be able to see
the dashboard so i'm just looking up how
do we do that
to actually visualize
that dashboard here i'm just looking at
my instructions when i was going through
it
[Music]
um we type in
micro k8s
linker d
viz dashboard
okay and so now we have the dashboard
running on port 50750
it's not bound to address
0.0.0.0 so i don't know how that's going
to work but we'll give it a go anyway
and that's where i ran into an issue
where i needed an ingress controller so
that we could actually see it
um i'm just trying to find where we are
so if we do this
notice that it's not resolving right so
the problem is is that we are running
the dashboard
but
the dashboard needs to be um exposed
somehow
and so i think the way i did it
um
was setting up an ingress so we'll type
in expose
this dashboard linker d
this is the part that i'm saying that i
wasn't sure if i'd be able to show you
because i literally didn't test this in
the ec2 i just said hey let's do this
tutorial okay and so here they're saying
like instead of using link or dvis
dashboard every time you'd like to see
the dashboard make an ingress controller
but we need one because we need to run
it on port 80 for it to work because i
googled as well like other stuff and it
says like if you expose it on an ingress
controller it's not port 80 it will mess
up
i couldn't you can't send an ingress
controller anything besides http https
which is 18443 and that's where we ran
into issue
so down below here it says engine x
that's what we were using before so we
probably should just use it
and um
i guess what we'll do
is we'll do what we did before which is
uh enable
um the index controller from our ingress
tutorial so we're going to leverage that
knowledge i'm just trying to find where
we are here so i'm going to type in
micro k8 status
and we are going to need ingress so
we'll go up here and type in
uh micro qris
ingress
notice that like traffic ingress
controller i don't know how to use that
one and i only know how to use the
nginx one so i don't want to learn
something new right now so we'll go back
up here and type in
enable
and while that's going on i'm going to
go take a look
at our ingress tutorial to try to get a
refresher here on how do we set this
stuff up
so
yeah we install ingress
oh it already does nginx so it is
installing nginx and so i guess all we
need to do is now create an ingress
yaml file
so
what we'll do here is
it's kind of a pain
to
write it out so what i'm going to do is
go over here back to our cloud9
environment because we should still have
that file in our micro ks environment
i'm just going to go
ctrl 0 to go back to normal size here
and we'll launch this here and we'll go
grab that and then tweak it just so that
it's a bit easier
and so
[Music]
i mean we probably could use the one
that they have here but i just don't
know about it
i guess we could try it also needs a
password so that authenticates it passes
it to basic off
um it's also using secret i don't think
we need to enable that
i don't think we need our rbac
this says it's on port 8084
dashboard i think this is fine so what
we'll do is we'll go ahead and copy the
contents here i know we're launching
this but if
we'll try to yeah give this a go first
so
um i'm just double checking here the
host does the hostname matter this
exposes the dashboard dashboard
example.com
and protects it with basic auth
hmm
i don't know if we need to have a host
name so we'll just say
cubectl or sorry um
linkerd
expose
dashboard stack overflow because i feel
like we might see an example that's not
using that
because this person probably wanted to
do a particular port and see they're
using the same code here notice that
they took out hostname because we don't
want to have that hostname
and it says it's never going to be a
path like that it needs to serve on the
root of the url so change the route here
and so that's what i remember i was
reading here
this is correct i've only added using
the rewrite target there
so
looking at this one here i'm going to go
copy this content we're going to go over
to our micro case environment i'm just
going to make a new one here new file
called
linker d
um
ingress
yaml
this doesn't work it's totally fine but
i just want to try if we can
and so i'm just going to see what they
did we can put anything we want in here
i think that's what it'll take
and so i don't see the annotation on
this oh i guess this is the secret so
it'd be down below here oh yeah so
engine x
we've got a bunch of headers here this
is this looks fine i guess
8084 that's totally fine so i think what
it's saying is you can't do this you
can't have link or d on that so i'm
going to delete that out of there
and then i'm going to go ahead and copy
all this here
i'm going to right click copy
go back to our environment here i'm
going to bump up the font i'm just doing
control plus to do that
and
i'm going to touch a new file called
ingress.yaml
and i'm going to do vi ingress.yaml
and this is vim so remember every key
matters so hit i
and then right click paste
and then just uh hit escape
and then what i'm doing is i'm hitting
um
k on my keyboard k goes up so hit k all
the way up i'm making sure nothing's cut
off and then hit j all the way down jj
jjj
and that looks fine so i'll do colon
wq write and quit
and so i have this ingress file and so
i'm going to try and deploy this so
we'll say cube ctl
apply
hyphen f ingress yemel
and it says
no matches for kind ingress in version
beta 1. so i'm going to hit up again
we'll hit vi ingress yaml and then we'll
hit k to go all the way up
down we're hit j to go down okay
i'm trying to get this beta so if i hit
h and l h moves me left l moves me right
i'm sorry for all the vim stuff
and so what i want you to do is move
over to the v using the l button and
then hit c for change
and then w for word
and now it's in insert mode okay so now
the keyboard acts like a normal keyboard
and we're going to type v1
okay because that code is just old and
hit escape
and then colon wq
all right and then we'll hit up again
and then we'll try to apply the ingest
controller
so it says no match ingress type so i'll
go over
oh you know it's even more wrong than i
think it is we go head up here again
sorry for revise so we'll hit h
to go to the left all the way to
extensions and hit cw when you're on the
e c for change w for the word
notice that it's an insert mode so now
we're typing normally and it's actually
networking
dot k8s
dot io
and then hit escape
and then colon wq
hit up we'll try to apply it again
oh it just doesn't want to work okay so
error validating ingress yaml
um
validation unknown field service port in
io k-8s
api networking if you choose to ignore
these errors
turn validation off
i think the reason why is the syntax
change as well so hit up again i'm so
sorry for this
and then hit j to go down
down down down and this syntax has
changed so instead of it being service
name back end like this it's actually if
you go over here to the colon or sorry
go to this line here and hit
or actually go to the sign here to sorry
the back end here colon and hit o
okay it inserts mode goes the next line
and then hit escape
and then hit i
and then hit tab to indent and then tab
again
it's not indenting right so i'll hit i
and i'll just backspace till we're in
the right space
and we'll type in service
colon
escape
we'll hit j to go down
d d
d d okay and then hit enter
or sorry o sorry uh i okay
indent
i know this is a big old mess name you
know what i'm going to make it easy for
you i'm just going to hit colon wq quit
here i'm going to remove this ingress
file we're going to just make a new one
we'll just do it over here because i
don't mean to give you all this vim
nonsense
and i'm just trying to get back to
normal size i gotta go back to this tab
here ctrl o you can't do it over here
and so the problem here is this is just
all old so this should be
we'll open up our other one as a
comparison here
you can tell how tired i am because this
is so darn complicated we'll go copy
again if you just want to watch you can
just watch me do this
all it's important is that you see how
it works so the back end here should be
service
and this should be port
okay and so we'll copy the contents
there
go back over to our virtual machine i'm
going to bump up the font because it's
too darn small
it's not letting me bump it up here we
go oh hit plus that's why
and i went too large now okay there we
go
and so we'll take touch ingress
yaml vi ingress yaml i to go insert mode
right click paste so we don't have any
mistakes hit escape pro colon wq right
to quit and then we will hit up to try
to run this again and hopefully we have
all the right syntax we still have a
darn error okay so
um unknown field port for ingress back
end oh i made a mistake
remove ingress yaml
we'll go back over here we'll
return to normal size i got to go off to
another screen because i can't do
control zero there go to the bottom here
and what i forgot to do was
do number
this is on space is four we need this on
spaces two
this should be number like this indent
and that is the right syntax so we'll go
ahead copy this again
touch ingress yaml
we have to spell that correctly i'll
bump up the font so you can see what i'm
doing
and we will do vi ingress again we'll
hit i to go insert mode right click
paste
hit escape
colon wq right quit
hit up
okay it looks a bit better so error
validating ingress validation data
unknown field port for in-gas back-end
what are they talking about it
definitely is a thing
so go back over here
and we'll just take a look at this
back end service port port definitely
exists
for sure i know that it definitely
is there something else that i'm doing
that's wrong here i'm just going to keep
looking
it looks right to me
i'm just reading it here
invalid type got string expected map oh
i know what it is
if it's a map
it's expecting
well it's kind of confusing i mean i
guess you could do this
because that would be a map right
hmm
let's just see what we do ingress
kubernetes
just see if we can see an example there
uh no we are doing it correctly
everything looks fine
i'll be back in a moment here and i'll
come back with the answer okay
all right so it looks like we've hit a
dead end so i tried launching linker d
in the background and doing port
forwarding so by that i mean like i did
an ampersand on the end here and so now
it's running in the background i don't
know how to shut it off and i could run
on another port and i tried also an
address so i ran on an address and you
can do that but then it said hey you
have to do dns binding
and it's just like almost impossible so
i think for the scope of this
we don't really need to do more i could
show you buoyant but i just don't care
about buoyant cloud i'm not here to try
to sell a third-party provider but let's
just take a look at linker d linker d um
viz
dashboard and just so we can kind of
maybe see what it's supposed to do
but holy smokes it is super hard to get
that set up and it's just because
you know we don't have in the community
that content that's just like available
to copy paste in there i'd have to spend
hours to figure that out or stuff like
that but anyway for the kcna totally out
of scope but i just wanted to show you
that like the idea is if we if we were
there we would see our grafana dashboard
that's powered by prometheus and we get
all these fun cool graphs okay so you
know hopefully we'll have an opportunity
to look at prometheus if i figure it out
um
if we attempt the managed service it
might be a bit easier but uh yeah that
is linker d at least service mesh how
you set up with micro k8s
with the exception of not being able to
solve that last part there but again not
super important for the kcna just going
through the motions to see the
components okay also i guess we should
shut down that environment so you're not
spending money so go over to ec2 and
this one's a bit easier we're just going
to terminate that one so we'll go over
there
and we'll look for our micro 8k8 linker
d and we will um terminate that okay
so there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along i'm going to
show you how to set up uh kubernetes on
a managed service like google cloud
platform we're actually going to look at
a bunch of them gcp
aws azure sivo digitalocean
just so you get an idea of what it's
like actually setting these up for
production um you know they're not going
to exactly be on the exam because the
exam is more focused on kubernetes cloud
data itself so you should know about
managed services but i'm going through
this with you because in practicality
this is where you'd actually deploy
kubernetes and if you get to see what
it's like on all the different providers
even if you can't do what i'm doing and
just watch through it you can understand
the differences between the offerings
how easy it is to do it but
measuring my frustration level as i work
through it
and just kind of get a bit of a
difference so we're starting with gcp
because it's the easiest um and you know
i just want to start off with something
really nice and light so what we'll do
here is make sure you have a google
cloud account i'm not going to show you
how to do that but uh once you do have
your account and your your full access
account there i'm going to go ahead and
create a new project you can see i was
doing one earlier here and it did not
delete but we'll say new project and
i'll say gke example 2
and i'm going to go ahead and go and hit
create so that's going to create our
project
and then
they usually create pretty darn quick
notice it's still going there so we
might have to wait a little bit
there it is it's ready we'll click over
to our gke example too
and from here at the top we'll type in
gke now if we don't want to do that we
could also go on the left-hand side here
if you click that button and go down
below and go to kubernetes engine but
i'm going to type in gke and google
makes it super super super super easy to
run kubernetes which is no surprise
because they originally created
kubernetes and then gave it to the cncf
right so if they didn't have the easiest
platform i would be uh surprised i'll go
ahead and enable that and while it's
going let's look up gke prices
because it's actually pretty in line
with aws now i used to say that gke had
a free control plane but looks like they
don't anymore the control plane
is 10 per hour regardless of its
autopilot mode or standard mode so
you're always paying for that control
plane all right
difference between autopilot mode and
standard mode well standard mode is just
like how aws runs with ec2 instances
it's just running on virtual machines um
and then autopilot mode is running on uh
uh cloud run so cloud run is like a bus
fargate it's just a way of running
serverless containers so this one you
pay for what you use this one you pay
for the underlying uh virtual machines
that you spin up same thing
um there are some nice things about
google cloud where they have a service
called antho so anthos is a way of
google cloud anthos
is a way of
having a gke cluster but you can
actually have um
nodes
running on different environments like
aws
on your environment stuff like that and
manage it from essentially location so
there's an additional cost for that i
don't really know the use case for this
because i just
can't really think about it but um one
nice thing about anthos is that it has
anthous migrate so you go migrate um
to gke for some reason like if you want
to do it's always under that and what it
can do is it can actually import a
virtual machine from anywhere like aws
and it will turn it into a container and
then run it on gke so it's like this
really easy way to get your
containers or your applications into
containers
like it will generate out a docker file
so i'm just drinking water here but
the advantage there is that if you had a
vm and you use that tool then you get
the docker file you wouldn't have to
write it yourself so that's kind of one
advantage that i like about that
but anyway we're over here we typed in
gke we're on our cluster and so we have
an option with quick start which is not
bad but i'm going to just do it the
old-fashioned way create we have two
options standard autopilot standard is
where you manage the nodes so
virtual machines underneath this is
using google or run cloud underneath
right serverless containers so we'll
choose gke standard
and we'll need to name our cluster so
i'll say gke example
and it has to be lowercase of course
zonal or regional we just don't want to
render a zone we'll let it choose
whatever zone it wants uh for the
control plane we'll have it release
channel
we don't care about stack version we'll
let it stay up to date
and we'll go next and hit
create
now there was a bunch of other options
but i didn't click them
and maybe i'll go back there i don't
even know if i ever looked at them when
i went there oh standard mode
configure here
default pool
yeah so i never even looked at this so
it's going to launch up three nodes we
really don't need three nodes we could
have made it two
which is too late now if you're watching
this maybe before you launch this maybe
you might want to make it two because
it's more like think about every node
that you run is going to cost money
right so we don't want these running too
long here it's using e2 e2 medium notice
like when i launched up my um uh
cloud9 environment i chose
four gigabytes of memory because that's
what i find it at like they say you can
run it on to run it on a less but i
would never run it on less than four
gigabytes the the nodes
100 gigabytes so you know i run it at 40
but like this is kind of more for a
production use case i'm going to go here
to security that looks fine metadata
that looks fine
automation options networking options
i'm just seeing if there's anything
interesting here
yeah the only thing i would have done is
i probably would have made it two nodes
okay or even one like i only need one
additional node there but we're running
three nodes which is fine
uh for you i i'd probably reduce it just
to save money but for me it's fine
because we're not going to keep this up
for long and so we are just waiting for
this to provision and so it says it
takes about five minutes it is like the
fastest set provisioning i know that
like
digitalocean says there's four minutes
but honestly gke
or uh like provisions clusters so darn
fast it's really awesome but i'll see
you back here in a moment when it's done
it's at 67
i'll see you then okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are back with gke and so uh again
i'm telling you this this one's the
easiest one to use all we got to do is
click connect at the top and what it's
going to do is show the command line
that we use with gcloud in order to
authenticate to the cluster
uh and then cube ctl will work but it's
even easier that we just hit run in
cloud shell it's going to launch cloud
shell it's going to establish that
connection and then we can do cube ctl
right away
and as this is working i'm just going to
maximize this window so we can see what
we're doing
and notice that it has a line here so
now we just have to hit enter
and then we'll say authorize
you're gonna be so disappointed when we
see uh the azure's uh cloud shell
because it's so painful and so if we
type in cue whoops
if we type in i was just typing there i
don't i don't know why i did that but if
we type in cube ctl get pods
give it a moment here to think so there
it is connecting if we do hyphen a we
can kind of see all the interesting
things that it has here so fluent bit
gke metrics connectivity agent dns
all this fun kind of stuff metric server
and so now what i want to do is just
deploy something so let's say cube ctl
um create deploy engine x image
equals nginx because i just want to
expose something so that we can see
something
um and i think we need a double hyphen
notice like when you're doing this when
i'm typing it's a bit delayed it might
be delayed for you because it is a
remote shell okay so it's created that
now now what's interesting here is if we
go
to i don't know why it's on our gka
thing but we'll go back to our engine
maybe because i expanded it
we can actually see
our cluster if we go to workloads
we can see it in here
okay we can click into here
we can see
stats and stuff it's all hooked up and
given us rich information go back to
workloads even notice like we can hit
deploy here
and specify information so i i didn't
have to do through here i could just
went here and said new container image
and just specify the repository and
stuff like that
so it does really add
a very nice additional layer if like
you're really not great at the scripting
here this makes things so much easier
and uh not not for everything though
like
and by the way we can go here we can
edit these live too so we want to edit
this server or like this sorry this
resource it'll pull up the ammo we can
edit it in line here which is really
nice but if we go over to the service or
service ingress
we can't create a service we can create
ingress if we already have a service
created so not everything is great in
google cloud world but it's still
extremely good
and one of the best okay so i'm going to
do
cube ctl expose
because we want to have a service so
that we can connect to ingress so that
we can
see what we built here so we're doing
engine x port equals port 80
okay hyphen hyphen
target port equals 80.
and then we want to type
equals node port because it has to be
either load balancer or node port
forward to work you can't use cluster ip
in order to hook up the ingress to get a
load balancer with kubernetes we'll go
ahead and hit enter that is now exposed
we can go up to our
services here
and then we can see the services there
and now if we want to add ingress
we can just checkbox it here and say
create ingress
and what it's going to do is set up an
external load bouncer at a google cloud
load balancer so that is fine
we'll go down here and choose nginx we
can't change either of these right there
that's fine http protocol is fine we can
preview
the ingress here so this is what it's
going to do very simple
right so nothing complicated we'll go
ahead and create i remember how painful
it was when we were doing ingress like
what we were doing with uh service mesh
right so it's so nice that this is super
easy to do because that is the honestly
the the biggest pain
for this stuff is um let me do k8
ingress i don't know if that's gonna be
the name of the ingress
oh it is okay
um because that is usually the largest
pain is just doing a deal with ingress
and so
google knows that and so they make it
super easy
so now what it's going to do
is it's going to spin up
a um
a load balancer
right so it's creating ingress and it
says external hp lb
and this does take quite a bit of time
so i'll see you back here in a bit okay
all right so we are back it wasn't a
long wait but just know that you should
hit the refresh button because i was
sitting here it just looked like it
wasn't done but it was done for a long
time but i was fine because i was doing
another follow along but if you're
sitting here don't sit here for 100
years hit the refresh button make sure
that it is done or not done so it is
done and
what it's done is it's actually set up a
load balancer for us in this case so no
if you scroll on down below it says load
balancing resources we can click through
those and you can see it actually set up
a load balancer
right here it is we have an ip address
we have um probably a like a dns record
something somewhere here but we have
load balancer we click back here we can
see it made a load bouncer for us
all right so now
if we want to access this i'm just
trying to remember how or i'll just look
up my instructions that i wrote
um
i didn't write write it down but you
know what we'll just type in cube ctl
um
because it's an ingress controller so we
type in get ingress
and there's its ip address it probably
is the same
yeah it's the same one as here
and so if i copy this
whoops
if i copy this
and we go new tab here and we paste it
in
ta-da our nginx page works okay one
other thing i want to show you is that
it has a code editor if you hit open
editor we didn't have a need for it but
if we did need to use one
just to give it a second to launch
the reason i'm showing it to you here is
because
it is really really awesome it's
basically
all visual studio code we could have
technically done
instead of using aws cloud9 we could
have technically used this uh but the
only thing is that it only has a single
context at least i don't know how to
change the context uh and so the reason
i went with cloud9 is because you can
spin up multiple virtual machines and
stuff like that and cloud shell is more
like tied to a single uh virtual machine
i don't know how to flip between them
okay
um but it is it's fine it runs really
fast and google cloud is very easy to
use but i was more comfortable with
cloud9 that's why i used it but i just
wanted to show it to you because when we
go to use
azure i just want to compare it to how
awful
their shell is like as their code editor
and it makes no sense because they make
visual studio code and it's terrible but
anyway we've accomplished our goal here
and so in order to get rid of all this
stuff uh what we're going to do is go
ahead and delete our cluster so i'll go
ahead here and i'm going to go and
delete our cluster
and now it did create a load bouncer so
i'm really hoping that it tears down the
load balancer with it
um
right so we go to load balancers
i don't want to kind of delete it and
cause an issue here oh it did vanish
right away so i guess it does tear it
down right away uh and if you really
really want to make sure that everything
is gone
we can go ahead and delete the project
or like the yeah the project that we
create so we go to manage resources and
then you'll see gk2 example we'll go
here hit delete and we'll put the name
in
and it will shut down so no we're not
getting billed for anything in that
project anymore uh it will be scheduled
for delete for march 18th but we don't
have to worry about it anymore okay
so we are done google cloud we'll move
over to azure then we'll do the really
hard one at us and then we'll do some
bonus ones okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this follow along i'm going to show
you how to provision um
a kubernetes cluster on microsoft azure
or azure i like to say azure it's more
fun to say
and so
their service is called aks or
kubernetes service azure kubernetes
service and you might have to enable
this somewhere in there that's not what
i'm going to show you it looks like they
got some free training which is kind of
cool um but i just know the way that i
know how to do it so what we'll do is
type in kubernetes at the top we're
going to go to kubernetes service notice
that they have something called azure
arc remember how we talked about anthos
well
azure arc is like azure's um multi-cloud
service where you can manage uh nodes on
other providers and on-premise in one
place so kind of a competing service but
works a bit different and so we'll do is
create a new cluster
and from here we will have our
subscription and we'll create a new
resource group because it'll make it
really easy to clean this up afterwards
so we'll just say
um
example so we know what to do there
everything's gonna be put in there and
the nice thing is they have some options
so we are doing this for devtest so we
want this to be nice and cheap i'm gonna
say aks
example here hopefully it lets me name
it that way yes it's fine the region's
fine i don't care about availability
zones the version is fine the one thing
about like different
providers is that they might have
different versions available and some
might be more progressive than others i
would imagine i would imagine that
google is the best at keeping that up to
date and the only difference between
like some of these tiers
is like the availability so we we want
less availability
because we just don't care
for it because for dev and test
down below notice it's giving us uh
standard b4s 16 gigabytes that's quite a
bit
that is insane but that's what they're
recommending i'm not going to leave that
up for long i guess we could change it
i'm going to leave it alone i just don't
want it to break okay
so because i i ran it on this um but to
be honest it's kind of expensive i'm
going to go with one node because i
don't want a bunch of them because i
don't know how expensive this thing is
and at 16 gigabytes of memory that could
be kind of expensive maybe look up the
cost of this
standard
price
usually they show you in the menu eh
so
if we go here to pricing
oh i don't know i'm not going to worry
about it but you know
it's
yeah sometimes it'll tell you right here
if you open this up they'll tell you the
cost 150 55 a month
again we're not running this for long so
you know
uh i guess we could try i just don't
want to break we'll go with b2s okay
i just don't know if that's what's going
to be on for the cluster right but i
would imagine that's all the nodes for
production workloads at least three
nodes are recommended but we only want
one so we'll say next
and it's going to run the system on a b2
yeah that should be fine everything will
be fine
i just don't know if it's using like
windows servers underneath because if
it's using windows servers
those always need a lot of memory
okay so enable virtual nodes um
nope we don't need that enable skill
sets sure we can
have that left on we have authentication
it's going to have system assigned
managed identity that's just how it
integrates with
azure
role-based access controls we'll have it
enabled
could we do azure active directory sure
but i'm not going to turn that on we
have the option between cubenet and
azure cni if you choose that you have a
lot more options but we're going to
stick with cube cube cni and we can't
use azure option unless we're using
azure cni uh notice we can use uh calico
but we're not doing any network policies
so it does not matter here today
um
we probably want routing but we're not
going to do it that way
uh we don't care about container
registry right now we don't care about
azure policies uh we don't need to worry
about encrypting the secret service kind
of similar to kms so azure key vault
would be the way to
secure your secrets in a more secure way
and we'll go ahead and review and create
and so this will take a bit of time it
takes
longer than google cloud but way faster
than aws okay so we'll go ahead and
create this
and we'll wait a while and i'll see you
back here in a bit i'm just waiting for
the next screen to make sure that it is
working correctly
there we go and so we'll wait till this
is done okay so see you then
all right so we are back uh didn't have
to wait super long i don't know if it
tells us the time here but um
again not super long to wait maybe
10 minutes
i'm not sure but down below it says
connect to cluster and that's the first
thing we want to do so let's click that
and we get a bunch of instructions so
that's kind of nice and so here it says
open cloud shell and run these two
commands so if we press this here it
actually runs the first two for us which
is nice
and from the google cloud one you
remember we had a shell so azure has a
shell it's not as nice okay
um it does have a code editor but like i
don't know if we showed the google cloud
run code editor i'll probably show it
now because i'm actually jumping between
all of them right now even though for
you it doesn't seem that way
but it has a code editor and it is a
terrible code editor
just awful and it's weird because like
microsoft makes visual studio code and
you think that they would do a much
better job here for it but notice that
it ran
these two commands here so it ran them
for us so we're in there and so now all
we have to do is kind of run the stuff
kind of here uh but looking through here
this stuff isn't very particularly
useful
um so i'm just trying to think here what
did i do i'm gonna go look at my
instructions
because i think they had a sample app
and that's what i ended up using is
there uh the app that they provide there
yeah so i looked up i think what i did
is i looked up ingress because it was
getting pretty confusing how to do it
because when i went over to
uh micro microsoft here and by the way
let's just test cube ctl to see if it's
working sorry for the small font i don't
know if there's much i can do about that
not really
font size
large
little
cube get pods so we'll say get pods
here right and we'll do hyphen a
and we'll just expand this so we can at
least see what's going on here
okay and so a lot less is running here
than what we see for a google cloud but
you see core dns
csi as your disk so it's that's how the
disk is being persisted with percent
volumes mesh your server tunnel front
okay so what we'll do
is minimize this for a second
uh is it still here is this it
uh
what'd you do asher
azure's interface is so janky uh but oh
yeah we just can click it again we can
reopen it i just wanted to make sure we
could find it so here
uh is
our kubernetes cluster so like they're
very good about showing us the latest
stuff so we go there you can see it
click into it
and um
it's similar to google cloud so we can
see namespaces we can add namespaces we
actually see a little bit more
information so we see workloads these
are all the system ones i don't remember
in google cloud is them really showing
us those at least they filter them out
so we have deployments pods replica sets
staple sets daemons uh json cron jobs
and you can add stuff but it's not
as nice so you go add with yaml
right it's not like a nice big old
interface so there is like with quick
start applications but these are
like applications so you would choose
deploy an application voters sample
applications yeah so that's the sample
app that you can deploy so like we could
deploy that but i'd rather just kind of
go through the steps ourselves so we
actually learn something and not just
press a bunch of buttons and have it do
it for us but notice like service
ingress it's not gonna be as nice as a
google cloud just period
uh then we've got our node pools and
stuff down below here but you can
integrate like git ops into it so i
whatever like github actions or whatever
azure uses but um what i want to do here
is bring back up our terminal here and
we are going to look up ingress
kubernetes
azure or azure um or aks
now the one thing about microsoft is
sometimes their services are clunky like
like they're either really good or
they're just
like there's nothing there but they're
always really good about being able to
copy paste and get things done via the
terminal so i know the first thing we
need to do is do a basic configuration
so we need to have
um
an ingus controller and so this one's
going to be the engine and nginx ingress
controller that we're going to use so
we're going to copy the contents of this
and we're going to go back over to here
we're going to go ahead and just paste
that on in
and it's going to use helm it's going to
install
the ingress controller like adabus has
their own but for whatever reason
kubernetes i'm using
nginx but you can configure whatever you
want so they have a more customized
complicated one which we're not going to
do
but once our ingress controller is
created
we are going to
then uh
build up these demos so
go back over here and it is running okay
great so now the next thing is we need
to get these two files because this is
the app they have they have
i guess we don't need both
um because when i ran it i just did both
because they said to do both
we'll do both because they might have
roots for both and i don't feel like
copying paste them out so what we'll do
is we'll need to create two files we'll
have to do touch app
uh app one yaml and we'll say touch
app to yaml and then here we'll type in
code app one yama to open up in the uh
the editor here uh and i have the code
here from prior so i'll what i'll do
here i'm just going to remove my old
ones
so that you can go through the pain that
i went through
getting these going here
okay and so just type clear here
we refresh that they're gone good this
this file's not actually here just
pretend that it's not here
uh so i'll do touch
app
one yemel
and we'll say code app one yaml here
okay it's empty right so then we'll go
over here we will copy the contents
paste it on in
did i get it yeah okay right click paste
or space control v
i can't right click paste but i can go
control v
whatever and uh we'll go the top right
corner save
code
app to yaml
okay
down here copy
control v
this is what i'm talking about their
editor is terrible makes no sense and
then we'll say uh code routes.yaml
because we need to set up um
is it ingress yeah it's ingress
and they have a pretty complex routing
for us so we'll copy that
and we will control v
and save it
and uh so now we have our three now i
won't get this code editor out of the
way if it'll let me
this is the best i can do and we'll need
to run these now here's the thing
they say
to run these like this but i'll show you
what happens
makes no sense what happens here so i'm
just going to paste that on in
notice i have to right click paste there
and i can't control v there it just
makes no sense
uh so if i do app one it does
it goes cannot find the file and i i
don't know why because if you go ls
it's right there so what i did is for
when we were doing our service mesh we
learned that there was a way to pipe the
contents of a file uh there and so i
tried that and that works so instead of
doing that we do cat
app one yellow i'm just gonna show you
that dumpster dumps the content there
but we can make a pipe and then say cube
ctl apply hyphen f
uh and so the contents will be this
hyphen here
don't ask me how it works i just know
how it works ingress basic because this
is the name space that this this stuff
is all being provisioned too if you
noticed
i didn't point that out but
uh well we the uh the controller is in
there anyway so we hit uh enter here
that'll be one
i hit up i hit ctrl a and i move over to
two and that's two and then we do our
routes
can't always trust written tutorials you
have to learn
okay and so now we have
all that stuff set up
so now what i want to do is just see
our ingress here so cube ctl
get
actually we can do all for fun
uh get all
uh hyphen all we learned that in our
namespaces tutorial and do hyphen
ingress basic and just see what we have
here
[Music]
no oh maybe we don't need the hyphen
knife at all that's probably for
deleting yeah there we go okay so
here we can see a bunch of stuff we have
our pods our services our deployments
our replica sets but it's not showing us
ingress and that's actually what we want
to see so we'll go ing
and i think it's working usually what
i'm looking for is if it has an address
because if it has an address then
ingress is working right if there is no
address there then we have a problem and
i know because i spent so much time
doing this the wrong way and being like
where's the darn address so if you got
this wrong just shut everything down
start over because it's super hard to
debug
but if we copy this we should be able to
go up here just like paste it on in and
there it is okay another way we could
see this is if we um we're here
and we go to our workloads
and
nope sorry ingress
and you go over here and we can see the
ip address there
so normally when you set up something
it's going to have a load balancer but
for whatever reason
it doesn't with this one doesn't set up
a load bouncer so
i don't know why so
but that's fine like there is a load
bouncer but i just mean like a managed
load bouncer like we used
whatever there's a called application
gateway um the load bouncers in
kubernetes or sorry uh azure are a
little bit funny names like there's one
called like they call them gateways a
lot
like application gateway and stuff like
that don't call them load bouncers but
it doesn't set up one but we're all done
here we accomplished our goal so in
order to shut this down what i'm going
to do is go
look up resources because it's all a
resource group so it should be easy for
us to shut down we go to resource groups
and i called this one
okay it's example so we click into that
and there's our cluster and we're going
to go ahead and delete the resource
group and then we say k it's example
go ahead we hit delete and that's it and
just make sure that it deletes azure is
a bit buggy okay you really don't want
this running
uh and causing you money but i'm
shutting my down just make sure to
refresh double check um azure is
notorious for like being delayed in
terms of updating so just come back
after 30 minutes an hour just make sure
that resource group is gone hit the
refresh triple check just be sure okay
but that's it we finished um our
kubernetes cluster for azure hurrah
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this follow along we're going to
learn how to set up eks so that's
awesome elastic kubernetes service to
run a cluster and the goal is we just
want to run anything on and expose it so
we can see the app running in our
browser i'm going to tell you right now
eks is the hardest and takes the longest
to set up
it's not important for the exam for you
to pass but it really does cement
knowledge and give you a practical way
of using kubernetes in production use
cases and so um you know if you do get
stuck don't worry just watch and just
see what the process is to understand uh
the caveats to actually getting a
managed service up and it for me i can
do it because i really know aws inside
and out but like if somebody was new to
it it's super super painful what we'll
do is we'll go to the top here and type
in eks of course you'll need an aws
account and so we'll go over here and
the first thing we are going to do
when it goes here is we're going to add
a cluster we'll go and create ourselves
a cluster i'm going to call mine eks
example
all right and it lets us choose the
kubernetes version we're going to need a
cluster service role
um
i'm not sure select whatever let's just
let us make one i i remember my other
account i already had one so i must have
created one uh prior but i guess what
we'll need is we'll need that cluster
rolled so there's a couple ways we can
do it so
here it gives you the instructions to do
it or what we can do is use this cloth
formation template so i am going to use
this cloudformation template you think
they'd have a link just to launch it
prior to 2020 etc etc whatever okay so
what i'll do is i'll copy the contents
here
tell you aws does not make it easy uh
and we'll go to cloudformation
it's almost like they want you to use
their managed
container services
but we'll go over to cloudformation this
is an infrastructure as a service tool
for setting stuff up uh notice like our
cloud9 environments are over here so
that all got set up here we'll create a
new stack
and um
we want to provide the template so
template is ready i just
want to
i guess i'll have to save it so
what we'll need to do is open up any
kind of editor so i have a vs code on my
local computer
so i'm just going to go grab that
if it will open here there we go
it's opening off screen here i'll show
it to you in a moment
okay so i have i'm just saving the file
over here you can see i have a bunch of
other cool scripts there we're gonna go
save that to our desktop
okay i'm gonna go to my desktop here
i'm just not sure what's on my desktop
so that's why i'm just not
sharing it very clearly and i'm just
going to call this
application.yaml
okay just notice over here it says
application.yaml right
and i'm going to go ahead and save that
and so now what i'll do is go back to
cloudformation and i guess we'll just
upload the template
here on our desktop
there it is we'll say open
and we'll say next
cluster or eks cluster i am rule it's so
silly that it's like this i wish it was
a managed rule it looked like they're
saying that it was at one point just
create it
just make it for me here ada best please
acknowledge yeah yeah yeah yeah
all these warnings for a roll um
prior to 2020
had an entry with the service link role
the policy is no longer required
okay well anyway uh we'll let that
create there for a moment it should not
take much time at all because it's a
role those should be super super fast
and we'll just keep hitting refresh
still works and there it's created so if
we go to stack info we can see that it's
completed as well we'll go back over
here and we'll refresh
and there is our role so we'll scroll on
down notice we can encrypt
our um
we can use uh encrypt our secrets using
kms so that is adabus's key management
service so that's a great way to encrypt
your secrets then we have all these
subnets and um i already know that's
going to tell us to like pair this down
it's not going to like them all but
what we'll do is we'll scroll on past
there we can see we can choose ipv4 ipv6
i'm going to leave it ipv4 public public
private private we'll leave it public
there's some advanced settings we're not
going to touch that
notice that it's using vpn cni so amazon
has its own i guess plugin and it's
going to automatically install that for
us the uh for that then we can choose a
particular version uh for this so it'll
be whatever version there we'll have
core dns which is a version there we can
choose our cube proxy version we'll go
next this is nice we can actually get
all logging into cloudwatch logs but i
don't care about any of this so i'm just
going to say next
and then here we have our tags our
networking stuff like that i'm expecting
it will complain
okay we'll hit create because usually it
doesn't work because it will say
cannot create the cluster because
there's not a sufficient capacity to
support the cluster
so
it could be based on
a does not have enough resources or
that's probably what it is so what i do
is i just like take off the last three
and then i hope that it works
just double checking there and we'll go
next next
create
and there we go now here's the part
that's crazy this is going to take
at least 30 minutes to spin up all right
it takes the longest i have no idea why
but um i literally am doing this uh
and and i'm going to be doing other
follow alongs while i'm waiting for this
to spin up and so i'm gonna stop the
video here i'll be back in a moment but
just go take a break watch your favorite
episode of the show and also if you are
spitting this up we probably should talk
about cost so if we go uh aws eks
pricing
right because if you don't have a lot of
money you might not want to be doing
this but if you go to i already told you
this but it's going to be 10 cents per
hour just for the
control plane node so that's going to be
the one that controls all of our nodes
and then we spin up other ones there and
eks can actually run either on ec2 so
you can run ec2 instances so you just
spin up those nodes and they're always
running or it can use a fargate so
fargate is serverless containers meaning
that
you only pay for what you use so you
don't pay for servers running all the
time but that means that there will be
cold starts you can even deploy this on
outpost so outpost is like a a server
rack that can be put in
a data center and runs away specific
stuff so if you want to deploy there as
well you can do that but um that's all
we're talking about for that for now and
i'll see you back here in a bit all
right so after a really really really
really really really long wait the
longest wait you'll ever have to wait
for a cluster eks is ready uh just
beware hit that uh refresh because
sometimes it's ready it'll just not
update and you have to hit that button
once in a while okay
so
if you go here we have compute
we'll have to create some node groups we
have networking we have add-ons
authentication logging
it's a little bit more bare bones
they're not really giving you a whole
lot here we can see our workloads here
if we click into them but you don't get
the same kind of controls we saw in
azure kubernetes service and um google
cloud kubernetes service like
where we could launch things and stuff
like that
so really it is cli driven
again eks is the hardest to set up but
it is pretty powerful but not from like
an easy to use kind of uh perspective
but we are gonna need some uh nodes okay
so i'm gonna pull up my instructions uh
off screen here because it is super hard
super hard uh to set this stuff up okay
and so um the first thing i think we'll
need is we'll need to open up cloud
shell so i'm going to open up cloud
shell here at the top there
oh it goes a whole new page you think
like the other ones that they load in
place but nope not aws it launches in a
new one they were the they were the
third provider in the first tier
providers to get a cloud shell so no
surprise there i guess theirs is a bit
clunky that's fine
uh and it doesn't have like a code
editor built in but like you don't need
it because you got cloud9 so it's not a
big deal
so we'll pull up the elastic kubernetes
service again here just so we have it
on this tab over here and um we're gonna
have to really rely on a tutorial for
this so
um we'll just say cloud shell
eks because aws does not have good
instructions here
this person here
great instructions okay so i'm going to
go here and what i'll do is i'll just
first make a bin directory
waiting for that cloud shell environment
it's also the slowest to start
okay
and the font is like super small so
we'll go here and we'll just go a little
extra large
okay and we're in better shape so i'll
go ahead and paste those commands in
good so it's going to create a bin
directory for us
we're going to install cube ctl
okay
we're going to um
update config this this allows cubectl
to talk to our cluster
all right hit enter on this one
sometimes when you paste it in the last
command doesn't get executed you have to
hit enter so just be careful there the
name here i believe we call it eks
example
i'm just going to double check yeah it
is okay
and then we want to install
eks ctl so eksctl is the um
this databus is cli for eks and it's a
way of making a lot easier to uh way of
working with eks we could even
provisioned
our cluster this way but that's not how
i did it
okay
so what we'll do is copy this contents
here
paste it on in hit paste
enter
and we'll go back over here to our
instructions and helm because we will
need helm because that is what we will
need to install the um
the ingress controller so remember when
we were doing or
whatever it's called the controller yeah
when we were doing the uh azure one we
used helm to install i i went through
very quickly but we used helm to install
it and so it's gonna be the same for aws
so now that we have it we need to um
actually create a node and or nodes and
those are managed with node groups so
back in our cluster we'll go to
workloads or configuration i guess and
we'll go to compute
and we'll add a node group
and we'll say my
node group
and then what we'll need is an iron rule
so
it's a little bit silly because we have
to go to i'm console make our own now
and we also have to look up how to make
one
so we have the i am cluster node we
looked at up earlier but if you still
have that link open you go under there
there's the node item rule
and they don't give you a cloud
formation template for whatever reason
but we can just create it in the cli
but um
i'm just looking here
i did it this way i went through the
management console because it was easier
so here we'll click on uh or we already
have it open up here and i'm going to
create a new role i'm going to follow
these instructions the thing is aws has
great documentation but it's very easy
to like glance over the most important
information because it's so text heavy
not broken up in a way that's easy but
what we'll do is we will create one for
i think it's for ec2 yeah so we'll
choose ec2 the reason it changes this
interface i do not like it why is it so
light and gray it looks like it's uh
doesn't work and then this interface is
still doesn't make any sense but we need
this one this one and
this one so we will copy that name and
we need that policy we'll hit enter
we'll grab that then clear the filters
it's still selected see that that means
that there's a policy selected even
though we don't see it we'll hit enter
on that one we'll select that one so now
we have two
and we'll go back up here and then it
says you probably want this one i go
okay great
and then we select that so we have our
three we'll go next make sure you have
the three that are there
and we'll go back and then it has a nice
name for us doesn't matter what we name
it
but i'm going to stick with the name
that they have here
paste it on in go to the bottom create
the role
and
our role is created so we can close that
tab go back over here refresh
if you didn't know aws and you weren't
like used to doing this like for some
services this would be super painful for
me it wasn't too hard but i can imagine
hard we don't need a launch template
that's totally fine labels taints tags
don't care
absolutes too notice it's using the t3
medium just like what we're using on
cloud nine so that four gigabytes is a
good option 20 uh this size
i like to do higher like 30 well
we'll leave it at 20. we'll leave it to
20 because when we're running it on
cloud9 it's sharing both the control
plane and the worker note like all the
the data planes so the idea is that 20
is probably enough for our nodes i'm
gonna put one minimum two maximum
desired is one
and one so that we are saving money here
not like when we were doing it with uh
google cloud
or azure in particular um so there are
three subnets those are fine we'll hit
next
this all looks fine we'll hit create
and now we have to wait for those nodes
to spin up
while that is
going let's go find our instructions
for
ingress
so what i'm going to do is type in
eks
the first one here
and this is the right one and so when i
first did this i did not want to read
all this and so i kind of skipped
through it and then i found out i had to
do all these steps
so these are some things that we're
going to have to do
so there's a bunch of prerequisites so
the idea is that we are going to be
using application load bouncer so that's
aws's load bouncer and then we're going
to use ingress in order to
get to our app and they even have a fun
example app that we're going to be using
but before we can do that we're going to
have to do a bunch of stuff the first
thing is to install
the application load balancer controller
okay and so here we will right click
and we have to do a bunch of stuff so
the first thing is we'll need to create
an impulse so we'll go ahead and the
nice thing is they just have raw data
here so we just hit copy we don't have
to
do a crazy amount of work we'll go back
to our cloud shell paste this on in here
we'll go back to our instructions
so we've
downloaded we just downloaded the file
and so now we'll end up creating it so
this is the same thing as if we went
through the the im policy and did it all
manually
so we'll hit paste hit enter
and now we have the policy created
that's one step
and we installed eks uh ctl because we
need to
um
install the item service and actually
when i ran this i forgot to replace the
my cluster part here so i'm gonna make
sure i don't forget to do that
and i'm gonna copy this here
and i'm going to paste
and
if you right click place it usually
always pops up like that so we'll say
eks cluster
make sure you don't spell that wrong
it's a pain to fix
okay or sorry eks example see i'm
already go i'm already doing it wrong so
100 make sure that's right because it's
such a pain to fix um and then we need
our ip our um
account id so on another tab here if you
drop down there's the account id as well
so i'm going to paste that on in there
okay and so that should be all good
notice the namespace is going to be cube
cube system so it's launching in the uh
the systems
namespace usually don't do that but for
this case you do and we'll hit paste
and that will create a service account
it says unable to create imcount without
an imoc id provider so it says eks ctl
utils run this first so it's just that
eks we haven't randy
um
ctl and so we just have to basically
kind of authenticate and it goes here
and says hey
if you want to run this you have to hit
you have to run
approve okay because that was just a dry
run so we do this
okay and that worked
and then what we need to do is go back
and run this i'm hitting up making sure
that name is correct making sure that
account id number is right again it's
big pain to fix run that
it's going to go ahead and create us a
service account
waiting for cloud formation stack so
it's actually spinning up a cloud
formation stack
so i think when we delete our cluster
then we can just like tear all this
stuff down which makes it a lot easier
right
so we are going to wait on that there
for a bit we'll go back to eks and also
see if our nodes are ready
so i don't see our nodes yet we refresh
here oh we just had to refresh there it
is and these i probably show up on ec2
so if we go over to ec2
we should see there it is
okay
um so that is our
ec2 instance running we do not see the
control plane aws is managing it we
can't touch it okay
so go back over here this one has
finished our node is ready so we can
deploy stuff to it but we're still
installing this thing here
so go back over here
and so now we're going to use a helm
chart to actually install the
application database load balancer now
we have our permissions so we grab this
first line here
we paste it on in we hit enter
oh it says it doesn't know what helm is
what are you talking about
because we definitely installed it so
let's go back to this instructions here
did i not copy and paste this maybe we
didn't run the last line so we'll hit
enter here
paste
enter
helm
okay there we go
we'll hit enter okay so eks has been
added so now uh we'll make sure that
it's up to date the repo or whatever
whatever it wants there repo update
and then the next thing is to actually
install it so we'll scroll past this
stuff it's saying
different use cases so we'll grab this
one where it's actually installing it
we'll right click paste
paste it in hit enter
enter
oh
stop stop stop
this is where i mess up i i put the
wrong name in here okay so i want to
paste this in again like this
and this is where i ran this issue where
i didn't have the right name so i'm
going to type in eks
example
so sorry about that and i'm going to
make sure this is spelled the same way
capital e is case sensitive
i really should just made it all
lowercase for us this looks fine we'll
hit paste
cannot reuse a name that is still in use
oh
no
no no no no no this is a pain um
now i don't know because we messed it up
so
maybe we can uninstall it i don't know
like helm uninstall
palm uninstall
uninstall release so it is possible to
do that so i'm really hoping that we can
uninstall whatever mess i made there
i should have just let it ran and then
corrected it
i don't know if we need um
the second part here but i'll just do
this
not found
oh
i know it's going in the cube system ctl
so we'll do
dang it
it's not gonna let me do it again is it
let's try this again hit enter
cannot reuse the name that is still in
use
okay so we'll do cube ctl
get pods
uh we'll say cube system
you're never supposed to really touch
cube system that's that's the idea here
uh yeah cube system you gotta put an n
on this
so i don't see anything there that's
important
i guess we'll have to look at the helm
chart and see what it's actually
installing so we'll type in um
this is where this is where the pain was
and this is actually where i messed it
up and it became really hard and uh i
mean like i made it even worse than
before
so what we'll do
it's not all lost it's just that we have
to have a little bit of a detour now
hopefully you don't have to do this and
uh you don't make that mistake and you
just carefully watch the video
but there is this thing here that's on
helm so if i type this in
we go a helm chart
it should be an artifact here and so the
idea is that if we open this we'll see
the contents of it right which we
learned in our helm
tutorial so
just going through here
i'm looking for the actual contents of
the repo
what does it install templates
installs a deployment ingress class
a bunch of things
okay
but what are they called though
because maybe you'll have like the
default name in here in the values
anyway i'm going to be back i'm going to
try to figure this out but i really wish
i didn't do that
all right so one other thing i might try
here is by doing an uh i think i say an
upgrade was it
i'm just on stack overflow on the
right-hand side so use an upgrade and
then do
a hyphen i flag and install the release
if it doesn't exist so what we'll do is
we're going to copy this
and i'm just going to see if this works
as a fix right if you installed and you
didn't make the mistake then you are
fine but for me whoops we don't want to
change the system uh the
that there but this is just kind of
painful so what we'll do is say eks
example here
make sure that is right
and then we'll go ahead and hit paste
hit enter
well it's only going to work if i type
it right you know so up grade
eks
example
paste
oh
nice okay so we are super super lucky
that we're back in business here um so
we'll go back over to our tutorial
and here we can verify whether it's
working so we'll go over here paste it
in
okay that looks fine and then we'll go
back over here and that's all there is
to that part next part is we need to do
this tagging for our subnets because if
we don't do it it doesn't know where
to use the load balancer so
what we need to do is go back to eks if
we go to details it should show us the
um
subnets here so i'm going to open one
two and three
and then we're going to have to add tags
so we'll give it a moment there and so
there this one is we'll check box it go
to tags
i told you a bus is a lot of work
um and so we need
i'm just going to open all three so i'm
gonna have to like
figure this stuff out here manage tags
manage tags
and
okay so the first one is this
so we grab this
paste it in and this is going to be eks
example
shared
okay
i'm just going to copy that so i don't
have to keep typing it
shared
shared and we don't just need one tag we
need two tags
so go here and
then they say you need this one as well
so we'll go here and then the value here
is one
and then here and then the value here is
one
and then we go here and the value here
is one and then we'll go save
save
and save
okay
oh you know what this is for private
it's supposed to be this one bro for
frick's sakes
no biggie we'll just go and add those
you can just tell like eks just crushes
my spirit okay we'll just
go back over here
copy that
why won't it paste
oh i can't actually remove it
okay
so stupid that interfaces
um we'll go over to here
remove
and then one and hit save and then go
back to here
and then we'll
add this here and then remove that one
and hit save great so those are all
updated so now we meet all of our
requirements so the next thing that we
want to do is run the fun app that comes
along here so they have a sample app
and they are using fargate but we are
not using fargate so we'll skip that and
we'll just go ahead and grab this it's
going to launch right into our node and
so we'll paste this in and we'll hit
enter
and it says that it's created the app
um and if we want to see the contents of
that file like we can just paste the
link up here and if we just take this
out we can actually see
what's here so we have a service
ingress a deployment and a namespace
okay the game is 2048 you might have
heard of this game before
and i think that's it but i'll double
check the instructions see if there's
anything additional here
uh no but it will say i guess we
download the file we actually have to
run it
okay so we will oh no no i think we did
yeah we ran it okay the instructions are
really weird how they just kind of weird
iterations there the same thing
but uh if we go down below here and we
do the get ingress right if we check our
ingress
right and if it has an address that's
how you always know if this stuff is
working so if we copy this
and go anywhere up here
it says cannot be reached
okay
uh but it has a port
so maybe what we'll do is we'll just
double check to make sure everything's
working correctly i'm going to go over
to
ec2 here
because that's where our load bouncers
are because it created an alb right
and if i go to the load bouncer here
i was just hoping that it worked
and so there is our load balancer
and i'm just going to make sure that it
can be reached it's also possible that
the node is still starting and there's
nothing wrong
with it
and so this would normally have a target
this is an alb right so this should oh
we actually have to go to target groups
to see
if we go to target groups here and
select
uh says healthy targets
it has targets
it says initial target registration is
in progress
so it's still
making like uh determining whether to
help you okay so now it's healthy if we
go back here and try it does it work
there we go cool and so we have a game
so join the two numbers to get started
uh
uh okay use your arrow keys oh okay
somebody in the bus had too much time on
their hands they're like okay
what excuse can i have to make a game
they probably worked in like the
kubernetes department or eks but anyway
that's a fun game and it's cool that we
get to deploy that so now
we are all done that was the hardest one
that was super hard and so
what we'll do is go over to eks
and we'll go ahead and delete it
to confirm
type in
my node group sorry so just notice we
are not deleting the cluster first go to
eks carefully you don't click on ecs
otherwise you go somewhere weird but we
have to destroy the node group first i
know this because it will complain if we
don't so we call this my node group
that's what it's telling us to type in
and then
once that is gone then we can go ahead
and delete the cluster i can try this
right now but i don't know if it'll take
it until the node group's gone
it hasn't finished attaching yet so
i'll be back here in a little bit it
takes a little bit time to delete
all right so now that our node group has
been deleted we can go ahead and delete
our cluster so we'll go to the top here
delete our cluster
and type in eks example now aws
does not like
azure and gcp where they have
resource groups or projects so you got
to be really careful about what is
lingering here so just make sure double
check to make sure these things are
deleted after it's deleted
uh we did create a load balancer um but
it was created through kubernetes so i'm
hoping that it just deletes itself
but if it doesn't you should double
check because a load balance is going to
cost you 15 bucks a month if you forget
to delete it
if you go to the left-hand side
to ec2 and go to load bouncers
you know it should be deleting or
something like that and uh you know
cloudformation some of these things were
spun up there so
sometimes that's a good indicator if
they're all getting torn down so i'm
going to go over here and just double
check
and so
we have the cluster roll
ah the load bouncer is here
okay
and so if i go to resources
it's just a roll so there's no load
balancer here
so i'm really hoping that it tears it
down
so what i'll do is i will i guess i'll
just have to make sure i'll just uh i'll
have a i'll check back in here with you
and just make sure that it's gone well
here this one's gone so let's go check
the ec2 instance
i didn't think it would delete the
cluster that fast because it takes so
long to create clusters if we go to our
load balancer
it's still here so
tricky tricky aws so we'll go ahead and
delete it
and that should be that i'm going to
just double check is there any auto
scaling groups
there shouldn't be
nope we're fine so that was the only
thing i was really worried about was
that autos or that application load
balancer because that costs you 15 bucks
a month if you forget about it but now
you're a-okay and we did the hardest one
so uh feel proud uh that you've tackled
uh some of the hardest managed providers
and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this follow along we're going to look
at how to utilize uh ibm's uh offering
for kubernetes so here i have an ibm
account you'll have to go create one i'm
going to go ahead and log in to my
account now they do have a very sleek ui
i have to say for um
a cloud provider and so give a moment to
log in here now i did already launch a
cluster and the reason why it takes so
long to launch them and i really don't
want to have to launch one and wait so
what i'll do is i'll kind of piecemeal
this in the sense that i will uh show
you kind of the creation process but i
won't hit the create button and then
we'll go to the active cluster and we'll
see if we can kind of do stuff there so
what i want to do is just make sure
my running cluster is already there so
i'm just kind of trying to remember i
don't use ibm cloud too much so i'm not
sure the interface too much but if i go
to kubernetes here i should have a
cluster already running
because it did take a long time for it
to spin up like longer than aws so i
think uh kubernetes or ibm wins the
longest time to revision control plane
award uh if there is ever a reward not a
good award to to win but the idea here
is you'll go to ibm cloud left-hand side
and you're going to go to kubernetes and
then from there you're going to create a
new cluster so i'll hit i guess i can't
right-click that but we click it and
they have two plans and don't get
shocked here i know this is 2 500
and that is a bit crazy okay but they do
have a free plan and that could be the
reason why it takes so long to provision
maybe it's slower so you you have a free
plan that lasts for a cluster that will
last for their days and it'll
automatically delete it's for uh just
tinkering around and doing things with
so notice that it is free but there
could be some additional charges but
let's take a look at the standard to
understand the cost of kubernetes on ibm
cloud so down below we have i
classic and vpc and then you can choose
your resource group um
for whatever and then it just shows you
geography availability metro symmetra is
just i guess the town or whatever uh and
then notice down below this is basically
the cost here that's driving up is the
amount of nodes but if we scroll past it
for a second there's these integrations
that they have which is nice activity
tracking logging monitoring and so these
technically add a cost so if you check
box them off it actually doesn't really
lower the cost there so it's not a true
cost but if we go up here maybe the
problem is our instance is too large so
it's at 16 gigabytes we know that the
minimum should probably be something
like four so if we switch over to uh
four here i'm just looking which one's
cheaper this one's the cheaper one and
so we will choose that one so save per
tool and now it's down to 982 still
really really expensive so let's go down
to one node and look it's 340 dollars so
for whatever reason i don't know
the logic behind it
but it's extremely extremely expensive
but hold on here let's take a look here
so this is 15 cents here
it still says three workers
three zones ah okay so that's the reason
why it's so darn expensive so if we were
to reduce the amount of zones
there we go
okay so that looks a lot more reasonable
so this says a hundred dollars and
i guess that actually is
pretty cost effective so like if we had
a two v uh c uh
uh v cpus and four memory let's go take
a look here so if we go as a comparison
we'll use ewbs for pricing here
uh and so we're using a t3 medium so if
we go to ht3 medium and we look at the
cost it says zero three three six and
theirs is
zero fifteen cents for something
comparable at least that's what i it
looks comparable to me we go 730 so it'd
be 24
but like with the control plane it
pretty much is the same cost but overall
the worker nodes are more expensive if
you had to scale up for whatever reason
ibm cloud is super super super expensive
uh all i can think of is that maybe
there's something i don't understand
about
this vm
so i'm just trying to look if there's
something maybe more cost effective
so like if we went virtual shared
i'm just trying to find the lowest cost
here
no so i guess they're just generally
expensive
uh okay so but anyway the idea is you'd
go free and then you'd uh
create the cluster i can't make more
than one free cluster but you create it
and then what it will do is it will
start to
uh provision like it will get it ready
to go
and i'm gonna tell you it takes
forever so it'll start the control plane
and then it has to start the nodes so
you will see it um if we go over here to
the ibm cloud
yeah you'll see like here it'll be like
progress progress progress progress and
then when that finish will say available
and you go to the worker nodes and this
will be like progress progress progress
progress but they do have a really nice
interface so it's not showing up here
but it was showing the instructions
before if i click help yeah there it is
and so it popped up and it was like
here's your instructions and i really
liked that and another thing is it has
the kubernetes dashboard so you press it
and i mean i haven't seen it work yet
but i'll click it and
we should be able to get our dashboard
so that's really nice i don't see any of
the providers doing that and i don't
know why they don't do that because it's
super super nice
um yeah i like that
but uh let's see if we can connect never
done it before so ibm has their own
cloud shell so we'll click on that and
add that there
we'll see if we can get like an ingress
controller connection we might not be
able to do it on the free tier but let's
see what we can accomplish
and while that's going i'm just pulling
up some instructions here to see if i
have some
reusable ones here
there we go so this one's up i'm not
sure if there's a way for me to increase
the font here
um
i don't see an option i can try control
plus which is kind of
a weird way of doing it but it will work
and so we'll go back over here this will
be all over uh too large and we'll copy
this line here that's to connect to the
cluster so paste that on in we'll hit
enter
and we'll type in cube ctl get pods
hyphen a just to kind of look at what
there is
now they got calico core dns
dashboard metrics hopefully every time i
do this with the providers you kind of
see that everything's a little bit
different and we'll carry that
information forward
uh there's olm operator i don't know
what that is but yeah we have some nodes
so i guess we can go ahead and start
launching stuff so we'll do what we
normally do so we'll do
cube ctl
create
deploy
engine x
image equals nginx
um
and i think that is it yeah okay and
we'll hit enter
so we have our deployment
look here deploy your app so set up an
image repository deploy your app we
already did that
expose your app test access your apps
create a node port to test your app
if we click this where does it go
i'm just curious if they like have
anything built in i was thinking maybe
we'd go like to the worker nodes or
something and
and uh you know like how we saw gcp
no it's just instructions okay so
if we go into worker note over here
can we click into this or configure it
no if we go to the worker pools
um nothing super exciting they have this
devops which is i guess like get ops
it's probably like do continuous
delivery so i guess that's kind of nice
but i'm not really seeing any kind of
like easy to use interface so i think
like
basically it's just
a cluster with no additional
fluff now what's interesting is they do
have a bunch of these add-ons here so
you can press it and it will
automatically install so that's kind of
nice
um
i'm just trying to look around here
because i really haven't poked around
it's all add-ons okay so that's pretty
much it so what we'll do is we'll try to
uh we'll make a service i guess so we'll
need a node port service
let's see what they say here so
i guess they're suggesting to make a
node port
get a public ip address worker node in
the cluster if you want to ask that
we're going to from private get the
private ip what i'm wondering about is
like ingress
um
yeah i don't know
i'm not sure let's say uh
ibm cloud ingress
kubernetes
so here we have a service that's being
exposed
up then there's ibm provider domain
so yeah i'm not sure i guess i could
spend more time with it it looks like
this is kind of the ingress here
i wonder if we could just use this
show more
oh it does say engine x
um
i'm thinking about it
yeah let's let's try it okay so we'll
say uh cube ctl
um expose sorry i'll bump this font up
here
i think i went to baker
deploy
um engine x
port 80. i'm just trying to remember off
the top my head
target port 80 that's the way i learn i
have to try to like recall from memory
and get it right and then we have the
type right
and we'll say node port
cool
um and so then we need ingress so we'll
go over here to this and i mean we've
done lots of different
ingress here
and so um i don't think there's like an
editor per se no but uh what i'll do i'm
just gonna do ls i'm gonna say bye
i'm gonna say ingress yaml
and this is vi so everything's hard so
i'm gonna hit i for insert and then i'm
going to right click and paste
it didn't like that so i'm going to hit
colon control q
it's all the way over here
uh
q
q quit
so i'm gonna try this again
ctrl v maybe oops sorry i control v
huh so i don't i can't seem to really
paste this in here so i think we're
pretty much bust here because
otherwise we in order to get this file
in here we need to connect cube ctl on
my local computer or something else so
i would say we're pretty much bust here
and i'm not really that worried about
trying to get ibm cloud to work but just
more show to show you the interface
we've seen a lot of times how this stuff
works
um but there is a little bit of trouble
here so i think that's all i can really
do here
for ibm cloud but hopefully that gives
you kind of an idea
of what it looks like for ibm cloud
but i was hoping what would happen is if
we deployed that ingress that maybe it
would just work but then down below
uh exposing the lb to your kubernetes
ingress cluster so there might be like
some alb stuff so i would think that
either maybe you'd have to like enable
alb but like since we're doing this in
the free tier i don't even know if they
give us that so that's why i i don't
have confidence that we can expose it
but we would need ingress a
so i think we're pretty much done here
i'm just going to go ahead and click in
here
and we're going to delete this cluster
and we'll i guess we'll type it again
here
and there we go
and just make sure it is deleting i'm
just going to refresh here
there we go and i'll see you later okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we are going to
learn how to launch a kubernetes cluster
on digitalocean so
if you've never used digitalocean
they're kind of like a cloud service
provider i call them a third tier cloud
cloud service provider because they were
traditionally a vps a virtual private
server basically just virtual machines
and they've expanded to have a bunch of
other stuff such as kubernetes so i
actually already launched a cluster on
here
um but i am going to show you how to
create one so uh digitalocean is known
for being really really really easy to
use so if we go here and create a
cluster
and we'll give a moment here the idea
here is we'll select our kubernetes
version so they have recommended version
and then your your location so maybe i
want to toronto we have our vpc network
we'll have our node pool name and then
here it's going to say how many nodes
you want we're going to go down to one
because we want to save money and notice
that it's making the recommendation of
about um
four gigabytes it says 2.5 of
ram usable so i guess that's fine
um you know like i aim for like two to
four uh gigabytes for for uh worker
notes like if it's a single node like
we're doing with
micro k8 it's on cloud nine then it
makes sense to have four gigabytes but
here two
two will do fine okay
so anyway twenty dollars a month very
very very cost effective
i don't even know if the control plane
cost anything digital ocean
that well so i can't say for certain so
i shouldn't say that
absolutely but i can't seem to find the
pricing but i think the the control
plane tier is free i think
um
unless one of the nodes is actually the
whatever node so anyway um
friend downtime that makes sense so
we'll have our name here whatever you
want to call it then we go ahead and
create the cluster
and so we'll wait here a moment
and so here it will start to spin up and
it says it'll take about four minutes to
create usually it has a message there
yeah and this is what i like about
digitalocean is that they give you all
the information you need right in place
so thank you for using oh thank you
thank you for using manage kubernetes
your kubernetes cluster is being
provisioned provisioning usually is
complete within four minutes you can
configure the cluster as you wait and
then go through these steps and it tells
you like how do you connect and all that
kind of stuff so that's really really
nice of them and they have one-click
installs just like how we saw with ibm
cloud
um i don't think we saw this for their
providers but like um i mean like google
cloud had that marketplace so i guess
they do
um and i guess azure i don't know i
don't know if we saw a marketplace for
azure but it's nice if you want to just
install a controller and if we want to
do anything we probably would need an
ingress controller if we could figure
out how to use it
um and so it's pretty clear okay
so i already have one running to save us
time because i don't want to wait a
hundred years for it to spin up or stop
the video and come back here
uh so i'm going to go into here
and notice i already spent a dollar
after a day so it's not too bad
but if we go to resources here we can
see
our node pool and we can see the two
nodes i guess underneath
and then there's a load balancer
attached so low bouncers and volume
should be managed etc
we have uh any insights here
just waiting for the load so we get some
metrics so that's nice of them
and there are some settings uh but and
they also have a button for kubernetes
dashboard so that's cool i didn't notice
that before only other provider i saw
that did that was ibm cloud so i like
that so i like having that button there
but anyway if we scroll on down
um we might want to go install the
ingress controller so because we if we
want to reach the internet right so just
press that button and it does take some
time and again that's why i did this
ahead of time just so i don't have to be
clicking a thousand things here but when
we want to connect um
the idea here is
we need to install the doctel kubernetes
cluster config thing this thing here so
in order to do this we're going to need
an environment so i'm going to go back
to my italy's account we're going to do
it via cloud9 okay
we probably could even do it um
oh sorry wrong account uh this is
developers
uh
andrew brown
i should already be logged in here but
i'm not
just give me a moment here
and i think this is the right password
so we'll just paste that on in there is
that the right account nope
nope nope nope i have more than one
account here
and
oh it's this one
i have a lot of aws accounts
so we'll get in here and what we'll do
is we'll go back to cloud9
we could probably do this in the shell
but just in case we need an editor could
have went over to gcp but we haven't
done much in gcp so i don't want to
force you to be over there okay
so we'll launch our micro k its
environment and then what we'll need to
do is install
the uh the docker
ctl right so they have a guide on that
and digitalocean is known for having
really really really really really good
guides they're just known for it and so
they have a snap install so that's
pretty nice
so once it spins up the idea is we're
going to
run this line and then using docker tl
integration cube ctl requires cube
config
so
i guess that would mess with our
configuration with micro k8s
um
i'm just trying to decide here because
you know what i actually want a fresh
environment i don't want to mess with a
micro case so we'll just say
docker
env environment
unless docker has its own
cloud shell
i don't think it does it really should
get one that would be really smart
that's a record docker if you're
watching or sorry not docker
digitalocean if you're watching go get
your own like
um
like get pods you know
you can also do this in git pods but
i don't want to switch right now
so
this we don't really need anything large
because we're not actually um
we're not actually running kubernetes on
it so i'm just going to create this
environment
and then we'll spin that up and as
that's way we're going to just take a
look at what our next episode so it says
sudo snap install
that and i believe i choose ubuntu
hopefully
and then using this integrations but we
could probably go over here just run the
next line
but we probably have to install cube ctl
as well right
snap runs in complete isolation you need
to be grant permissions in your equity
systems some doc requires this requires
cube consumed
okay well we'll figure it out i'm sure
it's not that hard but we'll wait for
this to spin up
while we're waiting we might as well
just poke around
here so
i guess we already kind of looked at all
this there's nothing really new to look
at
come on cloud9
so we're going to have to download this
config file for sure so i'm just going
to go ahead and download that now
and oh is it almost there it's
connecting
okay so now that we're in uh we'll have
to do sudo snap install cube ctl
uh and classic so i'm starting to
remember the the pseudosnap commands
and then for this one it'll probably
just be
doctl
okay
i guess this digitalocean ctl is what it
stands for there
and i guess we could probably do this
even though i'm not really
100 sure on it
because i know when i tested it i didn't
i didn't do that i just i had cube ctl
and ctl i ran the one line
actually i'm going to run this one
because it says i all have to do this
access token is required okay
doc ctl auth init
and so i need an access token so from
here what we do is we go to the api
and from here you can see i have a bunch
so i'm just going to delete these
and from here we're going to say cube
and we'll create it
and this key is going to be temporary so
i'm going to copy it and i'm going to
end up deleting this so it's not going
to be a big deal so i'm going to paste
that in there hit enter
and it says permission denied so i'm
going to do sudo in front of there and
then paste it again
and that's fine so now if i do soup tpl
get pods
let's see if i get environment
connection was free refused did you
specify the host or path
um
oh you know what it's because we didn't
run that other line so let's run this
because i think this is just an
alternate way so i think the
documentation
didn't we just
do that what if we do sudo on this
nope
what if we try this again the auth
token is valid
grant
oh so doc tl config
maybe we do have to run that other line
this one here
okay
paste
and then we'll hit up
maybe we'll
take out the pseudo maybe it's getting
confused because there's pseudo there
now i did this on my local host and it
was like super easy
yeah i'm not i'm oh you know what um are
we in the right cluster hold on let me
just double check here
go back to our kubernetes cluster i want
to make sure it's the um
the one that already is running uh which
is
i wanna do the one that's one day old
here
okay
and we will copy that again
and i will paste that in again
okay and i will run doc ctl
off in it again
and i will go grab
oh
this is so frustrating
it's probably you know my fault there
we'll just generate a new token
oh look there's tokens here
maybe it created these tokens tokens you
have generated with the api
i'm confused
okay what if we do docs ctl oops let's
do doc ctl um
cube ctl is that something we could do
i don't know i'll be back here in a
moment okay all right so every time we
try to run doc ctl auth in it we get uh
even though i have an api key here right
i copy and we paste it here
we get the silly error so maybe we just
do mk dir home ubuntu
is there a config directory
there isn't so i'm just going to make
one
is that the one it wanted
okay and now what if we round it again
maybe that's the problem
okay so
doc uh ctl often it worked that time i'm
not seeing any weird additional keys
there we're gonna try this again
using doc steel till snap grant it via
the doc ctl cube config plug to use this
command so sudo snap this so we'll try
this now
okay and i wonder if this no i'm just
gonna refresh here because there was
things popping up here i don't know how
they should up in the api yeah so
there's this now here i think this just
was created when we ran that connect
okay
and uh so we'll hit enter again
and for this this is permission to
deny so i'm just going to make it
manually
i'm trying to copy it one second maybe
just copy that
i'll try this again
there we go
cube ctl
get pods
there we go okay great so now um let's
launch ourself a
deploy
so what we'll do here is type in cube
ctl deploy or
create deploy
engine x image equals nginx
and then
oh it already exists
so maybe i made it prior
keep see a tail get pods
all right
we'll do cube ctl
get svc because i've already i might
have already
created a nginx cluster ip so i'm just
going to delete those because i was
doing that
previously i didn't
get rid of them so delete
svc
engine x
um
[Music]
cube ctl get ingress i'm just wondering
if i have anything there
so i did make one before i'm just going
to go ahead and delete it okay
okay so the first thing we want to do
now so we have our
pod right
so we'll do cube ctl get or
create
or sorry it's expose expose
deploy
nginx
um
port 80
target port 80.
so no sometimes i do equals and
sometimes i don't you don't you can do
it either way it doesn't matter and then
the port or the type
or kind where's the type i think it's
type is node port
and then we'll just do cube ctl
um get svc because i want to make sure
that is a node port
there we go i don't know if it has to be
a node port but that's the one i made
and so the next thing you do is install
the nginx ingress controller
okay and so then we need an ingress
so
i'm just wondering if we can look this
up on the docks here so
kubernetes uh
um i keep on saying docker but it's
digital lotion digitalocean
ingress
okay so here they have a service
and this one's just cluster ips not even
node port
and then they have a deployment here
which is fine
and then they do a second one for some
reason
okay
they install the nginx controller so
that's something that we did so the
nginx controller consists of a pod and a
service
the services the type load balancer etc
so i don't think we need to do this
because we press the button and that's
basically the same thing
okay
and so then we need an ingress
controller and the reason i'm looking it
up here is because maybe there is a
specific configuration
to um digitalocean but it looks like
just a standard one here
so
what i'll do here and i don't know if
there's anything about this domain name
stuff that we need to figure out i think
that's where i kind of ran into some
issues where i wasn't sure what to do
um let me scroll up here is there
anything about the domain name
a fully registered domain name is
available i don't really want one i just
want to deploy one without one so what
we'll do is we'll just copy the contents
here
and we're gonna go over here it's no
different than any ingress controller
for nginx i think
okay and we'll paste that on in there
and we're just going to take a look here
so one thing i don't want is i don't
want
the host
so what we'll do is take this out here
and then here for the service i'm going
to type nginx
the path is fine there this all looks
fine
and so what we'll do is type in cube ctl
um
apply hyphen f
ingress
okay and if this works
what we're expecting to see is an
address here
but i don't see one
and this is the problem i was running
into where i wasn't resolving
okay
so it says endpoints default they should
be back and not found i don't think that
matters
and it is pointing to the nginx instance
i just don't know why we don't have
so like ingress address
empty digitalocean
so notice that they're not using host so
they're saying it's empty as well
if you are using nginx controller you
don't need to see the ingress address
okay
when you install ingress controller to
the cluster it creates a load balancer
to handle all your incoming requests
make sure the below
part is completed
so let's copy this because we could have
installed it via helm or hit that button
and so this will just confirm that it's
installed i'm pretty sure it is
installed trying to make our way back to
the lotion so we hit this
and so it is there we can see the load
balancer
i'm actually curious because i think
that uh load balancers are in digital
ocean i don't use this lotion on a
regular basis so i'm not sure if we go
to load bouncers did it create one so it
did create a load bouncer for us
i'm just curious doesn't have an ip
address or a dns hostname
um so i maybe made one for each one and
there are ip addresses which is great
and so down below here it says you
should see an external ip address
corresponding to the ip address of
digitalocean load balancer
okay
and so there's one there one there but
we're going to look at what there is
here so this one has 10 24 oh sorry
external 157 230 70 53 is that the one
we're looking for
neither of those match the load balancer
they're all 68.
okay
well even if it is
let's just go grab this one
and see if that works
because
it says ingress engine x i'm just going
to double check that
this is ingress nginx controller
it's not the same thing
svc hmm
okay well it's there so it does work
and it is routing tangent x so it does
work even though we don't have the
address it's just a lack of confidence
because i just kind of expected the
address to be there but the digital
ocean wasn't too bad
so we'll go here
and we'll go ahead
and delete
this
and hit destroy
and we'll put the name in here
oh we want the load bouncer
i didn't checkbox the bouncer but when
we go destroy here
let destroy
that other one didn't have any resources
because that was the one that i just
spun up to show you
and so because i didn't checkbox that
thing i'm going to go to networking here
and just make sure i remove those
because this probably costs something i
would think so we'll hit destroy
we'll copy the name there and hit
destroy
i don't there's like any volumes
lingering around so i'm just gonna
double check
nope
there's no droplets or anything so uh
yeah that's all there is to it um and
there you go
that's it
[Music]
hey everybody this is andrew brown from
exam pro in this follow along i'm going
to show you how to launch a kubernetes
cluster on sibo so over here you can see
i have a credit balance of 250 dollars
when you first sign up you get 250 for
free uh for a month and so you can see
that i have a 0.3 spend because i
launched one cluster uh sivo actually
has a lot of great educational content
for kubernetes um so they cover a lot of
stuff here
uh and so you know it's just if you need
more stuff this is it mine is more
certification focused where there's this
general knowledge so maybe there's some
places where you can fill the gaps in
here by using their academy
they also have docs here i haven't
really gone through their docs so i'm
not sure
the quality of them but i do know their
academy is is a-okay
and you'll notice that they have
kubernetes but looks like they have
virtual machines load bouncers volumes
and some networking things so what we'll
do is go to kubernetes at the top here
i'm going to create myself a cluster and
here i'm just going to call this cluster
uh sivo cluster for fun
we can choose how many instances i just
want one we choose the default network
we can choose an existing firewall and
go default default whatever they have
there whatever that means i'm not sure
what firewalls are on sivo
and then there's a different sizes so
notice that i mean like if it was me i
would go straight to medium and so if
you go to extra then it goes hey you
should probably choose the medium so i'm
like okay cool i know i know what size
of carbonate clusters i should be using
so we go back here and it's 20 20 a
month now i do know that the control
plane for sibo is free so that is
something that's really great i'm not
sure again i'm not sure if they'll be
able to do that forever but that is one
of their positions when you go to sibo
pricing
sievo pricing here
that is um their advantage where they go
look
uh you are playing for the control plane
and all these other providers and for us
uh the control plane is a hundred
percent free okay so
uh obviously these costs are are quite
large but um
but yeah so that is an advantage with
sibo now what we'll do is go ahead and
launch a new cluster
oh sorry i was already launching one
wasn't i
uh so we'll go back to this tab here we
have our medium you can see monthly or
hourly you're not gonna get charged like
immediately twenty dollars it's gonna be
whatever it is percent
and then we have some stuff in the
marketplace so just like everything
there are marketplaces might just wanna
poke around here to see what they have
so pretty pretty standard stuff i like
how like the ci cds are here i didn't
notice them on the other ones but maybe
i just never noticed but anyway we'll go
ahead and create this cluster
and so we'll have to wait for it to
create and has this countdown here
saying how long it's going to take
um and it's relatively pretty quick i
think we'd say like a few minutes
and so um i'll see you back here when
it's done okay
all right so after waiting a little
while our cluster is running so we'll
have to take a look at how to uh get
working with this and the way it works
is you'll need to have a cube config and
just download that and use that so what
i'm going to do is make my way back over
to aws because we're going to use our
cloud9 environment and um i have one
provision from
um
before
the digitalocean one i'm actually just
going to go delete that and make a new
one right now
okay
and then what i'll do here is create a
new environment and we'll just say civo
env just so we have a way of interacting
with it i'm going to stay with the
ubuntu just because
i usually go with amazon linux but it
says it's so easy to do that pseudo snap
install for that cube ctl i figured
we'll stick with it we'll do a t2 micro
because we don't need anything else than
that we'll go ahead and spin that up
so while we're waiting there i guess the
question is is like how do we do ingress
because i didn't really do much
uh with sibo
so
maybe what we can do is go take a look
at their docs and see if they have
instructions for that so i'm going to go
here
i just want to see um how we can do
ingress so because that's always the
questions like how do you do ingress how
do you do load bouncing right
so ingress controller with your own tls
certificate
um i want to know
let's look at load balancing here
so creating a load balancer relies on
the sivo control uh
cloud control manager sending the
appropriate request to the cvo api to do
load balancing and so then down below
the low bouncy algorithm is provided in
the round robin here's the annotation i
imagine this is the annotation that we
expect to see in our ingress controller
or something like that
external traffic policy session affinity
firewall like yeah yeah what i really
just want is i just want to know how to
do it
like what are the step-by-step
instructions
um for us to
deploy so i'm not 100 sure
okay
and this kind of just says like how easy
it is to uh utilize this stuff and
that's always the question that i have
here so here they have ingress and
it looks like this but it's using tls i
don't really care about tls
all right so we'll go back here and this
environment's ready and we will do our
sudo snap install cube ctl classic
to get that going there and then for
civo we definitely have to download the
config cubeconfig so we'll download the
cubeconfig
and
i have to spell cubectl correctly it's
not going to work
and then what we need to do is we need
to upload this file so i'm just showing
this in my uh
folders off screen here we're going to
go to file
um upload local files
and then here i'm just dragging on in
that file here
and then we're going to hit close
and did it upload
yep so that's the contents of the file
and so what i'll do is i'll say move
to cube
config
we need to put the name of what we're
actually moving so sivo
this
uh sure we'll say touch or make
directory
cube
and then we'll move that into the right
place and then we'll see if we can do
this cube ctl get pods
great
and then i'll just do cube ctl
create deploy um
engine x hyphen hyphen image nginx and
we'll hit enter and so that creates that
there we'll go back to sivo and see if
there's any way we can kind of like view
our load like what kind of interface or
stuff does it give us or is it really
bare bones that's fine if it's bare
bones
but let's just see what we can see
so we're going here and we'll go into
our cluster
okay
and
um we'll go to install applications
marketplace uh i guess this one doesn't
really show you anything and that's
totally fine um
but uh i guess the question is is like
how are we going to network this so i'll
be back here in a moment and i'll figure
it out and i'll see you here
soon okay all right so i'm not sure if
this is going to work but because this
one is specifically with your own tls
certificate but i'm going to just try to
maybe follow through with instructions
here so we already created our nginx
thing and then the next thing we need to
do is expose it so what i'm going to do
is go back over to cloud9 we'll type in
cube ctl and by the way civo has their
own um
uh
like tool like to create stuff so i mean
that could be useful but i didn't
install it so i guess we'll just
do what we can here we'll type in expose
deploy nginx and sometimes you'll see
people do this and this is totally valid
as well but i just like to have with no
space or like no hyphen or forward slash
there we'll do 80 and then we'll do
target port
equals 80 and then we'll say
um kind or no it's type
and we'll say node port because that's
just what i've been used to doing
and so now we have a service and the
next thing we'll need is an ingress
controller so i'll type in ingress
yaml and then we'll go ahead
uh
yeah that's fine close tab because we
deleted that one there
and we'll go here and we'll copy the
contents here
and we'll modify it a bit so
replace with your cluster dns name so we
probably need that
i don't care about tls
this is going to go to engine x
we're going to leave the path normal
we're going to go to port 80
and
it's fine if the path prefix it just
looks slightly different because usually
when we do ingress they look a little
bit different here and we'll just type
in ingress here and so what we'll do is
grab our cluster dns name
which is here
okay and then we'll go ahead and post
that we usually don't do a host but um
for this since they're doing it let's
give it a try
and we'll do
cube ctl apply hyphen f ingress yaml
great and so now we can use cube ctl
get ingress
and it has an address
so go grab that
whoops
did not work as expected
404 not found
but at least um it's doing something you
know what i mean so we'll go back here
http colon slash
okay what if we try with the uh the host
and we'll advance
oops
um
can i advance
you cannot visit right now because the
website uses hsts network errors in
attack usually temporary with this page
will probably
work later so usually like if we have
that we just advance right it's not a
big deal what if i just try http can i
do that
or does it always forward
no it does okay um so that's not going
to work
hmm
so maybe we do need a tls but it does
say like
bring your own tls certificates so maybe
we can just gener generate one in place
um so
save the cluster in the desired
configuration so
three node cluster greenstone create
certificates so here they have a line to
create a certificate
okay
and we'll go to the next place here
and
[Music]
it
says waiting okay so generated it out
and then it says create a secret
okay
because maybe the requirements for civos
you have to have tls or
some kind of secure thing to connect i'm
not sure but that is kind of my guess
there
maybe we should just follow through
their tutorial here because
they might have other things configured
that i'm not aware of
so let's just
go all the way down the list and follow
their instructions
so we'll do this
and then we'll go down and we'll copy
the contents here
um
i'm just going to rename this
to
and then we'll just gut the content here
well i don't have to
get that cluster ip or dns again so i'm
just going to paste that there
and we'll scroll up and we'll just grab
this value here cut
and then we will
paste this here
and we will paste this here
and then we'll delete the old one if we
can find where it starts which is here i
believe
good
and so then we'll do
cube ctl apply hyphen f
ingress two
and then we'll do ingress and we'll have
two there which is totally fine
we're going to delete the old one i
guess
that's the one i made so cube ctl delete
ingress or
ing ingress
clear
and then check if everything works so
there they are
doing a curl there but it looks like you
can also just go to the demo so maybe
what we'll do is just copy this line
here
go to our browser type forward slash
demo
cannot be reached
so
i mean we can also try the curl
right but i don't think that's going to
make a difference because you know it's
either right or it's wrong you know
oh yeah so it's working it says it's
here
so if that's the case maybe it's just
not resolving yet because it's like new
or
something so i'm going to grab the ip
address instead
okay and then i'm just going to try this
instead
404 not found
so it is 100 working it could be
a firewall thing so they do have a
firewall
as we saw as the default so let's take a
look at what's there
um i'll just go back to command zero
here to resize our stuff because that
manage firewalls
and i don't know anything about civo so
i'm just hoping that's like open a port
so we will go in and
the default firewall has all ports open
so if you install anything out of the
box we advise to create custom firewalls
so everything is open
but technically according to uh to their
tutorial it is working correctly now why
i can't access it here
i don't know
okay but we do know that when we ran
this command
for ours and we could also probably even
try with the ip address maybe i don't
know if that would make it uh like if we
still get the same thing
so here it says 404 which is fine and
we'll try this one again
and here we get a 200 hello world so it
is working um i don't know if i know
enough about sibo to get beyond this
point but it's totally fine uh and i
think we are a-okay here so i'll go back
to cloud9
and we will go and clean this up
but just do that can i get back to
cloud9 easily yes i can
and we will delete our sivo environment
and we'll go back to our cluster here
kubernetes and we will go ahead and
delete
our
cluster
and we are all done there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a closer look at
namespaces so we have been using
namespaces throughout our labs but i
figured i'd give it a little extra
attention here just to talk about a few
extra commands i think that we should
know uh so you know if we want to and
again i'm in our micro case environment
so just make sure you have that spun up
there in cloud nine so you can follow
along here but
what we'll do here is type in cube ctl
get namespaces and so we can get a list
of our namespaces
the server doesn't have a typename
system maybe because we got to type it
right
all right and instead of typing
namespaces we can also type ns you can
see we created those ones prior fire ice
and wind depending on when we did the
labs if i want to make a new one it's
just cube ctl create ns
um
borg it would be our new namespace there
okay
and some interesting things is uh like
if you let's say we launched a pod so
let's make let's launch a
or a deployment into this name space so
we type in cube ctl
um
create deploy
uh hyphen hyphen image
nginx
um
n
borg okay and so what that will do
i really gotta learn how to spell keep
ctl right what that will do is launch it
in that name space so if we do
uh cube ctl get pods
that always shows for the default
namespace right it's not gonna show us
all of our apps it's gonna show what's
in the default namespace
all right so if we want something from
another namespace other than default we
have to put the n and then the name so
we do borg
and i think it's just not there yet
because it's still spinning up so if we
were to do
deploy here then we could see it
oh did that not work
exactly one name is required okay so i'm
not paying attention here
i'm just checked out here so we will put
the word engine x here
great and so now if we go back here we
can see that we have a pod but notice
that if we uh do not have that it should
not show up so all right so you need to
have that hyphen end or
if you want to be more verbose you can
do hyphen hyphen
name space it's important to list like
the variants because when i was taking
the exam like when i didn't know there
was a difference between deployment
deploy i couldn't tell if one was just
like purposely wrong or there was an
abbreviation or a shortcut for stuff so
just understand there's a lot of
shortcuts
and i don't think the exam would ever
try to trick you by having like fake
fake abbreviations like that okay
um so if you think it is kind of
generally says deployment or deploy then
it's probably the same thing on the exam
so one interesting thing that we could
do would be to um
list multiple resources so uh and this
is not namespace specific but what we
can do is we can say get
all
and that will actually list out a bunch
of resources so here we got our positive
deployments or replica sets and some
things won't ever show up there like um
maybe like
config maps
secrets
ingress okay and so that allows us to
bring in a lot more stuff so not all of
these things have stuff but notice we
are getting things listed out actually
they do we did get a lot of stuff here
so just realize that that's another way
with answers but now can you get
multiple name spaces so if i say get uh
you know pod and then i say hyphen or
hyphen name
um
default and
board just understand that you can only
pass it one which is kind of frustrating
i kind of wish there was a way to do
multiples if there is i sure don't know
how to do it but one interesting thing
is if you want to delete everything in a
namespace you can do delete all and so
remember what all returned right so
anything that all returned is what it
would delete so i think if we wanted to
get all of them we probably have to do
like cm secrets ingress like that
right but i'm just going to do all
and then we would do hyphen n and then
we would just say borg
it says uh
no name was specified
oh sorry so it'd be all
hyphen hyphen or sorry uh dash dash or
hyphen hyphen all and so that way you
don't specify name you can just say all
the names right and so it's deleted
those resources there i don't know if
the namespace still exists cubectl get
namespaces and that's still there as
well so we'd have to delete that
namespace cubectl delete nsborg
and there you go so that's all i really
wanted to show you is just some of those
extra commands because it's nice to have
that delete all ability uh when you put
everything in the namespace and you just
delete it okay there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this follow along we're gonna be
looking at role-based access controls
also known as rbac i'm going to tell you
right now they're a pain to set up
they're such a pain
and there's two types we have cluster
roles like cluster stuff and then
there's uh just roles and those are name
space which we do cover in the course
we're not going to do both because we
just be here all day and we really don't
need that for the kcna but i do want to
set up one a role uh for a particular
user and then restrict some resources
okay so i'm just going to type in clear
here make sure you launch that micro
creates environment
and this is a little bit tedious and
painful but we will get through it um
and we might have to kind of like piece
it together because it was a lot of work
for me to
get a working solution here so if you
can't get through it don't worry just
watch along if you do get stuck and just
understand all the components that go
involved
but i'll get through it here on video
here so do not worry but what we'll do
is type in micro k8
kate's status and we have the ability to
enable it and i just want to note if we
do rbac kubernetes here normally what
you would do but we're using micro case
but normally what you would do is you
would have to specify
when you start your
cluster the api server
you'd have to tell it to run an
authorization mode of rbac
now we don't have to do that we just
have to enable it here so just
understand that that's abstracted away
for us
but if you do see on the exam that flag
just remember you know what it does okay
and so what i want to do is just enable
rbac it's right here there it is and
we'll go ahead and hit enter and we'll
give it a moment to enable it shouldn't
take too long so it's reconfiguring the
api server so it's likely adding that
authorization mode flag so that it is
enabled and there it is
okay so
um i'm looking for my super complex
instructions for
uh just the role so the first thing
we're going to need is we're going to
need um
a way of identifying our users and
there's a few different ways to do that
if we go to authentication
kerneubernetti's kubernetes
don't worry if you can't say it i can't
say it half the time or spell it but
we have a few different ways that we can
authenticate
and
it
says it should say here the list
so
certifications bearer tokens there's
three ways
and it's not showing it here
let me double check let's go to the top
here i remember being the two of the top
um
maybe it's not this page
maybe it's controls here
well i'm gonna tell you i'm not sure
where the page is but i can tell you
that there are three ways uh at least at
least three ways of doing it so one's
using a certificate another one is
having a bearer access token and there's
another way
they're not going to ask you on the exam
so it's not a big deal
maybe like the security exam that would
be where that would matter but what
we're going to do is we're going to
generate out a certification because
that was the one that i found the
easiest to understand even though
there's a lot of steps involved so what
we'll have to do is generate out
ourselves a certificate and so we're
going to use openssl to do that so we'll
type in openssl we're going to type gen
rsa because rsa is the type of um
cryptographic thing that we want to do
there we'll type out to output um
the uh the thing that we're generating
here of the key and then we'll put the
name so i'm going to call everything
developer just to make things easier you
could put the name like andrew or
something here but just stick with me
here and do developer because it becomes
super hard
to swap this all out so uh 2048 i
believe is the length of the key that we
want we hit enter and it generates out
our rsa private key so now that we have
our rsa private key um we need to uh
create or generate a client site uh sign
request a csr don't ask me what that is
i do not remember but i just know that
we need to do it so we'll type in
openssl req new hyphen key
developer.key
hyphen out
developer.csr that's what we want to
generate a csr
s-e-b-j and then we which stands for
subject and then we have this very
special syntax so cn is going to be the
user's name which is developer we don't
want to make a mistake and then oh
capital o equals is going to be the
group because remember rbacs can have
users and groups we're going to call it
developer as well we could call it
developers but again for simplicity
we're just going to call it developer
okay i'm going to double check to make
sure that's okay
and if you're wondering like where did i
get all these instructions
oh also notice we've got this error so
it's possible
that this line didn't work i remember
getting this error so let me look here
because i did have a fix for it
can't load root orange okay so i think
it's like r d
here let's just look it up and see if we
can find it very quickly
so they say try removing your commenting
out rand line in this thing yeah that
was the problem here so this is maybe a
weird problem with ubuntu
um and so i almost didn't catch that
error there i'm gonna do ls did it
generate out that csr it shouldn't
because it wouldn't have worked so i'm
going to go ahead and delete that
and then what we're going to do
i grabbed that line over here this one
here and we're going to have to open
this up
so normally we could do like
c9 and file name but unfortunately like
last time i did npm install i could try
it right now and see if it works npm
install uh
this this would install the c9 client
i should be able to do c9 and then do
this
but it's not opening up so i think it's
because we're on ubuntu and on amazon x2
so i'm just going to clear that out and
so if since we can't use cloud9 to
easily open it we'll have to open up
invi
and vi is a big pain because every key
matters okay so i'm going to hit enter
and
before you touch your keyboard
understand that every single key doesn't
act like a normal key so if i hit
j it goes down if i hit k it goes up if
i go l it goes right
okay if i go h it goes left all right
every key is bound to something so
you've got to be very careful so what
we're going to do is hit j until we get
down to this rand line and then we're
going to hit i to go to insert mode look
down below it says insert mode here and
now your keyboard acts like a normal
keyboard and your cursor even though it
selects the r it's actually in front of
it and we're going to make a pound okay
that's going to comment it out now to
get out of insert mode we'll hit escape
on our keyboard
okay left and now do colon to execute
commands but then this right for w q for
quit
um and the problem is we're in read-only
mode so i had to do sudo there so what
i'll have to do is do colon cue
exclamation mark and then hit up
ctrl a to go to the front sudo enter
and it brought me back to the same spot
so we'll go i
insert mode
pound
escape
notice insert mode is out so now we're
in normal mode
colon wq
i use vim as my primary um
layout or keyboard layout so for me it's
normal but you know a lot of people
aren't and you know just got to be very
careful there so we've updated the open
ssl cnf and so what we'll do
if it generated a key i don't trust it
so i'm going to delete it
because i don't want to see that message
there and we'll hit up until we get back
to
this one
okay notice no errors we'll hit up
can we get this one no errors good now
the question is where am i getting these
crazy commands well the only way is to
look up tutorials because if you go on
the kubernetes docs they do not help
whatsoever um so at least like the
kubernetes docs is good in some places
bad in other places um but i'm just
trying to find the article ahead so it'd
be like rbac
rbac with kubernetes yeah and i think it
was like a mini cube that i used so i
had to adopt this
rbac probably spell it right so we can
find it easily
because one of the key skills of
learning kubernetes is being able to
find solutions and so this is the fellow
that made one i don't know if he has a
video but
generally like a lot of these commands
are here um yeah i think he has a video
i didn't watch it i just kind of like
went through and kind of adapted it to
to my needs
um but you know a lot of that stuff you
just got to look for it or understand
how this stuff works
so we generated our csr we fixed the rng
problem
and so now the next thing we need to do
um
is we need to generate out a crt okay
and so that's just another thing we need
to generate out but before we do we need
the crt these are cert certificates um
for kubernetes so if i type in
kubernetes certifications
or maybe certificates because it's not
certifications per se
um and we go maybe here
nope that's not it maybe here
that's not it
i'm just looking at i got the links here
i'm just trying to google it so we can
find it
best practice certifications okay so
kubernetes
best practices you can only imagine how
much time i spent looking this stuff up
and we go here and so what we're looking
for is where these um
certificates are so when you install
your kubernetes cluster it generates at
all these different kinds of
certificates so these certificates are
used to validate uh authenticity of
things right so you say okay this is
your certificate we'll
bind them together somehow and double
check and things like that so we need to
have the crt and the ca key and so we
need to know where these are now if
you're using minicube they install in a
particular place if you're using micro
k8s
they install a particular place but this
is where they are by default so micro
k8s
is somewhere else
and so if we want to know where it is
i think we'd have to look up like micro
k8s um off
okay
so if we go to the docs here
i think it might be under service and
ports
and if we scroll on down here
it shows you here var snap microwaves
current certs so this is where they are
so what we'll do is copy this directory
and we're going to do ls and then paste
it in to see where they are and we can
see we have a csr conf cube etc etc ah
there they are c a c a dot key and then
cr dot cert so this is where they are
and so now that we have that we now need
to type this big old ugly
command here so open ssl
x509 which is a type of certificate or
something i've seen 509 i don't really
know what it is you're going to see it
for years we'll say developer.csr
because we're going to need that
and then we do hyphen ca and then we
have hyphen ca key and then we have
hyphen ca
create serial and then out
um developer we didn't type everything
and i'm just kind of just like filling
out the
the obvious stuff
and then what we'll do is fill in
these ones here so we got to fill in a
value here
okay we got to fill a value in there
so what we need is
and we'll open up our readme to make
this a little bit easier i'm just going
to go ahead delete the contents here but
i need this address
actually just to make this easier i'm
going to copy this here because this is
such a pain to type
and we'll paste it in here
and i'm going to grab the contents here
just in case we make a mistake and we
have to type this like 100 times
or like execute it 100 times and so here
we want
uh ca cert
and here we want um
this is
ca key yeah
okay
and so this is the big old line that we
need so what we'll do
whoops
did i mess that up
okay so we'll copy that line
just clear this one out oops
again i'll copy this line again yank
paste
looks okay hit enter
and can't open
for reading no such file or directory
okay so i'll double check one more time
i clearly made a mistake
oops sorry ls
oh crt
sorry i wrote cert
uh here
okay so i'm gonna yank that line
oops didn't get it
try one more time
it's a bit hard to copy
i don't want to wrap the text there's a
way of wrapping it but it's just like
don't have to unwrap it so
hit enter
okay and generate out our crt
are you lost
okay so let's create a user now so the
way we do that is we're gonna type in
cube
ctl config
set
credentials
developer hyphen hyphen client
certificate
equals developer dot crt
hyphen hyphen client
hyphen key
developer dot key
if you hear rumbling i don't know if you
can hear it but my my stomach's been
like rumbling through a lot of the labs
so if you hear like a rumbling sound
it's probably my stomach um cube ctl
config set credentials developer that's
the developer that we want uh the client
credentials developer crt client hyphen
key developer dot key we'll hit enter
uh and i typed it wrong so that would be
a problem
oh boy it's acting funny so what i'll do
is i'll just copy the contents here
and if we do want to make this easier i
can just do this
so my life is not so painful
this uh backlash allows you to do multi
lines okay so
client
probably should be spelled right
paste that in there it didn't take it
one second we'll try this again
clear
paste it in again
it's not taking it
okay we'll make it one line all right i
don't know why it's being silly but
whatever
so we'll copy this again
that or there actually is an error okay
i just can't tell if it's a multi-line
error here
it's missing the y here
there we go okay so the developer has
been set
so now we have created our user
and if you want to see the users there's
a command it's called cube ctl config
view hyphen o because like if you do
view you get
a bunch of this stuff right and so
this config file
shows us things so we can see admin and
developer there if you want to be really
clever you can do um parsing so if you
do hyphen o you could pass it like
jsonpath
uh which is a i think it's like jq
syntax there's a name for that syntax i
can't remember what it's called i
covered in one of my other courses
asterisk
and then we say dot name here
okay
and um
did i type that right
i forgot the equals here
so we get the names really all it's
doing is it's just parsing it through
and grabbing out the admin and developer
so we can see that we have um uh two
users whoops
i just wonder if this is actually the
same contents as let me just type clear
again so type in uh view again here one
second so this is that file but i wonder
if this is the same file as our cube ctl
so if we type in cat which just means
concatenate like to print out and we go
cube config i wonder if it's just the
same darn file
uh it's similar so notice like there's
some additional stuff here so we have
certificate authority which is this big
old string here
server micro k8 we have context
uh uh kind config user preferences but
notice that when we do config view
it's just a shortened version so ah here
it is so look it says data omitted so it
is the same file it's just that it's
obscuring that just in case for security
because i would assume you do not want
to share your certificate authority data
um
i'm not worried about it because this is
locked in on a vm and this will be
deleted by the time you get to see it so
i'm not too worried about it but yeah so
all it did was really add it here and
then provide those links there that was
that big fancy link that we did with the
set credentials there so now the next
thing we need is a context so a context
is to say what user are we right now so
these are the users possible users and
the the things that we need to uh
authenticate them with notice this one
uses a token to authenticate but here
are the contexts so right now we are the
micro creates cluster and uh like that's
or sorry that's the context for this
cluster because you could have multiple
clusters uh that you want to connect to
and then this is the user that we are
we're the admin user okay and this is
for uh micro k8s so what we'll do
is um
we will actually we can see our current
uh
contacts by typing current config
current
context it'll just show us who we are
contact so i don't see here oh it's
right here right
okay so if we hit that we are micro case
right now that's who we are
um and so
yeah because the name is michael gates
the context is called micro caves okay
and so now what we can do is we can uh
switch
our context
so or actually we need to make a new
context sorry because we don't have a
context for our developer yet so we'll
type in cube ctl config set context
developer hyphen hyphen cluster equals
micro k8
cluster
and then hyphen hyphen user equals
developer okay
and so now if we go back and we view
you can now see that we have a context
here
and just make sure the cluster is
correct if that's wrong we'll end up
with an error
so um
we haven't switched context yet we are
still this context here
but um one thing we'll want to do is we
will want to uh set some permissions
here but before we do i just want to
show you a command to say what do we
have access to so there's a thing called
cubectl auth and auth we have this thing
this is can i and we can say list pods
and so if i say this it'll tell me
whether i'm allowed to list pause this
is a way of checking
role-based access controls before we
even set them okay and if we're a
developer i can say as
uh equals developer can i right now
oops
say uh hyphen hyphen as
developer am i allowed to look at it it
says no so i created this new user and
it's not the admin user and so it
doesn't have any access when we first
created it so if we were to switch over
to it like if we typed in cube ctl
um
to remember how we switch here
oh it's config use context
developer
really got to learn how to type properly
and so if we type in cube ctl get pods
we have no access this is forbidden
right you don't have any privileges uh
you're not allowed to do this okay so
what we need to do is create some role
based access controls to allow them to
have access to those pods so what we'll
do is go back and switch to our back to
our micro k8s
let's type clear here and that's where
we need to uh create ourselves a roll
and a rule binding so what i'll do i'm
just pulling up my example here and then
what uh we'll do is type in roll rbac
there's a role kubernetes
and get some example code so we'll go to
using rbac authorization we'll scroll on
down and here is basically the same
example that we want so i'll make a new
one in our case folder here new file um
role dot
yaml
we'll paste that on in there
uh this one's called pod reader sure
we'll leave it as is that's totally fine
and then we need a
um
a role binding i don't know why they go
like role in the role cluster this
really should show you end to end but
this is how they do it and so if we go
down i'm just looking for one that looks
like the one that we need
these ones are all
very silly
roll
binding i guess we'll use this one even
though i really don't like it we'll have
to adjust it where this is this one here
as well this is the one i think we
wanted role binding examples
okay so we'll go back here we'll make a
new file
roll binding
yaml
okay and um i'm just going to double
check because i might have modified this
a bit yeah mine's a lot more easier to
read so we'll just take out these
comments here so that we can just see
what we're doing i just don't want any
of the stuff in so i can see what's
going on just to make sure that it's
right so the idea here is that uh we
have a role binding kind and then we
have our metadata
uh read positive is fine the name space
is fine so the subject the kind is going
to be user the name is going to be
developer because we called our
developer
user
and so that's the subject now we need to
um
have the role reference and so i think
it's called pod readers if we go back to
the one
looks good to me
and then if we go back uh we'll just yep
that's fine we'll save it make sure that
little dot is cleared and so that should
be good so we are good to
set these up so we'll say cube ctl
apply hyphen f roll.yaml i wonder if we
can do multiple files like this i don't
ever try
does that work
nope
that i typed it wrong so i'll just hit
enter
oh you know what
we probably can do it let me just try
this
let me just try this and see if this
works
all right well if there is a way of
doing multiple ones i have no idea how
to do it
and then we'll just say rolebinding.yaml
there we go
and let's go take a look at what those
look like so we say get
cube ctl get roll
and we'll say describe the role
okay so get watch list pods all good
there and then we'll say
get roll binding
okay read pods
pod reader and we'll say describe it
oops
describe
user developer that's who's allowed to
use this role
um
so
now let's go back up remember that uh
auth command we had
here it is as developer can they use it
yes okay so now what we'll do is we'll
switch context so we'll say cube ctl
um
i already forgot what the command is it
is
config
use context
developer
i have to type
use
and we'll say cube ctl
get pods
cube ctl get pods you got a spell right
for it to work
and then we'll try svc
oh
our juice app is running again huh we
had destroyed the deploy
prior so it shouldn't be running but i
guess it's still running whatever
anyway um so notice that we get a denied
access for services but we can get it
for pods so it is working as expected
i'm going to just switch back to micro
case so we're not confused and that's
all i wanted you to learn there are uh
role based clusters and they're really a
pain to set up and it's just really time
consuming but if we go if you really
want to know how i know
there's a few tutorials if we say rbac
cluster roll 100 days of kubernetes i
know that um
there is a good example there i'm just
going to pull it up here if you're if
you want to look at it yourself if you
are on the example platform all these
links are there for you just so you know
but let me take a look here
i'm trying to find the example
um can't really find it but let's say
rbac um
micro k8s
tutorial
roll
ah yes
so
anis i know i don't know how to
pronounce her name i know her she's
super nice she's on twitter uh and so
she goes here and
i think she's just created a role in
cluster roles she does a cluster role
one and so if we go through here
um that's a role so they create a role
i guess i guess he does both
but let's just take a look at cluster
rule here so for cluster role you have
to create a service count um you'll have
to set up verbs right
so what resources
uh oh yeah this is where the sticky part
was so in order to um
i guess it's not hard but she was using
this third-party library and i just did
not want to use it because then you have
to install crew and do that and so
probably there's a way i could figure it
out but you know honestly we don't
really need to learn cluster roles it's
not that big of a deal
they're very similar to roles they're
just not names based right so you won't
see a namespace in them and they're for
workloads and not necessarily or sorry
like they're scoped at the cluster
cluster rules what was interesting was
service account because service account
isn't a user it is a
like for workloads and stuff like that
but i figured just doing a role and
stuff that is fine for kcna and just
conceptually understanding other ones is
good enough
so we'll do
is close off these other tabs close this
off here
this one and this one and that's all i
wanted to show you for rbac okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we're just going
to be looking at a bunch of
random
cube ctl commands that we just didn't
cover through any of the other follow
alongs but could appear on the exam or
just help you contextualize a few things
so i'm going to launch my micro k8
environment and as that is spinning up
what i'm going to do is make my way over
to google on a new tab we're gonna type
in cube ctl commands and you know this
is the one i usually point you to but i
just also noticed if you click even if
it's the cheat sheet right here left
hand side you go to cube ctl commands
and uh that's another way to get to it
so there's just some things like api
resource cluster management we might
want to just take a quick peek at um i
don't even look at top what's that the
top commands lets you see resource
consumption for nodes and or
pods cool so maybe we'll just play
around with a few of these just to see
what we can see
so i'm going to type in cube ctl
get pods to see what we have here
just to see if anything is running yet
um
and we can always just type in micro k8s
as well
i'm not sure if we have a permissions ah
there we go so we are fine there um i
thought we might have a permissions
issue there but i'm actually surprised
on the server that i don't have um
the cube ctl installed because we are on
ubuntu so
um i can't remember what we did for that
i think was something with the config
file but
um i think it was like cube ctl
um config and then we would just do this
dot cube
uh config
oh sorry micro cr8s
right
did not mean to open up that tab
okay it's all just having clear and if i
type in cube ctl get pods it's gonna
save me some trouble oh cue get pods can
i do that no so i see a lot of people
alias the k command i'm not sure how
that gets done but um
let's go back over to here and just look
at some of them here so we have cube
ctl top
and that might be fun to try so let's go
give that a go and see what that does
um qctl top
so this top command allows you to use to
see resources consumption on nodes so we
need to specify something maybe like
node
um is unavailable to handle requests
let's try pod
okay so that didn't work but uh maybe
just as a test we can do micro k8s
there
okay but we are we have pods right
all right so i'm not sure as the reason
why that's not working
but i'm not too worried about it because
it's not on the exam but i just saw it
there so i just wanted to give it a go
api versions is definitely something we
might want to try out so we'll just type
in clear cube ctl api versions
versions
and so here it's telling us all the api
versions so if we go back over here
we'll just give it a read print the
support api versions on the server in
the form of groups and versions so i
guess the idea is that
all of these things are apis so
what i mean by that is like if we go
create a file any kind of file like a
persistent volume if you go to the top
uh maybe that's not the best example but
the idea is you have a group and then
you have a version and so if any of the
syntax changes because the functionality
changes that might be version two that
might be version three or down below
like c auto scaling we have one two
v two beta one v two beta two and so by
copying this and putting this up here
into the api version will change the
nature of these files
all right and i don't know if like
it's you get what you get i would
imagine that you install a version of
kubernetes and then that's going to
support different ones so as new
versions of kubernetes come out i
imagine they might drop older versions
or things like that or maybe the betas
vanish i really don't know um but i mean
generally that's the idea behind the api
versions let's go back over to cube ctl
reference here
cluster info might be one that we might
want to run here so go ahead and just
type in clear at the bottom and then
we'll paste that on in there and hit
enter
so it says the control plane is running
uh nothing super exciting
now this is micro cave so i'm not sure
if we would get
more detailed information
if we're doing a managed provider if we
self-deployed versus a lightweight
distribution like microkates but
we get some information there which is
nice
cordon drain those are really for
managing nodes or spinning them
spinning them down uncord on as well
taint uh as well so these are we're not
going to be touching at all
this would be something you would do in
the cka the administrator
then we have other ones down below here
i don't even know what alpha is these
commands correspond to alpha features oh
that sounds like fun let's see what
alpha features we have so events is
experimental so i imagine that maybe
that can be turned on
um so yeah down below here so cube cube
ctl alpha events might turn it on i
suppose or something like that or maybe
you just have to put alpha in order to
access the events that's probably what
it is right
um then there's api resources so print
the supported api resources on the
server so we'll go ahead and copy this
we'll type in clear
and we'll hit enter
and so if we just scroll up here
and just expand it a bit not too
different from the
api versions per se but like
here it's saying what is the name of the
api resource so like bindings events
pods things like that what is its short
name what version is this one currently
on is it namespaced
and what kind is it right so actually uh
saying kind in terms of a component or
stuff and i guess this would be useful
if you wanted to know
what kubernetes components are namespace
and not right because we said that there
are certain components in our namespace
section that you can put in any states
that you can't put in a namespace and
this may also affect whether you use a
cluster role or a role for particular
things
because i would think that if you have a
role and then you have a component that
isn't that is not allowed to be
namespace you probably need to have to
use a cluster role uh we don't really
get that deep into that kind of stuff
with our back or roll based access
controls and that kind of level detail
because again the kcna level
we're not too worried about that
information maybe that's the csk or
ckad or the cka
um config we definitely used and there's
a lot of options under there explained
uh we have not used so
ctl explained uh the command describes
the fields associated with each
supported resource so that might be fun
let's try pods over here
enter
and we typed in that here so a pod is a
collection of containers that run on a
host this resource is created by clients
and schedules api version kind metadata
oh so it actually explains all the
fields within
um within pods so that's kind of useful
and maybe documentation that might not
show up actually on the page but it's
here in the commands
so that's nice but really all i really
wanted to do was show you api resources
and api versions because i definitely
definitely know that those will appear
on the exam and you need to know uh what
they're there for okay so api resources
show you all the possible supported
resources uh and then api versions is
all the supported api versions okay